This video is about working with rational
expressions. A rational expression is a fraction,
usually with variables in it, something like
x plus two over x squared minus three is a
rational expression. In this video, we'll
practice adding, subtracting, multiplying
and dividing rational expressions, and simplifying
them to lowest terms. We'll start with simplifying
to lowest terms. Recall, if you have a fraction
with just numbers in it something like 21
over 45, we can reduce it to lowest terms
by factoring the numerator and factoring the
denominator and then canceling common factors.
So in this example, the three is cancel, and
our fraction reduces to seven over 15. If
we want to reduce rational expression with
variables and add to lowest terms, we proceed
the same way. First, we'll factor the numerator,
that's three times x plus two, and then factor
the denominator. In this case of factors 2x
plus two times x plus two, we could also write
that as x plus two squared. Now we cancel
the common factors. And we're left with three
over x plus two. Definitely a simpler way
of writing that rational expression. Now next,
let's practice multiplying and dividing. Recall
that if we multiply two fractions with just
numbers in them, we simply multiply the numerators
and multiply the denominators. So in this
case, we would get four times two over three
times five or 8/15. If we want to divide two
fractions, like in the second example, then
we can rewrite it as multiplying by the reciprocal
of the fraction on the denominator. So here,
we get four fifths times three halves, and
that gives us 12 tenths. But actually, we
could reduce that fraction to six fifths,
we use the same rules when we compute the
product or quotient of two rational expressions
with variables on them. Here, we're trying
to divide to rational expressions. So instead,
we can multiply by the reciprocal, I call
this flipping and multiplying. And now we
just multiply the numerators. And multiply
the denominators. It might be tempting at
this point to multiply out to distribute out
the numerator and the denominator. But actually,
it's better to leave it in this factored form
and factored even more completely. That way,
we'll be able to reduce the rational expression
to cancel the common factors. So let's factor
even more the x squared plus x factors as
x times x plus one, and x squared minus 16.
And that's a difference of two squares, that's
x plus four times x minus four, the denominator
is already fully factored, so we'll just copy
it over. And now we can cancel common factors
here and here, and we're left with x times
x minus four. This is our final answer. Adding
and subtracting fractions is a little more
complicated because we first have to find
a common denominator. A common denominator
is an expression that both denominators divided
into, it's usually best of the long run to
use the least common denominator, which is
the smallest expression that both denominators
divided into.
In this example, if we just want a common
denominator, we could use six times 15, which
is 90 because both six and 15 divided evenly
into 90. But if we want the least common denominator,
the best way to do that is to factor the two
denominators. So six is two times 315 is three
times five, and then put together only the
factors we need for both six and 15 to divide
our numbers, so if we just use two times three
times five, which is 30. We know that two
times three will divide it and three times
five will also divide it and we won't be able
to get a denominator any smaller because we
need the factor of two three and five, in
order to ensure both these numbers divided,
once we have our least common denominator,
we can rewrite each of our fractions in terms
of that denominator. So seven, six, I need
to get a 30 in the denominator, so I'm going
to multiply that by five over five, and multiply
by the factors that are missing from the current
denominator in order to get my least common
denominator of 30. For the second fraction,
for 1515 times two is 30. So I'm going to
multiply by two over two, I can rewrite this
as 3530 s minus 830 s. And now that I have
a common denominator, I can just subtract
my two numerators. And I get 27/30. If I factor,
I can reduce this to three squared over two
times five, which is nine tenths. The process
for finding the sum of two rational expressions
with variables in them follows the exact same
process. First, we have to find the least
common denominator, I'll do that by factoring
the two denominators. So 2x plus two factors
as two times x plus 1x squared minus one,
that's a difference of two squares. So that's
x plus one times x minus one. Now for the
least common denominator, I'm going to take
all the factors, I need to get an expression
that each of these divides into, so I need
the factor two, I need the factor x plus one,
and I need the factor x minus one, I don't
have to repeat the factor x plus one I just
need to have at one time. And so I will get
my least common denominator two times x plus
one times x minus one, I'm not going to bother
multiplying this out, it's actually better
to leave it in factored form to help me simplify
later. Now I can rewrite each of my two rational
expressions by multiplying by whatever's missing
from the denominator in terms of the least
common denominator. So what I mean is, I can
rewrite three over 2x plus two, I'll write
the 2x plus two is two times x plus one, I'll
write it in factored form. And then I noticed
that compared to the least common denominator,
I'm missing the factor of x minus one. So
I multiply the numerator and the denominator
by x minus one I just needed in the denominator,
but I can't get away with just multiplying
by the denominator without changing my expression,
I have to multiply by it on the numerator
and the denominator. So I'm just multiplying
by one and a fancy form and not changing the
value here. So now I do the same thing for
the second rational expression. I'll write
the denominator in factored form to make it
easier to see what's missing from the denominator.
What's missing in this denominator, compared
to my least common denominator is just the
factor two. So I multiply the numerator and
the denominator by two. Now I can rewrite
everything. So the first rational expression
becomes three times x minus one over two times
x plus 1x minus one, and the second one becomes
five times two over two times x plus 1x minus
one, notice that I now have a common denominator.
So I can just add together my numerators.
So I get three times x minus one plus 10 over
two times x plus 1x minus one. I'd like to
simplify this. And the best way to do that
is to leave the denominator in factored form.
But I do have to multiply out the numerator
so that I can add things together. So I get
3x minus three plus 10 over two times x plus
1x minus one, or 3x plus seven over two times
x plus 1x minus one. Now 3x plus seven doesn't
factor. And there's therefore no factors that
I can cancel out. So this is already reduced.
As much as it can be. This is my final answer.
In this video, we saw how to simplify rational
expressions to lowest terms by factoring and
canceling common factors. We also saw how
to multiply rational expressions by multiplying
the numerator and multiplying the denominator
had divide rational expressions by flipping
and multiplying, and how to add and subtract
rational expressions by writing them in terms
of the least common denominator. This video
is about the difference quotient and the average
rate of change. These are topics that are
related to the concept of derivative and calculus.
For function y equals f of x, like the function
whose graph right here, a secant line is a
lie. that stretches between two points on
the graph of the function. I'm going to label
this x value has a, and this x value as B.
So this point here on the graph is going to
have an x value of a, and a y value given
by f of a, the second point will have x value
B and Y value, f of b. Now the average rate
of change for a function on the interval from
a to b can be defined as the slope have the
secret line between the two points A, F of
A and B, F of B. In symbols, that slope m
is the rise over the run, or the change in
y over the change in x, which is the difference
in Y coordinates f of b minus F of A over
the difference in x coordinates b minus a.
So this is the average rate of change. To
put this in context, if for example, f of
x represents the height of a tree, and x represents
time in years, then f of b minus f of a represents
a difference in height, or the amount the
tree grows. And B minus A represents a difference
in in years, so a time period. So this average
rate of change is the amount the tree grows
in a certain time period. For example, if
it grows 10 inches in two years, that would
be 10 inches per two years, or five inches
per year would be its average rate of change
its average rate of growth, let's compute
the average rate of change for the function
f of x equals square root of x on the interval
from one to four.
So
the average rate of change is f of four minus
f of one over four minus one, well, f of four
is the square root of four of one's the square
root of one. So that's going to be two minus
one over three or 1/3. Instead of calling
these two locations on the x axis, a and b,
this time, I'm going to call the first location,
just x and the second location, x plus h.
The idea is that h represents the horizontal
distance between these two locations on the
x axis. In this notation, if I want to label
this point on the graph of y equals f of x,
it'll have an x coordinate of x and a y coordinate
of f of x. The second point will have an x
coordinate of x plus h and a y coordinate
of f of x plus h. a difference quotient is
simply the average rate of change using this
x x plus h notation. So a different version
represents the average rate of change of a
function, f of x on the interval from x to
x plus h. Equivalent way, the difference quotient
represents the slope of the secant line for
the graph of y equals f of x between the points
with coordinates x, f of x, and x plus h,
f of x plus h. Let's work out a formula for
the difference quotient. Remember that the
formula for the average rate of change could
be written as f of b minus F of A over B minus
A, where a and b are the two locations on
the x axis. But now I'm calling instead of
a I'm using x instead of B, I'm using x plus
h. So I can rewrite this average rate of change
as f of x plus h minus f of x over x plus
h minus x. That simplifies a little bit on
the denominator. Because x plus h minus x,
I can cancel the access and I get the difference
quotient formula f of x plus h minus f of
x over h. The quantity h on denominator It
looks like a single entity, but it still represents
a difference in x values. Let's find and simplify
the difference quotient for this function
given first or write down the general formula
for the difference quotient. That's an F of
x plus h minus f of x over h. I'm going to
compute f of x plus h first, I do this by
shoving in x plus h, everywhere I see an x
in the formula for the function. So that's
going to give me two times x plus h squared
minus x plus h plus three. Notice how I use
parentheses here. That's important, because
I need to make sure I shove in the entire
x plus h for x. So the entire x plus h needs
to be subtracted, not just the x part, so
the parentheses are mandatory. Similarly,
the parentheses here signal that the entire
x plus h is squared as it needs to be, I'm
going to go ahead and simplify a bit right
now, I can multiply out the x plus h squared,
I can go ahead and distribute the negative
sign. So if I multiply out, I'm gonna get
x squared plus XH plus h x plus h squared.
Now I can distribute the two to get to x squared
plus 2x H plus two h x plus two h squared
minus x minus h plus three, these two terms
are actually the same, I can add them up to
get 4x H. And I think that's as simple as
I can get that part. Now, I'm going to write
out F of x plus h minus f of x. So that's
going to be this thing right here, minus f
of x. Again, I need to put the F of X formula
in parentheses to make sure I subtract the
whole thing. I'll distribute the negative.
And now I noticed that a bunch of things cancel
out. So the 2x squared and the minus 2x squared
add to zero, the minus x and the x add to
zero,
and the three and the minus three, add to
zero. So I'm left with 4x H plus two h squared
minus h. Finally, I'll write out the whole
difference quotient by dividing everything
by H. I can simplify this further, because
notice that there's an H in every single term
of the numerator. If I factor out this H,
H times 4x, plus two h minus one divided by
h, these two H's cancel, and I'm left with
a difference quotient of 4x plus two h minus
one. This difference quotient will become
important in calculus, when we calculate the
difference quotient for smaller and smaller
values of h, eventually letting h go to zero,
and ending up with an expression that has
no H's in it, and represents the derivative
or slope of the function itself. In this video,
we use the formula f of b minus F of A over
B minus A to calculate an average rate of
change, and the related formula f of x plus
h minus f of x over h to calculate and simplify
a difference quotient. This video will introduce
the idea of limits through some graphs and
examples. When I worked in San Francisco,
I used to eat at Julia sushi and salad bar
that had an interesting price structure, the
food there cost $10 a pound. But if you happen
to load up your plate to exactly one pound,
you got a free lunch. So let's let y equals
f of x represent the price of your lunch in
dollars as a function of its weight x in pounds.
And I want to write an equation to describe
f of x as a piecewise defined function. It
makes sense to use a piecewise defined function.
Because there are two situations, the weight
x could be exactly one pound, or it could
be different from one pound. If the weight
is exactly one pound, then f of x The price
is zero. But if x is different from a pound,
then the price is 10 times x as a graph, my
function is going to follow the line y equals
10x. But when x is exactly one, my function
is going to have a value of zero and not 10.
The open circle here represents a hole or
a place where a point is missing on the graph.
Now when x is near one, but not equal to one,
then the F of X values that is the y values
are very close to 10. In the language of limits,
we say that the limit as x approaches one
of F have x is equal to Ted. More informally,
we can write, as x approaches one, f of x
approaches 10. Notice that the value of f
at one is actually equal to zero, not 10.
And so the limit of f of x as x goes to one,
and the value of f at one, are not equal.
This illustrates the important fact that the
limit here as x goes to one doesn't care about
the value of f, at one, it only cares about
the value of f, when x is near one, in general,
for any function f of x, and for real numbers,
a and L, the limit as x goes to a of f of
x equals L means that f of x gets arbitrarily
close to L, as x gets arbitrarily close to
a, in other words, as x heads towards a, f
of x heads towards L. Let me draw this as
a picture. In this picture, I can say that
the limit as x goes to a of f of x is L. Because
by taking a sufficiently small interval around
a of x values, I can guarantee that my y values,
my f of x values lie in an arbitrarily small
interval around L. Now the limit doesn't care
about s value at exactly a. So if I change
the function, if I change the functions value
at a, or even leave the function undefined
at a, the limit is still L. But the limit
does care about what happens for x values
on both sides of a.
If, for example, the function didn't even
exist for x values bigger than a, then we
could no longer say that the limit, as x approached
a was out, the limit would not exist. In other
words, the limit of f of x is L, only if the
y values are approaching now, as x approaches
a from both the left and the right. For the
function g of x graph below, the limit as
x goes to two of g of x does not exist. Because
the y values approach one as the x values
approach two from the left and the y values
approach three, as the x values approach two
from the right. Although the limit doesn't
exist, we can say that the left sided limit
exists. And we write this as limit as x goes
to two from the left of g of x is equal to
one. The superscript minus sign here means
that x is going to two from the left side.
In other words, the x values are less than
two and approaching two. Similarly, we can
talk about right sided limits. In this example,
the limit as x goes to two from the right
side of g of x is three. And here, the superscript
plus side means that we're approaching two
from the right side. In other words, our x
values are greater than to and approaching
to. In general, the limit as x goes to a minus
of f of x equals L means that f of x approaches
L, as x approaches a from the left, and the
limit as x goes to a plus of f of x equals
our means that f of x approaches our as x
approaches a from the right limits from the
left or from the right are also called one
sided limits. In this last example, let's
look at the behavior of y equals h of x graph
below when x is near negative two. As x approaches
negative two from the right, our Y values
are getting arbitrarily large, larger than
any real number we might choose. We can write
this in terms of limits by saying the limit
as x goes to negative two from the right of
h of x is equal to infinity. As x approaches
negative two from the left, the y values are
getting smaller. In fact, they go below any
negative real number we might choose. In terms
of limits, we can say that the limit as x
goes to negative two from the left of h of
x is negative infinity. In this example, the
limit of h of x as x goes to negative two,
not specifying from the left or the right
means we have to approach negative two from
both sides. And so this limit does not exist,
because the limits from the left and the limit
from the right are heading in opposite directions.
I want to mention that some people say that
the limits from the right and the limits from
the left also do not exist. Because the functions
don't approach any finite number. I prefer
to say that these limits do not exist as a
finite number. But they do exist as infinity
and negative infinity. This video introduced
the idea of limits, and one sided limits and
infinite limits. This video gives some examples
of when limits fail to exist. For this function,
f of x graph below, let's look at the behavior
of f of x in terms of limits, as x approaches
negative one, one, and two. Let's start with
x approaching negative one. When x approaches
negative one from the last, the y value is
going to be approaching about one half. When
x approaches negative one from the right,
the y values sandvi, approaching one. So when
x approaches negative one, and we don't specify
from either the left or the right, we can
only say that the limit does not exist, because
these two limits from the left and right are
not equal.
Now let's look at the limit as x is approaching
one. This time, we approach from the left,
we get a limiting y value of two, we approach
from the right, the y values are going towards
two. So both of these left and right limits
are equal to
and therefore the limit as x goes to one of
f of x equals two. That's true, even though
f of one f of one itself does not exist. The
limit doesn't care what happens at exactly
x equals one just what happens when x is near
one.
Finally, let's look at the limit as x goes
to two. So here on the left side, the limit
is going to negative infinity. And on the
right side, it's negative infinity. So we
can say the limit as x goes to two is negative
infinity. Or we can also say that the limit
as x goes to two does not exist. This is the
correct answer. This is a better answer because
it carries more information. What values of
x does a limit of f of x fail to exist? Well,
let's see. Negative one and two are the only
two values. Let's talk about the ways that
limits can fail to exist, we've seen at least
a couple different ways. So we've seen examples
where the limit from the left is not equal
to the limit from the right. Here's our number
a where we're calculating the limit at. So
that's one example we've seen. We've also
seen examples where they're vertical asymptotes.
There's a vertical asymptote here at a, that
limit fails to exist because of the unbounded
behavior because the y values are going off
to infinity. There's one other way that limits
can fail to exist that comes up, sometimes
not quite as frequently. And that's wild behavior.
Not a technical term,
just to descriptive term.
Let's look at an example that has this wild
behavior, forcing a limit not to exist. And
the one of the most classic examples as the
limit as x goes to zero of sine pi over x
or sometimes you'll see sine one over x. If
you graph this on your graphing calculator
and zoom in near x equals zero, you're gonna
see something that looks roughly like this.
It just keeps oscillating up and down and
up and down, as x goes towards zero As x goes
towards zero, pi over x is getting bigger
and bigger. And you're going to go through
these oscillations between one and negative
one for the faster and faster.
From the other side, when x is negative, you'll
see a similar kind of behavior just oscillating
faster and faster. As x goes to zero,
here, this top values up here at one, and
the bottom value of these are all supposed
to hit it negative one. Now, when you try
to decide what the limit is, as x goes to
zero, well, the y values are going through
all possible real numbers and between negative
one and one infinitely often as x goes to
zero, so there's no single number that the
limit can settle at. And so the limit as x
goes to zero, of sine pi over x does not exist.
In this video, we saw three types of examples
when limits fail to exist, they can fail to
exist because the one sided limits on the
left and the right are not equal. Or they
can fail to exist because of vertical asymptotes.
Also, limits can fail to exist when there's
wild behavior. And the function fails to settle
down at any single value. This video is about
limit laws, rules for finding the limits of
sums, differences, products, and quotients
and functions. Let's start with an example.
Suppose that the limit as x goes to seven
of f of x is 30. And the limit as x goes to
seven of g of x is two. What's the limit as
x goes to seven of f of x divided by negative
three times g of
x.
Wilson's f of x is heading towards 30. And
g of x is heading towards two, it makes sense
that the quotient should head towards 30 divided
by negative three times two, or negative five.
in calculating this limit, by plugging in
numbers for the components, we were actually
using the limit loss, which are now state.
Suppose that c is a constant, just some number,
and that the limits as x goes to a of f of
x and g of x exist as finite numbers that
is not as limits that are infinity or negative
infinity. Then the limit of the sum f of x
plus g of x is equal to the limit of f of
x plus the limit of g of x. In other words,
the limit of the sum is the sum of the limits.
Similarly, the limit of the difference is
the difference of the limits. The limit of
C times f of x is just c times the limit of
f of x. And the limit of the product is the
product of the limits. The limit of the quotient
is the quotient of the limits, provided that
the limit of g of x is not equal to zero.
Since we can't divide by zero. Let's use these
limit laws in an example, to find the limit
as x goes to two of x squared plus 3x plus
six divided by x plus nine. Well, the limit
rule about quotients allows us to rewrite
this limit of a quotient as a quotient of
limits, provided that the limits of the numerator
and denominator exist, and that the limit
of the denominator is not zero. But we'll
see in a moment that these conditions do in
fact hold. Next, we can use the limit rule
about sums to rewrite the numerator as a sum
of limits. And we can rewrite the limit in
the denominator also as a sum of limits. Next,
we can use the limit rule about products to
rewrite the limit of x squared as the square
of the limit. That's because x squared is
really x times x. And so the limit of x squared
is really the limit of x times x, which by
the product rule is a limit of x times the
limit of x, which is the limit of x quantity
squared. Going back to the original problem,
we can now use the limit rule about multiplying
by a constant to rewrite the limit of three
times x as three times the limit of x. And
I'll just carry the rest forward. Now that
we've got things broken down into bite sized
pieces, we can start evaluating some limits.
Notice that the limit as x goes to two of
x is just two, because as x heads towards
2x, heads towards two, so we can replace all
these limits of access by just the number
two. So we get two squared plus three times
two. Now notice that the limit as x goes to
two of six, well, six doesn't have any x's
in it. So as x two heads towards to six days
at six, and the limit here is just six. So
in my original problem, I can replace the
set limit of six with six. And on the denominator
here, I get to plus nine. And after a little
arithmetic, this simplifies to 16/11. Notice
that we could have gotten this answer a lot
faster, just by substituting in the value
of two into our original expression. And in
fact, that's the beauty of the lemon laws,
they allow us to evaluate limits of rational
functions, just by plugging in the number
that x is going towards, as long as plugging
in that number doesn't make the denominator
zero. It's not nearly so simple. When plugging
in the value does make the done at zero. And
in the future, we'll build up a bunch of algebraic
techniques for handling the situation. In
this video, we've talked about the limit loss.
It's important to note, these limit laws only
apply if the limits of the component functions
actually exist as finite numbers.
If the limit of one or both of the component
functions don't exist, then a limit rules
just simply don't apply. And instead, we have
to use other techniques to try to evaluate
the limit of a sum, difference product or
quotient. This video is about the squeeze
theorem, which is another method for finding
limits. Let's start with an example. Suppose
we have a function g of x. We don't know much
about it. But we do know that for x value
is near one, g of x is greater than or equal
to four times the square root of x drawn here
in red, and less than or equal to 3x squared
minus 4x plus five, drawn here in blue. So
on the picture, G has to lie between the red
and the blue curves for x values near one,
it could look something like this. What can
we say about the limit of g of x as x goes
to one? Well, if you notice, the red curve
and the blue curve have the exact same limit
of four as x goes to one. And since the green
curve is squeezed in between the red and the
blue curve, its limit must also be for this
example as a special case of the squeeze theorem.
Now, let's say the squeeze theorem in general,
suppose that we have three functions, f of
x g of x and h of x. And let's suppose that
f of x is less than or equal to g of x, which
is less than or equal to h of x, at least
for x values near some number A. this inequality
doesn't necessarily have to hold for x equal
to a, because we're going to be talking about
limits. And limits don't care what happens
when x is exactly a just when x is near a.
Let's suppose also, that like in the previous
example, f of x and h of x have the exact
same limit as x approaches a. So we're going
to suppose that the limit as x goes to a of
f of x is equal to the limit as x goes to
a of h of x. And we'll call this limit. Now.
The picture looks a lot like the previous
example. Again, it doesn't matter exactly
what happens at x equals a, for example, g
of x could have a hole there. And its value
could be for example, way up here. Since g
of x is trapped here in between f of x and
h of x, which both have the same limit l at
a, we can conclude that the limit as x goes
to a of g of x is equal to l also. And that's
the squeeze theorem, also known as the pinching
theorem, and the sandwich theorem, three very
descriptive names that capture the idea of
geovax being trapped here, in between lower
and upper bounds. Now let's use the squeeze
there. To find the limit as x goes to zero
of x squared sine one over x. Now, you might
remember that sine one over x by itself has
this crazy oscillating behavior. In fact,
the limit as x goes to zero of sine one over
x does not exist, because the function never
settles down to a single finite value. At
first glance, you might think the limit of
x squared sine of one over x also wouldn't
exist. In fact, it's tempting to try to use
the product rule and say that the limit of
the product is the product of the limits.
But in fact, the product rule only applies
when the component limits both exist. And
since the second limit doesn't exist, the
product rule tells us absolutely nothing about
whether the limit that we're interested in
exists or doesn't. So we can't use the product
rule. But it turns out, we can use the squeeze
theorem. Now this example is a little trickier
than the first example, because in the first
example, we were told what the upper and lower
bounding functions should be. And in this
example, we have to come up with. But if we
look at a graph of x squared sine one over
x, we can see that it does seem to be trapped
in an envelope here.
Let's use algebra to see what those two bounding
functions might be. Now we know that sine
of one over x is always between one and negative
one, just because sine of anything has between
one and negative one. And if we multiply this
whole inequality by x squared, we get minus
x squared is less than or equal to x squared,
sine one over x, which is less than or equal
to x squared. Notice that x squared is always
positive, so we don't have to worry about
flipping any of the inequality signs when
we multiply by this positive number. So x
squared and minus x squared are good bounding
functions. And if we notice that the limit
as x goes to zero of x squared is zero, and
the limit as x goes to zero of negative x
squared is also zero, we can conclude by the
squeeze theorem, that the limit as x goes
to zero of x squared, sine of one over x is
also zero, because it squeezed in between
these two functions with the same limit. the
squeeze theorem is a great trick for evaluating
limits when you happen to have a function
that you're interested in, trapped in between
two other functions with the same limit. The
example in this video is a classic example,
where we have a crazy oscillating trig function,
multiplied by a power of x, that x is one
of our bounding functions. In this video,
we'll compute a bunch of limits using algebraic
tricks. All these limits are of the zero over
zero indeterminate form kind. Recall that
this means that the limits are of the form
the limit of f of x over g of x where the
limit of f of x equals zero and the limit
of g of x also equals zero. For a first example,
let's look at the limit as x goes to one of
x cubed minus one over x squared minus one.
Notice that the numerator and the denominator
are both going to zero as x goes to one. To
calculate this limit, we want to simplify
this expression. And one way to simplify it
is to factor it. So let's rewrite this as
the limit as x goes to one of x minus one
times x squared plus x plus one. We're factoring
the numerator here is a difference of cubes.
We can also factor the denominator as a difference
of squares, x minus one times x plus one.
Now, as long as x is not equal to one, we
can cancel out these two factors of x minus
one. And so the limit of this expression is
just the same as the limit of this expression.
Now we can just plug in one, because plugging
in one gives us a numerator of three and a
denominator of two. And that way, we've evaluated
our limits. Next, let's look at the limit
of five minus z quantity squared minus 25.
All divided by z. Once again, when we plug
in x equals zero in the numerator, we get
zero and then nominator we also get zero.
This time instead of factoring, the trick
is going to be to multiply out. So let's rewrite
this limit as the limit as t goes to zero
of
25 minus 10 z plus z squared minus 25. I just
distributed to get this expression divided
by z. Since 25 minus 25 is zero, I just have
the limit as t goes to zero of negative 10
z plus c squared over
z.
Now what? Well, I could factor out the Z here.
One z is not zero, I can cancel here. So my
original limit is the same as this limit.
Plugging in z equals zero, I just get negative
10 as my answer. This third example is also
a situation where the numerator is going to
zero, and the denominator is also going to
zero. In this case, I'm going to try to simplify
the expression by adding together the fractions
and the numerator. So I'll need a common denominator,
which is r plus three, times three. So rewriting,
I get the limit of one over r plus three,
I multiply that by three over three, in order
to get the appropriate common denominator,
minus 1/3, which I have to multiply by R plus
three over r plus three, all that over are
continuing to rewrite, I have in the numerator,
adding together these fractions mature, have
the denominator of R plus three times three,
I get three minus quantity r plus three. And
then this entire fraction is still divided
by our distributing the negative sign, I have
three minus r minus three divided by R plus
three times three, all divided by R. three
minus three is zero. So I can rewrite this
as negative r over r plus three, times three.
And now instead of dividing by r, which is
r of r one, I can multiply by the reciprocal,
one over R. R divided by R is one. So this
expression simplifies to negative one, over
r plus three, times three. So finally, I'm
in a good position, because now I can just
go ahead and let our go to zero. And by plugging
in R equals zero, I have a limit of negative
one over zero plus three times three, or negative
one, nine. This example is a little tricky,
because involve square roots can be hard to
deal with. Well, there's one nice trick for
dealing with square roots that works here,
which is the conjugate. So I'm going to take
the expression that we're given, and multiply
by the conjugate of the numerator, in this
case, because the numerator is the place where
the square root is by the conjugate of A minus
B, I just mean a plus b conjugate of A plus
B is a minus b. Well, of course, if I multiply
on the numerator, by something, I also have
to multiply the denominator by the same thing,
so that I won't alter the value of the expression.
So this limit here is equal to the limit of
the expression down here that looks more complicated,
than in a moment, if we're lucky, things will
clear up and become simpler. So Multiplying
the numerators across, I get the square root
of x plus three squared.
I get
plus two times the square root of x plus three
minus two times the square root of x plus
three minus four. On the denominator, I get
x times the square root of x plus three
plus
2x minus the square root of x plus three minus
two. Let's see what simplifies here. So the
square root of x plus three squared is just
x plus three. And I see that this expression
and this expression are opposites, so they
subtract to zero here. So on the numerator,
I just have x plus three, and then I still
have the minus four on the denominator, nominator
looks a little messy. I'll just copy it over
for now. Okay, so on my numerator, I'm getting
x minus one. Notice that when x goes to one,
that numerator is still going to zero. And
in fact, as I let x go to one, that denominator,
if I plug in here, everything is gonna also
cancel out to zero. So I still got a zero
over zero indeterminate form. But maybe I
can use one of the previous tricks of factoring.
Because look at here, if I factor an X out
of these two expressions as a square root
of x plus three out of these two expressions,
and I could maybe factor a two out of these
two, factoring by grouping, let's try that.
So we have x squared of x plus three times
x minus one from these two expressions, and
then I have a plus two times x minus one.
From these two expressions, this is looking
promising. So now I've got an x minus one
on the top. And if I factor out the x minus
one from each of these two expressions, I'm
going to have an x minus one on the bottom
times the square root of x plus three, plus
two. Now, for x values near one, but not equal
to one, I can cancel those. And my limit simplifies
to just one over square root of x plus three
plus two, plugging in one, I get a one on
the numerator, and square root of four, which
is two plus two, four on the denominator,
and we have calculated this limit. Last example
here, another zero over zero indeterminate
form. Anytime I see an absolute value, I'm
going to want to take cases, because the absolute
value of X plus five naturally follows in
the cases, if X plus five is greater than
zero, in other words, x is greater than negative
five, then the absolute value of this positive
number is just
itself.
On the other hand, if X plus five is less
than zero, in other words, x is less than
negative five, than the absolute value of
a negative number is its opposite. And we
make the expression x plus five, turn it into
its opposite by putting a negative sign in
front. Now let's look at one sided limits.
As x goes to negative five from the left,
we have
a situation where x is less than negative
five, this situation right here. And so we
can rewrite the absolute value by taking the
negative of the expression. We still have
a zero over zero and determinant form. But
if we use the old factoring trick,
factor out a two cancel, we got the limit
of two over negative one, which is just negative
two.
We do the same exercise on the right side.
When we're on the right, then x is greater
than negative five. So we're in this situation
here, where we can just replace the absolute
value with the stuff inside and again factoring
the numerator and canceling the X plus five
We just get a limit
of two.
So we have a left limit, and a right limit
that are different. And so in this example,
the limit does not exist. So we've seen a
five different kinds of limits all of the
zero or zero indeterminate form. And we've
used five different methods to evaluate them.
For the first example, we use factoring. For
the second example, do the opposite of factoring,
we multiplied out. For the third example,
we added together our rational expressions
to simplify things. The next example uses
the old multiply by the conjugate trick. And
the last example, we used cases and looked
at one sided limits.
The limit law about quotients tells us that
the limit of the quotient is the question
of the limit, provided that the limits of
the component functions actually exist, and
that the limit of the function on the denominator
is not equal to zero. But what happens if
the limit of the function on the denominator
is equal to zero? This video will begin to
answer that question. In fact, there are two
different situations we'll want to consider.
It could be that even though the limit on
the denominator is equal to zero,
the limit on the numerator exists and is not
equal to zero. Or it could happen that both
limits are zero. We'll focus on the first
situation, first starting with an example.
And we'll look at the second situation later
on.
In this example, the limit of the numerator,
negative 4x is just negative 12, which we
can see by plugging in three for x. But the
limit as x goes to three of the denominator
is zero. So we're exactly in one of these
situations where the numerator goes to a finite
nonzero number, but the denominator goes to
zero. Let's see what happens as we approach
three from the left first. As we approach
three from the left, x is going through numbers
that are slightly less than three numbers
like 2.9 2.99 2.999, and so on. If we plug
in those numbers into the expression, here
on our calculator, we didn't get answers of
116 1196, and 11,996. If even without a calculator,
we could approximate these answers pretty
closely by just thinking about the fact that
since x is very close to three, the numerator
is about negative four times three, so about
negative 12. The denominator 2.9 minus three
is negative 0.1. That quotient of two negative
numbers gives us a positive value of 120.
Similarly, we could approximate the value
when x is 2.9 times as almost negative 12
divided by 0.01, which is 1200. And approximate
the third value as 12,000. Either way, we
do it exact answers on our calculator or approximations
in our head when noticing that these values
are positive numbers that are getting larger
and larger as x goes towards three from the
left. This makes sense. Because if we look
at our expression, as x goes towards three
from the left, the numerator is getting close
to negative 12, which is a negative number.
And the denominator, since x is less than
three will always be a small negative number,
negative over negative is a positive. And
as x is getting really close to three, those
denominators are getting smaller and therefore
the fractions are getting bigger and bigger
in magnitude. So we can conclude that our
limit is positive infinity. We can make a
similar argument By looking at the limit,
as x goes to three from the positive side,
it's supposed to be an X minus three here.
So now x is going through a value is slightly
bigger than three 3.1 3.01 3.01. And again,
we can plug directly into our calculator and
figure out the answers are negative 124. Negative
1204, negative 12,004. Or we can make a similar
approximating argument. This answer is approximately
negative 12 over a positive point one, which
is negative 120, and so on. Like before, if
we consider the signs of our numerator and
denominator, we can see that as x goes to
three, our numerator is a negative number.
But our denominator is a positive number,
since we're approaching three from the right
where x is bigger than three, and therefore,
our quotient is a negative number, it's still
getting bigger and bigger in magnitude as
x goes towards three, because the denominator
is still getting tinier and tinier, while
the numerator stays pretty close to negative
12. So in this case, we're getting a negative
number that's bigger and bigger magnitude,
so that makes a limit of negative infinity.
Now, since our limit on the left is infinity,
and our limit on the right is negative infinity,
the only thing we can say about the limit
as x goes to three
is that it does not exist. Now let's look
at another example. The limit as x goes to
negative four of 5x, over the absolute value
of x plus four, notice that the limit of the
numerator is just negative 20 by plugging
in negative four for x, and the limit of the
denominator is zero. Because we've got an
absolute value in our expression, here, it's
screaming out at us to look at cases. Remember
that the absolute value of x plus four is
going to equal just x plus four, if x plus
four is positive, in other words, if x is
greater than negative four, however, if x
is less than negative four, then the expression
x plus four will be negative. So taking the
absolute value has to switch at sign in order
to make a negative expression positive. Alright,
so that's going to come in handy when we look
at the limit as x goes to negative four, from
the left, and from the right. So when we approach
negative four from the left, x is going to
be less than negative four. So we're going
to be in this situation here, where the absolute
value gives us the opposite sign. That means
that the limit as x goes to negative four
minus of this expression, the same as the
limit of 5x over negative x plus four. Now
reasoning as before, as x is going to negative
four from the left, the numerator here is
a negative number. Pretty close to negative
20. The denominator, since x is less than
negative 4x plus four is negative, the negative
of it is positive. So our quotient is negative.
And since denominator is getting really tiny,
while the numerators will pretty level at
at negative 20. This limit is going to be
bigger and bigger magnitude a limit of negative
infinity. Now let's look at the limit as x
goes to negative four from the right, in this
case, x is just a little bit bigger than negative
four. So we're in this case where the absolute
value doesn't change the expression. So we
can rewrite this As 5x
over x plus four,
now the numerator is still gonna be a negative
number, the denominator, since x is slightly
bigger than negative four, slightly to the
right, this expression is going to be positive
number. Negative or over a positive is a negative.
And again, since the denominator is getting
tiny, the fractions getting huge in magnitude.
And so this limit is negative infinity. Now,
in this case, look at what's going on, we've
got a negative infinity limit on the left
and a negative infinity limit on the right.
So we can conclude that the limit as x goes
to negative four of 5x, over the absolute
value of x plus four is equal to negative
infinity. In fact, we can confirm that by
looking at a graph. If we look, check out
the graph near x equals negative four, it's
gonna look something like this, with a vertical
asymptote at x equals negative four, like
expected. So we've seen that if the limit
of f of x is equal to something that's not
zero, and the limit of g of x is equal to
zero, then the limit of the quotient could
be negative infinity as it was in the past
example. It could also be infinity, or it
could just not exist. supposed to say does
not exist, if the one sided limits are infinity
on one side, and negative infinity on the
other. Now, what about this second situation
that I mentioned the beginning when the limit
of f of x is zero, and the limit of f of g
of x is zero? What can we say about the limit
of the quotient in this situation? Well, in
fact, in this situation, the limit of the
quotient, it could exist and be any finite
number, or infinity, or minus infinity, or
it could not exist at all. In fact, in this
sort of situation, which is called a zero,
or zero indeterminate form, anything could
happen. Which makes it in some ways the hardest,
but in some ways, the most fun situation of
all. So in another video, we'll talk about
techniques for dealing with 00 indeterminate
forms, and how to use algebra and other simplification
techniques to evaluate these these mysterious
limits. So in this video, we've looked at
the limits of quotients, when the limit of
the denominator is zero. We've done some examples
when the limit of the numerator was not zero,
but the limit of the denominator was zero.
And we saw that these situations corresponded
to vertical asymptotes, and gave us an answer
for the limit of the quotient of infinity,
or negative infinity, or sometimes infinity
on one side and negative infinity on the other.
We also hinted at fun things to come when
we look at the limits in this situation when
the numerator and the denominator are both
heading towards zero. And when anything can
happen. This video is about graphs and equations
of lines. Here we're given the graph of a
line, we want to find the equation, one standard
format for the equation of a line is y equals
mx plus b. here, m represents the slope, and
B represents the y intercept, the y value,
where the line crosses the y axis, the slope
is equal to the rise over the run. Or sometimes
this is written as the change in y values
over the change in x values. Or in other words,
y two minus y one over x two minus x one,
where x one y one and x two y two are points
on the line.
While we could use any two points on the line,
to find the slope, it's convenient to use
points where the x and y coordinates are integers.
That is points where the line passes through
grid points. So here would be one convenient
point to use. And here's another convenient
point to use. The coordinates of the first
point are one, two, and the next point this
is let's say, five negative one. Now I can
find this slope by looking at the rise over
the run. So as I go through a run of this
distance, I go through a rise of that distance,
especially gonna be a negative rise or a fall
because my line is pointing down. So let's
see counting off squares, this is a run of
1234 squares and a rise of 123. So negative
three, so my slope is going to be negative
three, over four. I got that answer by counting
squares. But I could have also gotten it by
looking at the difference in my y values over
the difference of my x values. That is, I
could have done negative one minus two, that's
from my difference in Y values, and divide
that by my difference in x values, which is
five minus one, that gives me negative three
over four, as before, so my M is negative
three fourths. Now I need to figure out the
value of b, my y intercept, well, I could
just read it off the graph, it looks like
approximately 2.75. But if I want to be more
accurate, I can again use a point that has
integer coordinates that I know it's exact
coordinates. So either this point or that
point, let's try this point. And I can start
off with my equation y equals mx plus b, that
is y equals negative three fourths x plus
b. And I can plug in the point one, two, for
my x and y. So that gives me two equals negative
three fourths times one plus b, solving for
B. Let's see that two equals negative three
fourths plus b. So add three fourths to both
sides, that's two plus three fourths equals
b. So b is eight fourths plus three fourths,
which is 11 fourths, which is actually just
what I eyeballed it today. So now I can write
out my final equation for my line y equals
negative three fourths x plus 11 fourths by
plugging in for m and b. Next, let's find
the equation for this horizontal line. a horizontal
line has slope zero. So if we think of it
as y equals mx plus b, m is going to be zero.
In other words, it's just y equals b, y is
some constant. So if we can figure out what
that that constant y value is, it looks like
it's to let's see, this three, three and a
half, we can just write down the equation
directly, y equals 3.5. For a vertical line,
like this one, it doesn't really have a slope.
I mean, if you tried to do the rise over the
run, there's no run. So you'd I guess you'd
be divided by zero and get an infinite slope.
But But instead, we just think of it as an
equation of the form x equals something. And
in this case, x equals negative two, notice
that all of the points on our line have the
same x coordinate of negative two and the
y coordinate can be anything. So this is how
we write the equation for a vertical line.
In this example, we're not shown a graph of
the line, we're just get told that it goes
through two points. But knowing that I go
through two points is enough to find the equation
for the line. First, we can find the slope
by taking the difference in Y values over
the difference in x values. So that's negative
three minus two over four minus one, which
is negative five thirds. So we can use the
standard equation for the line, this is called
the slope intercept form.
And we can plug in negative five thirds. And
we can use one point, either one will do will
still get the same final answer. So let's
use one two and plug that in to get two equals
negative five thirds times one plus b. And
so B is two plus five thirds, which is six
thirds plus five thirds, which is 11 thirds.
So our equation is y equals negative five
thirds x plus 11 thirds. This is method one.
method two uses a slightly different form
of the equation. It's called the point slope
form and it goes y minus y naught is equal
to m times x minus x naught where x naught
Why not is a point on the line, and again
is the slope. So we calculate the slope the
same way, by taking a difference in Y values
over a difference in x values. But then we
can simply plug in any point. For example,
the point one, two will work, we can plug
one in for x naught and two in for Y not in
this point slope form, that gives us y minus
two is equal to minus five thirds x minus
one. Notice that these two equations, while
they may look different, are actually equivalent.
Because if I distribute the negative five
thirds, and then add the two to both sides,
I get the same equation
as above.
So we've seen two ways of finding the equation
for the line is in the slope intercept form,
and using the point slope form. In this video,
we saw that you can find the equation for
a line if you know the slope. And you know
one point, you can also find the equation
for the line if you know two points, because
you can use the two points to get the slope
and then plug in one of those points. To figure
out the rest of the equation. We saw two standard
forms for the equation of a line the slope
intercept form y equals mx plus b, where m
is the slope, and B is the y intercept. And
the point slope form y minus y naught equals
m times x minus x naught, where m again is
the slope and x naught y naught is a point
on the line. This video is about rational
functions and their graphs. Recall that a
rational function is a function that can be
written as a ratio or quotient of two polynomials.
Here's an example. The simpler function, f
of x equals one over x is also considered
a rational function, you can think of one
and x as very simple polynomials. The graph
of this rational function is shown here. This
graph looks different from the graph of a
polynomial. For one thing, its end behavior
is different. The end behavior of a function
is the way the graph looks, when x goes through
really large positive, or really large negative
numbers, we've seen that the end behavior
of a polynomial always looks like one of these
cases. That is why marches off to infinity
or maybe negative infinity, as x gets really
big or really negative. But this rational
function has a different type of end behavior.
Notice, as x gets really big, the y values
are leveling off at about a y value of three.
And similarly, as x values get really negative,
our graph is leveling off near the line y
equals three, I'll draw that line, y equals
three on my graph, that line is called a horizontal
asymptote. A horizontal asymptote is a horizontal
line that our graph gets closer and closer
to as x goes to infinity, or as X goes to
negative infinity or both. There's something
else that's different about this graph from
a polynomial graph, look at what happens as
x gets close to negative five. As we approach
negative five with x values on the right,
our Y values are going down towards negative
infinity. And as we approach the x value of
negative five from the left, our Y values
are going up towards positive infinity. We
say that this graph has a vertical asymptote
at x equals negative five. vertical asymptote
is a vertical line that the graph gets closer
and closer to. Finally, there's something
really weird going on at x equals two, there's
a little open circle there, like the value
at x equals two is dug out. That's called
a hole. A hole is a place along the curve
of the graph where the function doesn't exist.
Now that we've identified some of the features
of our rational functions graph, I want to
look back at the equation and see how we could
have predicted those features just by looking
at the equation. To find horizontal asymptotes.
We need to look at what our function is doing
when x goes through really big positive or
really big negative numbers. Looking at our
equation for our function, numerator is going
to be dominated by the 3x squared term when
x is really big, right, because three times
x squared is going to be absolutely enormous
compared to this negative 12. If x is a big
positive or negative number in the denominator,
the denominator will be dominated by the x
squared term. Again, if x is a really big
positive or negative number, like a million,
a million squared will be much, much bigger
than three times a million or negative 10.
For that reason, to find the end behavior,
or the horizontal asymptote, for our function,
we just need to look at the terms on the numerator
and the term on the denominator that have
the highest exponent, those are the ones that
dominate the expression in size. So as x gets
really big, our functions y values are going
to be approximately 3x squared over x squared,
which is three. That's why we have a horizontal
asymptote at y equals
three. Now our vertical asymptotes, those
tend to occur where our denominator of our
function is zero. That's because the function
doesn't exist when our denominator is zero.
And when we get close to that place where
our denominator is zero, we're going to be
dividing by tiny, tiny numbers, which will
make our Y values really big in magnitude.
So to check where our denominators zero, let's
factor our function. In fact, I'm going to
go ahead and factor the numerator and the
denominator. So the numerator factors, let's
see, pull out the three, I get x squared minus
four, factor in the denominator, that factors
into X plus five times x minus two, I can
factor a little the numerator a little further,
that's three times x minus two times x plus
two over x plus 5x minus two. Now, when x
is equal to negative five, my denominator
will be zero, but my numerator will not be
zero. That's what gives me the vertical asymptote
at x equals negative five. Notice that when
x equals two, the denominators zero, but the
numerator is also zero. In fact, if I cancelled
the x minus two factor from the numerator
and denominator, I get a simplified form for
my function that agrees with my original function,
as long as x is not equal to two. That's because
when x equals two, the simplified function
exists, but the original function does not
it's zero over zero, it's undefined. But for
every other x value, including x values near
x equals two, our original function is just
the same as this function. And that's why
our function only has a vertical asymptote
at x equals negative five, not one at x equals
two, because the x minus two factor is no
longer in the function after simplifying,
it does have a hole at x equals two, because
the original function is not defined there,
even though the simplified version is if we
want to find the y value of our hole, we can
just plug in x equals two into our simplified
version of our function, that gives a y value
of three times two plus two over two plus
seven, or 12 ninths, which simplifies to four
thirds. So our whole is that to four thirds.
Now that we've been through one example in
detail, let's summarize our findings. We find
the vertical asymptotes and the holes by looking
where the denominator is zero. The holes happen
where the denominator and numerator are both
zero and those factors cancel out. The vertical
asymptotes are all other x values where the
denominator is zero, we find the horizontal
asymptotes by considering the highest power
term on the numerator and the denominator,
I'll explain this process in more detail in
three examples. In the first example, if we
circle the highest power terms, that simplifies
to 5x over 3x squared, which is five over
3x. As x gets really big, the denominator
is going to be huge. So I'm going to be dividing
five by a huge, huge number, that's going
to be going very close to zero, and therefore
we have a horizontal asymptote at y equals
zero. In the second example, the highest power
terms, 2x cubed over 3x cubed simplifies to
two thirds. So as x gets really big, we're
going to be heading towards two thirds and
we have a horizontal asymptote at y equals
two thirds. In the third example, the highest
power terms x squared over 2x simplifies to
x over two. As x gets really big, x over two
is getting really big. And therefore, we don't
have a horizontal asymptote at all. This is
going to infinity, when x gets through goes
through big positive numbers, and is going
to negative infinity when x goes through a
big negative numbers. So in this case, the
end behavior is kind of like that of a polynomial,
and there's no horizontal asymptote.
In general, when the degree of the numerator
is smaller than the degree of the denominator,
we're in this first case where the denominator
gets really big compared to the numerator
and we go to zero. In the second case, where
the degree of the numerator and the degree
of the denominator equal, things cancel out,
and so we get a horizontal asymptote at the
y value, that's equal to the ratio of the
leading coefficients. Finally, in the third
case, when the degree of the numerator is
bigger than the degree of the denominator,
then the numerator is getting really big compared
to the denominator, so we end up with no horizontal
asymptote. Finally, let's apply all these
observations to one more example. Please pause
the video and take a moment to find the vertical
asymptotes, horizontal asymptotes and holes
for this rational function. To find the vertical
asymptotes and holes, we need to look at where
the denominator is zero. In fact, it's going
to be handy to factor both the numerator and
the denominator. Since there if there are
any common factors, we might have a hole instead
of a vertical asymptote. The numerator is
pretty easy to factor. Let's see, that's 3x
times x plus one for the denominator, first
factor out an x. And then I'll factor some
more using a guess and check method. I know
that I'll need a 2x and an X to multiply together
to the to x squared, and I'll need a three
and a minus one or also minus three and a
one. Let's see if that works. If I multiply
out 2x minus one times x plus three, that
does give me back my 2x squared plus 5x minus
three, so that checks out. Now, I noticed
that I have a common factor of x in both the
numerator and the denominator. So that's telling
me I'm going to have a hole at x equals zero.
In fact, I could rewrite my rational function
by cancelling out that common factor, and
that's equivalent, as long as x is not equal
to zero. So the y value of my
whole
is what I get when I plug zero into my simplified
version, that would be three times zero plus
one over two times zero minus one times zero
plus three, which is three over negative three
or minus one. So my whole is at zero minus
one. Now all the remaining places in my denominator
that make my denominator zero will get me
vertical asymptotes. So I'll have a vertical
asymptote, when 2x minus one times x plus
three equals zero, that is, when 2x minus
one is zero, or x plus three is zero. In other
words, when x is one half, or x equals negative
three. Finally, to find my horizontal asymptotes,
I just need to consider the highest power
term in the numerator and the denominator.
That simplifies to three over 2x, which is
bottom heavy, right? When x gets really big,
this expression is going to zero. And that
means that we have a horizontal asymptote
at y equals zero. So we found the major features
of our graph, the whole, the vertical asymptotes
and the horizontal asymptotes. Together, this
would give us a framework for what the graph
of our function looks like. horizontal asymptote
at y equals zero, vertical asymptotes at x
equals one half, and x equals minus three
at a hole at the point zero minus one. plotting
a few more points, or using a graphing calculator
of graphing program, we can see that our actual
function will look something like this. Notice
that the x intercept when x is negative one
corresponds to where the numerator of our
rational function or reduced rational function
is equal to zero. That's because a zero on
the numerator that doesn't make the denominator
zero makes the whole function zero. And an
X intercept is where the y value of the whole
function is zero. In this video, we learned
how to find horizontal asymptotes of rational
functions. By looking at the highest power
terms, we learned to find the vertical asymptotes
and holes. By looking at the factored version
of the functions, the holes correspond to
the x values that make the numerator and denominator
zero, his corresponding factors cancel. The
vertical asymptotes correspond to the x values
that make the denominator zero, even after
factoring any any common any common factors
in the numerator denominator. This video focuses
on the behavior of functions and graphs, as
x goes through arbitrarily large positive
and negative values. You may have touched
on these ideas before in the past when you
studied horizontal asymptotes. But in this
video, we'll talk about the same ideas in
the language of limits. In this first example,
what happens to the function f of x drawn
below as x go through larger and larger positive
numbers? Well, the arrow here on the end is
supposed to mean the trend continues. So as
x gets bigger and bigger, the values of y,
that is f of x, get closer and closer to one,
we can write this in the language of limits
by saying the limit as x goes to infinity
of f of x is equal to one. Now what happens
to this function as x goes through larger
and larger negative numbers, by larger and
larger negative numbers, I mean numbers that
are negative but are larger and larger in
magnitude. So for example, negative five,
negative 10, negative 100, and negative a
million and so on. Well, assuming this trend
continues, it looks like f of x, even though
it's oscillating, it's settling down at a
value of two. So we say that the limit as
x goes to negative infinity, of f of x equals
to limits in which x goes to infinity, or
negative infinity are called limits at infinity.
The phrase limits at infinity should be contrasted
with the phrase infinite limits. An infinite
limit means that the y values, or the F of
X values go to infinity, or negative infinity.
limits and infinity correspond to horizontal
asymptotes, as drawn above, while infinite
limits correspond to vertical asymptotes.
The only exception to this when we don't have
a horizontal or vertical asymptote is when
x and f of x are both going infinite at the
same time, we'll see an example of this on
the next page. Let's figure out the limits
of infinity for these two functions, g of
x and h of x. The function g of x is actually
the function e to the minus x, and it has
a horizontal asymptote, heading right here
at y equals zero. So the limit as x goes to
infinity of g of x equals zero. But as we
head to the left, and x goes through larger
and larger negative values, our Y values don't
settle down to a particular finite value,
they get arbitrarily large. And so we say
that the limit as x goes to minus infinity
of g of x is equal to infinity. Now let's
look at the graph of y equals h of x. Please
pause the video for a moment and try to figure
out the limits of infinity for this function.
The limit as x goes to infinity of h of x
is negative infinity. Because as x goes to
infinity, the y values get below or more negative
than any finite number. Now as X goes to negative
infinity, the y values oscillate, and never
settle down at a particular number. So we
say that the limit as x goes to minus infinity
of h of x does not exist. Finally, let's look
at some limits of infinity of functions without
looking at their graphs first, to find the
limit as x goes to infinity of one over x.
Let's think about what happens to one over
x. As x gets bigger and bigger through positive
numbers. As x gets bigger and bigger, one
over x gets smaller and smaller. So the limit
as x goes to infinity of one over x equals
zero. To find the limit of one over x as x
goes to negative infinity, let's look at what
happens as X goes to negative numbers that
are larger and larger in magnitude. Now one
of our x goes through numbers that are negative,
but they're still getting smaller and smaller.
magnitude. So the limit as x goes to negative
infinity of one over x is also zero. We can
use similar reasoning to find the limit as
x goes to infinity of one over x cubed. As
x goes to infinity, x cubed also goes to infinity.
So one of our x cubed has to go to zero. To
find the limit as x goes to infinity of one
over the square root of x, notice that as
x goes to infinity, the square root of x still
goes to infinity. So one over the square root
of x also goes to zero. In other words, both
of these limits are equal to zero. Both of
these examples are actually closely related,
because both have the form of the limit as
x goes to infinity of one over x to the R,
where R is a number greater than zero. In
the second example, the square root of x is
really x to the R, where R is one half. In
fact, the limit as x goes to infinity of one
over x to the R is always equal to zero. Whenever
R is bigger than zero, we can even say the
same thing about the limit as x goes to negative
infinity of one over x to the R. As long as
we avoid exponents, like one half that don't
make sense for negative numbers. But for other
values of r, as x goes to negative infinity,
x to the R is getting bigger and bigger and
magnitude. And so one over x to the R is getting
smaller and smaller and magnitude and heading
towards zero. Notice that this is no longer
true. if r is less than zero, for example,
something like r equals negative two, because
one over x to the minus two is really x squared.
And the limit as x goes to infinity of x squared
is going to be infinity, not zero.
In this video, we looked at examples of limits
as x goes to infinity, and x goes to minus
infinity. And we saw that those limits could
be zero. Any other number, infinity, negative
infinity, or not exist. This video gives some
algebraic techniques for computing the limits
at infinity of rational functions. Let's find
the limit as x goes to infinity of this rational
function. The numerator and the denominator
of this rational function are each getting
arbitrarily large as x goes to infinity. One
way to see this is by estimating the graphs,
the graph of the numerator looks like a parabola
pointing upwards. And the graph of the denominator
looks like some kind of cubic. So something
like this, for both of these graphs, as x
goes to infinity, y also goes to infinity.
So this is an infinity over infinity indeterminate
form. And just like the zero have over zero
indeterminate forms we saw earlier, and infinity
over infinity and determinant form could turn
out to be absolutely anything. So we're going
to use algebra to rewrite this expression
in a different form that makes it easier to
evaluate. Specifically, we're going to factor
out the highest power of x that we can find
from the numerator, and then from the denominator.
In the numerator, I'm going to factor out
the highest power I see in the numerator,
which is x squared. When I factor x squared
out of 5x squared, I get five, when I factor
x squared out of negative 4x, that's like
dividing negative 4x by x squared, so I get
negative four divided by x. You can check
this works by distributing the x squared and
making sure we get back to the original expression.
Now the highest power of x SC, and the denominator
is x cubed. So I'll factor out an x cubed
for each from each of those terms, I get a
two minus 11 over x plus 12 over x squared.
Because factoring out an x cubed is the same
as dividing each term by x cubed and then
writing the x cubed on the side. Now, we can
rewrite again by canceling an x squared from
the top and the bottom to get the limit of
one over x times five minus four over x over
two minus 11 over x plus 12 over x squared.
Now as x goes to infinity, four over x goes
to zero, because I'm dividing for by larger
and larger numbers. Similarly 11 over x goes
to zero, and 12 over x squared goes to zero.
So I end up with one over x, which is itself
going to zero times something that's going
to five halves. So my limit is going to be
zero times five halves, which is just zero.
I've actually been applying limit laws to
do these last steps, which is fine, because
my component limits exist as finite numbers.
Something that wasn't true from my original
expression when I had infinity over infinity.
In this example, we're asked to find the limit
as x goes to negative infinity of a different
rational expression. I encourage you to stop
the video and try it for yourself first. In
this example, the highest power of x in the
numerator is x cubed, and the highest power
in the denominator is also x cubed. Factoring
out the x cubed from the numerator, we get
x cubed times three plus six over x plus 10
over x squared, plus two over x cubed. And
factoring out the x cubed from the denominator,
we get x cubed times two, plus one over X
plus five over x cubed. Now the x cubes cancel,
and all these parts go to zero. So when the
dust clears here, our limit is just three
halves. In this next example, the highest
power in the numerator is x to the fourth,
and the highest power in the denominator is
x squared. So we factor out the x to the fourth
from the numerator and the x squared from
the denominator and cancel as much as we can.
A lot of these pieces are going to zero.
So our limit is the same as the limit of x
squared times one over negative five. As x
goes to negative infinity, x squared is positive
and goes towards positive infinity. multiplying
by negative fifth turns it negative, but doesn't
change the fact that the magnitudes are getting
arbitrarily large. Therefore, our final limit
is negative infinity. Now let's look at the
same three examples again, more informally,
using a heuristic to get the same conclusions.
In the first example, the term 5x squared
dominates the numerator, because x squared
is much larger than x when x is large. In
the denominator, the highest power of x to
x cubed dominates, because x cubed is much
larger than x squared, or x when x is large.
If we ignore all the other terms in the numerator
and denominator, and just focus on the important
terms, which have the highest powers, then
we can rewrite our limit as the limit of 5x
squared over 2x cubed, which is the same as
the limit as x goes to infinity of five over
2x, just by canceling Xs, which is zero as
x goes to infinity. Similarly, if we just
focus on the highest power terms in the numerator
and denominator in the second example, we
get the limit of 3x cubed over 2x cubed, which
simplifies to the limit of three halves, which
is just three halves. In the third example,
the highest power terms are x to the fourth
and negative 5x squared. And we rewrite the
limit using only these highest power terms
and simplify, and we get the limit as x goes
to negative infinity of x squared over negative
five, which is negative infinity as before,
for rational functions, in general, looking
at the highest power terms, lets you reliably
predict the limits that infinity and negative
infinity when the degree of the numerator
is less than the degree of the denominator,
then the limit as x goes to infinity, or negative
infinity, is zero. As an example, one above,
when the degree of the numerator is equal
to the degree of the denominator, then the
limit is just the quotient of the highest
power terms, which is how we got three halves
as the limit in the second example. And finally,
if the degree of the numerator is greater
than the degree of the denominator, then the
limit is going to be plus or minus infinity.
Like it was in the third example. These shortcut
rules are really handy. But it's important
to also understand the technique of factoring
out highest power terms. Since this technique
can be used more generally. This video gave
two methods for computing limits and infinity
of rational functions. First, there's the
formal method of factoring out highest power
terms and simplifying. Second, there's the
informal method of looking at the degree of
the numerator and the degree of the denominator,
and focusing on the highest power terms. In
the past, you may have heard an informal definition
of continuity. Something like a function is
continuous, if you can draw it without ever
picking up your pencil. In this video, we'll
develop a more precise definition of continuity
based on limits. It can be helpful to look
at some examples of functions that are discontinuous,
that is functions that fail to be continuous.
In order to better understand what it means
to be continuous. Please pause this video
and try to draw graphs of at least two different
functions that fail to be continuous in different
ways. One common kind of discontinuity is
called a jump discontinuity. A function has
a jump discontinuity, if its graph separates
the two pieces with a jump in between them.
This particular function can be described
as a piecewise defined function with two linear
equations, f of x equals to x when x is less
than or equal to one, and f of x equals negative
x plus two, when x is greater than one. Another
common kind of discontinuity is called a removable
discontinuity.
You may have encountered these before, when
you learned about rational functions with
holes in them, for example, the function f
of x equals x minus three squared times x
minus four divided by x minus four, which
has a hole when x equals four, and otherwise
looks like the graph of x minus three squared.
This kind of discontinuity is called removable,
because you could get rid of it by plugging
the hole just by defining F to have an appropriate
value when x equals four. So in this case,
you'd want f of x to be the same when x is
not equal to four, but you'd want it to have
the value of one when x equals four. And that
would amount to plugging the hole and making
it continuous. In this original example, our
function had a removable discontinuity because
it wasn't defined when x equals four. But
a function could also have a removable discontinuity,
because it's defined in the wrong place at
x equals four, for example, too high or too
low, to fit the trend of f. a discontinuity
can also occur at a vertical asymptote, where
it's called an infinite discontinuity. For
example, the rational function g of x is one
over x minus two has an infinite discontinuity
at x equals two. Occasionally, you may encounter
a discontinuity is that don't look like any
of these. For example, the graph of the function
y equals cosine of one over X has a wild discontinuity
at x equals zero, because of the wild oscillating
behavior there. So for a function to be continuous
at x equals a, we need it to avoid all of
these problems. To avoid a jump discontinuity,
we can insist that the functions limit has
to exist at x equals a way to avoid a hole
or removable discontinuity, we can insist
that F has to be defined at x equals A to
avoid the other kind of removable discontinuity
in which f of a is defined, but it's in the
wrong place. We can insist that the limit
of f of x as x goes to a has to equal f of
a. Sometimes the definition of continuity
is written with just the third condition,
and the first two conditions are implied.
Notice that these three conditions not only
exclude jump this continuity and removal this
continuity is they also exclude infinite discontinuities
and wild discontinuities. For example, in
our third example, the function can't be continuous
at x equals two, because it fails to have
a limit at x equals two and it fails to have
a value at x equals two. In our wild, this
continuity example, the limit also fails to
exist at x equals zero, so the function can't
be continuous there. So what are the places
where this function f is not in us and why,
please take a moment to think about it for
yourself. The functions not continuous at
negative three, because the function is simply
not defined there, the functions not continuous
at x equals one, because of that jump discontinuity.
In the language of limits, we say that the
limit of f of x does not exist, when x equals
two, the limit of the function exists and
equals three, but the value of the function
is down here at negative one. So the function
is not continuous, because the limit doesn't
equal the value at x equals three, the function
is not continuous, because once again, the
limit doesn't exist. Notice that x equals
negative two. Even though the function turns
a corner, the function still continuous. Because
the limit exists and equals two, and the value
of the function is also two. The function
drawn here is not continuous at x equals negative
two, because the limit doesn't exist at x
equals negative two, the limit from the left
is one, while the limit from the right is
zero. But it is true that the value of the
function at x equals negative two is equal
to the limit of the function from the left
side. That is, f of negative two is equal
to the limit as x goes to negative two from
the left of f of x.
Notice that we can't say the same thing about
the right limit. The limit from the right
is zero, while the value of the function is
one, and those are equal. In this situation,
we say that f is continuous from the left,
but not from the right. By the same reasoning
at x equals one, the function is not continuous,
but it is continuous from the right, because
the limit from the right is equal to the value
of the function. Notice that f is not continuous
from the left here, because the limit from
the left is about one and a half, while the
value of the function is one. In general,
we say that a function f is continuous from
the left at x equals j. If the limit as x
goes to a from the left of f of x is equal
to f of a, and a function is continuous from
the right at x equals a. If the limit as x
goes to a from the right of f of x equals
f of a, in practical terms of function is
continuous from the left if the endpoint is
included on the left piece, and a function
is continuous from the right, if the endpoint
is included on the right piece. This video
gave a precise definition of continuity at
a point in terms of limits. Namely, a function
is continuous at the point x equals a. If
the limit as x goes to a of the function is
equal to the functions value
at A.
In a previous video, we gave a definition
for continuity at a point. In this video,
we'll discuss continuity on an interval and
continuous functions. We say that a function
f of x is continuous on the open interval
BC, if f of x is continuous at every point
in that interval. For x to be continuous on
a closed interval BC, we require it to be
continuous on every point in the interior
of BC, but we just require it to be continuous
from the right at B. And from the left at
sea. We can also talk about f being continuous
on half open intervals. For example, on half
open interval, BC, which is open at B and
closed at sea, or the other way around, or
the happy to open it all from B to infinity
and so on. In all of these cases, we require
F to be continuous on the interior of the
interval, and left or right continuous on
the closed endpoints of the interval
as appropriate.
So on what intervals is this function geovax
continuous? Well, it's continuous. On this
part, the arrows indicate it keeps on going.
So I'd say it's continuous from negative infinity
to negative one, not including the endpoint
negative one. It's also continuous here, and
we can include the endpoint this time. So
this is from negative one to one and Then
again, on this last section, we can't include
one. It's not continuous there. It's not even
defined there. So what kinds of functions
are continuous? What kinds of functions are
continuous everywhere? And by everywhere,
I mean, on the entire real line negative infinity
infinity? Well, polynomials are a great example.
Also, sine x and cosine x, the absolute value
of x is another common example. There are
certainly many other functions that are continuous
on the whole real line. I'll let you see if
you can come up with some more examples. Now,
if we ask the second question, what kinds
of functions are continuous on their domains,
we get a lot more answers, not only polynomials,
but also all rational functions, things like
f of x equals 5x minus two over x minus three
squared times x plus four is a good example
of a rational function, even though it's not
continuous everywhere. Because it's not continuous
when x equals three or negative four, it is
continuous on its whole domain, because three
and four are not in the domain of this rational
function. In addition, all trig functions,
inverse trig functions, log and either the
x functions. And pretty much all the functions
we normally encounter are continuous on their
domains, although their domains are not necessarily
the whole real line. For example, for natural
log of x, the domain is just zero, infinity,
and that's where the function is continuous.
In addition, the sums, differences, products
and quotients of continuous functions are
continuous on their domains, so for example,
y equals sine of x plus the natural log of
x is continuous where it's defined, the compositions
of continuous functions are continuous on
their domains. So for example, the function
y equals ln of sine of x is continuous, where
defined turns out to be a bunch of disjoint
intervals where sine is positive. Since continuity
is defined in terms of limits, it's sometimes
possible to use our knowledge of which functions
are continuous to calculate limits. For example,
if we want to find the limit as x goes to
zero of cosine of x, because cosine is continuous,
we can evaluate this limit just by plugging
in zero for x. And cosine of zero is one.
We're using the definition of continuity here
to say that the limit of the function is equal
to the value of the function. The second example
is a little trickier, because the function
inside is not continuous at x equals two.
In fact, it's not defined at x equals two.
But as X approaches 2x squared minus four
over 2x minus four times pi, can be rewritten
as x plus two times x minus two over two times
x minus two times pi, which is the same thing
as x plus two over two pi. For x not equal
to two. So as X approaches two, this expression
here, approaches two plus two over two times
pi, which is just two pi. In other words,
the limit as x goes to two of x squared minus
four over 2x minus four pi is just two pi.
And therefore, the limit as x goes to two
of cosine of this expression is just cosine
of two pi, which is again equal to one. We're
using here the fact that cosine is continuous,
and a property of continuous functions, which
says that the limit as x goes to a of f of
g of x is equal to f of the limit as x goes
to a of g of x. If f is a continuous function.
In other words, for continuous functions,
you can pass the limit inside the function.
That's all for continuity on intervals and
continuous functions. The intermediate value
theorem says that if f is a continuous function,
on the closed interval a b and if n is any
number, in between F of A and F of Bay, n
f has to achieve that value and somewhere.
In other words, if n is a number between F
of A and F of b, then there has to be a number
c in the interval a, b, such that f of c equals
n. In our example, there are three such possible
values for C, it could be right here, since
f of that number equals n, or it could be
here, or here, I'll just mark the middle one.
The intermediate value theorem can only be
applied to continuous functions. If the function
is not continuous, then it might jump over
and, and never achieve that value. When application
of the intermediate value theorem is to prove
the existence of roots or zeros of equations,
we call that a real root of p of x is a real
number c,
such that P of C is zero, we're going to want
to apply the intermediate value theorem
with n equal to zero. Our polynomial is defined
on the whole real line, not just an interval.
But the trick here is to pick an interval
a b, so that P of A is negative, and P of
B is positive, or vice versa. So that the
intermediate value theorem will tell us that
P has to pass through zero in between. I'm
just going to use trial and error here and
calculate a few values of p. So P of zero
is easy to calculate, P of zero is just seven.
P of one is going to be five minus three minus
12 plus seven, which equals negative three.
So in this very lucky example, the first two
numbers that we pick will work for our A and
B, so we can just let A be equal 01. Because
P of zero is a positive number, and P of one
is a negative number. So actually, the graph
should look a little different. The graph
looks more like this. But in any case, by
the intermediate value theorem, there has
to be a number c, in between, in this case,
zero and one, where our polynomial p achieves
this intermediate value of zero. And that
number See, we don't know what it is, but
we know it somewhere in the interval zero
to one, that value c gives us a real root
for our polynomial. There may be other real
roots, but we've proved there exists at least
one. The intermediate value theorem has lots
of other applications besides finding roots.
For example, suppose you have a wall that
runs in a circle around the castle, and the
height of the wall varies continuously as
a function of the angle. Surprisingly, the
intermediate value theorem can be used to
show there must be somewhere two diametrically
opposite places on the wall with exactly the
same height. So if you can figure out a way
to show this in this video, we stated the
intermediate value theorem, which holds for
continuous functions, and talked about a couple
of applications. This video introduces the
trig functions, sine, cosine, tangent, secant,
cosecant, and cotangent. For right triangles.
For a right triangle with sides of length
A, B and C angle theta as drawn, we define
sine of theta as the length of the opposite
side over the hypothesis. The side that's
opposite to our angle theta has measure a
and I have partners is this side here with
measure C. So that would be a oversee for
this triangle. Cosine of theta is defined
as the length of the adjacent side over the
length of high partners. This side here is
the side adjacent to theta. Of course, the
high partners is also adjacent to theta, but
it's special as the high partners so we don't
think of it as the adjacent side. So that
would be B oversea. tangent of theta is the
opposite side length over the adjacent side
length. So that would be a over b. The pneumonic
to remember this is so A toa. That's sine
is opposite over hypotenuse. Cosine is adjacent
over hypotenuse. And tangent is opposite over
adjacent. In fact, there's a relationship
between tangent and sine and cosine. Namely,
tangent of theta is equal to sine of theta
over cosine of theta. If you want to see why
that's, that's because sine of theta over
cosine of theta is given by sine, which is
opposite over hypotenuse, divided by cosine,
which is adjacent over hypotenuse. If we compute
these fractions by flipping and multiplying,
the high partners, length cancels, and we
just get opposite over adjacent, which is
by definition, tangent of theta. There are
three more trig functions that are defined
in terms of sine, cosine and tangent. First
of all, their sequence of theta, by definition,
that's one over cosine of theta. So it's going
to be one over the adjacent over hypotenuse,
which is the high partners over the adjacent,
which in this triangle is C over B. cosecant
of theta is defined as one over sine theta.
So that's one over the opposite over the hypotenuse,
which is the high partners over the opposite.
And for this triangle, that's going to be
C over a. Finally, cotangent of theta is defined
as one over tan theta, that's going to be
one over opposite over adjacent, flip and
multiply, I get adjacent over opposite birth,
which in this case is b over a. So notice
that the values for cotangent cosecant and
secant are the reciprocals of the values for
tangent, sine and cosine, respectively. Let's
use these definitions to find the exact values
of all six trig functions for the angle theta
in this triangle. I'll start with sine of
theta. That's the opposite of our hypothesis.
Well, for this angle theta, the opposite side
is down here, and as measured to the high
partners has measured five. So sine theta
is two over five. Cosine theta is adjacent
over hypotenuse, but I don't know the value
of this side length. But fortunately, I can
find it using the Fagor in theorem says I
have a right triangle here, I know that a
squared, I'll call this side length A plus
B squared, where b is this other leg of the
triangle is equal to c squared, where c is
the hypothesis. So here I have a squared plus
two squared equals five squared, which means
that a squared plus four equals 25. A squared
is 21. So A is plus or minus the square root
of 21. But since I'm talking about the length
of a side of a triangle, I can just use the
positive answer. Returning to my computation
of cosine theta, I can write it as adjacent,
which is the square root of 21. Over hypotony
News, which is five, tangent theta is the
opposite over the adjacent, so that's going
to be two over the square root of 21. To compute
secant of theta, that's one over cosine theta,
so that's going to be one over square root
of 21 over five, which is five over the square
root of 21. The reciprocal of my cosine value.
cosecant theta is one over sine theta, that's
going to be the reciprocal of my sine, so
five halves, and cotangent theta is one over
a tan theta, so it's going to be the reciprocal
of my 10 value square root of 21 over two.
Finally, we'll do an application. So if we
have a kite that's flying at an angle of elevation
as the angle from the horizontal bar of 75
degrees with a kite length string of 100 meters,
we want to find out how high it is. I'll call
the height Why? Well, we want to relate the
known quantities this angle and this hypothesis
to The unknown quantity, the unknown quantity
is the opposite side of our triangle. So if
we use sine of theta equals opposite of our
hypothesis, then we can relate these known
amounts sine of 75 degrees to our unknown
amount y, which is the opposite and are known
amount of 100 meters. solving for y, this
gives that y is 100 meters times sine of 75
degrees, we can use a calculator to compute
sine of 75 degrees, be sure you use degree
mode and not radian mode, when you type in
the 75. When I do the computation, I get a
final answer of 96.59 meters up to two decimal
places. Notice that we're ignoring the height
of the person in this problem.
To remember the definitions of the trig functions,
you can use the pneumonic, so tau, and the
fact that secant is the reciprocal of cosine
cosecant the reciprocal of sine and cotangent
the reciprocal of tangent. In this video,
I'll use geometry to compute the sine and
cosine of a 30 degree angle, a 45 degree angle
and a 60 degree angle. One way to compute
the sine of a 45 degree angle is to use a
right triangle with a 45 degree angle. This
particular right triangle has I have partners
of length one. Since all the angles of the
triangle have to add up to 180 degrees, and
we already have 90 degrees and 45 degrees,
the remaining angle must also be 45 degrees.
So we have an isosceles triangle with two
sides the same length, I'll call that side
length a. If we want sine of 45 degrees, let's
use this 45 degree angle here, then sine is
opposite over hypotenuse. So if I can figure
out how long this side length is, I'll be
able to compute sine of 45 degrees. Now the
Pythagorean theorem says this side length
squared plus that side land squared equals
I have hotness squared. So we have that a
squared plus a squared equals one squared.
All right, that is two A squared equals one.
So a squared is one half, and a is plus or
minus the square root of one half. Since we're
talking about the length of sides of triangles,
I can just use the positive square root it's
customary to rewrite this as the square root
of one over the square root of two, which
is one over the square root of two, and then
rationalize the denominator by multiplying
the top and the bottom by the square root
of two. That gives me a square root of two
in the numerator, and the square root of two
squared in the denominator, which is the square
root of two over two. So the side lengths
are the square root of two over two. Now I
can figure out the sine of 45 degrees, by
computing the opposite over the hypotenuse.
That's, I'm looking at this angle. So opposite
is square root of two over two hypothesis
one. So the sine of 45 degrees is the square
root of two over two. Cosine of 45 degrees
is adjacent over hypotenuse. That's this side
length over this hypothesis. So that's the
square root of two over two over one again,
what would happen if instead of using this
triangle with hypotony is one, we use this
triangle, also a 4545 90 triangle with hypotony
is five, not quite drawn to scale. Please
pause the video for a moment and repeat the
computation with this triangle. This time,
I'll call the side length B. Pythagoras theorem
tells me b squared plus b squared equals five
squared. So two, b squared equals 25. And
b squared equals 25 over two, B is going to
be the plus or minus the square root of 25
over two again, I can just use the positive
version. And so B is the square root of 25
over the square root of two, which is five
over the square root of two, rationalizing
the denominator, I get five root two over
two. Now, sine of my 45 degree angle is opposite
overhype hotness,
which is
five square root of two over two divided by
five. That simplifies to the square root of
two over two as before, and a similar computation
shows that cosine of 45 degrees is also square
root of two over two as before. This makes
sense because sine and cosine are based on
ratios of sides. And since these two triangles
are similar triangles, they'll have the same
ratios of sides. To find the sine and cosine
of 30 degrees, let's use this 30 6090 right
triangle with hypotony is one. If we double
the triangle, we get an angle of 30 here,
so a total angle of 60 degrees here, and this
angle is also 60 degrees. So we have a 60
6060 triangle, that's an equilateral triangle,
all side lengths are the same. Since this
side length has length one, this side length
is also one. This entire side length is one,
which means this short side of our original
triangle has length one half. Going back to
my original triangle, let's use the Pythagorean
Theorem to find the length of its longer side
x. But agrin theorem says x squared plus one
half squared equals one squared. So x squared
plus a fourth equals 1x squared is three fourths.
And so x is plus or minus the square root
of three fourths is the positive version,
and get the square root of three over the
square root of four, which is the square root
of three over two. Now using our original
triangle, again, let's compute the sine of
this 30 degree angle here. We know that sine
of 30 degrees is opposite of our hypothesis,
the opposite of this angle is one half and
the hypothesis is one. So we get a sine of
one half over one, which is one half cosine
of 30 degrees is adjacent over hypothesis.
So that's the square root of three over two
divided by one. To find sine of 60 degrees
and cosine of 60 degrees, we can actually
use this same green triangle and just focus
on this upper corner angle of 60 degrees instead.
So sine of 60 degrees. Opposite overhype hotness,
but this time the opposite to this angle is
the square root of three over two. Cosine
of 60 degrees adjacent over hypotenuse gives
us one half. I'll summarize the results in
this table below. Notice that a 30 degree
angle corresponds to pi over six radians since
30 degrees times pi over 180 is pi over six.
Similarly, 45 degrees corresponds to pi over
four radians and 60 degrees corresponds to
pi over three radians. I recommend that you
memorize the three numbers one half, root
two over two, and root three over two. And
the fact that one half and root three over
two go together. And root two over two goes
with itself. From that information, it's not
hard to reconstruct the triangles, you know
that a 4545 90 triangle is my sauciest triangle.
So it must have the side lengths were the
same number goes with itself. And a 30 6090
triangle has one side length smaller than
the other. So the smaller side must be one
half and the larger side must be root three
over two since root three is bigger than one
and so root three over two is bigger than
one half. Doing a visual check, you can easily
fill in the angles, the smaller angle must
be the 30 degree angle, and the larger one
must be the 60 degree one. In this video,
we computed the sine and cosine of three special
angles 30 degrees, 45 degrees, and 60 degrees.
This video defined sine and cosine in terms
of points on the unit circle. a unit circle
is a circle with radius one.
Up to now we defined sine and cosine and tangent
in terms of right triangles. For example,
to find sine of 14 degrees in theory, you
could draw a right triangle with an angle
of 14 degrees and then calculate the sign
as the length of the opposite side over the
length of pi partners. But if we use this
method to try to compute sine of 120 degrees,
things go horribly wrong. When we draw this
120 degree angle, and this right angle, there's
no way to complete this picture to get a right
triangle. So instead, we're going to use a
unit circle, that is a circle of radius one.
The figure below illustrates how right triangles
and a unit circle are related. If you draw
right triangles, with larger of hypotenuse
one with larger and larger angles, then the
top vertex sweeps out part of a unit circle.
Let's look at this relationship in more detail.
In this figure, I've drawn a right triangle
inside a unit circle, the high partners of
the triangle is the radius of the circle,
which is one, one vertex of the right triangle
is at the origin, another vertex of the right
triangle is at the edge of the circle, I'm
going to call the coordinates of that vertex
A, B. Now the base of this right triangle
has length a, the x coordinate, and the height
of the right triangle is B, the y coordinate.
If I use the right triangle definition of
sine and cosine of theta, this right here
is the angle theta, then cosine of theta is
adjacent over hypotenuse, so that's a over
one, or a. Notice that a also represents the
x coordinate of this point on the unit circle.
At angle theta from the x axis. I'll write
that down. For sine of theta, if I use the
right triangle definition, that's opposite
overhead partners, so B over one, which is
just B. But B also represents the y coordinate
of this point in the on the unit circle at
angle theta. For tangent theta, if we use
the right side triangle definition, its opposite
over adjacent. So that's B over A, I can think
of that as the y coordinate of the point over
the x coordinate of the point. Now for angles
theta, that can't be part of a right triangle,
because they're too big, they're bigger than
90 degrees, like now I'll call this angle
here theta, I can still use this idea of x
and y coordinates to calculate the sine and
cosine of theta. So if I just mark this point,
on the end of this line at angle theta, if
I mark that to have coordinates x and y, then
cosine theta, I'm still going to define as
the x coordinate of this point, sine theta
as the y coordinate, and tangent theta as
the ratio of the y coordinate over the x coordinate.
When we use this unit circle definition, we
always draw theta starting from the positive
x axis and going counterclockwise. Let's use
this unit circle definition to calculate sine,
cosine and tangent of this angle fee. In our
figure, we have a unit circle. And these numbers
are supposed to represent the x&y coordinates
of this point on the unit circle at the endpoint
of this line segment, that lies at angle fee
for the positive x axis. Sign fee is equal
to the y coordinate cosine fee is equal to
the x coordinate. And tangent of fee is given
by the ratio of the two, which works out to
negative 0.3639 up to four decimal places.
This video gives a method for calculating
sine cosine and tangent in terms of the unit
circle. Starting from the positive x axis,
you draw the angle theta going counterclockwise.
You look at the coordinates of the point on
the circle where that angle ends. And the
cosine of that angle theta is the x coordinate,
sine of theta is the y coordinate, and tangent
of theta is the ratio. This video gives three
properties of the trig function sine and cosine
that can be deduced from the unit circle definition.
Recall that the unit circle definition of
sine and cosine for angle theta is that cosine
theta is the x coordinate. And sine of theta
is the y coordinate for the point on the unit
circle at angle theta. The first property
is what I call the periodic property. This
says that the values of cosine and sine are
periodic with period two pi. And what that
means is that if you take cosine of an angle
plus two pi, you get the same thing as just
if you took cosine of the angle. So when we
write this down, we're assuming that theta
is measured in radians. If we want to measure
theta in degrees, the similar statement is
that cosine of theta plus 360 degrees is equal
to cosine of theta, we can make the same statements
for sine, sine of an angle plus two pi is
equal to sine of the original angle, here,
the angle being measured in radians. If we
want to measure the angle in degrees, the
statement is that sine of theta plus 360 is
equal to sine of theta, we can see why this
is true from the unit circle definition of
sine and cosine. This is our angle theta,
then theta plus two pi, the plus two pi adds
a full turn around the unit circle to our
angle, so we end up at the same place, theta
and theta plus two pi are just two different
names for the same location on the unit circle.
And since sine and cosine give you the y and
x coordinates of that point on the unit circle,
they have to have the same value. Similarly,
if we consider an angle theta, and an angle
theta minus two pi, the minus two pi means
we go the other direction around the unit
circle clockwise, we still end up in the same
place. And therefore, cosine of theta minus
two pi, the x coordinate of that position
is the same thing as cosine of theta, sine
of theta minus two pi is the same thing as
sine of theta, the same statements hold if
we add or subtract multiples of two pi. For
example, cosine of theta plus four pi is still
the same thing as cosine of theta. This time,
we've just gone to turns around the unit circle
and still gotten back to the same place. So
if we want to find cosine of five Pi, that's
the same thing as cosine of pi plus four pi,
which is the same thing as cosine of pi. Thinking
about the unit circle, pi is halfway around
the unit circle. So cosine of pi means the
x coordinate of this point right here. Well,
that point has coordinates negative one, zero,
so cosine of pi must be negative one. If I
want to take sine of negative 420 degrees,
well, that's sine of negative 360 degrees,
minus 60 degrees, which is the same thing
as sine of minus 60 degrees. Thinking about
the unit circle, minus 60 degrees, means I
start at the positive x axis and go clockwise
by 60 degrees that lands me about right here.
And so that's one of the special angles that
has an x coordinate of one half a y coordinate
of negative root three over two. And therefore
sine of negative 60 is negative root three
over two the y coordinate. The next property
I call the even odd property, it says that
cosine is an even function, which means that
cosine of negative theta is the same thing
as cosine of theta, while sine is an odd function,
which means that sine of negative theta is
the negative of sine of theta. To see why
this is true, let's look at an angle theta.
And the angle negative theta. A negative angle
means you go in the clockwise instead of counterclockwise
direction from the positive x axis.
The coordinates of this point by definition,
r cosine theta sine theta, whereas the coordinates
of this point are cosine negative theta, sine
of negative theta. But by symmetry, these
two points have the exact same x coordinate,
and therefore cosine of theta must equal cosine
of negative theta, while their y coordinates
have the same magnitude, but opposite signs.
This one's positive and this one's negative.
Have, therefore, sine of negative theta is
the negative of sine of theta. Let's figure
out if tan of theta isn't even or odd function.
Well, we know that tan of negative theta,
tangent by definition, is sine over cosine.
Well, we know that sine of negative theta
is the negative of sine of theta, whereas
cosine of negative theta is cosine of theta.
Therefore, we're getting negative sign theta
over cosine theta, which is negative tan of
theta. Since tan of negative theta is the
negative of tan of theta, tan theta is an
odd function. The last property on this video
is the Pythagorean property, which says that
cosine of theta squared plus sine of theta
squared is equal to one. A lot of times this
property is written with this shorthand notation,
cosine squared theta plus sine squared theta
equals one. But this notation, cosine squared
theta just means you take cosine of theta
and square it. This property is called the
Pythagorean property, because it comes from
the Pythagorean Theorem. Let me draw a right
triangle on the unit circle. I'll call this
angle theta. So the coordinates of this endpoint
here are cosine theta sine theta. Since this
is supposed to be a unit circle, the hypotenuse
of my right triangle has length one, the base
of my right triangle is just cosine theta,
same thing as the x coordinate of this point.
And the height of my triangle is the y coordinate
of the point sine theta. Now the Pythagorean
theorem says that this side length squared
plus that so that squared equals one squared,
since one squared is the same thing as one,
that gives me the Pythagorean property. But
tigrayan property is handy for computing values
of cosine given values of sine and vice versa.
And this problem, we're told that sine of
t is negative two sevenths. And T is an angle
that lies in quadrant three. When we say the
angle lies in quadrant three, that means the
terminal side of the angle lies here in quadrant
three. One way to find cosine of t is to use
the fact that cosine squared t plus sine squared
t is equal to one. That is cosine of t squared
plus negative 2/7 squared is equal to one,
I can write this as cosine of t squared plus
4/49 is equal to one and so cosine of t squared
is equal to one minus 4/49, which is 4540
nights. taking the square root of both sides,
that goes for the cosine t is plus or minus
the square root of 45 over 49, that's plus
or minus the square root of 45 over seven.
Now since we're in the third quadrant, we
know that cosine of t, which represents the
x coordinate of this point, must also be negative.
Therefore, cosine of t is going to be negative
square to 45 over seven. It's also possible
to solve this problem using the Pythagorean
theorem for right triangles directly. If we
look at the fact that sine of t is negative
two sevenths and ignore the negative sign
for now, we can think of this information
as telling us that we have a right triangle
angle theta, whose opposite side is two, and
whose high partners is seven.
We call this side here a them but Tiger in
theorem says us a squared plus two squared
is seven squared. So a squared plus four is
49. So a squared is 45. And a is plus or minus
the square root of 45. Since I'm worrying
about a triangle, I'm going to use the positive
value. Now, cosine of t is going to be adjacent
over hypotenuse. So that's going to be the
square root of 45 over seven. Now I go back
to thinking about positive and negative signs.
And I noticed that since I'm in the third
quadrant, my co sign is be negative, so I
just stick a negative sign in front. This
alternative solution, this is many of the
same ideas as the previous solution, and ultimately
gets us the same answer. This video gives
three properties of trig functions, the periodic
property, the even odd property, and the Pythagorean
property. This video is about the graphs of
sine and cosine. I want to graph the functions
y equals cosine t and y equals sine t, where
t is in radians, I'm gonna think of this being
the t axis, and this being the y axis. One
way to do this is to plot points. So I'll
fill in this chart, using my knowledge of
special angles on the unit circle. These points
will be easier to graph, if I convert them
all to decimals. Now plot the points for cosine
and connect the dots to get a graph of y equals
cosine t from t equals zero to t equals two
pi. To continue the graph for t values less
than zero or bigger than two pi, I could plot
more points. Or I could just use the fact
that the cosine values repeat. If I add or
subtract two pi to the my angle T, I'll be
at the same place on the unit circle. So my
cosine will be exactly the same. Therefore,
my values of cosine, which are represented
by my y values on this graph, repeat themselves.
For example, when my T value is two pi plus
pi over six about like here, it's cosine is
the same as the cosine of just pi over six.
So I'll take this dot here and repeat it over
here. Similarly, the when t is like two pi
plus pi over four, I get the same value of
cosine is when it's just pi over four. So
this.is going to repeat. And I can continue
repeating all my dots. This one repeats over
here at two pi plus, say pi over three. And
so my whole graph will repeat something like
this. It also repeats on this side, something
like this. Since subtracting two pi from my
t values will also give me the same value
of cosine. We can also plot points to get
a graph for sine and extend it by repetition.
Going forward, I'll usually write the function
sine and cosine as y equals cosine of x and
y equals sine of x. When I read it this way,
notice that x now refers to an angle, while
y refers to a value of cosine, or sine. That's
a different meaning of x and y, compared to
when we're talking about the unit circle,
where x refers to the cosine value, and y
refers to the sine value. Now let's look at
some properties of the graphs of sine and
cosine. The first thing you might notice is
that the graph of cosine and the graph of
sine are super similar to each other. In fact,
you can think of the graph of cosine as just
being the graph of sine shifted to the left
by pi over two. So we can write cosine of
x as the sine function of x plus pi over two,
since adding pi over two on the inside, move
the graph horizontally to the left by pi over
two. Or we can think of the graph of sine
as being constructed from the graph of cosine
by shifting the cosine graph right by pi over
two, that means we can write sine of x as
equal to cosine of x minus pi over two, since
subtracting pi over two on the inside, shifts
the cosine graph to the right by pi over two.
Next, let's look at domain and range. The
domain of sine and cosine is all real numbers.
All right, that is negative infinity to infinity,
but the range is just from negative one to
one. That makes sense, because sine and cosine
come from the unit circle. The input values
for the domain come from angles. And you can
use any numbers and angle positive or negative
as big as you want, just by wrapping a lot
of times around the circle. The output values
for the range, that is the actual values of
sine and cosine come from the coordinates
on the unit circle. And those coordinates
can't be any bigger than one or any smaller
than negative one. So that gives us a range.
As far as even an odd behavior, you can tell
from the graph. Here's cosine, that it's symmetric
with respect to the y axis and so it must
be even. Whereas the graph of sine is symmetric
with respect to the origin and must be odd.
The absolute maximum value have these two
functions is one and the absolute minimum
value is negative one. We can also use the
words midline amplitude and period to describe
these two functions. The midline is the horizontal
line, halfway in between the maximum and minimum
points. Here, the midline is y equals zero,
the amplitude is the vertical distance between
a maximum point and the midline. You can also
think of the amplitude as the vertical distance
between a minimum point and the midline, or
as half the vertical distance between a midpoint
and a max point. For the cosine function and
the sine function, the amplitude is one. A
periodic function is a function that repeats
at regular horizontal intervals. The horizontal
length of the smallest repeating unit is called
the period for Y equals cosine of x, the period
is two pi. Notice that the period is the horizontal
distance between successive peaks, or maximum
points, or between successive troughs, or
minimum points. algebraically, we can write
cosine of x plus two pi equals cosine of x
and sine of x plus two pi equals sine of x
to indicate that the functions repeat themselves
over an interval of two pi and have a period
of two pi. In this video, we graphed y equals
cosine of x and y equals sine of x. and observe
that they both have a midline at y equals
zero, an amplitude of one and a period of
two pi. sine u sort of functions are functions
that are related to sine and cosine by transformations
like stretching and shrinking and shifting.
This video is about graphing these functions.
Let's start by graphing the function, y equals
three sine of 2x. This function is related
to the function y equals sine x. So I'll graph
that first. Now, the three on the outside
stretches this graph vertically by a factor
of three, while the two on the inside compresses
that horizontally by a factor of one half.
If instead I want to graph y equals three
sine 2x plus one, this plus one on the outside
shifts everything up by one unit. Let's compare
the midline amplitude and period of our original
y equals sine x are transformed y equals three
sine 2x. And our further transformed y equals
three sine 2x plus one, the original sine
has a midline at y equals zero, an amplitude
of one and a period of two pi. For the transformed
function, y equals three times sine of 2x.
The two on the inside shrinks everything horizontally
by a factor of one half. So it changes the
period of two pi into a period of one half
times two pi,
which is pi.
Since the two on the inside only affects x
values and horizontal distances, it doesn't
affect the midline, which is a y value, or
the amplitude, which is a vertical distance.
But the three on the outside does affect these
things. Well, in particular, it affects the
amplitude, since everything is stretched out
vertically by a factor of three, the amplitude
of one get stretch to an amplitude of three.
In this case, the midline doesn't actually
change, because multiplying a y value of zero
by three is still a y value of zero. Now on
the third function, we've taken the second
function and added one on the outside, so
that shifts everything up by one. Therefore,
instead of having a midline at y equals zero,
we now have a midline at y equals one. The
amplitude doesn't change though it's still
three because shifting everything up by one
doesn't affect the distance between the mid
mind and the end the maximum point. Also,
the period is still pi since the period is
a horizontal measure, and adding one on the
outside only affects vertical things. Now
next, let's graph the function y equals three
times sine of two times quantity x minus pi
over four. This function is very closely related
to the First function we graphed on the previous
page, that was y equals three sine of 2x.
In fact, if we give the name f of x to that
function, and maybe we can call g of x, this
other function, then we can get g of x by
taking f of x and plugging in x minus pi over
four in for x. In other words, g of x is f
of x minus pi over four. This relationship
gives me an idea for graphing g of x, the
function we want to graph, we can first graph
f of x, we already did that on the previous
page. And then we can shift its graph to the
right by pi over four, because that's what
you do when you subtract a number on the inside
of a function. So here's the graph of y equals
three sine 2x. Recall that it's just the graph
of sine stretched vertically by a factor of
three, and shrunk horizontally by a factor
of one half. Now, to graph the function that
I want, I'm going to shift this graph over
by pi over four to the right. Notice that
since I had my function written in factored
form, I could just read off the horizontal
shift. But if I had written it instead, as
y equals three sine 2x minus pi over two,
which is algebraically equivalent, it would
be easy to get confused and think that I needed
to shift over by pi over two. So it's best
to factor first, before figuring out what
the shift is, we're factoring out the coefficient
of x. If instead, we wanted to graph this
function, same as the one we just graphed,
it's just with a minus one on the outside,
that minus one would just bring everything
down by one. Let's take a moment to look at
midline amplitude, and period for the original
parent function, y equals sine of x, and our
final transformed function, y equals three
sine of two times quantity x minus pi over
four minus one, our original sine function
has midline at y equals zero amplitude of
one and period of two pi. For our transform
function, the three on the outside stretches
vertically, so it makes the amplitude three.
The minus one on the outside shifts everything
down by one. So it brings the midline, y equals
zero, down to Y equals negative one, the two
on the inside, shrinks everything horizontally
by a factor of one half. So the period becomes
one half times two pi, which is pi. Finally,
there's a horizontal shift going on our transformed
function shifts to the right, by pi over four,
this horizontal shift is sometimes called
the phase shift. The function we just analyzed
was y equals three sine 2x minus pi over four
minus one, which could also be written as
y equals three sine 2x minus pi over two minus
one. This is a function of the form y equals
a sine B x minus c plus d, where b is positive.
If we have a function of this form, or the
similar function with cosine in it, then we
know that the midline is going to be at y
equals D. That's because the original midline
of sine or cosine at y equals zero gets shifted
up by D, we know that the amplitude is going
to be a because this A multiplied on the outside
stretches everything vertically by a factor
of A.
to be a little more accurate, we should say
the amplitude is the absolute value of A in
case a is negative. If a is negative, then
that amounts to a vertical reflection or a
reflection over the x axis. We know that the
period of the original sine or cosine is two
pi. And we know that this factor of B amounts
to a horizontal shrink by a factor of one
over B or I guess it could be a horizontal
stretch by a factor of one over b If b is
less than one, so because we're starting with
a period of two pi, and we're multiplying
by one over B, our new period is going to
be two Pi over B. The trickiest thing is the
horizontal shift. And to get that right, I
like to factor out this B for my equation.
So instead of writing y equals a cosine bx
minus c plus d, I'm going to write y equals
A cosine B times quantity x minus c over b
plus d. Similarly, if it's a sine function,
I write y equals a sine B times x minus quantity
c over b plus d, then I can read off the horizontal
shift as C over B. And that'll be a shift
to the right, if C over B is positive and
a shift to the left, if C over b is negative,
this might seem backwards from what you're
used to, but it's because we have that minus
sign there. So if C over B is positive, we're
actually subtracting on the inside. So that
shifts right, if C of b over b is negative
minus a negative is actually adding something,
and that's why it shifts it to the left. So
as one final example, say I wanted to graph
y equals 1/3, cosine of one half x plus three
minus five, that would have a midline at y
equals minus five, an amplitude of 1/3, a
period of two pi divided by one half, which
is four pi, and a horizontal shift. Better
rewrite this horizontal shift of six units
to the left, the horizontal shift is sometimes
called the phase shift. And that's all for
graphs of sinusoidal functions. This video
is about graphing the trig functions, tangent,
secant, cotangent and cosecant. To gain an
intuition for the graph of y equals tangent
of x, I think it's handy to look at the slope
of a line at angle theta on the unit circle.
The slope of this line is the rise over the
run. But the rise is given by sine of theta,
and the run is given by cosine of theta. So
the slope is given by sine theta over cosine
theta, which is simply tan of theta. So if
I want to graph y equals tan of x, I can think
of x as being the angle and y as being the
slope of the line at that angle. Notice if
the angle is zero, the slope is zero. But
as the angle increases towards pi over two,
the slope gets bigger and bigger heading towards
infinity. As the angle goes from zero towards
negative pi over two, the slope is getting
negative and heading towards negative infinity
at exactly pi over two and negative pi over
two, we have a vertical line. And so the slope
is undefined.
Using this information, let's graph a rough
sketch of y equals tan x. Remember, we're
thinking of x as the angle and y as the slope,
we're going to go between an angle of negative
pi over two and pi over two. So we said that
the slope was zero when the angle is zero,
and then it heads up towards positive infinity
as we go towards the angle goes towards pi
over two with an undefined value at pi over
two, it goes negative heading towards negative
infinity as the angle heads towards negative
pi over two, also with an undefined value
at negative pi over two. You can also verify
that for angles slightly bigger than pi over
two, we have the same line as for angles that
are approaching negative pi over two, and
therefore this picture repeats and it turns
out that tangent is periodic With period not
to pi, like sine and cosine, but just pi,
the period of pi makes sense because if you
take a line and rotate it by 180 degrees,
it's the same line with the same slope, and
therefore has the same value of tangents.
In this graph of y equals 10x, notice that
the x intercepts, all right values of x have
the form negative two pi, negative pi, zero,
pi, two pi, etc, you can write that as pi
times k, where k is an integer, that is a
positive or negative whole number or zero.
This makes a lot of sense because tangent
of x is sine of x over cosine of x. And so
you're going to get x intercepts, that's where
y is zero, which is where the numerator is
zero, and sine x is zero, at values of the
form pi, two pi, and so on. From the graph,
you can see the vertical asymptotes are at
values like negative three pi over two, negative
pi over two, pi over two, and three pi over
two, these values can be written as pi over
two times k, where k is an odd integer. Again,
this makes sense from the definition of tangents
since vertical asymptotes, will occur where
the denominator is zero, and cosine x is zero,
at numbers, like negative pi over two pi over
two, three pi over two, and so on, the domain
of tangent is the x axis for which it's defined.
So that's going to be everything except for
the vertical asymptotes, we can write that
as x such that x is not equal to pi over two
times k, for K, an odd integer. The range
or the y values go all the way from negative
infinity to infinity. And the period, as we
mentioned previously, is pi. Since the smallest
repeating unit has a horizontal width of pi,
to graph y equals secant x, I'm going to remember
that secant is one over cosine. So if I start
with a graph of cosine, I can take the reciprocal
of the y values to get the graph of secant,
the reciprocal of one is one, the reciprocal
of zero is undefined, so I'm not going to
have a value at pi over two, negative pi over
two, three pi over two, or negative three
pi over two. When I take the reciprocal of
numbers, just less than one, I'm going to
get numbers just greater than one, but I would
take the reciprocal of positive numbers getting
close to zero, I'm going to get really big
positive numbers going up towards infinity.
Similarly, on the other side, over here, I
have numbers close to zero, but negative,
so their reciprocals will be negative numbers
heading towards negative infinity. The reciprocal
of negative one is negative one. And similarly
here, so I'm getting kind of positive and
negative buckets and upside down buckets as
the graph of my sequence.
Notice that secant has a period of two pi,
which makes sense, since cosine has a period
of two pi, it has a range that goes from negative
infinity to negative one inclusive, and from
one to infinity. That makes sense because
the range of cosine is between one and negative
one, and we're taking the reciprocal of those
values. The domain is everything except for
the vertical asymptotes. Now the vertical
asymptotes are where cosine is zero. So that
is at values of the form pi over two, three
pi over two, etc. That's values of the form
pi over 2k, where k is an odd integer. So
the domain is going to be x values such that
x is not equal to pi over 2k. For K and odd
integer. The x intercepts of secant Well,
it doesn't have any, because you can't take
one over something and get the numbers zero
for your y value. We've seen the graph of
y equals Tana x and y equals secant x. This
is the graph of y equals cotangent x. It looks
similar to the graph of tangent x, it's just
a decreasing function instead of an increasing
one, and it has its vertical asymptotes. And
it's x intercepts in different places. Finally,
this green graph is the graph of y equals
cosecant x. It's related to the graph of sine
x, since cosecant is one over sine x, and
in fact, if I draw the graph of sine x in
between, you can see how it kind of bounces
off. Because it's the reciprocal. I encourage
you to memorize the general shape of these
graphs, you can always figure out the details
by thinking how about how they're related
to the graphs of cosine of x, and sine x.
This video is an introduction to solving trig
equations. Let's start with the equation two
cosine x plus one equals zero, I want to find
all the solutions in the interval from zero
to two pi, and then get a general formula
for all solutions, not just those in that
interval. Let me start by rewriting this equation
to isolate the tricky part, which is cosine
of x. So I'm going to write to cosine x equals
negative one, and then divide both sides by
two. Now I'm looking for the angles x between
zero and two pi, whose cosine is negative
one half. Since negative one half is one of
the special values on the unit circle, I can
use my knowledge of the unit circle, to see
that the angle between zero and two pi must
be either two pi over three, or four pi over
three, my answer needs to include both of
these values. There are no other spots on
the unit circle whose cosine is negative one
half. But there are more angles, because we
can always take one of these angles and add
multiples of two pi to it. So if I want to
find all solutions, I can take these two principles
solutions, two pi over three, and four pi
over three, and simply add multiples of two
pi to them. For example, two pi over three
plus two pi, or two pi over three minus two
pi, two pi over three plus four pi, and so
on. A much more efficient way to write this
is to write two pi over three plus two pi
times k, any integer that is any positive
or negative whole number or zero. Similarly,
I can write four pi over three plus two pi
k, to capture all solutions, based on the
principal solution for pi over three by adding
and subtracting multiples of two pi.
This is my final solution. Next, let's look
at a tricky equation involving tangent. As
usual, I'm going to start out by cleaning
things up and isolating the tricky part, which
in this case is tangent. So let me add tangent
to both sides. That'll give me three, tan
x equals the square root of three. And so
tan x is the square root of three over three.
The square root of three over three looks
suspiciously similar to value the value of
square to three over two, which is a special
value on my unit circle. So my suspicion is
that my unit circle will again help me find
this value of x without a calculator. Recall
that tan x is sine x over cosine x. So I'm
looking for angles on the unit circle between
zero and two pi with a ratio of sine over
cosine will give me square root of three over
three, I actually only need to look in the
first quadrant and the third quadrant, because
those are the quadrants where a tangent is
positive. And I really only need to look at
angles whose either sine or cosine has a squared
of three in it. So by trial and error, I can
see that tan pi over six, which is sine pi
over six over cosine pi over six will give
me one half over root three over two That's
the same thing as one half times two over
three, which is one over root three. If I
rationalize that, I get root three over three,
so that value works. If I try tan of pi over
three, instead, I get root three, which is
not equal to root three over three. So pi
over three doesn't work. Similarly, I can
work out some the values in the third quadrant,
and see that seven pi over six works. But
four pi over three does not. So my answer
to part A includes just the two values, pi
over six, and seven pi over six. Now if I
want to find all solutions, not just those
in the interval from zero to two pi, I noticed
that I can take one of these principal solutions,
and add multiples of two pi to it, because
that'll give me the same angle. So I get pi
over six plus two pi k, and pi over six, sorry,
seven pi over six plus two pi, K, any integer.
This is a correct answer. But it's not as
simple as it could be. Notice that seven pi
over six over here on the unit circle is exactly
pi more than pi over six. So instead of taking
both of these and adding multiples of two
pi to them, I could get all the same answers
by just taking one of them and adding multiples
of pi to it. So a more efficient answer is
to say that x equals pi over six, plus pi
times k, for K any integer. This will still
capture all the same solutions. Because when
k is even, I'll get this family solutions.
And when k is odd, I'll get this family. For
example, when k is one, pi over six plus one
times pi is just the original seven pi over
six. If you think about the fact that tangent
has a period of pi, instead of two pi, it
makes a lot of sense that you should be able
to write the solutions in this form. In this
video, we solved basic trig equations by first
isolating sine, or tangent, or the same thing
would work with cosine. And then using the
unit circle, to find principal solutions.
Principal solutions are just solutions between
zero and two pi. And then adding multiples
of two pi to these principal solutions to
get all solutions. For tangent, we noticed
that it was equivalent to just use one principal
solution and add multiples of pi instead of
two pi. In this video, we'll introduce the
idea of the derivative using graphs, secant
lines and tangent lines.
So I have a function here, drawn in black,
the function is y equals f of x. But actually
here f of x equals x squared. I also have
a tangent line to my function drawn in red.
This tangent line is the tangent line at the
point 1.5 2.25. By a tangent line, I mean
a line that touches the graph of my function
at this one point, and heads off in the same
direction as the function. Well, normally
to compute the slope, we need two points.
But for the tangent line, we really only have
the exact coordinates of this one point, we
could approximate the slope by guessing the
coordinates of some other points on the red
line. But in the long run, we'll end up with
a more accurate estimate if we do something
else. So what we're going to do instead is
we're going to calculate the slope of a secant
line. A secant line is a line that goes through
two points on my graph. So in this case, my
secant line is going through my original point,
and this other point at x equals three. So
that's the point three, three squared or three
nine. Okay, so here's my secant line. To calculate
the slope of my secant line, I use the fact
that slope is rise over run. Or in other words,
it's the change in y over the change in x.
And that's going to be written in function
notation. F of three minus f of 1.5 is giving
me the change in y and three minus one point
gives me the change in x. Wilson's f of x
is x squared, this is the same thing as three
squared minus 1.5 squared over three minus
1.5. So that's just nine minus 2.25, over
1.5, which ends up as 4.5. So 4.5 is the slope
of this second line. Well, the idea here is
that the slope of my secant line is an approximation
of the slope of my tangent line. But in this
example, really the secant line that I've
used, it's, its slope is only a very rough
approximation of the tangent line, not very
accurate, all. So how could I get a better
approximation of the slope of my tangent line?
Well, one thing I could do is I could use
as my second point, instead of using this
point way out here, I could use a point closer
to my first point. So for example, I could
use the point two, f of two. In other words,
the point two, four, as my second point for
my second line, so let me draw that. And let
me calculate its slope, which after some arithmetic
is going to give me an answer of 3.5. Well,
I could continue to pick second points for
my secant line, closer and closer to my first
point. And I should end up with more and more
accurate approximations of my tangent line,
let me make a little chart for this. For my
next secant line, I could take my second point,
something pretty close to 1.5, say 1.6. And
after some arithmetic, I get a slope of 3.1.
To take my second point to be 1.51, that's
going to give me a slope of 3.01, and so on.
To write this more generally, if I take my
second point as x, then the slope of my secant
line is going to be given by again the rise
over the run. So that's going to be f of x
minus f of 1.5 divided by x minus 1.5. Change
in y over the change in x, that's my slope.
Now, there's no reason I necessarily have
to take my second point to be on the right
side of my first point, I could be using stead
points on the left side here. Continue with
my chart, letting my second point be one,
I can do the same computations to get a slope
of a secant line of 2.5. Here, I could get
even closer on the left, say something like
1.4 and get a slope of 2.9, and so on. In
general, if I have a point x f of x, and I
use a secant line through that point in our
original point, I calculate the slope as change
in y over change in x, which is going to be
f of 1.5 minus f of x divided by 1.5 minus
x.
Actually, I can rewrite this a little bit
to make it look more like the expression up
here. If I multiply the numerator and denominator
by negative one, then I can rewrite this as
f of x minus f of 1.5 divided by x minus 1.5.
So that these two expressions look exactly
the same. So the only difference here on my
mind is that over here, I was thinking of
x as being a little bit bigger than 1.5. And
here I'm thinking of x as being a little smaller
than 1.5. But I get the exact same expression
for the slope of the secant line either way.
Now, this process of picking points closer
and closer to our original point from the
left, and from the right, should remind you
of limits. And indeed, the slope of the tangent
line is the limit as x goes to 1.5 of the
slope of my secant lines, which are given
by this expression. This quantity is so important
that's given its own name, it's called the
derivative of f of x at x equals 1.5. So in
other words, the derivative which is written
as f prime at 1.5, is the limit as x goes
to 1.5 of f of x minus f of 1.5 over x minus
1.5. Now based on our numerical tables, for
example, here, we can see that that limit
seems to be heading towards three, whether
X approaches 1.5, from the right or from the
left. So I'll write down the answer of three.
You know, it's pretty strong. If you wanted
to have a really precise argument. We'd actually
need to use algebra to compute this limit.
Exactly using the formula for the function
itself, f of x equals x squared. And we'll
do examples like that in a future video. But
for now, the main point is just that the slope
of the tangent line is the limit of the slope
of the secant lines, which is given by this
formula. For now, let's look at an animation
that shows how the slope of our secant lines
approach the slope of our tangent line. So
this black curve here is the function y equals
x squared. The red line is the tangent line
through the point where x equals 1.5. And
the blue line is a secant line that goes through
the point with x coordinate 1.5. And a second
point with x coordinate 2.5. The points are
shown here on the right. So I'm going to use
this slider here and drag my second point
closer to my first point. So notice how as
the x coordinate, my second point gets closer
and closer to 1.5. My secant line is getting
closer and closer to my tangent line. So the
slope of my tangent line really is the limit
of the slope of my secant lines, as my x coordinate
of my second point goes to 1.5. So this is
true, even if I start with my second point
on the left instead of the right, as I drag
that second point closer and closer to the
first point, the slope of my secant lines
gets closer and closer to the slope of that
red tangent line. We saw in our example, that
the slope of our tangent line, or the derivative
at 1.5, was given by the limit as x goes to
1.5 of f of x minus f of 1.5 divided by x
minus 1.5. Well, in general, the derivative
of a function y equals f of x at an x value
a is given by f prime of A equals the limit
as x goes to a of f of x minus F of A over
x minus a, the function is said to be differentiable
at A. If this limit exists. In particular,
both the limit from the left and a limit from
the right have to exist and be equal for the
function to be differentiable
at x equals a.
There's another equivalent version of the
definition of derivative that's very common
and very useful. If we're looking at the graph
of a function, I'm trying to calculate the
slope of the secant line between the points
A, F of A and x f of x, then let's introduce
the letter H to be the quantity x minus a.
So h represents the run, when I'm calculating
the slope of this secant line, I can write
H equals x minus a, or equivalently x equals
a plus H. And so I can rewrite the definition
of derivative in terms of H as f prime of
A equals the limit as x goes to a of f of
a plus h minus F of A divided by h, just by
substituting in this expression for x. And
h for x minus a. Well as x goes to a, x minus
a is going to zero. In other words, h is going
to zero. So this is equivalent to the limit
as h goes to zero of f of a plus h minus f
of a over h. One way to think of this is that
we're just relabeling this point right here,
as the point A plus h, f of a plus H. And
the slope of the tangent line is still the
limit of the rise over the run as the run
goes to zero, this is the definition of derivative
that we'll use most frequently going forward
when we actually calculate derivatives based
on the definition in future videos. But for
now, let's look at some examples to practice
recognizing the derivative rather than computing
it. So each of these following two expressions
are supposed to represent the derivative of
some function at some value a. So for each
example, we're supposed to find the function
and figure out the value of A. Now remember,
we've got two definitions of derivative going
on. They're both equivalent, but they look
different. One of them looks like derivative
of f at a is the limit as x goes to a of f
of x minus F of A over x minus a. And the
other version is the limit as h goes to zero
of f of a plus h minus f of a over h. Now,
you might notice That our first expression
looks more like this first definition, because
x is going to some number that's not zero.
And we have both x and a number in the denominator
here. Whereas our second expression looks
more like the second definition, we've got
the age going to zero, and we've just got
the age on the denominator here. Okay, so
let's look at this first one here. First,
let's figure out what A is here. It seems
like a has got to be negative one. Since x
is approaching negative one. That kind of
makes sense, because now here on the denominator,
x plus one could be thought of as x minus
negative one. So that's our x minus a with
a is negative one. Okay, great. So we've got
a, now we need to find an F. And we will need
the numerator here to look like f of x minus
f of a, well, let's try the simplest thing,
we can, let's try f of x equals x plus five
squared, then X plus five squared is our f
of x. and f of a is our f of negative one
is going to be negative one plus five squared,
which is 16. So that matches up perfectly,
we've got our f of x here, our f of a here,
and our x minus a at the bottom. That's exactly
the definition of derivative done the first
one. All right, now the second one. Now, again,
we need to figure out what a is. And we need
to find figure out what f is. This part of
the expression here is supposed to be f of
a plus h. So I'm going to guess, make a guess
here, that f of x should be three to some
power, let's just try three to the X and see
how that works. Now we need this nine to be
f of a. So nine has to be three to the A.
And the only way that can work is if a is
two. So continuing on the top, we need f of
a plus h, that is f of two plus h,
two B three to the two plus H and that actually
works perfectly. If our f of x is three to
the x, it's all falling into place. So we've
got our f of two plus h, r f of two, and r
h. And it all works where f of x being three
to the x and a being two. In this video, we
introduced the idea of derivative as a slope
of a tangent line. And we gave two equivalent
definitions of the derivative in terms of
limits. We'll continue with some interpretations
of derivatives in the next video. This video
is algebraically intensive, and is concerned
with calculating derivatives using the limit
definition of derivative. Well, there are
actually two versions of the limit definition
of derivative. And I'll mostly use this one,
the limit as h goes to zero of f of a plus
h minus f of a over h. If you're interested,
you can try reworking the problems using the
alternative definition of derivative. The
limit as x goes to a of f of x minus F of
A over x minus a first example, find the derivative
of f of x, which is one over the square root
of three minus x at x equals negative one.
Well, in other words, we want to find f prime
of negative one. So that's the limit as h
goes to zero of f of negative one plus h minus
f of negative one over h. Using our definition
of f, that's the limit of one over the square
root of three minus negative one plus h minus
one over the square root of three minus negative
one, all over h. Let me clean this up a bit.
So this is one over the square root of, let's
see, it's three minus negative one, so that's
three plus one, or four minus h minus one
over the square root of four
over h. And I guess I can replace the square
root of four with two.
Now, unfortunately, I can't just evaluate
this by plugging in H equals zero, because
if I try that, I get one of these zero over
zero indeterminate forms. You'll run across
these a lot when calculating derivatives by
definition, it kind of makes sense because
remember the context where computing slopes
of secant lines as these points get closer
and closer together. So our rise and our runs
are both going to zero. So it makes sense,
we'll get these zero or zero indeterminate
forms, we have to use our algebraic tricks
that we learned before, for rewriting our
expression in a way that we can calculate
the limit. And I see two things going on here,
there's square roots lurking, and there's
also fractions. So it's anybody's guess which
trick I might want to apply First, the trick
for square roots, which would be multiplying
the top and the bottom by the conjugate. And
the trick for fractions, which would be adding
together my fraction for the common denominator.
I guess I'll try my fraction trick first.
So my common denominator for my two fractions
here, is just the product of these two denominators.
So that's the square root of four minus h
times two. Let me rewrite my fractions with
this common denominator. Continuing here,
I get the limit of two minus the square root
of four minus h over squared, a four minus
h times two, all over h. instead of dividing
by H, let me multiply by one over h. And let's
see here, let's see if we can evaluate by
plugging in H equals zero at this stage. Unfortunately,
when I try to plug in, I'm still getting the
zero of zero indeterminate form. But I'm not
out of tricks, I haven't used the conjugate
trick yet. So let's try multiplying the top
and the bottom by the conjugate of the top.
Once I multiply out here, I'll get four plus
two square to four minus h minus two square
to four minus h, minus the square root of
four minus h squared, that's going to cancel
out nicely. And on the bottom, I have two
h squared of four minus h times two plus square
to four minus h, I'll leave that factored
for now. That's good thing, I have unlimited
space here, I'm kind of need it. Now on the
numerator, I'm going to get four minus four
minus h, is carrying the denominator along
for the ride now, oh, I see something good.
I see in the numerator, we're getting a four
minus four plus H. Subtracting out those fours
to zero, and then cancelling out, my H is
that divide by each other, I think I finally
got something that I can evaluate without
getting a zero over zero indeterminate form.
All right, so here we've got. So as h goes
to zero, I'm just going to get one over two
times the square root of four times two plus
a squared of four, which equals 1/16. So by
now, you may have forgotten what the original
problem was, I think I have it, let's go back
up here, we were looking for the derivative
of f of x, which was one over a squared of
three minus x at x equals negative one, we
set up the limit definition, did a bunch of
algebra first adding together fractions, then
using the conjugate trick, and eventually
found that that derivative equaled 1/16. The
algebra doesn't get much harder than this
problem here. In this next example, we're
asked to find the equation of the tangent
line to y equals x cubed minus 3x at x equals
two. So the slope of the tangent line is given
by the derivative, f prime of two. So let's
calculate the derivative first. f prime of
two is the limit as h goes to zero of f of
two plus h minus f of two, all over h. So
that's the limit of two plus h cubed minus
three times two plus h minus
two cubed minus three times two. I'm just
plugging in first two plus h for x in the
definition of my function, and then I'm plugging
in two for x. Now all of that needs to be
over h. Once again, if I try to plug in zero
for H in these expressions, I'm just gonna
get something that all cancels out to zero
at the top, and also have zero at the bottom,
one of my classic zero over zero indeterminate
forms. So instead, I need to use algebra to
simplify things. And hope I can calculate
the limit after that. So a good trick for
simplifying here is to multiply out two plus
h cubed multiplies out to two cubed, plus
three times two squared times h, plus three
times two times h squared plus h cubed. I'm
getting this from the formula for multiplying
out of cubic which I've memorized. But you
can also get it more slowly just by writing
out two plus h times itself three times and,
and distributing. Now I need to subtract three
times two, and three times h. And finally,
I needed to subtract my two cubed and then
add my three times to all this over h. Now
if you have my terms cancel out to zero here,
two cubed minus two cubed. And let's see I've
got a minus three times two and a plus three
times two. And I notice all the terms that
are left have H's and so I'm going to factor
out an H from the top from the remaining terms
here. And that gives me let's say, three times
two squared, so that's 12, plus six H, plus
h squared minus three over h. Now, h divided
by h is one. So I'm just left with the limit
as h goes to zero of 12 plus six h plus h
squared minus three, as h goes to zero, I
can just plug in H zero, and I get 12 minus
three, which is nine. So my slope of my tangent
line, my derivative is nine. I'm not quite
done, I still need to find the equation of
the tangent line, I just know that its slope
is nine. So the equation of the tangent line
equation of any line is something like y equals
mx plus b. and here m is nine. So I have y
equals 9x plus b, I just need to find the
intercept B. Now, usually, to find the intercept,
I need a plug in a point. what point do I
have here to plug in? Well, remember, we're
talking about a tangent line here. So we've
got the point of tangency, the point where
x equals two, and the corresponding y value
is y equals two cubed minus three times two,
or two. So my tangent line has to go through
the point to two, which means if I plug in
this point for x and y, I get two equals nine
times two plus b, which means that B has to
equal negative 16. So the equation of my tangent
line then becomes y equals 9x minus 16. I
found that by first calculating the derivative
to get my slope, and then using the point
of tangency, plugging in the x value to get
the y value, and plugging Matt in to get b
to finish off the equation. So in this video,
we used our tricks for evaluating limits algebraically
to compute some derivatives, using the definition
of derivative. This is pretty labor intensive.
So fortunately, pretty soon, we'll learn some
shortcut methods for calculating derivatives
without resorting to the definition. We've
seen that the derivative of a function y equals
f of x at a point, x equals A represents the
slope of a tangent line through the point
A f of a. But if the function f of x represents
some practical quantity, like distance as
a function of time, or fuel efficiency as
a function of speed, then the derivative will
also have a practical interpretation. This
video is about interpreting the derivative
in different contexts.
One of the most famous contexts for interpreting
derivatives is problems involving motion.
So let's say I'm on a bike ride, heading straight
north from campus. And let's suppose that
y equals f of x represents my distance from
campus. So x is the time and hours and y or
f of x is my distance and miles, the distance
away from campus. Distance north of campus.
It's kind of fun to see what this graph here
means in terms of my bike ride. In particular,
what's going on up here, where my y values
reach their maximum. And what about here,
where my function is constant. Please pause
the video for a moment and see if you can
make up a story that fits the graph. So here
at the top, my distance is no longer increasing,
it's actually starting to decrease. So I must
have turned around and be heading back towards
campus again, over here, where my f of x is
constant, I probably stopped at a coffee shop
to take a rest or maybe I'm fixing a flat
tire. Now let's get to the questions at hand.
Consider these two points, three, f of three,
and four F of four, we want to interpret the
slope of the secant line through those two
points. Slope is change in y over change in
x. And y here is distance and x here is time.
So change in distance over change in time.
Sounds a lot like speed, or more accurately,
velocity. Velocity just means speed in a certain
direction, and is positive. If distance is
increasing, and negative if it's decreasing.
Speed is the absolute value of velocity, and
there's always positive or zero. So in our
case, the velocity here must be negative,
because our distance is decreasing. And we
could estimate it very roughly as about, say
four minus 12 over four minus three, so about
negative eight miles per hour. But what is
this negative eight miles per hour refer
to.
Since we're looking at the change in distance,
over this entire hour long interval, the slope
of my secant line gives my average velocity
over this interval. It doesn't give my exact
velocity, and exactly three hours or exactly
four hours, only my average velocity. If I
want to know my exact velocity at exactly
three hours, I need to look instead at the
slope of the tangent line at x equals three.
The velocity at an exact instant of time is
sometimes called the instantaneous velocity
to distinguish it from the average velocity
over a time interval. Let's think for a minute
about why the velocity at exactly three hours
is given by the slope of the tangent line.
We saw in a previous video that the slope
of the tangent line is the limit of the slope
of the secant lines More precisely, the limit
as x goes to three of f of x minus f of three
over x minus three. Wow, well, each of these
ratios represents an average velocity on the
interval from three to x. And so the limit
is the limit of average velocities on tinier
and tinier intervals of time, one minute,
one second 100th of a second, in the limit,
as the length of the time interval goes to
zero, we're going to get the exact velocity
at exactly three hours. So to repeat, in this
example, the slope of the secant line represents
the average velocity over time interval, and
the derivative at x equals three, written
f prime of three, which is also the slope
of the tangent line, that derivative represents
the instantaneous velocity at x equals three.
More generally, if f of x represents any quantity
that's changing, then the slope of the secant
line represents an average rate of change.
While the slope of the tangent line, f prime
of a represents an instantaneous rate of change.
Let's see how that works in a couple of other
examples. Let's suppose that f of x represents
the temperature of a cup of coffee and degrees
Fahrenheit as a function of time and minutes
since he said it on the counter. So let's
interpret the first equation. f of zero is
140. Well, that just means that at time zero,
the temperature is 140 degrees. What about
the equation f of 10 minus f of zero is negative
20. That's saying that the temperature goes
down by 20 degrees as x the time goes from
zero to 10 minutes. Now, what about this quotient
here being equal to negative two? Well, this
quotient looks a lot like the slope of a secant
Why, right, so it must be an average rate
of change. And in this context, we have the
temperature is decreasing by an average of
two degrees per minute, as x changes from
zero to 10 minutes. Finally, the derivative
of f at 15 is negative point five means that
at exactly 15 minutes, the temperature is
decreasing at a rate of point five degrees
per minute. negative numbers here always mean
decreasing, and f prime is an instantaneous
rate of change. Let's look at another example.
Please pause the video and try this one for
yourself. Here g of x represents the fuel
efficiency of a Toyota Prius and mpg as a
function of x, the speed in miles per hour
that is traveling g of 45 is 52 means that
at 45 miles per hour, the fuel efficiency
is 52 miles per gallon. The second statement
is saying that as speed increases from 35
to 45 miles per hour, fuel efficiency goes
up by 10. That's 10 miles per gallon. The
third statement says that the average rate
of change
of fuel efficiency is two miles per gallon
per mile per hour, as speed increases from
35 to 40 miles per hour. So going up from
35 to 40, gives you better fuel efficiency
here. On the other hand, when you're going
60 miles per hour, your fuel efficiency is
decreasing at a rate of two miles per gallon
per mile per hour. So I bet the optimal fuel
efficiency here occurs somewhere between 40
and 60 miles per hour. In this video, we've
interpreted the slope of the secant line as
the average rate of change, and the slope
of the tangent line with the derivative as
an instantaneous rate of change. I hope that
these general principles will help you interpret
the derivative in a variety of contexts that
you might encounter throughout your life.
In this video, we'll think of the derivative
of a function as being a function in itself,
we relate the graph of a function to the graph
of its derivative, and we'll talk about where
the derivative does not exist. We've seen
that for a function f of x and a number A,
the derivative of f of x at x equals A is
given by this formula. But what if we let
a very, if we compute f prime of a lots of
different values of a, we can think of the
derivative of f prime as itself being a function,
I'm going to rewrite this definition of derivative
with x in the place of a just to make it look
a little more like standard function notation.
So f prime as a function of x is the limit
as h goes to zero of f of x plus h minus f
of x over h. This isn't anything substantially
different from what we've been doing before,
it's just a difference in perspective. So
let's do one more example of computing the
derivative by hand using the definition, but
a general number x instead of a specific value,
the function we're going to use is f of x
equals one over x. And first, let's just write
down the definition of derivative in general.
So f prime of x is given by this formula.
And using the fact that f of x is one over
x, I can rewrite this as one over x plus h
minus one over x all over h. So as usual,
this is a zero over zero indeterminate form.
If I plug in zero for H, I'm just going to
get one over x minus one over x on the numerator,
which is zero. and plugging in zero for H
gives me zero on the denominator two. So I'll
need to use some algebra to rewrite things
to get an A form that I can evaluate it. Let's
add together our fractions in the numerator
here. The common denominator I need to use
is x plus h times x. So I multiply this fraction
by x over x and the next fraction by x plus
h over x plus h. All that's over h. And now
continuing, I get x minus x plus h over x
plus h times X and instead of dividing the
whole thing by h here, multiply by one over
h to get the limit have x minus x minus h
over x plus h times x times h. Now I can subtract
off my x's here. And after I do that, I can
divide my minus h by my H, to get just a minus
one on the numerator here. So that's just
the limit of negative one over x plus h times
x. And now I'm in a good position because
I can plug in H equals zero and get something
that makes sense. Namely, I'm getting a limit
of negative one over x plus zero times x or
negative one over x squared as my derivative.
In this example, we're given the graph of
a function that's supposed to represent the
height of an alien spaceship above the Earth's
surface, we want to graph the rate of change.
The rate of change means the derivative of
our function, but we're not given an equation
to work with. So we'll just have to estimate
the derivative based on the shape of the graph
by thinking about slopes of tangent lines.
I'll start by drawing a new set of axes where
I can graph my derivative. And I'll consider
my original function, which I'll call g of
x, piece by piece.
For x values between zero and two, my original
function g of x looks like a line, it has
slope negative one, since the rise is negative
two, while the run is two, for any point on
the straight line segment, the tangent line
will also be a straight line with slope negative
one, and therefore, the derivative will be
negative one. For x values between zero and
two, I'm going to ignore the time being what
happens when x is exactly zero or exactly
two, and just look at the interval of X values
between two and three. Here, g of x is completely
flat. So tangent lines at any of these points
will have slope zero. And I'll draw a derivative
of zero. When x is between two and three,
I'll postpone worrying about the derivative
when x is exactly three. And just think about
the derivative when x is between three and
five, where g of x is flat again, so it's
tangent lines will have slopes of zero. And
I'll draw again, a derivative is zero when
x is between three and five. Now things get
a little more interesting. As x increases
from five to about seven, g of x is an increasing
function. The slope of tangent lines here
are positive, starting at about, say, a slope
of three, and decreasing to a slope of zero,
when x is seven, I can draw that down here.
As x increases from seven, the tangent lines
now have negative slopes, going to a maximum
negative slope of about negative one here,
and then heading towards a slope of zero,
when x is just shy of 10. My estimates of
three and negative one for the slopes of my
tangent lines are just rough estimates based
on approximating the rise over the run. As
x increases from 10, the tangent line slope
is positive, and getting steeper and steeper,
so my derivative is going to be positive and
increasing. That's the basic shape of the
derivative. Now let's see what happens at
these special points like 235 and zero. To
figure out the derivative at x equals two,
let's go back to the definition of derivative
as the limit of the slopes of the secant lines.
If I draw a secant line, using a point on
the left, I'll just get this line that lines
up with this line and has a slope of negative
one. But if I compute the slope of a secant
line, using a point on the right, I'll get
a slope of zero. So the limit from the left
and the limit from the right of the slopes
of my secret lines will be different. And
so my limit does not exist and my derivative
does not exist. And so I'll just draw this
as an open circle at x equals two. Next, let's
look at the derivative when x equals three.
Remember that the derivative at three is the
limit as h goes to zero, of g of three plus
h minus g of three over eight. Well, if H
is bigger than zero, then g of three plus
H is going to be about a half, because three
plus H is to the right of three. On the other
hand, if H is less than zero, g of three,
plus H is two, because three plus H is actually
a number less than three, g of three itself
is equal to one half, based on the filled
in bubble here. so if we calculate the limit,
as h goes to zero from the positive side,
we get the limit of one half minus one half
over age, which is just the limit of zeros,
so that's zero. On the other hand, if we compute
the limit from the left, we get the limit
of two minus a half over eight, which is the
limit of three halves over h. And as h goes
to zero, that limit is negative infinity.
So once again, the left limit and write limit
are not equal. And so the limit of the slopes
of the secant lines does not exist, and there's
no derivative at x equals three. And I'll
draw an open circle there to
add x equals five, again, we have a corner.
And by the same sort of argument, we can conclude
that the derivative does not exist. And finally,
when x equals zero, we can only have a limit
from the right not the left. And so by that
sort of technical reason, we don't have a
derivative at that left endpoint either. So
we've drawn a rough graph of the rate of change
of the height of our alien spaceship, as it
comes closer to Earth beams down to pick up
Earthlings and then makes us escape up to
the mothership. It's interesting to observe
that the domain of the original function g
of x is from zero to infinity, but the domain
of g prime is somewhat smaller, and just goes
from zero to two, then from two to three,
then from three to five, and finally, from
five to infinity, missing some places where
the function originally existed. We saw in
the previous example, that the derivative
doesn't necessarily exist at all the x values
where the original function exists.
Please pause the video for a moment and try
to come up with as many different ways as
you can, that a derivative can fail to exist
at an x value x equals a. Well, one kind of
boring way that a function can fail to
have a derivative at x equals A is if f of
x itself fails to exist. at x equals a, for
example, if it has a hole, like in this picture,
we saw in the previous example, with the alien
spacecraft, that a derivative can fail to
exist when the function turns a corner. When
we tried to evaluate the derivative in that
example, by taking the limit of the slope
of the secant lines, the limit from the left,
and a limit from the right did not agree.
A famous example of a function that turns
a corner is the absolute value function. For
the absolute value function, f prime of x
is negative one, since the slope here is negative
one, when x is less than zero, and it's positive
one when x is greater than zero, but f prime
of zero itself does not exist. A function
with a casp also fails to have a derivative
at the cusp. In the alien spaceship example,
we also saw that F can fail to have a derivative
at a discontinuity. But there's another way
that a derivative can fail to exist, even
when f has no cost per corner discontinuity.
Let's look at the function f of x equals x
to the 1/3 graphed here, what's going on at
x equals zero. At that instant, the tangent
line is a vertical with a slope that's infinite
or undefined. So the limit of the slopes of
the secant lines will fail to exist because
it'll be infinite. A function is called differentiable
at x equals a, if the derivative exists at
a function is differentiable on an open interval,
if f is differentiable at every point in that
interval. So all of the examples on the
previous slides are examples of places where
a function is not differentiable. All of these
examples are important. But I'm going to focus
on the example involving discontinuity. In
general, if f of x is not continuous at x
equals a, then f is not differentiable at
x equals a. This is what we saw in the example
involving the jump discontinuity. an equivalent
way of saying the same thing is that f is
differentiable at x equals a, then f has to
be continuous at x
previous slides are examples of places where
a function is not differentiable. All of these
examples are important. But I'm going to focus
on the example involving discontinuity. In
general, if f of x is not continuous at x
equals a, then f is not differentiable at
x equals a. This is what we saw in the example
involving the jump discontinuity. an equivalent
way of saying the same thing is that f is
differentiable at x equals a, then f has to
be continuous at x
equals a.
However, if all we know is that f is continuous
at x equals a, then we can't conclude anything
about whether or not is differentiable there,
f may or may not be differentiable at x equals
a. Remember the square root example, the square
root of x is continuous at x equals zero,
but it's not differentiable there because
of the corner. In this video, we related the
graph of a function to the graph of its derivative.
By thinking about the slopes of tangent lines,
we also looked at several ways that a derivative
can fail to exist at a point and noted that
if a function is differentiable, it has to
be continuous. This video gives a proof that
differentiable functions are continuous. What
we want to show here is that if a function
is differentiable at a number x equals a,
then it's continuous at x equals a. Let me
call the function f of x. And I'm going to
start out by writing down what it means for
f of x to be differentiable at x equals a.
That means that the limit as x goes to a of
f of x minus F of A over x minus a exists
and equals this finite number that we call
f prime
However, if all we know is that f is continuous
at x equals a, then we can't conclude anything
about whether or not is differentiable there,
f may or may not be differentiable at x equals
a. Remember the square root example, the square
root of x is continuous at x equals zero,
but it's not differentiable there because
of the corner. In this video, we related the
graph of a function to the graph of its derivative.
By thinking about the slopes of tangent lines,
we also looked at several ways that a derivative
can fail to exist at a point and noted that
if a function is differentiable, it has to
be continuous. This video gives a proof that
differentiable functions are continuous. What
we want to show here is that if a function
is differentiable at a number x equals a,
then it's continuous at x equals a. Let me
call the function f of x. And I'm going to
start out by writing down what it means for
f of x to be differentiable at x equals a.
That means that the limit as x goes to a of
f of x minus F of A over x minus a exists
and equals this finite number that we call
f prime
of a. Now I'm going to multiply both sides
of this equation
by the limit as x goes to a of x minus a.
Now wait a second, before I go any further
on to make sure this is legit. Does this limit
actually exist? Well, yeah, because the limit
as x goes to a of x exists, that's just a,
and the limit as x goes to a of a exists,
that's a also. So the limit of the difference
has to exist. And actually, that limit of
the difference is the difference of the limits,
which is just going to be a minus a or a zero.
So I've actually just multiplied both sides
by zero and a fancy form.
by the limit as x goes to a of x minus a.
Now wait a second, before I go any further
on to make sure this is legit. Does this limit
actually exist? Well, yeah, because the limit
as x goes to a of x exists, that's just a,
and the limit as x goes to a of a exists,
that's a also. So the limit of the difference
has to exist. And actually, that limit of
the difference is the difference of the limits,
which is just going to be a minus a or a zero.
So I've actually just multiplied both sides
by zero and a fancy form.
This is actually a surprisingly useful thing
to do. Because I have a product of a limit
of two limits here, both of which exist. So
by the product rule for limits, I can rewrite
this as the limit as x goes to a
This is actually a surprisingly useful thing
to do. Because I have a product of a limit
of two limits here, both of which exist. So
by the product rule for limits, I can rewrite
this as the limit as x goes to a
of x minus a times f of x minus F of A over
x minus a. And canceling these two copies
of x minus a, which is fine to do when x is
near a, just not when x equals a, I get that
the limit of f of x minus f of a is equal
to this limit over here. Well, we said this
limit was just zero. So my limit on the left
is equal to zero.
of x minus a times f of x minus F of A over
x minus a. And canceling these two copies
of x minus a, which is fine to do when x is
near a, just not when x equals a, I get that
the limit of f of x minus f of a is equal
to this limit over here. Well, we said this
limit was just zero. So my limit on the left
is equal to zero.
And now I'm so close, I'd like to apply five
the limit rule to this difference to break
it up into a difference of limits, but I can't
quite do that, because I'm not sure yet that
the limit, as x goes to a of f of x exists,
that's sort of part of what I'm trying to
prove as far as continuity. So instead, I
think I'm gonna add to both sides, a limit
that I do know exists. And that's the limit
And now I'm so close, I'd like to apply five
the limit rule to this difference to break
it up into a difference of limits, but I can't
quite do that, because I'm not sure yet that
the limit, as x goes to a of f of x exists,
that's sort of part of what I'm trying to
prove as far as continuity. So instead, I
think I'm gonna add to both sides, a limit
that I do know exists. And that's the limit
of f of a.
Now, I do know that both of these two limits
on the left side exists, so I can use the
limit rule about sums to rewrite this limit.
Now, I do know that both of these two limits
on the left side exists, so I can use the
limit rule about sums to rewrite this limit.
Now, on the left side, I can cancel out my
copies of f of a, whatever number that is,
and I get that the limit as x goes to a of
f of x which has to exist by the the limit
rule for psalms that I applied
Now, on the left side, I can cancel out my
copies of f of a, whatever number that is,
and I get that the limit as x goes to a of
f of x which has to exist by the the limit
rule for psalms that I applied
above.
That limit their past to equal the limit as
x goes to a of f of a, well, f of a is just
some number, doesn't matter what X is doing
f of a is it's just f of a, whatever that
is. So this limit on the right is just f of
a, and look at that. That's exactly what it
means for a function to be continuous at x
equals a, the limit as x goes to a of f of
x equals f of a. So f is continuous at x equals
a, hella proof is complete. In this video,
we prove that if f is differentiable at x
equals a, then f is continuous at x equals
a. This statement is equivalent to another
statement known in logic as its contrapositive,
which says that if f is not continuous, at
x equals a, then f is not differentiable at
x equals a. In this video, we'll learn a few
rules for calculating derivatives, namely,
the power role, and the derivatives of sums,
differences and constant multiples. These
rules will give us shortcuts for finding derivatives
quickly, without needing to resort to the
old limit definition of derivative. In this
video, we'll only do statements of the rules
and some examples, there won't be any proofs
or justification for why the rules hold. Instead,
these proofs will be in a separate later video.
Let's start with some basics. First of all,
if we have a constant C, and we will have
the function f of x equals C. So if I graph
that, it's just going to be a straight horizontal
line.
That limit their past to equal the limit as
x goes to a of f of a, well, f of a is just
some number, doesn't matter what X is doing
f of a is it's just f of a, whatever that
is. So this limit on the right is just f of
a, and look at that. That's exactly what it
means for a function to be continuous at x
equals a, the limit as x goes to a of f of
x equals f of a. So f is continuous at x equals
a, hella proof is complete. In this video,
we prove that if f is differentiable at x
equals a, then f is continuous at x equals
a. This statement is equivalent to another
statement known in logic as its contrapositive,
which says that if f is not continuous, at
x equals a, then f is not differentiable at
x equals a. In this video, we'll learn a few
rules for calculating derivatives, namely,
the power role, and the derivatives of sums,
differences and constant multiples. These
rules will give us shortcuts for finding derivatives
quickly, without needing to resort to the
old limit definition of derivative. In this
video, we'll only do statements of the rules
and some examples, there won't be any proofs
or justification for why the rules hold. Instead,
these proofs will be in a separate later video.
Let's start with some basics. First of all,
if we have a constant C, and we will have
the function f of x equals C. So if I graph
that, it's just going to be a straight horizontal
line.
So the derivative
df dx, ought to be zero, because the slope
of the tangent line of this straight line
is just
df dx, ought to be zero, because the slope
of the tangent line of this straight line
is just
zero.
Another simple example, is the derivative
of the function f of x equals x. So again,
if I draw the graph, that's just going to
be a straight line with slope one. And so
the tangent line for the straight line will
also have slope one. And the derivative, f
prime of x has to be always equal to one.
These two simple examples are actually special
cases of the power rule, which is one of the
most useful rules for calculating
Another simple example, is the derivative
of the function f of x equals x. So again,
if I draw the graph, that's just going to
be a straight line with slope one. And so
the tangent line for the straight line will
also have slope one. And the derivative, f
prime of x has to be always equal to one.
These two simple examples are actually special
cases of the power rule, which is one of the
most useful rules for calculating
derivatives.
So the power rule says that if you have the
function, y equals x to the n, where n is
any real number, then you can find the derivative
d y dx, simply by pulling that exponent and
down and multiplying it in the front and then
reducing the exponent by one. So for example,
if you want to calculate the derivative of
y equals x to the 15th, D y dX here is just
going to be 15 times x to the 15 minus one,
or 14. The second example, f of x equals the
cube root of x might not immediately look
like an example where we can apply the power
rule. But if we rewrite it, by putting the
cube root in exponential tation as x to the
1/3, now we can apply the power rule, we bring
the 1/3 down, multiplied on the front and
So the power rule says that if you have the
function, y equals x to the n, where n is
any real number, then you can find the derivative
d y dx, simply by pulling that exponent and
down and multiplying it in the front and then
reducing the exponent by one. So for example,
if you want to calculate the derivative of
y equals x to the 15th, D y dX here is just
going to be 15 times x to the 15 minus one,
or 14. The second example, f of x equals the
cube root of x might not immediately look
like an example where we can apply the power
rule. But if we rewrite it, by putting the
cube root in exponential tation as x to the
1/3, now we can apply the power rule, we bring
the 1/3 down, multiplied on the front and
reduce the
exponent of 1/3 by one, or 1/3 minus one is
negative two thirds. So we found the derivative
here using the power rule, we could rewrite
it if we want to using exponent rules, as
one over 3x to the two thirds, either answers
good.
exponent of 1/3 by one, or 1/3 minus one is
negative two thirds. So we found the derivative
here using the power rule, we could rewrite
it if we want to using exponent rules, as
one over 3x to the two thirds, either answers
good.
In the third example, g of x is one over x
to the 3.7. Again, we need to do a little
rewriting before we can apply the power rule.
So I'm going to rewrite g of x as x to the
minus 3.7. Using exponent rules, now I can
find dg dx by pulling down the negative 3.7
multiplying in the front, and now I have to
reduce negative 3.7 by one, so I subtract
one that gives me x to the negative 4.7. Again,
I can rewrite this if I wish as negative 3.7
over x to the 4.7. It's important to notice
that in all these examples and in fact, in
any example where the power rule applies,
the variable x is in the base. And the exponent
is just a constant, just a real number. The
constant multiple rules says that if c is
just a constant real number, and f is a differentiable
function, then the derivative of C times f
of x is just c times the derivative of f of
x. In other words, when we take the derivative,
we can just pull a constant outside of the
derivative sign. Let's use this rule in an
example. If we want to take the derivative
of 5x cubed, that's the same thing as five
times the derivative of x cubed. And now using
the power rule, we can bring down the three
and get 15x squared. f and g are differentiable
functions, then the derivative of f of x plus
g of x is the derivative of f plus the derivative
of g. Similarly, for a difference, if f and
g are differentiable functions, then the derivative
of the difference is just the difference of
the derivatives. Now let's use all these rules
together to calculate the derivative of this
polynomial. To find the y dx, we can use the
sum and difference rule to calculate the derivative
of each term separately. Now using the constant
multiple rule and the power rule, we can bring
out the seven, bring down the three getting
x squared here, similarly, for the next term,
five times two times x to the one, four times
the derivative of x, which is just one, and
the derivative of a constant two is just zero.
So simplifying, we get 21x squared minus 10x
plus four, and notice that the derivative
of the original polynomial is just another
polynomial of one less degree. In this video,
we use some shortcuts to calculate the derivatives
of various functions, especially polynomials.
If you're interested in seeing where these
rules come from, how they're derived from
the limit definition of derivative, then look
for another video coming soon on proofs. This
video is about identities involving trig functions
like sine and cosine. But I want to start
with some examples that just involve
In the third example, g of x is one over x
to the 3.7. Again, we need to do a little
rewriting before we can apply the power rule.
So I'm going to rewrite g of x as x to the
minus 3.7. Using exponent rules, now I can
find dg dx by pulling down the negative 3.7
multiplying in the front, and now I have to
reduce negative 3.7 by one, so I subtract
one that gives me x to the negative 4.7. Again,
I can rewrite this if I wish as negative 3.7
over x to the 4.7. It's important to notice
that in all these examples and in fact, in
any example where the power rule applies,
the variable x is in the base. And the exponent
is just a constant, just a real number. The
constant multiple rules says that if c is
just a constant real number, and f is a differentiable
function, then the derivative of C times f
of x is just c times the derivative of f of
x. In other words, when we take the derivative,
we can just pull a constant outside of the
derivative sign. Let's use this rule in an
example. If we want to take the derivative
of 5x cubed, that's the same thing as five
times the derivative of x cubed. And now using
the power rule, we can bring down the three
and get 15x squared. f and g are differentiable
functions, then the derivative of f of x plus
g of x is the derivative of f plus the derivative
of g. Similarly, for a difference, if f and
g are differentiable functions, then the derivative
of the difference is just the difference of
the derivatives. Now let's use all these rules
together to calculate the derivative of this
polynomial. To find the y dx, we can use the
sum and difference rule to calculate the derivative
of each term separately. Now using the constant
multiple rule and the power rule, we can bring
out the seven, bring down the three getting
x squared here, similarly, for the next term,
five times two times x to the one, four times
the derivative of x, which is just one, and
the derivative of a constant two is just zero.
So simplifying, we get 21x squared minus 10x
plus four, and notice that the derivative
of the original polynomial is just another
polynomial of one less degree. In this video,
we use some shortcuts to calculate the derivatives
of various functions, especially polynomials.
If you're interested in seeing where these
rules come from, how they're derived from
the limit definition of derivative, then look
for another video coming soon on proofs. This
video is about identities involving trig functions
like sine and cosine. But I want to start
with some examples that just involve
quadratic functions. If I want to find the
solutions to this equation, I can rewrite
it x squared minus 6x minus seven equals zero,
factor it, x minus seven times x plus one
equals zero, set the factors equal to 0x minus
seven equals zero, or x plus one equals zero.
And that gives me the solutions, x equals
seven, or x equals negative one. Next, let's
look at this more complicated equation. I'm
going to try to solve that for x by multiplying
out the right hand side. Next, our combined
terms on the right hand side. So that gives
me x squared minus 6x on both sides, well,
x squared minus 6x is equal to x squared minus
6x. That's true no matter what I plug in for
x, and therefore, all values of x satisfy
this equation, we can say that the solution
set is all real numbers. The second equation
is called an identity, because it holds for
all values of the variable. The first equation,
on the other hand is not an identity, because
it only holds for some values of x and not
all values. Please pause the video for a moment
and try to decide which of the following three
equations or identities that is, which of
these equations hold for all values of the
variable. To start out, you might want to
test them by plugging in a few values of the
variable and see if the equation holds. The
first equation is not an identity. It does
hold for some values of x. For example, if
x equals zero, then sine of two times zero
is zero. Two times sine of zero is also zero.
So it does hold when x is zero. However, when
x is say pi over two, then sine of two times
pi over two, that's the same thing as sine
of pi, which is zero, but two times sine of
pi over two, that's two times one, or two,
and zero is not equal to two. So the equation
does not hold for x equals pi
quadratic functions. If I want to find the
solutions to this equation, I can rewrite
it x squared minus 6x minus seven equals zero,
factor it, x minus seven times x plus one
equals zero, set the factors equal to 0x minus
seven equals zero, or x plus one equals zero.
And that gives me the solutions, x equals
seven, or x equals negative one. Next, let's
look at this more complicated equation. I'm
going to try to solve that for x by multiplying
out the right hand side. Next, our combined
terms on the right hand side. So that gives
me x squared minus 6x on both sides, well,
x squared minus 6x is equal to x squared minus
6x. That's true no matter what I plug in for
x, and therefore, all values of x satisfy
this equation, we can say that the solution
set is all real numbers. The second equation
is called an identity, because it holds for
all values of the variable. The first equation,
on the other hand is not an identity, because
it only holds for some values of x and not
all values. Please pause the video for a moment
and try to decide which of the following three
equations or identities that is, which of
these equations hold for all values of the
variable. To start out, you might want to
test them by plugging in a few values of the
variable and see if the equation holds. The
first equation is not an identity. It does
hold for some values of x. For example, if
x equals zero, then sine of two times zero
is zero. Two times sine of zero is also zero.
So it does hold when x is zero. However, when
x is say pi over two, then sine of two times
pi over two, that's the same thing as sine
of pi, which is zero, but two times sine of
pi over two, that's two times one, or two,
and zero is not equal to two. So the equation
does not hold for x equals pi
over two.
Since it doesn't hold for all values of the
variable, it's not an identity. The second
equation is an identity. You can build some
evidence for this by plugging in numbers.
For example, cosine of zero plus pi, which
is negative one is the same thing as negative
of cosine of zero. You can also check for
example, that cosine of pi over six plus pi
is the same thing as negative cosine of pi
over six. But even if we check a zillion examples,
that's just evidence, it's not a proof that
the identity holds, we could have just gotten
lucky with the values we picked, we can build
a little bit stronger evidence, by looking
at graphs, I'm going to put theta on the x
axis in a pie graph, y equals cosine of theta
plus
Since it doesn't hold for all values of the
variable, it's not an identity. The second
equation is an identity. You can build some
evidence for this by plugging in numbers.
For example, cosine of zero plus pi, which
is negative one is the same thing as negative
of cosine of zero. You can also check for
example, that cosine of pi over six plus pi
is the same thing as negative cosine of pi
over six. But even if we check a zillion examples,
that's just evidence, it's not a proof that
the identity holds, we could have just gotten
lucky with the values we picked, we can build
a little bit stronger evidence, by looking
at graphs, I'm going to put theta on the x
axis in a pie graph, y equals cosine of theta
plus
pi,
that's just like the graph of cosine shifted
over to the left by pi. On the other hand,
if I graph y equals negative cosine theta,
that's the graph of cosine theta, reflected
across the x axis, which gives us the exact
same graph. So graphing both sides gives us
strong evidence that this equation is an identity,
it holds for all values of theta. Now, the
strongest evidence of all would be an algebraic
proof, which we'll do later in the course,
once we have a formula for the cosine of a
sum of two angles.
that's just like the graph of cosine shifted
over to the left by pi. On the other hand,
if I graph y equals negative cosine theta,
that's the graph of cosine theta, reflected
across the x axis, which gives us the exact
same graph. So graphing both sides gives us
strong evidence that this equation is an identity,
it holds for all values of theta. Now, the
strongest evidence of all would be an algebraic
proof, which we'll do later in the course,
once we have a formula for the cosine of a
sum of two angles.
In the meantime, let's look at equation C.
It turns out equation C is an identity. And
we could build evidence for it again by plugging
in values for x, or by graphing the left side
and the right side separately, and checking
to see that the graphs coincided. But for
this example, I'm going to go ahead and do
an algebraic verification.
In the meantime, let's look at equation C.
It turns out equation C is an identity. And
we could build evidence for it again by plugging
in values for x, or by graphing the left side
and the right side separately, and checking
to see that the graphs coincided. But for
this example, I'm going to go ahead and do
an algebraic verification.
In particular, I'm going to start with the
left side of the equation, and rewrite things
and rewrite things until I get to the right
side of the equation. The first thing I'll
rewrite
In particular, I'm going to start with the
left side of the equation, and rewrite things
and rewrite things until I get to the right
side of the equation. The first thing I'll
rewrite
is secant and tangent in terms of their constituent
functions, sine and cosine. Since secant of
x is one over cosine x, and tangent of x is
sine x over cosine x, I can rewrite this expression
as one over cosine x minus sine x times sine
x over cosine x. I can clean up those fractions
and write this as one over cosine x minus
sine squared x over cosine x. Now, I noticed
that I have two fractions with the same denominator.
So I can pull them together as one minus sine
squared x over cosine x. Next, I'm going to
rewrite the numerator one minus sine squared
x using the Pythagorean identity that says
that cosine squared x plus sine squared x
equals one, and therefore, one minus sine
squared x is equal to cosine squared x just
by subtracting sine squared x from both sides.
So I can replace my numerator, one minus sine
squared x with cosine squared x. And canceling
one cosine from the top and from the bottom,
that's the same thing as cosine of x, which
is the right hand side that I was trying to
get to. So a combination of a bunch of algebra,
and the Pythagorean identity allows me to
prove that this equation is true for all values
of x,
is secant and tangent in terms of their constituent
functions, sine and cosine. Since secant of
x is one over cosine x, and tangent of x is
sine x over cosine x, I can rewrite this expression
as one over cosine x minus sine x times sine
x over cosine x. I can clean up those fractions
and write this as one over cosine x minus
sine squared x over cosine x. Now, I noticed
that I have two fractions with the same denominator.
So I can pull them together as one minus sine
squared x over cosine x. Next, I'm going to
rewrite the numerator one minus sine squared
x using the Pythagorean identity that says
that cosine squared x plus sine squared x
equals one, and therefore, one minus sine
squared x is equal to cosine squared x just
by subtracting sine squared x from both sides.
So I can replace my numerator, one minus sine
squared x with cosine squared x. And canceling
one cosine from the top and from the bottom,
that's the same thing as cosine of x, which
is the right hand side that I was trying to
get to. So a combination of a bunch of algebra,
and the Pythagorean identity allows me to
prove that this equation is true for all values
of x,
it's an identity. The best way to prove that
an equation is an identity
is to use algebra and to use other identities,
like the Pythagorean identity to rewrite one
side of the equation till it looks like the
other side. The best way to prove the net
equation is not an identity is to plug in
numbers that break the identity. That is make
the equation not true. Now if you're just
trying to decide if an equation has an identity
or not, and not worried about proving it,
then I recommend plugging in numbers, or graphing
the left and right sides to see if those graphs
are the same. Recall that an identity is an
equation that holds for all values of the
variable. This video states and proves three
identities called the Pythagorean identities.
The first one is the familiar cosine squared
theta plus sine squared theta equals one.
The second one says tan squared theta plus
one equals secant squared theta. And the third
one goes cotangent squared theta plus one
equals cosecant squared theta. Let's start
by proving that cosine squared theta plus
sine squared theta equals one. I'll do this
by drawing the unit circle with a right triangle
inside it by the definition of sine and cosine,
the x&y coordinates of this top point, r cosine
theta and sine theta, the high partners, my
triangle is one, since that's the radius of
my unit circle. Now the length of the base
of my triangle is the same thing as the x
coordinate of this point. So that's equal
to cosine theta. The height of this triangle
is the same thing as the y coordinate of this
point. So that's sine theta. Now the Pythagoras
theorem for right triangles, says this side
length squared plus that side length squared
is equal to the hypothenar squared. So by
the Pythagorean theorem, we have that cosine
theta squared plus sine theta squared equals
one squared, I can rewrite that as cosine
squared theta plus sine squared theta equals
one, since one squared is one, and cosine
squared theta is just a shorthand notation
for cosine theta squared. That completes the
proof of the first Pythagorean identity, at
least in the case, when the angle theta is
in the first quadrant. In the case, when the
angle was in a different quadrant, you can
use symmetry to argue the same identity holds.
But I won't give the details here. To prove
the next Pythagorean identity, tan squared
theta plus one equals secant squared theta,
let's use the first without your an identity,
which said that cosine squared theta plus
sine squared theta equals one, I'm going to
divide both sides of this equation by cosine
squared theta. Now I'm going to rewrite the
left side by breaking apart the fraction into
cosine squared theta over cosine squared theta
plus sine squared theta over cosine squared
theta. Now cosine squared theta over cosine
squared theta is just one. And I can rewrite
the next fraction as sine of theta over cosine
of theta squared. That's because when I square
a fraction, I can just square the numerator
and square the denominator. And sine squared
theta is shorthand for sine of theta squares.
Similarly, for cosine squared theta. Now on
the other side of the equal sign, I can rewrite
this fraction as one over cosine theta squared.
Again, that's because when I square the fraction,
I just get the one squared, which is one divided
by the cosine theta squared, which is this.
I'm almost done. sine theta over cosine theta
is the same thing as tangent theta. And one
over cosine theta is the same thing as secant
theta. Using the shorthand notation, that
says one plus tan squared theta equals sequencer
data, which, after rearranging is exactly
the identity that we were looking for. The
proof of the third for that green identity
is very similar. Once again, I'll start with
the identity
is to use algebra and to use other identities,
like the Pythagorean identity to rewrite one
side of the equation till it looks like the
other side. The best way to prove the net
equation is not an identity is to plug in
numbers that break the identity. That is make
the equation not true. Now if you're just
trying to decide if an equation has an identity
or not, and not worried about proving it,
then I recommend plugging in numbers, or graphing
the left and right sides to see if those graphs
are the same. Recall that an identity is an
equation that holds for all values of the
variable. This video states and proves three
identities called the Pythagorean identities.
The first one is the familiar cosine squared
theta plus sine squared theta equals one.
The second one says tan squared theta plus
one equals secant squared theta. And the third
one goes cotangent squared theta plus one
equals cosecant squared theta. Let's start
by proving that cosine squared theta plus
sine squared theta equals one. I'll do this
by drawing the unit circle with a right triangle
inside it by the definition of sine and cosine,
the x&y coordinates of this top point, r cosine
theta and sine theta, the high partners, my
triangle is one, since that's the radius of
my unit circle. Now the length of the base
of my triangle is the same thing as the x
coordinate of this point. So that's equal
to cosine theta. The height of this triangle
is the same thing as the y coordinate of this
point. So that's sine theta. Now the Pythagoras
theorem for right triangles, says this side
length squared plus that side length squared
is equal to the hypothenar squared. So by
the Pythagorean theorem, we have that cosine
theta squared plus sine theta squared equals
one squared, I can rewrite that as cosine
squared theta plus sine squared theta equals
one, since one squared is one, and cosine
squared theta is just a shorthand notation
for cosine theta squared. That completes the
proof of the first Pythagorean identity, at
least in the case, when the angle theta is
in the first quadrant. In the case, when the
angle was in a different quadrant, you can
use symmetry to argue the same identity holds.
But I won't give the details here. To prove
the next Pythagorean identity, tan squared
theta plus one equals secant squared theta,
let's use the first without your an identity,
which said that cosine squared theta plus
sine squared theta equals one, I'm going to
divide both sides of this equation by cosine
squared theta. Now I'm going to rewrite the
left side by breaking apart the fraction into
cosine squared theta over cosine squared theta
plus sine squared theta over cosine squared
theta. Now cosine squared theta over cosine
squared theta is just one. And I can rewrite
the next fraction as sine of theta over cosine
of theta squared. That's because when I square
a fraction, I can just square the numerator
and square the denominator. And sine squared
theta is shorthand for sine of theta squares.
Similarly, for cosine squared theta. Now on
the other side of the equal sign, I can rewrite
this fraction as one over cosine theta squared.
Again, that's because when I square the fraction,
I just get the one squared, which is one divided
by the cosine theta squared, which is this.
I'm almost done. sine theta over cosine theta
is the same thing as tangent theta. And one
over cosine theta is the same thing as secant
theta. Using the shorthand notation, that
says one plus tan squared theta equals sequencer
data, which, after rearranging is exactly
the identity that we were looking for. The
proof of the third for that green identity
is very similar. Once again, I'll start with
the identity
cosine squared theta plus sine squared theta
equals one, and this time, I'll divide both
sides by sine squared theta. I'll break up
the fraction on the left. And now I'll rewrite
my fractions as cosine theta over sine theta
squared plus one equals one over sine theta
squared. cosine over sine can be written As
cotangent, and one over sine can be written
as cosecant. That gives me the identity that
I'm looking for. We've now proved three trig
identities. The first one, we proved using
the unit circle, and the Pythagorean Theorem.
The second and third identities, we proved
by using the first identity, and a bit of
algebra. The sum and difference formulas are
formulas for computing the sine of a sum of
two angles, the cosine of a sum of two angles,
the sine of a difference of two angles, and
the cosine of a difference of two angles.
Please pause the video for a moment to think
about this question. Is it true that the sine
of A plus B is equal to the sine of A plus
the sine of B? No, it's not true. And we can
see by an example, if we plug in say, A equals
pi over two and B equals pi, than the sine
of pi over two plus pi, is the same thing
as a sine of three pi over two, which is negative
one. Whereas the sine of pi over two plus
the sine of pi is equal to one plus zero,
which is one, negative one is not equal to
one. So this equation does not hold for all
values of a and b. There are a few values
of a and b for which it does hold. For example,
if a is zero, and B is zero, but it's not
true in general, instead, we need more complicated
formulas. It turns out that the sine of the
sum of two angles A plus B is given by sine
of A cosine of B plus cosine of A, sine of
B. The cosine of A plus B is given by cosine
A cosine B minus sine A sine Bay. I like to
remember these with a song, sine cosine cosine
sine cosine cosine minus sine sine. Please
feel free to back up the video and sing along
with me, I encourage you to memorize the two
formulas for the sine of a
cosine squared theta plus sine squared theta
equals one, and this time, I'll divide both
sides by sine squared theta. I'll break up
the fraction on the left. And now I'll rewrite
my fractions as cosine theta over sine theta
squared plus one equals one over sine theta
squared. cosine over sine can be written As
cotangent, and one over sine can be written
as cosecant. That gives me the identity that
I'm looking for. We've now proved three trig
identities. The first one, we proved using
the unit circle, and the Pythagorean Theorem.
The second and third identities, we proved
by using the first identity, and a bit of
algebra. The sum and difference formulas are
formulas for computing the sine of a sum of
two angles, the cosine of a sum of two angles,
the sine of a difference of two angles, and
the cosine of a difference of two angles.
Please pause the video for a moment to think
about this question. Is it true that the sine
of A plus B is equal to the sine of A plus
the sine of B? No, it's not true. And we can
see by an example, if we plug in say, A equals
pi over two and B equals pi, than the sine
of pi over two plus pi, is the same thing
as a sine of three pi over two, which is negative
one. Whereas the sine of pi over two plus
the sine of pi is equal to one plus zero,
which is one, negative one is not equal to
one. So this equation does not hold for all
values of a and b. There are a few values
of a and b for which it does hold. For example,
if a is zero, and B is zero, but it's not
true in general, instead, we need more complicated
formulas. It turns out that the sine of the
sum of two angles A plus B is given by sine
of A cosine of B plus cosine of A, sine of
B. The cosine of A plus B is given by cosine
A cosine B minus sine A sine Bay. I like to
remember these with a song, sine cosine cosine
sine cosine cosine minus sine sine. Please
feel free to back up the video and sing along
with me, I encourage you to memorize the two
formulas for the sine of a
sum of angles and the cosine of a sum of angles.
Once you do, it's easy to figure out the sine
and cosine of a difference of two angles.
One way to do this is to think of sine of
A minus B as sine of A plus negative B. And
then use the angle sum formula. So this works
out to sine cosine plus cosine, sine. And
now, if I use the fact that cosine is even,
I know that cosine of negative B is cosine
of B. And since sine is odd, sine of negative
b is negative sine of B. So I can rewrite
this as sine of A cosine of B minus cosine
of A sine of B. Notice that this new formula
for the difference is the same as the formula
for the sum is just that plus sign turned
into a minus sign. We can do the same trick
for cosine of A minus B, that's cosine of
A plus minus b, which is cosine A cosine minus
b minus sine of A sine of negative B. Again,
using even an odd properties, this gives us
cosine A cosine B plus sine A sine B. Once
again, the formula for the difference is almost
exactly like the for the song, just that minus
sign has switched to
a plus sign. Now let's use the angle sum formula
to find the exact value for the sign of 105
degrees. Now, 105 degrees is not a special
angle on the unit circle, but I can write
it as the sum of two special angles. I can
write it as 60 degrees plus 45 degrees. Therefore,
the sine of 105 degrees is the sine of 60
plus 45. And now by the angle some formula,
this is sine, cosine, cosine, sine. And I
for my Unit Circle, I can figure out that
sine of 60 degrees is root three over two
cosine of 45 degrees root two over two, cosine
of 60 degrees is one half, and sine of 45
degrees is root two over two. So this simplifies
to root six plus root two over four. For our
last example, let's find the cosine of v plus
W, given the values of cosine v and cosine
W, and the fact that v and w are angles in
the first quadrant. Remember, to compute the
cosine of a sum, we can't just add together
the two cosines. That wouldn't even make sense
in this case, because adding point nine and
point seven would give something bigger than
one and the cosine of something's never bigger
than one. Instead, we have to use the angle
sum formula for cosine. So that goes cosine
of v plus w equals cosine, cosine, minus sine,
sine. Now, I've already know the cosine of
v and the cosine of W, so I could just plug
those in. But I have to figure out the sine
of v and the sine of W from the given information.
And one way to do that is to draw right triangles.
So here, I'm going to draw a right triangle
with angle V,
A minus B as sine of A plus negative B. And
then use the angle sum formula. So this works
out to sine cosine plus cosine, sine. And
now, if I use the fact that cosine is even,
I know that cosine of negative B is cosine
of B. And since sine is odd, sine of negative
b is negative sine of B. So I can rewrite
this as sine of A cosine of B minus cosine
of A sine of B. Notice that this new formula
for the difference is the same as the formula
for the sum is just that plus sign turned
into a minus sign. We can do the same trick
for cosine of A minus B, that's cosine of
A plus minus b, which is cosine A cosine minus
b minus sine of A sine of negative B. Again,
using even an odd properties, this gives us
cosine A cosine B plus sine A sine B. Once
again, the formula for the difference is almost
exactly like the for the song, just that minus
sign has switched to a plus sign. Now let's
use the angle sum formula to find the exact
value for the sign of 105 degrees. Now, 105
degrees is not a special angle on the unit
circle, but I can write it as the sum of two
special angles. I can write it as 60 degrees
plus 45 degrees. Therefore, the sine of 105
degrees is the sine of 60 plus 45. And now
by the angle some formula, this is sine, cosine,
cosine, sine. And I for my Unit Circle, I
can figure out that sine of 60 degrees is
root three over two cosine of 45 degrees root
two over two, cosine of 60 degrees is one
half, and sine of 45 degrees is root two over
two. So this simplifies to root six plus root
two over four. For our last example, let's
find the cosine of v plus W, given the values
of cosine v and cosine W, and the fact that
v and w are angles in the first quadrant.
Remember, to compute the cosine of a sum,
we can't just add together the two cosines.
That wouldn't even make sense in this case,
because adding point nine and point seven
would give something bigger than one and the
cosine of something's never bigger than one.
Instead, we have to use the angle sum formula
for cosine. So that goes cosine of v plus
w equals cosine, cosine, minus sine, sine.
Now, I've already know the cosine of v and
the cosine of W, so I could just plug those
in. But I have to figure out the sine of v
and the sine of W from the given information.
And one way to do that is to draw right triangles.
So here, I'm going to draw a right triangle
with angle V,
and another right triangle with angle W. Since
I know that the cosine of V is point nine,
I can think of that as nine over 10.
and another right triangle with angle W. Since
I know that the cosine of V is point nine,
I can think of that as nine over 10.
And I can think of that as adjacent over hypotenuse
in my right triangle. So I'll decorate my
triangles adjacent side with the number nine
and the hypotenuse with 10. Similarly, since
I know that the cosine of W is point seven,
which is seven tenths, I can put a seven on
this adjacent side, and a 10 on this iPod
news. Now, the Pythagorean Theorem, lets me
compute the length of the unlabeled side.
So this one is going to be the square root
of 10 squared minus nine squared, that's going
to be the square root of 19. And here I have
the square root of 10 squared minus seven
squared. So that's the square root of 51.
I can now find the sign of V as the opposite
over the hi partners. So that's the square
root of 19 over 10. And the sign of W will
be the square root of 51 over 10. Because
we're assuming v and w are in the first quadrant,
we know the values of sign need to be positive,
so we don't need to Jimmy around with positive
or negative signs in our answers, we can just
leave them as is.
And I can think of that as adjacent over hypotenuse
in my right triangle. So I'll decorate my
triangles adjacent side with the number nine
and the hypotenuse with 10. Similarly, since
I know that the cosine of W is point seven,
which is seven tenths, I can put a seven on
this adjacent side, and a 10 on this iPod
news. Now, the Pythagorean Theorem, lets me
compute the length of the unlabeled side.
So this one is going to be the square root
of 10 squared minus nine squared, that's going
to be the square root of 19. And here I have
the square root of 10 squared minus seven
squared. So that's the square root of 51.
I can now find the sign of V as the opposite
over the hi partners. So that's the square
root of 19 over 10. And the sign of W will
be the square root of 51 over 10. Because
we're assuming v and w are in the first quadrant,
we know the values of sign need to be positive,
so we don't need to Jimmy around with positive
or negative signs in our answers, we can just
leave them as is.
Now we're ready to plug into our formula.
So we have that cosine of v plus w is equal
to point nine times point seven minus the
square root of 19 over 10, times the square
root of 51 over 10.
Now we're ready to plug into our formula.
So we have that cosine of v plus w is equal
to point nine times point seven minus the
square root of 19 over 10, times the square
root of 51 over 10.
using a calculator, this works out to a decimal
approximation of 0.3187. This video gave the
angle sum and difference formulas and use
them to compute some values. To see a proof
for why the sum formulas hold, please watch
my other video. This video gives formulas
for sine of two theta and cosine of two theta.
Please pause the video for a moment and see
if you think this equation sine of two theta
equals two sine theta is true or false. Remember
that true means always true for all values
of theta were false means sometimes they're
always false. This equation is false, because
it's not true for all values of theta. One
way to see this is graphically, if I graph
y equals sine of two theta, that's like the
graph of sine theta, squished in horizontally
by a factor of one half. On the other hand,
if I graph y equals two sine beta, that's
like the graph of sine theta stretched vertically
by a factor of two. These two graphs are not
the same. So instead, we need a more complicated
formula for sine of two theta. And that formula
is sine of two theta is two sine theta, cosine
theta. It's not hard to see why that formula
works based on the angle some formula. Recall
that sine of A plus B is equal to sine A cosine
B plus cosine A sign Therefore, sine of two
theta, which is sine of theta plus theta is
going to be sine theta, cosine theta, plus
cosine theta sine theta. simply plugging in
theta for a and theta for B, in this angle,
some formula, will sine theta cosine theta
is the same thing as cosine theta sine theta.
So I can rewrite this as twice sine theta
cosine theta. That gives me this formula.
There's also a formula for cosine of two theta.
And that formula is cosine squared theta minus
sine squared theta. Again, we can use the
angle sum formula to see where this comes
from. cosine of A plus B is equal to cosine
of A cosine of B minus sine A, sine B. So
if we want cosine of two theta, that's just
cosine of theta plus theta, which is cosine
theta, cosine theta, minus sine theta, sine
theta by plugging in beta for a and b, this
can be rewritten as cosine squared theta minus
sine squared theta, which is exactly the formula
above. Now there are a couple other formulas
for cosine of two theta that are also popular.
One of them is one minus two sine squared
theta. And the other one is cosine of two
theta is two cosine squared theta minus one,
you can get each of these two formulas from
the original one using the Pythagorean identity.
We know that cosine squared theta plus sine
squared theta is one. So cosine squared theta
is one minus sine squared theta. If I plug
that into my original formula, which I've
copied here, so I'm plugging in, instead of
cosine squared, I'm gonna write one minus
sine squared theta, I still have a nother
minus sine squared theta. So that's the same
thing as one minus twice science grid data,
which is exactly what I'm looking for. Similarly,
I can use the Pythagorean identity to write
sine squared theta as one minus cosine squared
theta. Again, I'll take this equation and
copy it below. But this time, I'm going to
plug in for sine squared right here. So that
gives me cosine of two theta is cosine squared
theta minus the quantity one minus cosine
squared theta. That simplifies to two cosine
squared theta minus one after distributing
the negative sign and combining like terms.
using a calculator, this works out to a decimal
approximation of 0.3187. This video gave the
angle sum and difference formulas and use
them to compute some values. To see a proof
for why the sum formulas hold, please watch
my other video. This video gives formulas
for sine of two theta and cosine of two theta.
Please pause the video for a moment and see
if you think this equation sine of two theta
equals two sine theta is true or false. Remember
that true means always true for all values
of theta were false means sometimes they're
always false. This equation is false, because
it's not true for all values of theta. One
way to see this is graphically, if I graph
y equals sine of two theta, that's like the
graph of sine theta, squished in horizontally
by a factor of one half. On the other hand,
if I graph y equals two sine beta, that's
like the graph of sine theta stretched vertically
by a factor of two. These two graphs are not
the same. So instead, we need a more complicated
formula for sine of two theta. And that formula
is sine of two theta is two sine theta, cosine
theta. It's not hard to see why that formula
works based on the angle some formula. Recall
that sine of A plus B is equal to sine A cosine
B plus cosine A sign Therefore, sine of two
theta, which is sine of theta plus theta is
going to be sine theta, cosine theta, plus
cosine theta sine theta. simply plugging in
theta for a and theta for B, in this angle,
some formula, will sine theta cosine theta
is the same thing as cosine theta sine theta.
So I can rewrite this as twice sine theta
cosine theta. That gives me this formula.
There's also a formula for cosine of two theta.
And that formula is cosine squared theta minus
sine squared theta. Again, we can use the
angle sum formula to see where this comes
from. cosine of A plus B is equal to cosine
of A cosine of B minus sine A, sine B. So
if we want cosine of two theta, that's just
cosine of theta plus theta, which is cosine
theta, cosine theta, minus sine theta, sine
theta by plugging in beta for a and b, this
can be rewritten as cosine squared theta minus
sine squared theta, which is exactly the formula
above. Now there are a couple other formulas
for cosine of two theta that are also popular.
One of them is one minus two sine squared
theta. And the other one is cosine of two
theta is two cosine squared theta minus one,
you can get each of these two formulas from
the original one using the Pythagorean identity.
We know that cosine squared theta plus sine
squared theta is one. So cosine squared theta
is one minus sine squared theta. If I plug
that into my original formula, which I've
copied here, so I'm plugging in, instead of
cosine squared, I'm gonna write one minus
sine squared theta, I still have a nother
minus sine squared theta. So that's the same
thing as one minus twice science grid data,
which is exactly what I'm looking for. Similarly,
I can use the Pythagorean identity to write
sine squared theta as one minus cosine squared
theta. Again, I'll take this equation and
copy it below. But this time, I'm going to
plug in for sine squared right here. So that
gives me cosine of two theta is cosine squared
theta minus the quantity one minus cosine
squared theta. That simplifies to two cosine
squared theta minus one after distributing
the negative sign and combining like terms.
So I have one double angle formula for sine
of two theta. And I have three versions of
the double angle formula for cosine of two
theta.
So I have one double angle formula for sine
of two theta. And I have three versions of
the double angle formula for cosine of two
theta.
Now let's use these formulas in some examples.
Let's find the cosine of two theta. If we
know that cosine theta is negative one over
root 10, and theta terminates in quadrant
three, we have a choice of three formulas
for cosine of two theta, I'm going to choose
the second one, because it only involves cosine
if they had on the right side. And they already
know my value for cosine theta. Of course,
I could use one of the other ones,
Now let's use these formulas in some examples.
Let's find the cosine of two theta. If we
know that cosine theta is negative one over
root 10, and theta terminates in quadrant
three, we have a choice of three formulas
for cosine of two theta, I'm going to choose
the second one, because it only involves cosine
if they had on the right side. And they already
know my value for cosine theta. Of course,
I could use one of the other ones,
but then I'd have to work out the value of
sine theta. So plugging in, I get cosine of
two theta is twice negative one over root
n squared minus one, which simplifies to two
tenths minus one or negative eight tenths,
negative four fifths. Finally, let's solve
the equation two cosine x plus sine of 2x
equals zero. What makes this equation tricky
is that one of the trig functions has the
argument of just x, but the other tree function
has the argument of 2x. So I want to use my
double angle formula to rewrite sine of 2x.
I'll copy down the two cosine x, and now sine
of 2x is equal to two sine x cosine x. At
this point, I see a way to factor my equation,
I can factor out a two cosine x from both
of these two terms. That gives me one plus
sine x and the product there is equal to zero.
That means that either two cosine x is equal
to zero One plus sine x is equal to zero,
that simplifies to cosine x equals zero, or
sine x is negative one. Using my unit circle,
I see that cosine of x is zero at pi over
two, and three pi over two, while sine of
x is negative one at three pi over two, there's
some redundancy here, but my solution set
is going to be pi over two plus multiples
of two pi, and three pi over two plus multiples
of two pi. This video proved the double angle
formulas, sine of two theta is two sine theta
cosine theta. and cosine of two theta is cosine
squared theta minus sine squared theta. It
also proved to alternate versions of the equation
for cosine of two theta. This video introduces
higher order derivatives and notation. We've
seen that f prime of x denotes the derivative
of the function f of x, but f prime of x is
also itself a function. So we can take its
derivative, that would be f prime prime of
x, which is usually written instead as f double
prime of x. This is called the second derivative
of f. And it means the derivative of the derivative,
we can also talk about the third derivative,
f triple prime of x, which might sometimes
be written f to the three of x if you get
tired of writing all those primes, and we
can talk about the nth derivative f, parentheses
n of x, the parentheses here are important
to show that it's the nth derivative. The
second, third and nth derivative are referred
to as higher order
but then I'd have to work out the value of
sine theta. So plugging in, I get cosine of
two theta is twice negative one over root
n squared minus one, which simplifies to two
tenths minus one or negative eight tenths,
negative four fifths. Finally, let's solve
the equation two cosine x plus sine of 2x
equals zero. What makes this equation tricky
is that one of the trig functions has the
argument of just x, but the other tree function
has the argument of 2x. So I want to use my
double angle formula to rewrite sine of 2x.
I'll copy down the two cosine x, and now sine
of 2x is equal to two sine x cosine x. At
this point, I see a way to factor my equation,
I can factor out a two cosine x from both
of these two terms. That gives me one plus
sine x and the product there is equal to zero.
That means that either two cosine x is equal
to zero One plus sine x is equal to zero,
that simplifies to cosine x equals zero, or
sine x is negative one. Using my unit circle,
I see that cosine of x is zero at pi over
two, and three pi over two, while sine of
x is negative one at three pi over two, there's
some redundancy here, but my solution set
is going to be pi over two plus multiples
of two pi, and three pi over two plus multiples
of two pi. This video proved the double angle
formulas, sine of two theta is two sine theta
cosine theta. and cosine of two theta is cosine
squared theta minus sine squared theta. It
also proved to alternate versions of the equation
for cosine of two theta. This video introduces
higher order derivatives and notation. We've
seen that f prime of x denotes the derivative
of the function f of x, but f prime of x is
also itself a function. So we can take its
derivative, that would be f prime prime of
x, which is usually written instead as f double
prime of x. This is called the second derivative
of f. And it means the derivative of the derivative,
we can also talk about the third derivative,
f triple prime of x, which might sometimes
be written f to the three of x if you get
tired of writing all those primes, and we
can talk about the nth derivative f, parentheses
n of x, the parentheses here are important
to show that it's the nth derivative. The
second, third and nth derivative are referred
to as higher order
derivatives.
There are many alternative notations for derivatives
stemming from their tangled and contentious
history in the 1600s. There are a few different
notations for functions themselves. Most often
we write a function of something like f of
x, but we can also use the variable y to refer
to the output of a function. When we're looking
at the first derivative. We've been using
the notation f prime of x. But you might also
see y prime, this means the same thing. Another
notation is df dx, is known as lug nuts denotation.
After five minutes, you might see something
like dy dx of f of x. And you might see dy
dx, another version of Lebanon's notation.
Sometimes you'll also see a capital D used
to refer to the derivative. If we're looking
at the second derivative, we've seen that
in Haitian f double prime of x, y double prime
is a similar notation, or we might write dy
dx of df
There are many alternative notations for derivatives
stemming from their tangled and contentious
history in the 1600s. There are a few different
notations for functions themselves. Most often
we write a function of something like f of
x, but we can also use the variable y to refer
to the output of a function. When we're looking
at the first derivative. We've been using
the notation f prime of x. But you might also
see y prime, this means the same thing. Another
notation is df dx, is known as lug nuts denotation.
After five minutes, you might see something
like dy dx of f of x. And you might see dy
dx, another version of Lebanon's notation.
Sometimes you'll also see a capital D used
to refer to the derivative. If we're looking
at the second derivative, we've seen that
in Haitian f double prime of x, y double prime
is a similar notation, or we might write dy
dx of df
dx.
And the shorthand for that is d squared f
dx squared. Similarly, we might write d squared
y dx squared using y in the place of F for
the function.
And the shorthand for that is d squared f
dx squared. Similarly, we might write d squared
y dx squared using y in the place of F for
the function.
There's similar notations for third derivative,
I'll jump ahead to nth derivatives. So that
would be F to the n of x, or y to the n, d
to the n of f dx to the n, or D to the n of
y dx to the N. When using live minutes notation,
we want to emphasize that we're evaluating
our derivative at a particular value of x,
we might write something like at x equals
three, or at x equals a, using a vertical
line. For better or for worse, you'll need
to become familiar with all of these alternative
notations.
There's similar notations for third derivative,
I'll jump ahead to nth derivatives. So that
would be F to the n of x, or y to the n, d
to the n of f dx to the n, or D to the n of
y dx to the N. When using live minutes notation,
we want to emphasize that we're evaluating
our derivative at a particular value of x,
we might write something like at x equals
three, or at x equals a, using a vertical
line. For better or for worse, you'll need
to become familiar with all of these alternative
notations.
That's all for this video on higher order
derivatives and notation. This video is about
the derivative of e to the x, one of my favorite
functions ever simply because it has such
a great derivative. As you may recall, he
is an irrational number whose decimal approximation
is something like 2.718 looks like it's repeating.
But then it keeps going on forever, never
repeating never terminating.
That's all for this video on higher order
derivatives and notation. This video is about
the derivative of e to the x, one of my favorite
functions ever simply because it has such
a great derivative. As you may recall, he
is an irrational number whose decimal approximation
is something like 2.718 looks like it's repeating.
But then it keeps going on forever, never
repeating never terminating.
Its value notice is somewhere in between two
and three. Here is a graph of y equals e to
the x.
Its value notice is somewhere in between two
and three. Here is a graph of y equals e to
the x.
It says exponential function increase thing
looks a lot like two to the x or three to
the x, not only is the graph of e to the x
increasing, but it's increasing more and more
rapidly. So for negative values of x, the
slope of this graph is positive but very close
to zero. Over here, when x equals zero, that
slope is looks like approximately a slope
of one, we'll see that it is in fact exactly
one. And as the x values increase, this tangent
lines get steeper and steeper. I'm going to
state without proof, three really useful facts
about E. First, if you take the limit, as
n goes to infinity of one plus one over N
raised to the nth power, that limit exists
and equals E, you might have seen something
like that when you took precalculus, and looked
at compound interest compounded over smaller
and smaller time periods. But even if you
haven't seen it before, it's a really important
fact worth memorizing, you'll see it again
later in the class. A second important formula
is that the limit as h goes to zero of e to
the H minus one over h equals one. Now this
expression here on the left may remind you
of a derivative, in fact, I can rewrite it
as the limit as h goes to zero of e to the
zero plus h minus e to the zero since either
the zero is one over h, that's equal to one.
And this expression right here on the left
is just the derivative of e to the x at x
equals zero, according to the limit definition
of derivative. So this fact, is really saying
that the derivative of e to the x at x equals
zero, that derivative is equal to one. So
for the third fat,
It says exponential function increase thing
looks a lot like two to the x or three to
the x, not only is the graph of e to the x
increasing, but it's increasing more and more
rapidly. So for negative values of x, the
slope of this graph is positive but very close
to zero. Over here, when x equals zero, that
slope is looks like approximately a slope
of one, we'll see that it is in fact exactly
one. And as the x values increase, this tangent
lines get steeper and steeper. I'm going to
state without proof, three really useful facts
about E. First, if you take the limit, as
n goes to infinity of one plus one over N
raised to the nth power, that limit exists
and equals E, you might have seen something
like that when you took precalculus, and looked
at compound interest compounded over smaller
and smaller time periods. But even if you
haven't seen it before, it's a really important
fact worth memorizing, you'll see it again
later in the class. A second important formula
is that the limit as h goes to zero of e to
the H minus one over h equals one. Now this
expression here on the left may remind you
of a derivative, in fact, I can rewrite it
as the limit as h goes to zero of e to the
zero plus h minus e to the zero since either
the zero is one over h, that's equal to one.
And this expression right here on the left
is just the derivative of e to the x at x
equals zero, according to the limit definition
of derivative. So this fact, is really saying
that the derivative of e to the x at x equals
zero, that derivative is equal to one. So
for the third fat,
the third fact,
it talks about the derivative of e to the
x in general. And that third fact is that
the derivative of the function, either the
X is the function, e to the x, e to the x
is its own derivative. So this is a generalized
version of the second fact. Because the second
fact is saying that the derivative at x equals
zero is one, well, one is just the same thing
as e to the zero. So it saying the drought
of either the exit at x equals zero is equal
to zero. And in general, the derivative of
e to the x at any x is just e to the x. Now,
fact, one is frequently taken as the definition
of E. Sometimes fact two instead is taken
as a definition of he, since he is the unique
number with this, this property, the unique
number, you can plug in here and get this
limit equal one, it's possible to prove that
fact one implies fact two and vice versa.
But I won't do that here. It's also possible
to prove that fact two implies fact three
about the derivative in general. And that's
pretty straightforward from the definition
of derivative. So I will show you that argument.
So let's start out assuming fact to and try
to prove fact three using the definition of
direct by the definition of derivative. The
derivative of e to the x is the limit as h
goes to zero of e to the x plus h minus e
to the x over h. If I factor out an E to the
X, from both terms on the numerator, I get
the limit of e to the x times e to the H minus
one over h. Notice that e to the x times e
to the H is in the x plus h by the exponent
rules. Now, either the X has nothing to do
with H, so it's just a constant as far as
H is concerned. And I can pull it all the
way out of the limit sign and rewrite this
limit. Now by factor two, which I'm assuming
this limit here is just one, which means that
my derivative
it talks about the derivative of e to the
x in general. And that third fact is that
the derivative of the function, either the
X is the function, e to the x, e to the x
is its own derivative. So this is a generalized
version of the second fact. Because the second
fact is saying that the derivative at x equals
zero is one, well, one is just the same thing
as e to the zero. So it saying the drought
of either the exit at x equals zero is equal
to zero. And in general, the derivative of
e to the x at any x is just e to the x. Now,
fact, one is frequently taken as the definition
of E. Sometimes fact two instead is taken
as a definition of he, since he is the unique
number with this, this property, the unique
number, you can plug in here and get this
limit equal one, it's possible to prove that
fact one implies fact two and vice versa.
But I won't do that here. It's also possible
to prove that fact two implies fact three
about the derivative in general. And that's
pretty straightforward from the definition
of derivative. So I will show you that argument.
So let's start out assuming fact to and try
to prove fact three using the definition of
direct by the definition of derivative. The
derivative of e to the x is the limit as h
goes to zero of e to the x plus h minus e
to the x over h. If I factor out an E to the
X, from both terms on the numerator, I get
the limit of e to the x times e to the H minus
one over h. Notice that e to the x times e
to the H is in the x plus h by the exponent
rules. Now, either the X has nothing to do
with H, so it's just a constant as far as
H is concerned. And I can pull it all the
way out of the limit sign and rewrite this
limit. Now by factor two, which I'm assuming
this limit here is just one, which means that
my derivative
is e to the x, just like I wanted to show.
Here's a slightly tricky example, asking you
to compute the derivative of a function that
involves lots of ears and X's
is e to the x, just like I wanted to show.
Here's a slightly tricky example, asking you
to compute the derivative of a function that
involves lots of ears and X's
combined in lots of different ways. You'll
need to use not only the rule for the derivative
of e to the x that we just talked about, but
also the power rule and other rules. derivatives
that we've talked about
combined in lots of different ways. You'll
need to use not only the rule for the derivative
of e to the x that we just talked about, but
also the power rule and other rules. derivatives
that we've talked about
earlier.
So please pause the video and try to compute
this derivative yourself paying careful attention
to what's a variable and what's the constant.
So please pause the video and try to compute
this derivative yourself paying careful attention
to what's a variable and what's the constant.
Okay, so we're taking the derivative here
with respect to x, that's our variable. And
I'm taking the derivative of this entire expression,
which I can split up as a sum of derivatives.
For the first term, I can just use the power
rule, E is a constant coefficient, so I just
need to take down the exponent of two multiplied
on the front, times x to the One Power. Now
for the second part,
Okay, so we're taking the derivative here
with respect to x, that's our variable. And
I'm taking the derivative of this entire expression,
which I can split up as a sum of derivatives.
For the first term, I can just use the power
rule, E is a constant coefficient, so I just
need to take down the exponent of two multiplied
on the front, times x to the One Power. Now
for the second part,
here, I do have my either the x function multiplied
by two, so its derivative is just two times
the derivative of e to the x, which is either
the X
here, I do have my either the x function multiplied
by two, so its derivative is just two times
the derivative of e to the x, which is either
the X
for my third part, I have just x times a constant
e squared. So the derivative of x is one times
that constant. And so I just get e squared.
Finally, to take the derivative of x to the
power of E squared, I can use the power rule
because my variable is in the base, and I
have a constant e squared in my exponent.
So using the power rule, I bring down the
E squared times that by x and subtract one
from the exponent. This video states the happy
fact that the derivative of e to the x is
just e to
for my third part, I have just x times a constant
e squared. So the derivative of x is one times
that constant. And so I just get e squared.
Finally, to take the derivative of x to the
power of E squared, I can use the power rule
because my variable is in the base, and I
have a constant e squared in my exponent.
So using the power rule, I bring down the
E squared times that by x and subtract one
from the exponent. This video states the happy
fact that the derivative of e to the x is
just e to
the x. This video prove some of the rules
for taking derivatives.
First, the constant row, it makes sense that
the derivative of a constant real number has
to be zero, because the slope of a horizontal
line
First, the constant row, it makes sense that
the derivative of a constant real number has
to be zero, because the slope of a horizontal
line
is zero.
But we can also prove this fact, using the
limit definition of derivative. The derivative
of any function is the limit as h goes to
zero of the function of x plus h minus the
function at x divided by H. Well, here, our
function is just a constant. So we're taking
the limit as h goes to zero of the constant
minus the constant divided by h, which is
just the limit as h goes to zero of zero over
h, which is just the limit of zero, which
is zero. Intuitively, it also makes sense
that the derivative of the function y equals
x is got to be one, because the graph of y
equals x is a straight line with slope one.
But again, we can prove this using the limit
definition of derivative. So the derivative
of x is the limit as h goes to zero of x plus
h minus x over h. Well, that simplifies to
the limit of h over h, since the Xs can't
So in other words, the limit as h goes to
zero of one, which is one as wanted
But we can also prove this fact, using the
limit definition of derivative. The derivative
of any function is the limit as h goes to
zero of
the function of x plus h minus the function
at x divided by H. Well, here, our function
is just a constant. So we're taking the limit
as h goes to zero of the constant minus the
constant divided by h, which is just the limit
as h goes to zero of zero over h, which is
just the limit of zero, which is zero. Intuitively,
it also makes sense that the derivative of
the function y equals x is got to be one,
because the graph of y equals x is a straight
line with slope one. But again, we can prove
this using the limit definition of derivative.
So the derivative of x is the limit as h goes
to zero of x plus h minus x over h. Well,
that simplifies to the limit of h over h,
since the Xs can't So in other words, the
limit as h goes to zero of one, which is one
as wanted
x,
h to the n minus one, and then finally, a
term of h to the N. That's the binomial expansion
of x plus h to the n. Now, we still have to
subtract the x to the n that we had up here,
and we still have to divide this whole thing
by H. Okay, that's looking kind of horribly
complicated.
h to the n minus one, and then finally, a
term of h to the N. That's the binomial expansion
of x plus h to the n. Now, we still have to
subtract the x to the n that we had up here,
and we still have to divide this whole thing
by H. Okay, that's looking kind of horribly
complicated.
But
notice that the X to the ends can So notice
that all of the remaining terms have an H
in them. So if we factor out that H, we get
an x to the n minus one, plus a bunch of other
terms. And canceling the H's,
notice that the X to the ends can So notice
that all of the remaining terms have an H
in them. So if we factor out that H, we get
an x to the n minus one, plus a bunch of other
terms. And canceling the H's,
we get
one term that doesn't have any ages in it,
and another bunch of terms that all have H's
in them, as h goes to zero, all these other
terms drop out because they go to zero. And
what we're left with is simply n times x to
the n minus one, which is exactly what we
want for the power role. I think that's a
pretty good proof if you're comfortable with
the binomial formula. But if you haven't seen
the binomial formula before, that might leave
you feeling a little cold. So I'm going to
offer you another proof using the other form
of the limit definition of derivative. So
let me clear some space here. And I'll start
over using this definition, f prime at a is
the limit as x goes to a of our function evaluated
at x. So that's x to the n minus our function
evaluated at a, that's a to the n over x minus
a. Again, I'm going to need to rewrite things
in order to evaluate this limit, since it's
currently in a zero over zero and determinant
form. So I'm going to rewrite the top by factoring
out a copy of x minus a, which gives me x
to the n minus one plus x to the n minus two
A plus x to the n minus three A squared, you
see the pattern here. And I keep going until
I get to x a to the n minus two and finally
a to the n minus one, that's still over x
minus a, you can verify this factoring formula,
simply by multiplying out and checking that
you In fact, do get x to the n minus a to
the n, after all your intermediate terms cancel.
Now that I've factored, I can cancel my x
minus a, and simply evaluate my limit by plugging
in x equal to A to get a to the n minus one
plus a to the n minus two A plus, and so on
each of these terms is equal to a to the n
minus one. And there are a total of n terms,
since we got them from the terms above that
started with x to the n minus one and did
with x to the zero. So that's n terms. So
that means we've got a final sum of n times
a to the n minus one for a derivative f prime
of A, which is exactly what we wanted to show.
Next, I'll prove the constant multiple rule
that says that if c is a real number constant,
and f is a differentiable function, then the
derivative of a constant times f is just the
constant times the derivative of f. Starting
with the limit definition of derivative, I
have that the derivative of C times f of x
is the limit as h goes to zero of C times
f of x plus h minus c times f of x over h.
Now if I factor out the constant C, from both
of these terms, and actually I can pull it
all the way out of the limit side, since the
constant has nothing to do with h. So now
I get that was equal to the constant times
the limit as h goes to zero of f of x plus
h minus f of x over h, which is just a constant
times the derivative of f, which is what we
wanted to prove.
one term that doesn't have any ages in it,
and another bunch of terms that all have H's
in them, as h goes to zero, all these other
terms drop out because they go to zero. And
what we're left with is simply n times x to
the n minus one, which is exactly what we
want for the power role. I think that's a
pretty good proof if you're comfortable with
the binomial formula. But if you haven't seen
the binomial formula before, that might leave
you feeling a little cold. So I'm going to
offer you another proof using the other form
of the limit definition of derivative. So
let me clear some space here. And I'll start
over using this definition, f prime at a is
the limit as x goes to a of our function evaluated
at x. So that's x to the n minus our function
evaluated at a, that's a to the n over x minus
a. Again, I'm going to need to rewrite things
in order to evaluate this limit, since it's
currently in a zero over zero and determinant
form. So I'm going to rewrite the top by factoring
out a copy of x minus a, which gives me x
to the n minus one plus x to the n minus two
A plus x to the n minus three A squared, you
see the pattern here. And I keep going until
I get to x a to the n minus two and finally
a to the n minus one, that's still over x
minus a, you can verify this factoring formula,
simply by multiplying out and checking that
you In fact, do get x to the n minus a to
the n, after all your intermediate terms cancel.
Now that I've factored, I can cancel my x
minus a, and simply evaluate my limit by plugging
in x equal to A to get a to the n minus one
plus a to the n minus two A plus, and so on
each of these terms is equal to a to the n
minus one. And there are a total of n terms,
since we got them from the terms above that
started with x to the n minus one and did
with x to the zero. So that's n terms. So
that means we've got a final sum of n times
a to the n minus one for a derivative f prime
of A, which is exactly what we wanted to show.
Next, I'll prove the constant multiple rule
that says that if c is a real number constant,
and f is a differentiable function, then the
derivative of a constant times f is just the
constant times the derivative of f. Starting
with the limit definition of derivative, I
have that the derivative of C times f of x
is the limit as h goes to zero of C times
f of x plus h minus c times f of x over h.
Now if I factor out the constant C, from both
of these terms, and actually I can pull it
all the way out of the limit side, since the
constant has nothing to do with h. So now
I get that was equal to the constant times
the limit as h goes to zero of f of x plus
h minus f of x over h, which is just a constant
times the derivative of f, which is what we
wanted to prove.
The difference rule can be proved just like
the sum rule by writing out the definition
of derivative and regrouping terms. Or we
could use kind of a sneaky shortcut, and put
together two of our previous roles. So if
we think of f of x minus g of x as being f
of x plus minus one times g of x, then we
can use the sum rule to rewrite this as a
sum of derivatives, and then use the constant
multiplier rule to pull the constant of negative
one out, and then we have exactly what we
wanted to prove. So in this video, we gave
the proof of the content multiple rule, the
summon difference rules, and a proof of the
power rule when n is a positive integer. This
video gives rules for calculating derivatives
of functions that are products, or quotients
of other functions. In this video, you'll
find statements of the product rule and the
quotient rule, and some examples. But no proofs,
proofs are in a separate video. Before we
start, let's recall the Psalm and the difference
rules. If f and g are differentiable functions,
then the derivative of the psalm f of x plus
g of x is just the sum of the derivatives.
And a similar statement holds for differences.
The derivative of the difference is the difference
of the derivatives. So does the same sort
of rule hold for products of functions, in
other words, is the derivative of the product
equal to the product of the derivatives? Let's
look at a simple example. To find out. For
example, if f of x is x, and g of x is x squared,
then if we take the derivative of the product,
x times x squared, well, that's just the derivative
of x cubed. We know how to do that with the
power rule. So it's 3x squared. On the other
hand, if we look at the product of the derivatives,
we get one times 2x or just 2x. And these
two things are not equal. So unfortunately,
the answer is no such a simple product rule
does not hold. But not lose hope. There is
a product rule, it's just a little more complicated
than the sum and difference rule. The product
rule says that
if f and g are differentiable functions, then
the derivative of the product f of x times
g of x is equal to f of x times the derivative
of g of x plus the derivative of f of x times
g of x. In other words, to take the derivative
of a product, we take the first function times
the derivative of the second, plus the derivative
of the first times the second. Let's use this
in an example. To take the derivative of the
square root of t times e to the t, we have
to take the first function squared of t times
the derivative of the second function, plus
the derivative of the first function
The difference rule can be proved just like
the sum rule by writing out the definition
of derivative and regrouping terms. Or we
could use kind of a sneaky shortcut, and put
together two of our previous roles. So if
we think of f of x minus g of x as being f
of x plus minus one times g of x, then we
can use the sum rule to rewrite this as a
sum of derivatives, and then use the constant
multiplier rule to pull the constant of negative
one out, and then we have exactly what we
wanted to prove. So in this video, we gave
the proof of the content multiple rule, the
summon difference rules, and a proof of the
power rule when n is a positive integer. This
video gives rules for calculating derivatives
of functions that are products, or quotients
of other functions. In this video, you'll
find statements of the product rule and the
quotient rule, and some examples. But no proofs,
proofs are in a separate video. Before we
start, let's recall the Psalm and the difference
rules. If f and g are differentiable functions,
then the derivative of the psalm f of x plus
g of x is just the sum of the derivatives.
And a similar statement holds for differences.
The derivative of the difference is the difference
of the derivatives. So does the same sort
of rule hold for products of functions, in
other words, is the derivative of the product
equal to the product of the derivatives? Let's
look at a simple example. To find out. For
example, if f of x is x, and g of x is x squared,
then if we take the derivative of the product,
x times x squared, well, that's just the derivative
of x cubed. We know how to do that with the
power rule. So it's 3x squared. On the other
hand, if we look at the product of the derivatives,
we get one times 2x or just 2x. And these
two things are not equal. So unfortunately,
the answer is no such a simple product rule
does not hold. But not lose hope. There is
a product rule, it's just a little more complicated
than the sum and difference rule. The product
rule says that if f and g are differentiable
functions, then the derivative of the product
f of x times g of x is equal to f of x times
the derivative of g of x plus the derivative
of f of x times g of x. In other words, to
take the derivative of a product, we take
the first function times the derivative of
the second, plus the derivative of the first
times the second. Let's use this in an example.
To take the derivative of the square root
of t times e to the t, we have to take the
first function squared of t times the derivative
of the second function, plus the derivative
of the first function
times the second function. So that's the square
root of t times the derivative of e to the
t is just e to the t.
times the second function. So that's the square
root of t times the derivative of e to the
t is just e to the t.
And to find the derivative of the square root
of t, it's going to be easier to write it
in exponential form. Now we can just use the
power roll. Bring down the one half t to the
one half minus one is negative one half and
I found the derivative. I'm going to clean
this up a little bit, and I'm done. quotient
rule says that the derivative of a quotient
of two functions
And to find the derivative of the square root
of t, it's going to be easier to write it
in exponential form. Now we can just use the
power roll. Bring down the one half t to the
one half minus one is negative one half and
I found the derivative. I'm going to clean
this up a little bit, and I'm done. quotient
rule says that the derivative of a quotient
of two functions
is given By this quotient on the denominator,
we have the denominator function g of x squared.
And on the numerator, we have g of x times
the derivative
is given By this quotient on the denominator,
we have the denominator function g of x squared.
And on the numerator, we have g of x times
the derivative
of f of x
minus f of x times the derivative of g of
x. The way I remember this is this chant.
If you think of f of x as the high function,
and g of x is a low function, you can say
this is low D high minus high D low
minus f of x times the derivative of g of
x. The way I remember this is this chant.
If you think of f of x as the high function,
and g of x is a low function, you can say
this is low D high minus high D low
over low low,
we're low low means the low function squared.
Let's start with a pretty simple example.
So this derivative, taking us back to z here,
we're low low means the low function squared.
Let's start with a pretty simple example.
So this derivative, taking us back to z here,
we put the low low on the bottom, and then
we go low,
D high.
z squared is to z minus high, D low the derivative
of Z's cubed plus one is three z squared plus
zero, don't really need to write the zero
there, I can simplify here a little bit to
z to the fourth plus two z minus three z to
the fourth,
z squared is to z minus high, D low the derivative
of Z's cubed plus one is three z squared plus
zero, don't really need to write the zero
there, I can simplify here a little bit to
z to the fourth plus two z minus three z to
the fourth,
over, I'm
not going to bother multiplying out this denominator,
I think it looks simpler with it factored.
So when I cancel things on the numerator,
I'm getting to z minus z to the fourth over
z cubed plus one squared as the derivative
of my quotient. So in this video, we saw the
product rule and the quotient rule. I've written
the rules here using the prime notation instead
of the dy dx notation, but you should check
that the formulas are really the same as before.
For the proofs of these fabulously useful
rules, you'll have to watch the next video.
In this video, I'll prove the product rule
and the quotient rule, along with one more
related rule, called the reciprocal rule.
First, the proof of the product rule. To find
the derivative of the product, f of x times
g of x, I'm going to start as usual with the
limit definition of derivative. So the limit
as h goes to zero of f of x plus h g of x
plus h minus f of x g of x, Oliver H. Now
I'd like to make this expression here look
more like the expression above it, which is
where I'm heading for. And to do this, I'm
going to use a classic trick of adding zero
to my expression and kind of a devious way.
So I'm going to rewrite my expression, leaving
the first term and the last term of the numerator
as they are, but inserting two new terms that
cancel. So I'm subtracting the term, f of
x, g of x plus h, and then adding it back
again. So they won't change the value of my
expression. This is not as pointless as it
seems, because now we can factor out the common
factor of g of x plus h from the first two
terms, and the common factor of f of x from
the next two terms. So I'm going to do that.
And now I'll rewrite again, splitting up my
sum into two pieces here. You can use just
algebra fractions to see that this expression
here and this expression here are the same.
Notice that I'm taking the limit of this entire
expression here. Now my limit rules allow
me to rewrite this limit as four separate
limits, provided that these four limits do
in fact exist, which that tell you show you
in a moment that they do. So this first limit
here is just equal to g of x, because G is
a continuous function. G is continuous because
by assumption it's differentiable, so it has
to be continuous. This second limit here,
you'll recognize as the definition of the
derivative of f, so that limit exists at equals
d dx of f of x. The third limit, well, f of
x has nothing to do with age. So that limit
is just f of x. And finally, the fourth limit
is the derivative of g. And we've done it.
Well, modulus some minor rearrangement, you'll
see that this expression here, is exactly
the same as this expression here, just with
the order of the terms switched around. Before
we go on to prove the quotient rule, it'll
be really handy to prove the reciprocal rule,
which states that the derivative of reciprocal,
one over f of x is given by negative the derivative
of f of x divided by f of x squared. So to
prove this fact, let's start as usual, with
the definition of derivative. The derivative
of one over f of x is the limit as h goes
to zero of one over f of
not going to bother multiplying out this denominator,
I think it looks simpler with it factored.
So when I cancel things on the numerator,
I'm getting to z minus z to the fourth over
z cubed plus one squared as the derivative
of my quotient. So in this video, we saw the
product rule and the quotient rule. I've written
the rules here using the prime notation instead
of the dy dx notation, but you should check
that the formulas are really the same as before.
For the proofs of these fabulously useful
rules, you'll have to watch the next video.
In this video, I'll prove the product rule
and the quotient rule, along with one more
related rule, called the reciprocal rule.
First, the proof of the product rule. To find
the derivative of the product, f of x times
g of x, I'm going to start as usual with the
limit definition of derivative. So the limit
as h goes to zero of f of x plus h g of x
plus h minus f of x g of x, Oliver H. Now
I'd like to make this expression here look
more like the expression above it, which is
where I'm heading for. And to do this, I'm
going to use a classic trick of adding zero
to my expression and kind of a devious way.
So I'm going to rewrite my expression, leaving
the first term and the last term of the numerator
as they are, but inserting two new terms that
cancel. So I'm subtracting the term, f of
x, g of x plus h, and then adding it back
again. So they won't change the value of my
expression. This is not as pointless as it
seems, because now we can factor out the common
factor of g of x plus h from the first two
terms, and the common factor of f of x from
the next two terms. So I'm going to do that.
And now I'll rewrite again, splitting up my
sum into two pieces here. You can use just
algebra fractions to see that this expression
here and this expression here are the same.
Notice that I'm taking the limit of this entire
expression here. Now my limit rules allow
me to rewrite this limit as four separate
limits, provided that these four limits do
in fact exist, which that tell you show you
in a moment that they do. So this first limit
here is just equal to g of x, because G is
a continuous function. G is continuous because
by assumption it's differentiable, so it has
to be continuous. This second limit here,
you'll recognize as the definition of the
derivative of f, so that limit exists at equals
d dx of f of x. The third limit, well, f of
x has nothing to do with age. So that limit
is just f of x. And finally, the fourth limit
is the derivative of g. And we've done it.
Well, modulus some minor rearrangement, you'll
see that this expression here, is exactly
the same as this expression here, just with
the order of the terms switched around. Before
we go on to prove the quotient rule, it'll
be really handy to prove the reciprocal rule,
which states that the derivative of reciprocal,
one over f of x is given by negative the derivative
of f of x divided by f of x squared. So to
prove this fact, let's start as usual, with
the definition of derivative. The derivative
of one over f of x is the limit as h goes
to zero of one over f of
x plus
h minus one over f of x over h. Now, these
fractions here are just crying out to be combined
by finding a common denominator that common
denominators f of x plus h times f of x. So
let me do that. I've just multiplied the first
fraction by f of x over f of x and the second
fraction by f of x plus h over f of x plus
h in order to rewrite with a common denominator.
So that gives me f of x minus f of x plus
h divided by f of x plus h times f of x. And
instead of dividing this whole thing by H,
I'll multiply it by one of our age, which
gives me another factor of H in the denominator.
Now, this expression here is looking a lot
like the derivative of
h minus one over f of x over h. Now, these
fractions here are just crying out to be combined
by finding a common denominator that common
denominators f of x plus h times f of x. So
let me do that. I've just multiplied the first
fraction by f of x over f of x and the second
fraction by f of x plus h over f of x plus
h in order to rewrite with a common denominator.
So that gives me f of x minus f of x plus
h divided by f of x plus h times f of x. And
instead of dividing this whole thing by H,
I'll multiply it by one of our age, which
gives me another factor of H in the denominator.
Now, this expression here is looking a lot
like the derivative of
f.
It's just in the reverse order. So let me
factor out a negative sign in order to let
me switch that order here. So this becomes
f of x plus h minus f of x over h, and then
I've got the times one over f of x plus h
times f of x. Now I can split this limit up
first, I'll factor out the negative sign.
And then I'll write this product as a product
of two limits, which I can do provided the
component limits exist. And I'll check that
these limits do exist. Let's see the first
limit here. The first limit here is just the
derivative of
It's just in the reverse order. So let me
factor out a negative sign in order to let
me switch that order here. So this becomes
f of x plus h minus f of x over h, and then
I've got the times one over f of x plus h
times f of x. Now I can split this limit up
first, I'll factor out the negative sign.
And then I'll write this product as a product
of two limits, which I can do provided the
component limits exist. And I'll check that
these limits do exist. Let's see the first
limit here. The first limit here is just the
derivative of
f.
And the second limit here exists because f
is continuous, f is continuous since is differentiable.
So by continuity, as H is going to zero, since
x plus h is approaching x, f of x plus h is
just approaching f of x. And I can rewrite
this limit as one over f of x times f of x.
And so this is in other words, negative the
derivative of f of x divided by f of x squared.
Now we've proved the reciprocal rule. Now
we're in a great position to prove the quotient
rule with very little effort. So instead of
going back to the definition of derivative,
this time, I'm just gonna think of the quotient
f of x over g of x as a product of f of x
times the reciprocal
And the second limit here exists because f
is continuous, f is continuous since is differentiable.
So by continuity, as H is going to zero, since
x plus h is approaching x, f of x plus h is
just approaching f of x. And I can rewrite
this limit as one over f of x times f of x.
And so this is in other words, negative the
derivative of f of x divided by f of x squared.
Now we've proved the reciprocal rule. Now
we're in a great position to prove the quotient
rule with very little effort. So instead of
going back to the definition of derivative,
this time, I'm just gonna think of the quotient
f of x over g of x as a product of f of x
times the reciprocal
of g of x.
And now, by the product rule, that's just
the first function times the derivative of
the second plus the derivative of the first
times the second. And by the quotient rule,
the derivative of this reciprocal is negative
derivative of g over g of x squared. And I
still have this second term here, which I'm
just going to write as derivative f of x divided
by g of x.
And now, by the product rule, that's just
the first function times the derivative of
the second plus the derivative of the first
times the second. And by the quotient rule,
the derivative of this reciprocal is negative
derivative of g over g of x squared. And I
still have this second term here, which I'm
just going to write as derivative f of x divided
by g of x.
Okay,
so we're almost there. If we combine these
two fractions, using a common denominator
of g of x squared, we just have to multiply
this second fraction by g of x over g of x
to get that common denominator. Now we get
negative f of x times the derivative of g
of x plus the derivative of f of x times g
of x divided by g of x squared. And hopefully,
this bottom expression is the same as this
top expression. And, yes, after rearranging
the terms it is. So that's the end of the
proof of the quotient rule. So this video
gave proofs of the product rule, the reciprocal
rule, and then the quotient rule. This video
is about two limits involving trig functions
that turn out to be very useful. Namely, the
limit as theta goes to zero of sine theta
so we're almost there. If we combine these
two fractions, using a common denominator
of g of x squared, we just have to multiply
this second fraction by g of x over g of x
to get that common denominator. Now we get
negative f of x times the derivative of g
of x plus the derivative of f of x times g
of x divided by g of x squared. And hopefully,
this bottom expression is the same as this
top expression. And, yes, after rearranging
the terms it is. So that's the end of the
proof of the quotient rule. So this video
gave proofs of the product rule, the reciprocal
rule, and then the quotient rule. This video
is about two limits involving trig functions
that turn out to be very useful. Namely, the
limit as theta goes to zero of sine theta
over theta. And the limit as theta goes to
zero of cosine theta minus one over theta.
These limits turn out to have really nice
simple answers, as long as we keep theta in
radians,
over theta. And the limit as theta goes to
zero of cosine theta minus one over theta.
These limits turn out to have really nice
simple answers, as long as we keep theta in
radians,
not degrees. Let's consider the limit on the
left first, that's the limit as theta goes
to zero of sine theta over theta. Notice that
we can't just evaluate this limit by plugging
in zero for theta, because as theta goes to
zero sine theta, and the numerator also goes
to zero, and theta itself goes to zero, so
we end up with a zero over zero indeterminate
form. We can however, build up some evidence
of what this limit by might be by using a
calculator and a table of values, or by looking
at a graph. So here's the theta axis. And
here's the y axis. And you can see that as
theta goes to zero from either the right or
the left, it's looking like the y value is
going to one. The second limit here on the
right, is also zero over zero and determinant
form. Since as theta goes to zero, cosine
theta goes to one, so cosine theta minus one
goes to zero. But again, looking at the graph,
we have some evidence to suggest that as theta
goes to zero, our expression is also going
to
not degrees. Let's consider the limit on the
left first, that's the limit as theta goes
to zero of sine theta over theta. Notice that
we can't just evaluate this limit by plugging
in zero for theta, because as theta goes to
zero sine theta, and the numerator also goes
to zero, and theta itself goes to zero, so
we end up with a zero over zero indeterminate
form. We can however, build up some evidence
of what this limit by might be by using a
calculator and a table of values, or by looking
at a graph. So here's the theta axis. And
here's the y axis. And you can see that as
theta goes to zero from either the right or
the left, it's looking like the y value is
going to one. The second limit here on the
right, is also zero over zero and determinant
form. Since as theta goes to zero, cosine
theta goes to one, so cosine theta minus one
goes to zero. But again, looking at the graph,
we have some evidence to suggest that as theta
goes to zero, our expression is also going
to
zero.
these graphs provide strong evidence, but
graphs can be misleading, and they're no substitute
for a rigorous proof. So for a pretty cool
geometric and algebraic proof of these facts,
please see the proof video for this section.
The fact that the limit as theta goes to zero
of sine theta over theta is one is really
handy when you want to approximate sine theta.
Because intuitively, this is saying that sine
theta is approximately equal to theta itself
when theta is near zero, because the ratio
is approximately one. So if I want to approximate
sine of this value of theta, without a calculator,
I can use that fact. And say that the sine
of 0.01769 is going to be approximately equal
to 0.01769. This is an important time to remind
you that when we're doing these limits, we're
assuming that theta is in radians. If it's
not in radians, we won't get this nice limit
of one here. So that's our approximation.
And we can check it on a calculator, and I
actually get an exact value of this number
up to 10 decimal places. So as you can see,
this is a really good approximation. We can
use this same limit fat, again, in the next
example, to calculate this complicated limit
as x goes to zero, the limit of tan of 7x
over sine of forex. So when I see tangents
and signs and expression, I'm always tempted
to rewrite things. And just in terms of sine
and cosine, so I'm going to do that first
I'm going to rewrite tangent as as sine over
cosine. That still divided by sine of forex,
and now I'm going to flip and multiply to
get sine of 7x over cosine of 7x times one
over sine of 4x. Now intuitively, if x is
near zero, therefore 7x and 4x are also near
zero, then sine of 7x is approximately equal
to 7x. And sine of 4x is approximately equal
to 4x. So intuitively, this limit should be
pretty much the same thing as the limit as
x goes to zero of 7x over cosine 7x times
4x. And canceling the access, this is just
the same as seven fourths times the limit
of one of our cosine 7x. Since cosine of 7x
is going to one, this should just be seven
fourths. So this is the intuitive approach,
let me also give you a more rigorous approach.
So more rigorously, I'm going to rewrite this
limit by multiplying by 7x over 7x. And by
multiplying by 4x, over 4x, that hasn't changed
my expression, I'm just multiplying by one
and fancy forms. But this is really useful.
Because if I regroup here, and write the sine
7x over the 7x, times the one over cosine
7x. Now I'm going to write the Forex over
the sign for x. And I'm still left with a
7x from the top and a 4x. From the bottom
here, I can cancel out those x's. And I can
notice that this limit here, as x goes to
07, x is going to zero, so sine 7x over 7x
is just going to be equal to one. And similarly
as x goes to zero, for x is going to zero.
So the limit of 4x ever signed for x is the
reciprocal of one, it's also one. And finally,
this limit in the middle here, as x goes to
07, x is going to zero, so cosine of 7x is
going to one, and everything in the world
is going to one except the 7/4. So this limit
is seven forth.
these graphs provide strong evidence, but
graphs can be misleading, and they're no substitute
for a rigorous proof. So for a pretty cool
geometric and algebraic proof of these facts,
please see the proof video for this section.
The fact that the limit as theta goes to zero
of sine theta over theta is one is really
handy when you want to approximate sine theta.
Because intuitively, this is saying that sine
theta is approximately equal to theta itself
when theta is near zero, because the ratio
is approximately one. So if I want to approximate
sine of this value of theta, without a calculator,
I can use that fact. And say that the sine
of 0.01769 is going to be approximately equal
to 0.01769. This is an important time to remind
you that when we're doing these limits, we're
assuming that theta is in radians. If it's
not in radians, we won't get this nice limit
of one here. So that's our approximation.
And we can check it on a calculator, and I
actually get an exact value of this number
up to 10 decimal places. So as you can see,
this is a really good approximation. We can
use this same limit fat, again, in the next
example, to calculate this complicated limit
as x goes to zero, the limit of tan of 7x
over sine of forex. So when I see tangents
and signs and expression, I'm always tempted
to rewrite things. And just in terms of sine
and cosine, so I'm going to do that first
I'm going to rewrite tangent as as sine over
cosine. That still divided by sine of forex,
and now I'm going to flip and multiply to
get sine of 7x over cosine of 7x times one
over sine of 4x. Now intuitively, if x is
near zero, therefore 7x and 4x are also near
zero, then sine of 7x is approximately equal
to 7x. And sine of 4x is approximately equal
to 4x. So intuitively, this limit should be
pretty much the same thing as the limit as
x goes to zero of 7x over cosine 7x times
4x. And canceling the access, this is just
the same as seven fourths times the limit
of one of our cosine 7x. Since cosine of 7x
is going to one, this should just be seven
fourths. So this is the intuitive approach,
let me also give you a more rigorous approach.
So more rigorously, I'm going to rewrite this
limit by multiplying by 7x over 7x. And by
multiplying by 4x, over 4x, that hasn't changed
my expression, I'm just multiplying by one
and fancy forms. But this is really useful.
Because if I regroup here, and write the sine
7x over the 7x, times the one over cosine
7x. Now I'm going to write the Forex over
the sign for x. And I'm still left with a
7x from the top and a 4x. From the bottom
here, I can cancel out those x's. And I can
notice that this limit here, as x goes to
07, x is going to zero, so sine 7x over 7x
is just going to be equal to one. And similarly
as x goes to zero, for x is going to zero.
So the limit of 4x ever signed for x is the
reciprocal of one, it's also one. And finally,
this limit in the middle here, as x goes to
07, x is going to zero, so cosine of 7x is
going to one, and everything in the world
is going to one except the 7/4. So this limit
is seven forth.
In this video, we found that the limit as
theta goes to zero of sine theta over theta
is equal to one. And the limit as theta goes
to zero of cosine theta minus one over theta
is equal to zero. There's a nice proof of
these facts in a later video for this section.
When you compose two functions, you apply
the first function. And then you apply the
second function to the output of the first
function. For example, the first function
might compute population size from time in
years.
In this video, we found that the limit as
theta goes to zero of sine theta over theta
is equal to one. And the limit as theta goes
to zero of cosine theta minus one over theta
is equal to zero. There's a nice proof of
these facts in a later video for this section.
When you compose two functions, you apply
the first function. And then you apply the
second function to the output of the first
function. For example, the first function
might compute population size from time in
years.
So its input would be time in years, since
a certain date, as output would be number
of people in the population. The second function
g, might compute health care costs as a function
of population size. So it will take population
size as input, and its output will be healthcare
costs. If you put these functions together,
that is compose them, then you'll go all the
way from time in years to healthcare costs.
This is your composition, g composed with
F. The composition of two functions, written
g with a little circle, f of x is defined
as follows. g composed with f of x is G evaluated
on f of x, we can think of it schematically
and so diagram, f acts on a number x and produces
a number f of x, then g takes that output
f of x and produces a new number, g of f of
x. Our composition of functions g composed
with F is the function that goes all the way
from X to g of f of x. Let's work out some
examples where our functions are defined by
tables of values. If we want to find g composed
with F of four, by definition, this means
g of f of four. To evaluate this expression,
we always work from the inside out. So we
start with the x value of four, and we find
f of four using the table of values for f
of x. When x equals four, f of x is seven,
so we can replace F of four with the number
seven. Now we need to evaluate g of seven,
seven becomes our new x value in our table
of values for G, the x value of seven corresponds
to the G of X value of 10. So g of seven is
equal to 10. We found that g composed with
F of four is equal to 10. If instead we want
to find f composed with g of four, well, we
can rewrite that is f of g of four, and again,
work from the inside out. Now we're trying
to find g of four, so four is our x value.
And we use our table of values for G to see
that g of four is one. So we replaced by a
four by one, and now we need to evaluate f
of one. Using our table for F values, f of
one is eight. Notice that when we've computed
g of f of four, we got a different answer
there when we computed F of G, F four. And
in general, g composed with F is not the same
thing as f composed with g.
So its input would be time in years, since
a certain date, as output would be number
of people in the population. The second function
g, might compute health care costs as a function
of population size. So it will take population
size as input, and its output will be healthcare
costs. If you put these functions together,
that is compose them, then you'll go all the
way from time in years to healthcare costs.
This is your composition, g composed with
F. The composition of two functions, written
g with a little circle, f of x is defined
as follows. g composed with f of x is G evaluated
on f of x, we can think of it schematically
and so diagram, f acts on a number x and produces
a number f of x, then g takes that output
f of x and produces a new number, g of f of
x. Our composition of functions g composed
with F is the function that goes all the way
from X to g of f of x. Let's work out some
examples where our functions are defined by
tables of values. If we want to find g composed
with F of four, by definition, this means
g of f of four. To evaluate this expression,
we always work from the inside out. So we
start with the x value of four, and we find
f of four using the table of values for f
of x. When x equals four, f of x is seven,
so we can replace F of four with the number
seven. Now we need to evaluate g of seven,
seven becomes our new x value in our table
of values for G, the x value of seven corresponds
to the G of X value of 10. So g of seven is
equal to 10. We found that g composed with
F of four is equal to 10. If instead we want
to find f composed with g of four, well, we
can rewrite that is f of g of four, and again,
work from the inside out. Now we're trying
to find g of four, so four is our x value.
And we use our table of values for G to see
that g of four is one. So we replaced by a
four by one, and now we need to evaluate f
of one. Using our table for F values, f of
one is eight. Notice that when we've computed
g of f of four, we got a different answer
there when we computed F of G, F four. And
in general, g composed with F is not the same
thing as f composed with g.
Please
pause the video and take a moment to compute
the next two examples. We can replace f composed
with F of two by the equivalent expression,
f of f of two. Working from the inside out,
we know that f of two is three, and f of three
is six. If we want to find f composed with
g of six, rewrite that as f of g of six isn't
the table for g, g of six is eight. But F
of eight, eight is not on the table as an
x value for the for the f function. And so
there is no F of eight, this does not exist,
we can say that six is not in the domain,
for F composed with g. Even though it was
in the domain of g, we couldn't follow all
the way through and get a value for F composed
with g of six. Next, let's turn our attention
to the composition of functions that are given
by equations.
pause the video and take a moment to compute
the next two examples. We can replace f composed
with F of two by the equivalent expression,
f of f of two. Working from the inside out,
we know that f of two is three, and f of three
is six. If we want to find f composed with
g of six, rewrite that as f of g of six isn't
the table for g, g of six is eight. But F
of eight, eight is not on the table as an
x value for the for the f function. And so
there is no F of eight, this does not exist,
we can say that six is not in the domain,
for F composed with g. Even though it was
in the domain of g, we couldn't follow all
the way through and get a value for F composed
with g of six. Next, let's turn our attention
to the composition of functions that are given
by equations.
p of x is x squared plus x and q of x is negative
2x. We want to find q composed with P of one.
As usual, I can rewrite this as Q of P of
one and work from the inside out. P of one
is one squared plus one, so that's two. So
this is the same thing as Q of two. But queue
of two is negative two times two or negative
four. So this evaluates to negative four.
In this next example, we want to find q composed
with P of some arbitrary x, or rewrite it
as usual as Q of p of x and work from the
inside out. Well, p of x, we know the formula
for that, that's x squared plus x. So I can
replace my P of x with that expression. Now,
I'm stuck with evaluating q on x squared plus
x. Well queue of anything is negative two
times that thing. So q of x squared plus x
is going to be negative two times the quantity
x squared plus x, what I've done is I've substituted
in the whole expression x squared plus x,
where I saw the X in this formula for q of
x, it's important to use the parentheses here,
so that we'll be multiplying negative two
by the whole expression and not just by the
first piece, I can simplify this a bit as
negative 2x squared minus 2x. And that's my
expression for Q composed with p of x. Notice
that if I wanted to compute q composed with
P of one, which I already did in the first
problem, I could just use this expression
now, negative two times one squared minus
two and I get negative four, just like I did
before. Let's try another one. Let's try p
composed with q of x. First I read right this
P of q of x. Working from the inside out,
I can replace q of x with negative 2x. So
I need to compute P of negative 2x. Here's
my formula for P. to compute P of this expression,
I need to plug in this expression everywhere
I see an x in the formula for P. So that means
negative 2x squared plus negative 2x. Again,
being careful to use parentheses to make sure
I plug in the entire expression in for x.
let me simplify. This is 4x squared minus
2x. Notice that I got different expressions
for Q of p of x. And for P of q of x. Once
again, we see that q composed with P is not
necessarily equal to P composed with Q. Please
pause the video and try this last example
yourself rewriting and working from the inside
out, we're going to replace p of x with its
expression x squared plus x. And then we need
to evaluate p on x squared
As usual, I can rewrite this as Q of P of
one and work from the inside out. P of one
is one squared plus one, so that's two. So
this is the same thing as Q of two. But queue
of two is negative two times two or negative
four. So this evaluates to negative four.
In this next example, we want to find q composed
with P of some arbitrary x, or rewrite it
as usual as Q of p of x and work from the
inside out. Well, p of x, we know the formula
for that, that's x squared plus x. So I can
replace my P of x with that expression. Now,
I'm stuck with evaluating q on x squared plus
x. Well queue of anything is negative two
times that thing. So q of x squared plus x
is going to be negative two times the quantity
x squared plus x, what I've done is I've substituted
in the whole expression x squared plus x,
where I saw the X in this formula for q of
x, it's important to use the parentheses here,
so that we'll be multiplying negative two
by the whole expression and not just by the
first piece, I can simplify this a bit as
negative 2x squared minus 2x. And that's my
expression for Q composed with p of x. Notice
that if I wanted to compute q composed with
P of one, which I already did in the first
problem, I could just use this expression
now, negative two times one squared minus
two and I get negative four, just like I did
before. Let's try another one. Let's try p
composed with q of x. First I read right this
P of q of x. Working from the inside out,
I can replace q of x with negative 2x. So
I need to compute P of negative 2x. Here's
my formula for P. to compute P of this expression,
I need to plug in this expression everywhere
I see an x in the formula for P. So that means
negative 2x squared plus negative 2x. Again,
being careful to use parentheses to make sure
I plug in the entire expression in for x.
let me simplify. This is 4x squared minus
2x. Notice that I got different expressions
for Q of p of x. And for P of q of x. Once
again, we see that q composed with P is not
necessarily equal to P composed with Q. Please
pause the video and try this last example
yourself rewriting and working from the inside
out, we're going to replace p of x with its
expression x squared plus x. And then we need
to evaluate p on x squared
plus x.
That means we plug in
x squared plus x,
everywhere we see an x in this formula, so
that's x squared plus x quantity squared plus
x squared plus x. Once again, I can simplify
by distributing out, that gives me x to the
fourth plus 2x cubed plus x squared plus x
squared plus x, or x to the fourth plus 2x
cubed plus 2x squared plus x. In this last
set of examples, we're asked to go backwards,
we're given a formula for a function of h
of x. But we're supposed to rewrite h of x
as a composition of two functions, F and G.
Let's think for a minute, which of these two
functions gets applied first, f composed with
g of x, let's see, that means f of g of x.
And since we evaluate these expressions from
the inside out, we must be applying g first,
and then F. In order to figure out what what
f and g could be, I like to draw a box around
some thing inside my expression for H, so
I'm going to draw a box around x squared plus
seven, then whatever's inside the box, that'll
be my function, g of x, the first function
that gets applied, whatever happens to the
box, in this case, taking the square root
sign, that becomes my outside function, my
second function f. So here, we're gonna say
g of x is equal to x squared plus seven, and
f of x is equal to the square root of x, let's
just check and make sure that this works.
So I need to check that when I take the composition,
f composed with g, I need to get the same
thing as my original h. So let's see, if I
do f composed with g of x, well, by definition,
that's f of g of x.
everywhere we see an x in this formula, so
that's x squared plus x quantity squared plus
x squared plus x. Once again, I can simplify
by distributing out, that gives me x to the
fourth plus 2x cubed plus x squared plus x
squared plus x, or x to the fourth plus 2x
cubed plus 2x squared plus x. In this last
set of examples, we're asked to go backwards,
we're given a formula for a function of h
of x. But we're supposed to rewrite h of x
as a composition of two functions, F and G.
Let's think for a minute, which of these two
functions gets applied first, f composed with
g of x, let's see, that means f of g of x.
And since we evaluate these expressions from
the inside out, we must be applying g first,
and then F. In order to figure out what what
f and g could be, I like to draw a box around
some thing inside my expression for H, so
I'm going to draw a box around x squared plus
seven, then whatever's inside the box, that'll
be my function, g of x, the first function
that gets applied, whatever happens to the
box, in this case, taking the square root
sign, that becomes my outside function, my
second function f. So here, we're gonna say
g of x is equal to x squared plus seven, and
f of x is equal to the square root of x, let's
just check and make sure that this works.
So I need to check that when I take the composition,
f composed with g, I need to get the same
thing as my original h. So let's see, if I
do f composed with g of x, well, by definition,
that's f of g of x.
Working from the inside out, I can replace
g of x with its formula x squared plus seven.
So I need to evaluate f of x squared plus
seven. That means I plug in x squared plus
seven, into the formula for for F. So that
becomes the square root of x squared plus
seven, two, it works because it matches my
original equation. So we found a correct answer
a correct way of breaking h down as a composition
of two functions. But I do want to point out,
this is not the only correct answer. I'll
write down my formula for H of X again, and
this time, I'll put the box in a different
place, I'll just box the x squared. If I did
that, then my inside function, my first function,
g of x would be x squared. And my second function
is what happens
Working from the inside out, I can replace
g of x with its formula x squared plus seven.
So I need to evaluate f of x squared plus
seven. That means I plug in x squared plus
seven, into the formula for for F. So that
becomes the square root of x squared plus
seven, two, it works because it matches my
original equation. So we found a correct answer
a correct way of breaking h down as a composition
of two functions. But I do want to point out,
this is not the only correct answer. I'll
write down my formula for H of X again, and
this time, I'll put the box in a different
place, I'll just box the x squared. If I did
that, then my inside function, my first function,
g of x would be x squared. And my second function
is what happens
to the box.
So my f of x is what happens to the box, and
the box gets added seven to it, and taking
the square root. So in other words, f of x
is going to be the square root of x plus seven.
Again, I can check that this works. If I do
f composed with g of x, that's f
So my f of x is what happens to the box, and
the box gets added seven to it, and taking
the square root. So in other words, f of x
is going to be the square root of x plus seven.
Again, I can check that this works. If I do
f composed with g of x, that's f
of g of x.
So now g of x is x squared, so I'm taking
f of x squared. When I plug in x squared for
x, I do in fact get the square root of x squared
plus seven. So this is an alternative correct
solution. In this video, we learn to evaluate
the composition of functions. by rewriting
it and working from the inside out. We also
learn to break apart a complicated function
into a composition of two functions by boxing
one piece of the function and letting the
first function applied in the composition.
Let that be the inside of the box and the
second function applied in the composition
be whatever happens to the box.
So now g of x is x squared, so I'm taking
f of x squared. When I plug in x squared for
x, I do in fact get the square root of x squared
plus seven. So this is an alternative correct
solution. In this video, we learn to evaluate
the composition of functions. by rewriting
it and working from the inside out. We also
learn to break apart a complicated function
into a composition of two functions by boxing
one piece of the function and letting the
first function applied in the composition.
Let that be the inside of the box and the
second function applied in the composition
be whatever happens to the box.
This video is about solving rational equations.
A rational equation like this one equation
that has rational expressions and that, in
other words, an equation that has some variables
in the denominator. There are several different
approaches for solving a rational equation,
but they all start by finding the least common
denominator. In this example, the denominators
are x plus three and x, we can think of one
as just having a denominator of one. Since
the denominators don't have any factors in
common, I can find the least common denominator
just by multiplying them together. My next
step is going to be clearing the denominator.
By this, I mean that I multiply both sides
of my equation by this least common denominator,
x plus three times x, I multiply on the left
side of the equation, and I multiply by the
same thing on the right side of the equation.
Since I'm doing the same thing to both sides
of the equation, I don't change the the value
of the equation. Multiplying the least common
denominator on both sides of the equation
is equivalent to multiplying it by all three
terms in the equation, I can see this when
I multiply out, I'll rewrite the left side
the same as before, pretty much. And then
I'll distribute the right side to get x plus
three times x times one plus x plus three
times x times one over x. So I've actually
multiplied the least common denominator by
all three terms of my equation. Now I can
have a blast canceling things. The x plus
three cancels with the x plus three on the
denominator. The here are nothing cancels
out because there's no denominator, and here
are the x in the numerator cancels with the
x in the denominator. So I can rewrite my
expression as x squared equals x plus three
times x times one plus x plus three. Now I'm
going to simplify. So I'll leave the x squared
alone on this side, I'll distribute out x
squared plus 3x plus x plus three, hey, look,
the x squared is cancel on both sides. And
so I get zero equals 4x plus three, so 4x
is negative three, and x is negative three
fourths. Finally, I'm going to plug in my
answer to check. This is a good idea for any
kind of equation. But it's especially important
for a rational equation because occasionally
for rational equations, you'll get what's
called extraneous solution solutions that
don't actually work in your original equation
because they make the denominator zero. Now,
in this example, I don't think we're going
to get the extraneous equations, because negative
three fourths is not going to make any of
these denominators zero, so it should work
out fine when I plug in. If I plug in, I get
this, I can simplify the denominator here,
negative three fourths plus three, three is
12, for sets becomes nine fourths, and this
is one or flip and multiply to get minus four
thirds. So here, I can simplify my complex
fraction, it ends up being negative three
nights, and one minus four thirds is negative
1/3. So that all seems to check out. And so
my final answer is x equals negative three
fourths. This next example looks a little
trickier. And it is, but the same approach
will work. First off, find the least common
denominator. So here, my denominators are
c minus five, c plus one, and C squared minus
four c minus five, I'm going to factor that
as C minus five times c plus one. Now, my
least common denominator needs to have just
enough factors to that each of these denominators
divided into it. So I need the factor c minus
five, I need the factor c plus one. And now
I've already got all the factors I need for
this denominator. So here is my least common
denominator. Next step is to clear the denominators.
So I do this by multiplying both sides of
the equation by my least common denominator.
In fact, I can just multiply each of the three
terms by this least common denominator. I
went ahead and wrote my third denominator
in factored form to make it easier to see
what cancels. Now canceling time dies, this
dies, and both of those factors die.
This video is about solving rational equations.
A rational equation like this one equation
that has rational expressions and that, in
other words, an equation that has some variables
in the denominator. There are several different
approaches for solving a rational equation,
but they all start by finding the least common
denominator. In this example, the denominators
are x plus three and x, we can think of one
as just having a denominator of one. Since
the denominators don't have any factors in
common, I can find the least common denominator
just by multiplying them together. My next
step is going to be clearing the denominator.
By this, I mean that I multiply both sides
of my equation by this least common denominator,
x plus three times x, I multiply on the left
side of the equation, and I multiply by the
same thing on the right side of the equation.
Since I'm doing the same thing to both sides
of the equation, I don't change the the value
of the equation. Multiplying the least common
denominator on both sides of the equation
is equivalent to multiplying it by all three
terms in the equation, I can see this when
I multiply out, I'll rewrite the left side
the same as before, pretty much. And then
I'll distribute the right side to get x plus
three times x times one plus x plus three
times x times one over x. So I've actually
multiplied the least common denominator by
all three terms of my equation. Now I can
have a blast canceling things. The x plus
three cancels with the x plus three on the
denominator. The here are nothing cancels
out because there's no denominator, and here
are the x in the numerator cancels with the
x in the denominator. So I can rewrite my
expression as x squared equals x plus three
times x times one plus x plus three. Now I'm
going to simplify. So I'll leave the x squared
alone on this side, I'll distribute out x
squared plus 3x plus x plus three, hey, look,
the x squared is cancel on both sides. And
so I get zero equals 4x plus three, so 4x
is negative three, and x is negative three
fourths. Finally, I'm going to plug in my
answer to check. This is a good idea for any
kind of equation. But it's especially important
for a rational equation because occasionally
for rational equations, you'll get what's
called extraneous solution solutions that
don't actually work in your original equation
because they make the denominator zero. Now,
in this example, I don't think we're going
to get the extraneous equations, because negative
three fourths is not going to make any of
these denominators zero, so it should work
out fine when I plug in. If I plug in, I get
this, I can simplify the denominator here,
negative three fourths plus three, three is
12, for sets becomes nine fourths, and this
is one or flip and multiply to get minus four
thirds. So here, I can simplify my complex
fraction, it ends up being negative three
nights, and one minus four thirds is negative
1/3. So that all seems to check out. And so
my final answer is x equals negative three
fourths. This next example looks a little
trickier. And it is, but the same approach
will work. First off, find the least common
denominator. So here, my denominators are
c minus five, c plus one, and C squared minus
four c minus five, I'm going to factor that
as C minus five times c plus one. Now, my
least common denominator needs to have just
enough factors to that each of these denominators
divided into it. So I need the factor c minus
five, I need the factor c plus one. And now
I've already got all the factors I need for
this denominator. So here is my least common
denominator. Next step is to clear the denominators.
So I do this by multiplying both sides of
the equation by my least common denominator.
In fact, I can just multiply each of the three
terms by this least common denominator. I
went ahead and wrote my third denominator
in factored form to make it easier to see
what cancels. Now canceling time dies, this
dies, and both of those factors die.
cancel out the denominators, the whole point
of multiplying by the least common denominator,
you're multiplying by something that's big
enough to kill every single denominator so
you don't have to deal with denominators anymore.
Now I'm going to simplify by multiplying out.
So I get, let's see, c plus one times four
c, that's four c squared plus four c, now
I get minus just c minus five, and then over
here, I get three c squared plus three, I
can rewrite the minus quantity c minus five
as a minus c plus five. And now I can subtract
the three c squared from both sides to get
just a C squared over here, and the four c
minus c, that becomes a three C. And finally,
I can subtract the three from both sides to
get c squared plus three c plus two equals
zero. got myself a quadratic equation that
looks like a nice one that factors. So this
factors to C plus one times c plus two equals
zero. So either c plus one is zero, or C plus
two is zero, so C equals negative one, or
C equals negative two. Now let's see, we need
to still check our answers. Without even going
to the trouble of calculating anything, I
can see that C equals negative one is not
going to work, because if I plug it in to
this denominator here, I get a denominator
of zero, which doesn't make sense. So C equals
minus one is an extraneous solution, it doesn't
actually satisfy my original equation. And
so I can just cross it right out, C equals
negative two. I can go if I go ahead, and
that doesn't make any of my denominators zero.
So if I haven't made any mistakes, it should
satisfy my original equation, but, but I'll
just plug it in to be sure. And after some
simplifying, I get a true statement. So my
final answer is C equals negative two. In
this video, we solved a couple of rational
equations, using the method of finding the
least common denominator, and then clearing
the denominator, we cleared the denominator
by multiplying both sides of the equation
by the least common denominator or equivalently.
multiplying each of the terms by that denominator.
There's another equivalent method that some
people prefer, it still starts out the same,
we find the least common denominator, but
then we write all the fractions over that
least common denominator. So in this example,
we'd still use the least common denominator
of x plus three times x.
cancel out the denominators, the whole point
of multiplying by the least common denominator,
you're multiplying by something that's big
enough to kill every single denominator so
you don't have to deal with denominators anymore.
Now I'm going to simplify by multiplying out.
So I get, let's see, c plus one times four
c, that's four c squared plus four c, now
I get minus just c minus five, and then over
here, I get three c squared plus three, I
can rewrite the minus quantity c minus five
as a minus c plus five. And now I can subtract
the three c squared from both sides to get
just a C squared over here, and the four c
minus c, that becomes a three C. And finally,
I can subtract the three from both sides to
get c squared plus three c plus two equals
zero. got myself a quadratic equation that
looks like a nice one that factors. So this
factors to C plus one times c plus two equals
zero. So either c plus one is zero, or C plus
two is zero, so C equals negative one, or
C equals negative two. Now let's see, we need
to still check our answers. Without even going
to the trouble of calculating anything, I
can see that C equals negative one is not
going to work, because if I plug it in to
this denominator here, I get a denominator
of zero, which doesn't make sense. So C equals
minus one is an extraneous solution, it doesn't
actually satisfy my original equation. And
so I can just cross it right out, C equals
negative two. I can go if I go ahead, and
that doesn't make any of my denominators zero.
So if I haven't made any mistakes, it should
satisfy my original equation, but, but I'll
just plug it in to be sure. And after some
simplifying, I get a true statement. So my
final answer is C equals negative two. In
this video, we solved a couple of rational
equations, using the method of finding the
least common denominator, and then clearing
the denominator, we cleared the denominator
by multiplying both sides of the equation
by the least common denominator or equivalently.
multiplying each of the terms by that denominator.
There's another equivalent method that some
people prefer, it still starts out the same,
we find the least common denominator, but
then we write all the fractions over that
least common denominator. So in this example,
we'd still use the least common denominator
of x plus three times x.
But our next step would be to write each of
these rational expressions over that common
denominator by multiplying the top and the
bottom by the appropriate things. So one,
in order to get the common denominator of
x plus 3x, I need to multiply the top and
the bottom by x plus three times x, whenever
x, I need to multiply the top and the bottom
just by x plus three since that's what's missing
from the denominator x. Now, if I simplify
a little bit, let's say this is x squared
over that common denominator, and here I have
just x plus three times x over that denominator,
and here I have x plus three over that common
denominator. Now add together my fractions
on the right side, so they have a common denominator.
So this is x plus three times x plus x plus
three. And now I have two fractions that have
that are equal, that have the same denominator,
therefore, their numerators have to be equal
also. So the next step is to set the numerators
equal. So I get x squared is x plus three
times x plus x plus three. And if you look
back at the previous way, we solve this equation,
you'll recognize this equation. And so from
here on we just continue as before. When choosing
between these two methods, I personally tend
to prefer the clear the denominators method,
because it's a little bit less writing, you
don't have to get rid of those denominators
earlier. You don't have to write them as many
times, but some people find this one a little
bit easier to remember, a little easier to
understand either of these methods is fine.
One last caution. Don't forget at the end,
to check your solutions and eliminate any
extraneous solutions. These will be solutions
that make the denominators of your original
equation. Go to zero. This video gives the
derivative of sine cosine and other trig functions.
A graph of the function y equals sine x is
given in blue here, we can estimate the shape
of the derivative of sine x by looking at
the slopes of the tangent lines. Here, when
x equals zero, the tangent line has a positive
slope of approximately one. As x increases
to pi over two, the slope of the tangent line
is still positive, but decreases to zero.
Next, the slope turns negative more and more
negative reaching a negative value of negative
one, before returning again to zero. Continuing
like this, we see that the graph of the derivative
y equals sine prime of x looks like the graph
of y equals cosine x below. Please pause the
video and do a similar exercise for the graph
of y equals cosine of x below, that is use
the graph of y equals cosine x to estimate
the shape of the graph of y equals cosine
prime of x. Notice that when x equals zero,
the slope of the tangent line here is zero,
that slope turns negative, and then reaches
zero again before turning positive. So the
graph of the derivative should look something
like this. This new blue graph looks like
the vertical reflection of the blue graph
above suggesting that the derivative of cosine
of x is equal to the negative of sine of x.
So we have graphical evidence that the derivative
of sine x is equal to cosine of x, and the
derivative of cosine of x is equal to negative
sine of x. For proofs of these facts, please
see the separate proof video for this section.
Once we have the derivatives of sine and cosine,
we have the power to compute the derivatives
of a lot of other trig functions as well.
But our next step would be to write each of
these rational expressions over that common
denominator by multiplying the top and the
bottom by the appropriate things. So one,
in order to get the common denominator of
x plus 3x, I need to multiply the top and
the bottom by x plus three times x, whenever
x, I need to multiply the top and the bottom
just by x plus three since that's what's missing
from the denominator x. Now, if I simplify
a little bit, let's say this is x squared
over that common denominator, and here I have
just x plus three times x over that denominator,
and here I have x plus three over that common
denominator. Now add together my fractions
on the right side, so they have a common denominator.
So this is x plus three times x plus x plus
three. And now I have two fractions that have
that are equal, that have the same denominator,
therefore, their numerators have to be equal
also. So the next step is to set the numerators
equal. So I get x squared is x plus three
times x plus x plus three. And if you look
back at the previous way, we solve this equation,
you'll recognize this equation. And so from
here on we just continue as before. When choosing
between these two methods, I personally tend
to prefer the clear the denominators method,
because it's a little bit less writing, you
don't have to get rid of those denominators
earlier. You don't have to write them as many
times, but some people find this one a little
bit easier to remember, a little easier to
understand either of these methods is fine.
One last caution. Don't forget at the end,
to check your solutions and eliminate any
extraneous solutions. These will be solutions
that make the denominators of your original
equation. Go to zero. This video gives the
derivative of sine cosine and other trig functions.
A graph of the function y equals sine x is
given in blue here, we can estimate the shape
of the derivative of sine x by looking at
the slopes of the tangent lines. Here, when
x equals zero, the tangent line has a positive
slope of approximately one. As x increases
to pi over two, the slope of the tangent line
is still positive, but decreases to zero.
Next, the slope turns negative more and more
negative reaching a negative value of negative
one, before returning again to zero. Continuing
like this, we see that the graph of the derivative
y equals sine prime of x looks like the graph
of y equals cosine x below. Please pause the
video and do a similar exercise for the graph
of y equals cosine of x below, that is use
the graph of y equals cosine x to estimate
the shape of the graph of y equals cosine
prime of x. Notice that when x equals zero,
the slope of the tangent line here is zero,
that slope turns negative, and then reaches
zero again before turning positive. So the
graph of the derivative should look something
like this. This new blue graph looks like
the vertical reflection of the blue graph
above suggesting that the derivative of cosine
of x is equal to the negative of sine of x.
So we have graphical evidence that the derivative
of sine x is equal to cosine of x, and the
derivative of cosine of x is equal to negative
sine of x. For proofs of these facts, please
see the separate proof video for this section.
Once we have the derivatives of sine and cosine,
we have the power to compute the derivatives
of a lot of other trig functions as well.
And notice that a nice way to remember which
of these answers have negative signs in them
is that the derivatives of the trig functions
that start with a co
And notice that a nice way to remember which
of these answers have negative signs in them
is that the derivatives of the trig functions
that start with a co
always have a negative, and the root of the
trig functions that don't have the ko are
positive. Now let's use these formulas in
an example. g of x is a complicated expression
involving several trig functions as well as
a constant m, and I have a couple choices
of how to proceed. I could try to rewrite
all my trig functions in terms of sine and
cosine and simplify, or I could attack the
derivative directly using the quotient rule.
I'm going to use the direct approach In this
case, but sometimes you'll find that rewriting
will make things easier. So using the quotient
rule on the denominator, I get the original
denominator squared. On the numerator, I get
low D high to compute the derivative of x
cosine x, I need the product rule. So I get
x times the derivative of cosine, which is
negative sine x, plus the derivative of x,
which is just one times cosine of x. Now I
have to do a minus Hi, x cosine of x dillow.
The derivative of M is just zero because M
is a constant, plus the derivative of cotangent
which is negative cosecant squared of x. So
I found the derivative, I'm going to go ahead
and simplify a little bit by multiplying out
then rewriting everything in terms of sine
and cosine, and then multiplying the numerator
and denominator by sine squared of x, we have
a somewhat simplified expression for the derivative,
you should memorize the derivatives of the
trig functions will prove that the first two
formulas are correct in a separate proof video.
In this video, I'll give proofs for the two
special trig limit. And I'll also prove that
the derivative of sine is cosine. And the
derivative of cosine is minus sign. To prove
that the limit of sine that over theta is
one as theta goes to zero, I'm going to start
with a picture. In this picture, I have a
unit circle a circle of radius one, and I
have two right triangles, a green triangle
and a smaller red triangle, both with angle
theta. Now I'm going to argue in terms of
areas, if I want to compute the area of this
sector that I've shaded in blue here, in other
words, that pie shaped piece, I can first
compute the area of the circle, which is pi
times one squared for the radius. But since
the sector has angle theta, and the full circle
has angle two pi, I need to multiply that
area of the circle by the ratio theta over
two pi to represent the fraction of the area
of the circle that's included in this sector.
So in other words, the area of the sector
is just going to be theta over two, where
theta is given in the radians. Now if I want
to compute the area of the little red triangle,
I can do one half times the base times the
height. Now the base is going to be equal
to cosine theta, because I have a circle of
radius one angle theta here, and the height
is going to be sine theta. Finally, the area
of the green triangle is also one half times
the base times the height. But now the base
is a full one unit, and the height is given
by tangent theta, since opposite, which is
the height here over adjacent, which is one
has to equal tangent theta. Now if I put all
those areas together, I know that the area
of the red triangle, alright is cosine theta
sine theta over two has to be less than or
equal to the area of the blue sector, theta
over two, which is less than or equal to the
area of the big green triangle, which is tan
theta over two. Now I'm going to multiply
through this inequality by two and rewrite
things in terms of sine and cosine to get
cosine theta sine theta is less than or equal
to theta is less than or equal to sine theta
over cosine theta. Now I'm going to divide
through my inequalities by sine theta, which
won't change the inequalities as long as theta
is greater than zero, so that sine theta is
positive.
always have a negative, and the root of the
trig functions that don't have the ko are
positive. Now let's use these formulas in
an example. g of x is a complicated expression
involving several trig functions as well as
a constant m, and I have a couple choices
of how to proceed. I could try to rewrite
all my trig functions in terms of sine and
cosine and simplify, or I could attack the
derivative directly using the quotient rule.
I'm going to use the direct approach In this
case, but sometimes you'll find that rewriting
will make things easier. So using the quotient
rule on the denominator, I get the original
denominator squared. On the numerator, I get
low D high to compute the derivative of x
cosine x, I need the product rule. So I get
x times the derivative of cosine, which is
negative sine x, plus the derivative of x,
which is just one times cosine of x. Now I
have to do a minus Hi, x cosine of x dillow.
The derivative of M is just zero because M
is a constant, plus the derivative of cotangent
which is negative cosecant squared of x. So
I found the derivative, I'm going to go ahead
and simplify a little bit by multiplying out
then rewriting everything in terms of sine
and cosine, and then multiplying the numerator
and denominator by sine squared of x, we have
a somewhat simplified expression for the derivative,
you should memorize the derivatives of the
trig functions will prove that the first two
formulas are correct in a separate proof video.
In this video, I'll give proofs for the two
special trig limit. And I'll also prove that
the derivative of sine is cosine. And the
derivative of cosine is minus sign. To prove
that the limit of sine that over theta is
one as theta goes to zero, I'm going to start
with a picture. In this picture, I have a
unit circle a circle of radius one, and I
have two right triangles, a green triangle
and a smaller red triangle, both with angle
theta. Now I'm going to argue in terms of
areas, if I want to compute the area of this
sector that I've shaded in blue here, in other
words, that pie shaped piece, I can first
compute the area of the circle, which is pi
times one squared for the radius. But since
the sector has angle theta, and the full circle
has angle two pi, I need to multiply that
area of the circle by the ratio theta over
two pi to represent the fraction of the area
of the circle that's included in this sector.
So in other words, the area of the sector
is just going to be theta over two, where
theta is given in the radians. Now if I want
to compute the area of the little red triangle,
I can do one half times the base times the
height. Now the base is going to be equal
to cosine theta, because I have a circle of
radius one angle theta here, and the height
is going to be sine theta. Finally, the area
of the green triangle is also one half times
the base times the height. But now the base
is a full one unit, and the height is given
by tangent theta, since opposite, which is
the height here over adjacent, which is one
has to equal tangent theta. Now if I put all
those areas together, I know that the area
of the red triangle, alright is cosine theta
sine theta over two has to be less than or
equal to the area of the blue sector, theta
over two, which is less than or equal to the
area of the big green triangle, which is tan
theta over two. Now I'm going to multiply
through this inequality by two and rewrite
things in terms of sine and cosine to get
cosine theta sine theta is less than or equal
to theta is less than or equal to sine theta
over cosine theta. Now I'm going to divide
through my inequalities by sine theta, which
won't change the inequalities as long as theta
is greater than zero, so that sine theta is
positive.
And I get cosine theta is less than or equal
to theta over sine theta is less than or equal
to one over cosine theta. Now this middle
expression is the reciprocal of the expression
I want to take the limit of. So I'm going
to go ahead and take limits. And since the
limits of the two expressions on the outside,
both exist, and equal one by the sandwich
theorem, the limit of the expression on the
inside has to exist an equal one as well.
Now I've cheated a little bit here. And I've
really just taken the limit from the right
because I've assumed that theta is greater
than zero. But you can check that if you say
that less than zero, so that sign that as
negative, the limit from the left will also
equal one, the inequalities will flip around
first, but you'll still get it use the sandwich
theorem to get a limit of one. And that's
a cool geometric proof of this useful limit
from calculus. To show that the limit of cosine
theta minus one over theta is zero, we can
actually rewrite this expression and reuse
the limit that we just computed. So let me
write down my limit. And I'm going to multiply
this expression by cosine theta plus one on
the numerator and the denominator. So I haven't
changed the expression, I'm just multiply
that by one. Now, if I multiply my numerator
out,
And I get cosine theta is less than or equal
to theta over sine theta is less than or equal
to one over cosine theta. Now this middle
expression is the reciprocal of the expression
I want to take the limit of. So I'm going
to go ahead and take limits. And since the
limits of the two expressions on the outside,
both exist, and equal one by the sandwich
theorem, the limit of the expression on the
inside has to exist an equal one as well.
Now I've cheated a little bit here. And I've
really just taken the limit from the right
because I've assumed that theta is greater
than zero. But you can check that if you say
that less than zero, so that sign that as
negative, the limit from the left will also
equal one, the inequalities will flip around
first, but you'll still get it use the sandwich
theorem to get a limit of one. And that's
a cool geometric proof of this useful limit
from calculus. To show that the limit of cosine
theta minus one over theta is zero, we can
actually rewrite this expression and reuse
the limit that we just computed. So let me
write down my limit. And I'm going to multiply
this expression by cosine theta plus one on
the numerator and the denominator. So I haven't
changed the expression, I'm just multiply
that by one. Now, if I multiply my numerator
out,
I get cosine squared theta minus one. And
from the trig identity, sine squared theta
plus cosine squared theta equals one, I know
that cosine squared theta minus one has to
equal minus sine squared. So I can rewrite
my limit as the limit of minus sine squared
theta over theta cosine theta plus one. And
now I can regroup to write my sine theta over
theta, and my other copy of sine theta over
cosine theta plus one, the limit of the first
expression is going to be negative one, because
of the limit we just proved. And the limit
of the second expression is just zero over
one plus one, or zero, and therefore, my entire
limit is just going to be negative one times
zero, or zero, which is exactly what we want
it to prove. Now we can use these two limits
that we've just proved to calculate the derivatives
of sine and cosine, using the limit definition
of derivative and prove the results that were
stated previously. According to the limit
definition of derivative, the derivative of
sine x is the limit as h goes to zero of sine
of x plus h minus sine of x divided by H.
As usual, this is a zero for zero indeterminate
form limits. So I'm going to need to rewrite
things to evaluate it. And I'm going to rewrite
using the angle sum formula for sine, the
sine of x plus h is equal to sine x cosine
H, cosine plus cosine x sine H. Now if I rearrange
things, and factor out a sine x from the first
term, I can break up my limit into pieces
and compute every piece. So this is sine x
times zero plus cosine x times one. And so
my final answer is cosine x as we wanted the
proof that the derivative of cosine is minus
sine is very similar. So please stop the video
and try it for yourself before proceeding.
Using the limit definition of derivative,
we have that the derivative of cosine of x
is the limit as h goes to zero of cosine of
x plus h minus cosine of x over h, we can
rewrite the cosine of x plus h using the angle
sum formula as the cosine of x times the cosine
of H minus the sine of x times the sine of
H. And then we still have the minus cosine
of x over h. As before, we're going to regroup
things and factoring out the cosine x from
the first part, the same familiar limits just
put together in different ways. So here, cosine
of x as h goes to zero is just cosine of x.
This limit we know is zero. sine of x is just
saying sine of x, and sine of h over h is
going to one which means that our final answer
is going to be negative sine of x times one
or just negative sine of x, which is exactly
what we wanted. That's all for the proofs
of these four useful calculus facts. rectilinear
motion or linear motion means the motion of
an object along a straight line. For example,
a particle moving left and right, or a ball
going up and down. In this video, we'll see
what the derivative and the second derivative
tell us about the motion of an object constrained
to move along a straight line. In this example,
A particle is moving up and down along a straight
line. And its position is given by this equation
where the positive positions mean that the
particle is above its Baseline Position, whatever
I'm calling position zero, and negative positions
mean the particle is below this Baseline Position.
I'm asked to find s prime of T and S double
prime of t. So by deriving I get four t cubed
minus 16 t squared plus 12 T for the first
derivative, and 12 t squared minus 32 t plus
12. For the second derivative,
I get cosine squared theta minus one. And
from the trig identity, sine squared theta
plus cosine squared theta equals one, I know
that cosine squared theta minus one has to
equal minus sine squared. So I can rewrite
my limit as the limit of minus sine squared
theta over theta cosine theta plus one. And
now I can regroup to write my sine theta over
theta, and my other copy of sine theta over
cosine theta plus one, the limit of the first
expression is going to be negative one, because
of the limit we just proved. And the limit
of the second expression is just zero over
one plus one, or zero, and therefore, my entire
limit is just going to be negative one times
zero, or zero, which is exactly what we want
it to prove. Now we can use these two limits
that we've just proved to calculate the derivatives
of sine and cosine, using the limit definition
of derivative and prove the results that were
stated previously. According to the limit
definition of derivative, the derivative of
sine x is the limit as h goes to zero of sine
of x plus h minus sine of x divided by H.
As usual, this is a zero for zero indeterminate
form limits. So I'm going to need to rewrite
things to evaluate it. And I'm going to rewrite
using the angle sum formula for sine, the
sine of x plus h is equal to sine x cosine
H, cosine plus cosine x sine H. Now if I rearrange
things, and factor out a sine x from the first
term, I can break up my limit into pieces
and compute every piece. So this is sine x
times zero plus cosine x times one. And so
my final answer is cosine x as we wanted the
proof that the derivative of cosine is minus
sine is very similar. So please stop the video
and try it for yourself before proceeding.
Using the limit definition of derivative,
we have that the derivative of cosine of x
is the limit as h goes to zero of cosine of
x plus h minus cosine of x over h, we can
rewrite the cosine of x plus h using the angle
sum formula as the cosine of x times the cosine
of H minus the sine of x times the sine of
H. And then we still have the minus cosine
of x over h. As before, we're going to regroup
things and factoring out the cosine x from
the first part, the same familiar limits just
put together in different ways. So here, cosine
of x as h goes to zero is just cosine of x.
This limit we know is zero. sine of x is just
saying sine of x, and sine of h over h is
going to one which means that our final answer
is going to be negative sine of x times one
or just negative sine of x, which is exactly
what we wanted. That's all for the proofs
of these four useful calculus facts. rectilinear
motion or linear motion means the motion of
an object along a straight line. For example,
a particle moving left and right, or a ball
going up and down. In this video, we'll see
what the derivative and the second derivative
tell us about the motion of an object constrained
to move along a straight line. In this example,
A particle is moving up and down along a straight
line. And its position is given by this equation
where the positive positions mean that the
particle is above its Baseline Position, whatever
I'm calling position zero, and negative positions
mean the particle is below this Baseline Position.
I'm asked to find s prime of T and S double
prime of t. So by deriving I get four t cubed
minus 16 t squared plus 12 T for the first
derivative, and 12 t squared minus 32 t plus
12. For the second derivative,
S prime of t, which can also be written, D
STD represents the instantaneous rate of change
of S of t, the position over time, well, the
change in position over time is just the velocity.
And this can also be written as v of t, s
double prime of t, the second derivative of
s with respect to t, can also be thought of
as the derivative of the velocity function.
So that represents the rate of change of velocity
over time, how fast the velocity is increasing
or decreasing. And that is called acceleration.
And it can be written as a lefty. Like position,
velocity and acceleration can be both positive
and negative. A positive velocity means the
position is increasing. So the particle is
moving up, while a negative velocity means
the position is decreasing, so the particle
is moving down. Of course, a velocity of zero
means the particles at rest, at least for
that instant. from physics, we know that force
equals mass times acceleration. So if the
acceleration is positive, then that means
the force is in the positive direction, it's
like the particle is being pulled up. If on
the other hand, the acceleration is negative
than the force is in the negative direction,
and it's like the particle is being pulled
down. an acceleration of zero means there's
no force on the particle at that instant,
and the velocity continues as is. Let's use
these ideas about velocity acceleration. And
the following table of values to describe
the particles motion at time equals 1.5 seconds.
At time 1.5 seconds, the position of the particle
is positive, so that means the particle is
above its Baseline Position of zero. its velocity
is negative, so that means that its position
is decreasing. In other words, the particle
is moving down. Its acceleration is negative
acceleration is the derivative of velocity.
So a negative acceleration means the velocity
is decreasing. Well, a negative velocity that's
decreasing is getting more and more negative.
So in fact, the particle is moving down faster
and faster. This can be a little bit confusing,
because even though the velocity is decreasing,
it's getting more and more negative, the speed,
which is the absolute value of velocity is
increasing. We can also see what the particle
is doing at 1.5 seconds by looking at this
graph, where the time is drawn on the x axis
and position s of t is on the y axis. From
the graph, we can see that when t is zero,
S of t is also zero. So the particle starts
at its Baseline Position of zero. At time
1.5 seconds, the particle is above this starting
position, but moving downwards. And since
the slope of this graph is getting steeper
and steeper, we can conclude that the speed
of the particle is increasing. Same thing
was we concluded from the table of values.
Now let's do the same analysis when time is
2.5 seconds. s of 2.5 seconds is negative.
So the particle is below its starting position.
Velocity s prime of t is also negative. So
the particle is still going down. But now
the acceleration as double prime of t is positive.
That means that the velocity Today is increasing,
well, a negative velocity that's increasing
is getting less negative closer to zero. So
the particle must be slowing down. And in
fact, the speed is decreasing. Again, the
graph agrees with this reasoning, at 2.5 seconds,
our position is way down here, our graph is
decreasing, so the particles moving down,
and the slope seems to be leveling off. So
the particle speed is decreasing. Even though
it's velocity,
S prime of t, which can also be written, D
STD represents the instantaneous rate of change
of S of t, the position over time, well, the
change in position over time is just the velocity.
And this can also be written as v of t, s
double prime of t, the second derivative of
s with respect to t, can also be thought of
as the derivative of the velocity function.
So that represents the rate of change of velocity
over time, how fast the velocity is increasing
or decreasing. And that is called acceleration.
And it can be written as a lefty. Like position,
velocity and acceleration can be both positive
and negative. A positive velocity means the
position is increasing. So the particle is
moving up, while a negative velocity means
the position is decreasing, so the particle
is moving down. Of course, a velocity of zero
means the particles at rest, at least for
that instant. from physics, we know that force
equals mass times acceleration. So if the
acceleration is positive, then that means
the force is in the positive direction, it's
like the particle is being pulled up. If on
the other hand, the acceleration is negative
than the force is in the negative direction,
and it's like the particle is being pulled
down. an acceleration of zero means there's
no force on the particle at that instant,
and the velocity continues as is. Let's use
these ideas about velocity acceleration. And
the following table of values to describe
the particles motion at time equals 1.5 seconds.
At time 1.5 seconds, the position of the particle
is positive, so that means the particle is
above its Baseline Position of zero. its velocity
is negative, so that means that its position
is decreasing. In other words, the particle
is moving down. Its acceleration is negative
acceleration is the derivative of velocity.
So a negative acceleration means the velocity
is decreasing. Well, a negative velocity that's
decreasing is getting more and more negative.
So in fact, the particle is moving down faster
and faster. This can be a little bit confusing,
because even though the velocity is decreasing,
it's getting more and more negative, the speed,
which is the absolute value of velocity is
increasing. We can also see what the particle
is doing at 1.5 seconds by looking at this
graph, where the time is drawn on the x axis
and position s of t is on the y axis. From
the graph, we can see that when t is zero,
S of t is also zero. So the particle starts
at its Baseline Position of zero. At time
1.5 seconds, the particle is above this starting
position, but moving downwards. And since
the slope of this graph is getting steeper
and steeper, we can conclude that the speed
of the particle is increasing. Same thing
was we concluded from the table of values.
Now let's do the same analysis when time is
2.5 seconds. s of 2.5 seconds is negative.
So the particle is below its starting position.
Velocity s prime of t is also negative. So
the particle is still going down. But now
the acceleration as double prime of t is positive.
That means that the velocity Today is increasing,
well, a negative velocity that's increasing
is getting less negative closer to zero. So
the particle must be slowing down. And in
fact, the speed is decreasing. Again, the
graph agrees with this reasoning, at 2.5 seconds,
our position is way down here, our graph is
decreasing, so the particles moving down,
and the slope seems to be leveling off. So
the particle speed is decreasing. Even though
it's velocity,
which you can think of as speed with direction
is increasing, simply because it's a negative
velocity that's getting less negative. Notice
that in the first example, when velocity and
acceleration are both in the same direction,
that is, they're both negative the particle
was speeding up. And the second example, were
velocity and acceleration when the opposite
directions one positive one negative, the
particle is slowing down.
which you can think of as speed with direction
is increasing, simply because it's a negative
velocity that's getting less negative. Notice
that in the first example, when velocity and
acceleration are both in the same direction,
that is, they're both negative the particle
was speeding up. And the second example, were
velocity and acceleration when the opposite
directions one positive one negative, the
particle is slowing down.
This is true in general, when velocity acceleration
had the same sign, that as they're both positive
or both negative, then the particle is speeding
up.
This is true in general, when velocity acceleration
had the same sign, that as they're both positive
or both negative, then the particle is speeding
up.
And when velocity acceleration have opposite
signs, then the particle is slowing down.
One way to think about this is in terms of
force, forces in the same direction as acceleration.
So if velocity acceleration have the same
sign, that means force is the same direction
as the particles already going, so it's making
the particle speed up. But if velocity and
acceleration have opposite signs, then the
force is going against the way that particles
moving, so it's causing it to slow down. Let's
continue the same example with some more questions,
it'll be helpful to write down the velocity
and acceleration functions that we calculated
earlier. I've also graphed position, velocity
and acceleration here at the right. And before
you go on, it's a fun exercise to figure out
which one is which, without even looking at
the equations just based on the shapes of
the graphs. And where they're increasing where
they're decreasing where they're positive
and where they're negative. Velocity is the
derivative of position. So velocity needs
to be positive, where position is increasing.
The only pairs of functions that have this
property are the blue one, that's positive,
when the red ones increasing, and the green
function, which is positive, when the blue
one is increasing. Now acceleration, which
is the derivative of velocity also needs to
be positive, when velocity is increasing.
So the only way to correctly label the functions
with both of these relationships is to make
the red one be position, the blue one be velocity,
and the green one be acceleration. This agrees
with the equations that
And when velocity acceleration have opposite
signs, then the particle is slowing down.
One way to think about this is in terms of
force, forces in the same direction as acceleration.
So if velocity acceleration have the same
sign, that means force is the same direction
as the particles already going, so it's making
the particle speed up. But if velocity and
acceleration have opposite signs, then the
force is going against the way that particles
moving, so it's causing it to slow down. Let's
continue the same example with some more questions,
it'll be helpful to write down the velocity
and acceleration functions that we calculated
earlier. I've also graphed position, velocity
and acceleration here at the right. And before
you go on, it's a fun exercise to figure out
which one is which, without even looking at
the equations just based on the shapes of
the graphs. And where they're increasing where
they're decreasing where they're positive
and where they're negative. Velocity is the
derivative of position. So velocity needs
to be positive, where position is increasing.
The only pairs of functions that have this
property are the blue one, that's positive,
when the red ones increasing, and the green
function, which is positive, when the blue
one is increasing. Now acceleration, which
is the derivative of velocity also needs to
be positive, when velocity is increasing.
So the only way to correctly label the functions
with both of these relationships is to make
the red one be position, the blue one be velocity,
and the green one be acceleration. This agrees
with the equations that
we have over here.
The first question asks, When is the particle
at rest, the particle is temporarily at rest
when the velocity is zero. In other words,
S prime of t is zero. So plugging in the equation
for S prime of t, we can factor out a four
T, and factor some more. To conclude the T
has to be 01, or three.
The first question asks, When is the particle
at rest, the particle is temporarily at rest
when the velocity is zero. In other words,
S prime of t is zero. So plugging in the equation
for S prime of t, we can factor out a four
T, and factor some more. To conclude the T
has to be 01, or three.
This conclusion agrees with our graph of V
of t, which has x intercepts at 01 and three,
and also agrees with our graph of position
s of t. Since the particle stops for a moment,
it changed direction, when t equals 01. And
three, the particle is moving up when velocity
is positive, and moving down when velocity
is negative. Since we know from the previous
question, the velocity equals zero, when t
equals 01. And three, we can look in between
those values to figure out whether the velocity
is positive or negative, just by plugging
in values. So for example, when t is negative
one, if I plug into the negative one to the
equation for velocity, I get a negative number.
So velocity must be negative when t is less
than zero, between zero and one. If I plug
in, for example, t equals one half, I get
a value of S prime of t or V of t of 2.5,
which is a positive number. If I plug in a
value of t in between one and three, say t
equals two, I get a value of v of t of negative
eight, which is a negative number. And finally,
if I plug in a value of t greater than three,
so For, I get a positive answer for V of t.
So from the sign chart, I see that V of t
is negative when t is between negative infinity
and zero, and in between one and three, and
V of t is positive when t is between
This conclusion agrees with our graph of V
of t, which has x intercepts at 01 and three,
and also agrees with our graph of position
s of t. Since the particle stops for a moment,
it changed direction, when t equals 01. And
three, the particle is moving up when velocity
is positive, and moving down when velocity
is negative. Since we know from the previous
question, the velocity equals zero, when t
equals 01. And three, we can look in between
those values to figure out whether the velocity
is positive or negative, just by plugging
in values. So for example, when t is negative
one, if I plug into the negative one to the
equation for velocity, I get a negative number.
So velocity must be negative when t is less
than zero, between zero and one. If I plug
in, for example, t equals one half, I get
a value of S prime of t or V of t of 2.5,
which is a positive number. If I plug in a
value of t in between one and three, say t
equals two, I get a value of v of t of negative
eight, which is a negative number. And finally,
if I plug in a value of t greater than three,
so For, I get a positive answer for V of t.
So from the sign chart, I see that V of t
is negative when t is between negative infinity
and zero, and in between one and three, and
V of t is positive when t is between
zero and
one, and between three and infinity. Of course,
I could have reached the same conclusion just
by looking at the graph of velocity and where
it's above and below the x axis, or even by
looking at the graph of position and seeing
where it's increasing and where it's decreasing.
To answer the next question, the particle
will be speeding up when V of t and a of t
are both positive or both negative. And the
particle will be slowing down when V of t
and a of t have opposite signs. So let's make
a similar sign chart to figure out where a
of t is positive and negative. First, it'll
be helpful to find out where a if t is zero.
So if I set zero equal to my S double prime,
that's 12 t squared minus 32 t plus 12, I
could factor out
one, and between three and infinity. Of course,
I could have reached the same conclusion just
by looking at the graph of velocity and where
it's above and below the x axis, or even by
looking at the graph of position and seeing
where it's increasing and where it's decreasing.
To answer the next question, the particle
will be speeding up when V of t and a of t
are both positive or both negative. And the
particle will be slowing down when V of t
and a of t have opposite signs. So let's make
a similar sign chart to figure out where a
of t is positive and negative. First, it'll
be helpful to find out where a if t is zero.
So if I set zero equal to my S double prime,
that's 12 t squared minus 32 t plus 12, I
could factor out
a four
and then use the quadratic equation to find
the solution. Since this equation doesn't
factor easily, this simplifies to four thirds
plus or minus the square root of seven over
three, which is approximately 0.45, and 2.22.
Now I can build a similar sign chart for acceleration,
mark the places where acceleration is zero.
and plug in values of t, say t equals zero
is the equation for acceleration, I get a
positive answer here. When I plug in, say
t equals one, I get a negative answer here.
And when I plug in, say, t equals three, I
get another positive answer here. Now, if
I put this together with my velocity chart,
which changed sign at 01, and three, and went
from negative to positive, to negative to
positive, I can try to figure out where velocity
acceleration both have the same sign. It might
be helpful actually to shade in where acceleration
is positive. And separately shade in where
velocity is positive. And then look for the
places where both are shaded. So between zero
and 4.5, and greater than three. And then
I can also look where both are unshaded that
looks like in between one and 2.22. So that's
where they're both negative. And then I'll
know that V of t and a of t have opposite
signs everywhere else. A slightly better answer,
we'll use exact values of four thirds plus
or minus squared of seven thirds instead of
these decimal approximations. So let me write
that down. So here is where the particle speeding
up. And here, it's where it's slowing down,
we can check our work by looking at the graph
of position, the particle speeding up with
the position graph is getting steeper and
steeper, that's the red graph is getting steeper
and steeper here, here. And here, just like
we found algebraically. As our final example,
let's look at net change in position and distance
traveled between one and four seconds for
the same particle. At time, one second position
is five thirds, or about 1.67 millimeters
at time for its position is given by 32 thirds,
or about 10.67 millimeters, all I'm doing
is plugging one and four into this equation.
So the net change in position is just the
difference of these two numbers. As a four
minus as of one, which is nine millimeters.
At first glance, it might seem like the total
distance traveled between one and four seconds
should also be nine millimeters, but actually,
it's a little more complicated. Because the
particle switches direction during that time
period, it doesn't go straight from its position
at one second to its position at four seconds.
Remember what the graph Position looked like
the particle switches direction at one second
and at three seconds. So to find the total
distance, we need the distance of travels
from one second to three seconds, plus the
distance that travels from three seconds to
four seconds. Another way of thinking about
this is that we need the absolute value of
s three minus s one, plus the absolute value
of s four minus s three, we need these absolute
value signs because this difference in position
will be negative instead of positive when
the particles moving down. Plugging in the
t values into our equation, we get negative
27 minus five thirds, plus the absolute value
of 32 thirds minus negative 27, which is a
total of 199 thirds, or 66.3 repeating millimeters,
quite a bit more than the nine millimeter
difference in position. This video gave an
in depth analysis of a particle moving up
and down along a straight
and then use the quadratic equation to find
the solution. Since this equation doesn't
factor easily, this simplifies to four thirds
plus or minus the square root of seven over
three, which is approximately 0.45, and 2.22.
Now I can build a similar sign chart for acceleration,
mark the places where acceleration is zero.
and plug in values of t, say t equals zero
is the equation for acceleration, I get a
positive answer here. When I plug in, say
t equals one, I get a negative answer here.
And when I plug in, say, t equals three, I
get another positive answer here. Now, if
I put this together with my velocity chart,
which changed sign at 01, and three, and went
from negative to positive, to negative to
positive, I can try to figure out where velocity
acceleration both have the same sign. It might
be helpful actually to shade in where acceleration
is positive. And separately shade in where
velocity is positive. And then look for the
places where both are shaded. So between zero
and 4.5, and greater than three. And then
I can also look where both are unshaded that
looks like in between one and 2.22. So that's
where they're both negative. And then I'll
know that V of t and a of t have opposite
signs everywhere else. A slightly better answer,
we'll use exact values of four thirds plus
or minus squared of seven thirds instead of
these decimal approximations. So let me write
that down. So here is where the particle speeding
up. And here, it's where it's slowing down,
we can check our work by looking at the graph
of position, the particle speeding up with
the position graph is getting steeper and
steeper, that's the red graph is getting steeper
and steeper here, here. And here, just like
we found algebraically. As our final example,
let's look at net change in position and distance
traveled between one and four seconds for
the same particle. At time, one second position
is five thirds, or about 1.67 millimeters
at time for its position is given by 32 thirds,
or about 10.67 millimeters, all I'm doing
is plugging one and four into this equation.
So the net change in position is just the
difference of these two numbers. As a four
minus as of one, which is nine millimeters.
At first glance, it might seem like the total
distance traveled between one and four seconds
should also be nine millimeters, but actually,
it's a little more complicated. Because the
particle switches direction during that time
period, it doesn't go straight from its position
at one second to its position at four seconds.
Remember what the graph Position looked like
the particle switches direction at one second
and at three seconds. So to find the total
distance, we need the distance of travels
from one second to three seconds, plus the
distance that travels from three seconds to
four seconds. Another way of thinking about
this is that we need the absolute value of
s three minus s one, plus the absolute value
of s four minus s three, we need these absolute
value signs because this difference in position
will be negative instead of positive when
the particles moving down. Plugging in the
t values into our equation, we get negative
27 minus five thirds, plus the absolute value
of 32 thirds minus negative 27, which is a
total of 199 thirds, or 66.3 repeating millimeters,
quite a bit more than the nine millimeter
difference in position. This video gave an
in depth analysis of a particle moving up
and down along a straight
line.
A similar analysis could be done for a particle
moving left and right along a straight line,
where a positive position means the particles
on the right side, and a negative position
means the particles on the left side of his
Baseline Position. Of course, the same analysis
can be done for other objects, not just particles.
A typical application is to a ball being thrown
straight up and then falling down again. This
video will give an economic application of
the derivative to a cost function. Suppose
that the total cost of producing x tie dyed
t shirts is C of x.
A similar analysis could be done for a particle
moving left and right along a straight line,
where a positive position means the particles
on the right side, and a negative position
means the particles on the left side of his
Baseline Position. Of course, the same analysis
can be done for other objects, not just particles.
A typical application is to a ball being thrown
straight up and then falling down again. This
video will give an economic application of
the derivative to a cost function. Suppose
that the total cost of producing x tie dyed
t shirts is C of x.
I'm going to sketch a few graphs, and you
try to decide which graph is the most reasonable
representation for C of x. Pause the video
for a moment to think about it. All of these
candidate graphs that I've drawn have a nonzero
y intercept, that's meant to reflect the idea
that there's some fixed startup cost and buying
equipment before you can even get started.
Now, I would like to suggest that C of x should
be an increasing function of x, because it's
going to cost more money to make more t shirts,
you need more supplies and labor. So this
function is out. Now it's somewhat reasonable,
I think that C of x might be a linear function
of x like it is here, if you've got the same
cost per t shirt, whether you make 10 t shirts,
or 1000 t shirts, the slope in that case would
represent the cost per t shirt. And the linear
function would mean that cost per t shirt
is constant, no matter how many t shirts you're
making. But in reality, it's probably going
to be cheaper to make 1000 t shirts than it
is to make just a few t shirts. And therefore
the cost per t shirt, sure slope should be
going down as x increases. So this function
right here is the one whose slope is going
down for larger access. And so I would say
that this is the most reasonable representation
for C of x as a function of x. In other words,
C of x should be an increasing function, but
C prime of x should be decreasing. C of 204
minus C of 200 represents the additional cost
for making 204 t shirts instead of 200. In
formula, you might think of that as the cost
of making the last four t shirts. The ratio
C of 200 for a minus C of 200 over four is
the average rate of change of C of x. The
units are units of cost, which is probably
dollars per t shirt. And formula you might
think of this as the additional cost per t
shirt of making the last four t shirts. C
prime of 200 is the instantaneous rate of
change of C of x. c of x is known as the cost
function. And C prime of x is called the marginal
cost, which is the rate at which cost is increasing
per additional t shirt made. It might seem
a little bit weird to take the derivative
of C of x since x can really only take on
integer values. But we can always approximate
C of x with a function whose domain is all
real numbers. To make this a little more specific,
let's use a cost function of C of x equals
500 plus 300 times the square root of x. In
this example, x is supposed to be the number
of iPads that are produced, and C of x is
the cost of producing them in dollars. Then
C of 401 minus C of 400. given by 500 plus
300, times the square root of 401 minus 500
plus 300 times the square root of 400. This
simplifies to $7.50, rounded to the nearest
cent. This means that it costs an additional
$7.50 to go from producing 400 iPads to 401
iPad. In this fictitious example,
I'm going to sketch a few graphs, and you
try to decide which graph is the most reasonable
representation for C of x. Pause the video
for a moment to think about it. All of these
candidate graphs that I've drawn have a nonzero
y intercept, that's meant to reflect the idea
that there's some fixed startup cost and buying
equipment before you can even get started.
Now, I would like to suggest that C of x should
be an increasing function of x, because it's
going to cost more money to make more t shirts,
you need more supplies and labor. So this
function is out. Now it's somewhat reasonable,
I think that C of x might be a linear function
of x like it is here, if you've got the same
cost per t shirt, whether you make 10 t shirts,
or 1000 t shirts, the slope in that case would
represent the cost per t shirt. And the linear
function would mean that cost per t shirt
is constant, no matter how many t shirts you're
making. But in reality, it's probably going
to be cheaper to make 1000 t shirts than it
is to make just a few t shirts. And therefore
the cost per t shirt, sure slope should be
going down as x increases. So this function
right here is the one whose slope is going
down for larger access. And so I would say
that this is the most reasonable representation
for C of x as a function of x. In other words,
C of x should be an increasing function, but
C prime of x should be decreasing. C of 204
minus C of 200 represents the additional cost
for making 204 t shirts instead of 200. In
formula, you might think of that as the cost
of making the last four t shirts. The ratio
C of 200 for a minus C of 200 over four is
the average rate of change of C of x. The
units are units of cost, which is probably
dollars per t shirt. And formula you might
think of this as the additional cost per t
shirt of making the last four t shirts. C
prime of 200 is the instantaneous rate of
change of C of x. c of x is known as the cost
function. And C prime of x is called the marginal
cost, which is the rate at which cost is increasing
per additional t shirt made. It might seem
a little bit weird to take the derivative
of C of x since x can really only take on
integer values. But we can always approximate
C of x with a function whose domain is all
real numbers. To make this a little more specific,
let's use a cost function of C of x equals
500 plus 300 times the square root of x. In
this example, x is supposed to be the number
of iPads that are produced, and C of x is
the cost of producing them in dollars. Then
C of 401 minus C of 400. given by 500 plus
300, times the square root of 401 minus 500
plus 300 times the square root of 400. This
simplifies to $7.50, rounded to the nearest
cent. This means that it costs an additional
$7.50 to go from producing 400 iPads to 401
iPad. In this fictitious example,
if I want to compute C prime of 400, instead,
I can see that C prime of x is equal to 300
times one half x to the minus one half. So
C prime of 400 is going to be 300 times one
half times 400 to the negative one half, which
simplifies to 300 over two times the square
root of 400, which is also 7.5, or $7.50.
Per iPad. Up to rounding to the nearest cent,
these two answers are equal. And it makes
sense that C prime of 400 should equal approximately
this difference. Since C prime of 400, the
derivative is approximately equal to the average
rate of change going from 400 to 401, which
is just this difference, divided by one. Once
again, C prime of 400 is called the marginal
cost, and represents the rate at which the
cost function is increasing with each additional
item. This video gave an example of the cost
function, and it's derivative, which is known
as marginal cost. This video introduces logarithms.
logarithms are a way of writing exponents.
The expression log base a of B equals c means
that a to the C equals b. In other words,
log base a of B is the exponent that you raise
a to to get be. The number A is called the
base of the logarithm. It's also called the
base when we write it in this exponential
form. Some students find it helpful to remember
this relationship, log base a of B equals
c means a to the C equals b, by drawing arrows,
if I want to compute C prime of 400, instead,
I can see that C prime of x is equal to 300
times one half x to the minus one half. So
C prime of 400 is going to be 300 times one
half times 400 to the negative one half, which
simplifies to 300 over two times the square
root of 400, which is also 7.5, or $7.50.
Per iPad. Up to rounding to the nearest cent,
these two answers are equal. And it makes
sense that C prime of 400 should equal approximately
this difference. Since C prime of 400, the
derivative is approximately equal to the average
rate of change going from 400 to 401, which
is just this difference, divided by one. Once
again, C prime of 400 is called the marginal
cost, and represents the rate at which the
cost function is increasing with each additional
item. This video gave an example of the cost
function, and it's derivative, which is known
as marginal cost. This video introduces logarithms.
logarithms are a way of writing exponents.
The expression log base a of B equals c means
that a to the C equals b. In other words,
log base a of B is the exponent that you raise
a to to get be. The number A is called the
base of the logarithm. It's also called the
base when we write it in this exponential
form. Some students find it helpful to remember
this relationship, log base a of B equals
c means a to the C equals b, by drawing arrows,
a to the C equals b.
Other students like to think of it in terms
of asking a question, log base a of fee, asks,
What power do you raise a two in order to
get b? Let's look at some examples. log base
two of eight is three, because two to the
three equals eight. In general, log base two
of y is asking you the question, What power
do you have to raise to two to get y? So for
example, log base two of 16 is four, because
it's asking you the question to two what power
equals 16? And the answer is four. Please
pause the video and try some of these other
examples. log base two of two is asking, What
power do you raise to two to get to? And the
answer is one. Two to the one equals two.
log base two of one half is asking two to
what power gives you one half? Well, to get
one half, you need to raise two to a negative
power. So that would be two to the negative
one. So the answer is negative one. log base
two of 1/8 means what power do we raise to
two in order to get 1/8. Since one eight is
one over two cubed, we have to raise two to
the negative three power to get one over two
cubed. So our exponent is negative three,
and that's our answer to our log expression.
Finally, log base two of one is asking to
to what power equals one, or anything raised
to the zero power gives us one, so this log
expression evaluates to zero. Notice that
we can get positive negative and zero answers
for our logarithm expressions. Please pause
the video and figure out what these logs evaluate
to to work out log base 10 of another Again,
notice that a million is 10 to the sixth power.
Now we're asking the question, What power
do we raise tend to to get a million? So that
is what power do we raise 10? to to get 10
to the six? Well, of course, the answer is
going to be six. Similarly, since point O
one is 10 to the minus three, this log expressions,
the same thing as asking, what's the log base
10 of 10 to the minus three? Well, what power
do you have to raise 10? to to get 10 to the
minus three? Of course, the answer is negative
three. Log base 10 of zero is asking, What
power do we raise 10 to to get zero. If you
think about it, there's no way to raise 10
to an exponent get zero. Raising 10 to a positive
exponent gets us really big positive numbers.
Raising 10 to a negative exponent is like
one over 10 to a power that's giving us tiny
fractions, but they're still positive numbers,
we're never going to get zero. Even if we
raised 10 to the zero power, we'll just get
one. So there's no way to get zero and the
log base 10 of zero does not exist. If you
try it on your calculator using the log base
10 button, you'll get an error message. Same
thing happens when we do log base 10 of negative
100. We're asking 10 to what power equals
negative 100. And there's no exponent that
will work. And more generally, it's possible
to take the log of numbers that are greater
than zero, but not for numbers that are less
than or equal to zero. In other words, the
domain of the function log base a of x, no
matter what base you're using, for a, the
domain is going to be all positive numbers.
A few notes on notation. When you see ln of
x, that's called natural log, and it means
the log base e of x, where he is that famous
number that's about 2.718. When you see log
of x with no base at all, by convention, that
means log base 10 of x, and it's called the
common log. Most scientific calculators have
buttons for natural log, and for common log.
Let's practice rewriting expressions with
logs in them. log base three of one nine is
negative two can be rewritten as the expression
three to the negative two equals 1/9. Log
of 13 is shorthand for log base 10 of 13.
So that can be rewritten as 10 to the 1.11394
equals 13. Finally, in this last expression,
ln means natural log, or log base e, so I
can rewrite this equation as log base e of
whenever E equals negative one. Well, that
means the same thing as e to the negative
one equals one over e, which is true. Now
let's go the opposite direction. We'll start
with exponential equations and rewrite them
as logs. Remember that log base a of B equals
c means the same thing
Other students like to think of it in terms
of asking a question, log base a of fee, asks,
What power do you raise a two in order to
get b? Let's look at some examples. log base
two of eight is three, because two to the
three equals eight. In general, log base two
of y is asking you the question, What power
do you have to raise to two to get y? So for
example, log base two of 16 is four, because
it's asking you the question to two what power
equals 16? And the answer is four. Please
pause the video and try some of these other
examples. log base two of two is asking, What
power do you raise to two to get to? And the
answer is one. Two to the one equals two.
log base two of one half is asking two to
what power gives you one half? Well, to get
one half, you need to raise two to a negative
power. So that would be two to the negative
one. So the answer is negative one. log base
two of 1/8 means what power do we raise to
two in order to get 1/8. Since one eight is
one over two cubed, we have to raise two to
the negative three power to get one over two
cubed. So our exponent is negative three,
and that's our answer to our log expression.
Finally, log base two of one is asking to
to what power equals one, or anything raised
to the zero power gives us one, so this log
expression evaluates to zero. Notice that
we can get positive negative and zero answers
for our logarithm expressions. Please pause
the video and figure out what these logs evaluate
to to work out log base 10 of another Again,
notice that a million is 10 to the sixth power.
Now we're asking the question, What power
do we raise tend to to get a million? So that
is what power do we raise 10? to to get 10
to the six? Well, of course, the answer is
going to be six. Similarly, since point O
one is 10 to the minus three, this log expressions,
the same thing as asking, what's the log base
10 of 10 to the minus three? Well, what power
do you have to raise 10? to to get 10 to the
minus three? Of course, the answer is negative
three. Log base 10 of zero is asking, What
power do we raise 10 to to get zero. If you
think about it, there's no way to raise 10
to an exponent get zero. Raising 10 to a positive
exponent gets us really big positive numbers.
Raising 10 to a negative exponent is like
one over 10 to a power that's giving us tiny
fractions, but they're still positive numbers,
we're never going to get zero. Even if we
raised 10 to the zero power, we'll just get
one. So there's no way to get zero and the
log base 10 of zero does not exist. If you
try it on your calculator using the log base
10 button, you'll get an error message. Same
thing happens when we do log base 10 of negative
100. We're asking 10 to what power equals
negative 100. And there's no exponent that
will work. And more generally, it's possible
to take the log of numbers that are greater
than zero, but not for numbers that are less
than or equal to zero. In other words, the
domain of the function log base a of x, no
matter what base you're using, for a, the
domain is going to be all positive numbers.
A few notes on notation. When you see ln of
x, that's called natural log, and it means
the log base e of x, where he is that famous
number that's about 2.718. When you see log
of x with no base at all, by convention, that
means log base 10 of x, and it's called the
common log. Most scientific calculators have
buttons for natural log, and for common log.
Let's practice rewriting expressions with
logs in them. log base three of one nine is
negative two can be rewritten as the expression
three to the negative two equals 1/9. Log
of 13 is shorthand for log base 10 of 13.
So that can be rewritten as 10 to the 1.11394
equals 13. Finally, in this last expression,
ln means natural log, or log base e, so I
can rewrite this equation as log base e of
whenever E equals negative one. Well, that
means the same thing as e to the negative
one equals one over e, which is true. Now
let's go the opposite direction. We'll start
with exponential equations and rewrite them
as logs. Remember that log base a of B equals
c means the same thing
as a to the C equals b,
the base stays the same in both expressions.
So for this example, the base of three in
the exponential equation, that's going to
be the same as the base in our log. Now I
just have to figure out what's in the argument
of the log. And what goes on the other side
of the equal sign. Remember that the answer
to a log is an exponent. So the thing that
goes in this box should be my exponent for
my exponential equation. In other words, you
and I'll put the 9.78 as the argument of my
log. This works because log base three of
9.78 equals u means the same thing as three
to the U equals 9.78, which is just what we
started with. In the second example, the base
of my exponential equation is E. So the base
of my log is going to be the answer to my
log is an exponent. In this case, the exponent
3x plus seven. And the other expression, the
four minus y becomes my argument of my log.
Let me check, log base e of four minus y equals
3x plus seven means e to 3x plus seven equals
four minus Y, which is just what I started
with. I can also rewrite log base e as natural
log. This video introduced the idea of logs.
And the fact that log base a of B equal c
means the same thing as a to the C equals
b. So log base a of B is asking you the question,
What power exponent Do you raise a to in order
to get b. In this video, we'll work out the
graph, so some log functions and also talk
about their domains. For this first example,
let's graph a log function by hand by plotting
some points. The function we're working with
is y equals log base two of x, I'll make a
chart of x and y values. Since we're working
this out by hand, I want to pick x values
for which it's easy to compute log base two
of x. So I'll start out with the x value of
one. Because log base two of one is zero,
log base anything of one is 02 is another
x value that's easy to compute log base two
of two, that's asking, What power do I raise
to two to get to one? And the answer is one.
Power other powers of two are easy to work
with. So for example, log base two of four
that saying what power do I raise to to to
get four, so the answer is two. Similarly,
log base two of eight is three, and log base
two of 16 is four. Let me also work with some
fractional values for X. If x is one half,
then log base two of one half that saying
what power do I raise to two to get one half?
Well, that needs a power of negative one.
It's also easy to compute by hand, the log
base two of 1/4 and 1/8. log base two of 1/4
is negative two, since two to the negative
two is 1/4. And similarly, log base two of
1/8 is negative three. I'll put some tick
marks on my x and y axes. Please pause the
video and take a moment to plot these points.
Let's see I have the point, one, zero, that's
here to one that's here, for two, that is
here. And then eight, three, which is
the base stays the same in both expressions.
So for this example, the base of three in
the exponential equation, that's going to
be the same as the base in our log. Now I
just have to figure out what's in the argument
of the log. And what goes on the other side
of the equal sign. Remember that the answer
to a log is an exponent. So the thing that
goes in this box should be my exponent for
my exponential equation. In other words, you
and I'll put the 9.78 as the argument of my
log. This works because log base three of
9.78 equals u means the same thing as three
to the U equals 9.78, which is just what we
started with. In the second example, the base
of my exponential equation is E. So the base
of my log is going to be the answer to my
log is an exponent. In this case, the exponent
3x plus seven. And the other expression, the
four minus y becomes my argument of my log.
Let me check, log base e of four minus y equals
3x plus seven means e to 3x plus seven equals
four minus Y, which is just what I started
with. I can also rewrite log base e as natural
log. This video introduced the idea of logs.
And the fact that log base a of B equal c
means the same thing as a to the C equals
b. So log base a of B is asking you the question,
What power exponent Do you raise a to in order
to get b. In this video, we'll work out the
graph, so some log functions and also talk
about their domains. For this first example,
let's graph a log function by hand by plotting
some points. The function we're working with
is y equals log base two of x, I'll make a
chart of x and y values. Since we're working
this out by hand, I want to pick x values
for which it's easy to compute log base two
of x. So I'll start out with the x value of
one. Because log base two of one is zero,
log base anything of one is 02 is another
x value that's easy to compute log base two
of two, that's asking, What power do I raise
to two to get to one? And the answer is one.
Power other powers of two are easy to work
with. So for example, log base two of four
that saying what power do I raise to to to
get four, so the answer is two. Similarly,
log base two of eight is three, and log base
two of 16 is four. Let me also work with some
fractional values for X. If x is one half,
then log base two of one half that saying
what power do I raise to two to get one half?
Well, that needs a power of negative one.
It's also easy to compute by hand, the log
base two of 1/4 and 1/8. log base two of 1/4
is negative two, since two to the negative
two is 1/4. And similarly, log base two of
1/8 is negative three. I'll put some tick
marks on my x and y axes. Please pause the
video and take a moment to plot these points.
Let's see I have the point, one, zero, that's
here to one that's here, for two, that is
here. And then eight, three, which is
here.
And the fractional x values, one half goes
with negative one, and 1/4 with negative two
1/8 with negative three.
And the fractional x values, one half goes
with negative one, and 1/4 with negative two
1/8 with negative three.
And if I connect the dots, I get a graph that
looks something like this. If I had smaller
and smaller fractions, I would keep getting
more and more negative answers when I took
log base two of them, so my graph is getting
more and more negative, my y values are getting
more and more negative as x is getting close
to zero. Now I didn't draw any parts of the
graph over here with negative X values, I
didn't put any negative X values on my chart.
That omission is no accident. Because if you
try to take the log base two or base anything
of a negative number, like say negative four
or something, there's no answer. This doesn't
exist because there's no power that you can
raise to two to get a negative number. So
there are no points on the graph for negative
X values. And similarly, there are no points
on the graph where x is zero, because you
can't take log base two of zero, there's no
power you can raise to to to get zero. I want
to observe some key features of this graph.
First of all, the domain is x values greater
than zero. In interval notation, I can write
that as a round bracket because I don't want
to include zero to infinity, the range is
going to be the y values, while they go all
the way down into the far reaches of the negative
numbers. And the graph gradually increases
y value is getting bigger and bigger. So the
range is actually all real numbers are an
interval notation negative infinity to infinity.
Finally, I want to point out that this graph
has a vertical asymptote at the y axis, that
is at the line x equals zero. I'll draw that
on my graph with a dotted line. A vertical
asymptote is a line that our functions graph
gets closer and closer to so this is The graph
of y equals log base two of x. But if I wanted
to graph say, y equals log base 10 of x, it
would look very similar, it would still have
a domain of X values greater than zero, a
range of all real numbers and a vertical asymptote
at the y axis, it would still go through the
point one zero, but it would go through the
point 10. One instead, because log base 10
of 10 is one, it would look pretty much the
same, just a lot flatter over here. But even
though it doesn't look like it with the way
I've drawn it, it still gradually goes up
to n towards infinity. In fact, the graph
of y equals log base neaa of X for a bigger
than one looks pretty much the same, and has
the same three properties. Now that we know
what the basic log graph looks like, we can
plot at least rough graphs of other log functions
without plotting points. Here we have the
graph of natural log of X plus five. And again,
I'm just going to draw a rough graph. If I
did want to do a more accurate graph, I probably
would want to plot some points. But I know
that roughly a log graph, if it was just like
y equals ln of x, that would look something
like this, and it would go through the point
one zero,
And if I connect the dots, I get a graph that
looks something like this. If I had smaller
and smaller fractions, I would keep getting
more and more negative answers when I took
log base two of them, so my graph is getting
more and more negative, my y values are getting
more and more negative as x is getting close
to zero. Now I didn't draw any parts of the
graph over here with negative X values, I
didn't put any negative X values on my chart.
That omission is no accident. Because if you
try to take the log base two or base anything
of a negative number, like say negative four
or something, there's no answer. This doesn't
exist because there's no power that you can
raise to two to get a negative number. So
there are no points on the graph for negative
X values. And similarly, there are no points
on the graph where x is zero, because you
can't take log base two of zero, there's no
power you can raise to to to get zero. I want
to observe some key features of this graph.
First of all, the domain is x values greater
than zero. In interval notation, I can write
that as a round bracket because I don't want
to include zero to infinity, the range is
going to be the y values, while they go all
the way down into the far reaches of the negative
numbers. And the graph gradually increases
y value is getting bigger and bigger. So the
range is actually all real numbers are an
interval notation negative infinity to infinity.
Finally, I want to point out that this graph
has a vertical asymptote at the y axis, that
is at the line x equals zero. I'll draw that
on my graph with a dotted line. A vertical
asymptote is a line that our functions graph
gets closer and closer to so this is The graph
of y equals log base two of x. But if I wanted
to graph say, y equals log base 10 of x, it
would look very similar, it would still have
a domain of X values greater than zero, a
range of all real numbers and a vertical asymptote
at the y axis, it would still go through the
point one zero, but it would go through the
point 10. One instead, because log base 10
of 10 is one, it would look pretty much the
same, just a lot flatter over here. But even
though it doesn't look like it with the way
I've drawn it, it still gradually goes up
to n towards infinity. In fact, the graph
of y equals log base neaa of X for a bigger
than one looks pretty much the same, and has
the same three properties. Now that we know
what the basic log graph looks like, we can
plot at least rough graphs of other log functions
without plotting points. Here we have the
graph of natural log of X plus five. And again,
I'm just going to draw a rough graph. If I
did want to do a more accurate graph, I probably
would want to plot some points. But I know
that roughly a log graph, if it was just like
y equals ln of x, that would look something
like this, and it would go through the point
one zero,
with a vertical asymptote along the y axis.
Now if I want to graph ln of x plus five,
that just shifts our graph by five units,
it'll still have the same vertical asymptote,
since the vertical line shifted up by five
units is still a vertical line. But instead
of going through one zero, it'll go through
the point, one, five. So I'll draw a rough
sketch here. Let's compare our starting function
y equals ln x, and the transformed version
y equals ln x plus five in terms of the domain,
the range and the vertical asymptote. Our
original function y equals ln x had a domain
of zero to infinity. Since adding five on
the outside affects the y values, and the
domain is the x values, this transformation
doesn't change the domain. So the domain is
still from zero to infinity. Now the range
of our original y equals ln x was from negative
infinity to infinity. Shifting up by five
does affect the y values, and the range is
talking about the y values. But since the
original range was all real numbers, if you
add five to all set of all real numbers, you
still get the set of all real numbers. So
in this case, the range doesn't change either.
And finally, we already saw that the original
vertical asymptote of the y axis x equals
zero, when we shift that up by five units,
it's still the vertical line x equals zero.
In this next example, we're starting with
a log base 10 function. And since the plus
two is on the inside, that means we shift
that graph left by two. So I'll draw our basic
log function. Here's our basic log function.
So I'll think of that as y equals log of x
going through the point one, zero, here's
its vertical asymptote. Now I need to shift
everything left by two. So my vertical asymptote
shifts left, and now it's at the line x equals
negative two, instead of at x equals zero,
and my graph, let's see my point, one zero
gets shifted to, let's see negative one zero,
since I'm subtracting two from the axis, and
here's a rough sketch of the resulting graph.
Let's compare the features of the two graphs
drawn here. We're talking about domains, the
original kind of domain of from zero to infinity.
But now I've shifted that left. So I subtracted
two from all my exercises. And here's my new
domain, which I can also verify just by looking
at the picture. My range was originally from
negative infinity to infinity. Well, shifting
left only affects the x value, so it doesn't
even affect the range. So my range is still
negative infinity to infinity. My vertical
asymptote was originally at x equals zero.
And since I subtract two from all my x values,
that shifts that to x equals negative two.
In this last problem, I'm not going to worry
about drawing this graph. I'll just use algebra
to compute its domain. So let's think about
What's the issue, when you're taking the logs
of things? Well, you can't take the log of
a negative number or zero. So whatever is
inside the argument of the log function, whatever
is being fed into log had better be greater
than zero. So I'll write that down, we need
to minus 3x, to be greater than zero. Now
it's a matter of solving an inequality. Two
has got to be greater than 3x. So two thirds
is greater than x. In other words, x has to
be less than two thirds. So our domain is
all the x values from negative infinity to
two thirds, not including two thirds, it's
a good idea to memorize the basic shape of
the graph of a log function. It looks something
like this, go through the point one zero,
and has a vertical asymptote on the y axis.
Also, if you remember that you can't take
the log of a negative number, or zero, then
that helps you quickly compute domains for
log functions. Whatever's inside the log function,
you set that greater than zero, and solve.
This video is about combining logs and exponents.
Please pause the video and take a moment to
use your calculator to evaluate the following
four expressions.
with a vertical asymptote along the y axis.
Now if I want to graph ln of x plus five,
that just shifts our graph by five units,
it'll still have the same vertical asymptote,
since the vertical line shifted up by five
units is still a vertical line. But instead
of going through one zero, it'll go through
the point, one, five. So I'll draw a rough
sketch here. Let's compare our starting function
y equals ln x, and the transformed version
y equals ln x plus five in terms of the domain,
the range and the vertical asymptote. Our
original function y equals ln x had a domain
of zero to infinity. Since adding five on
the outside affects the y values, and the
domain is the x values, this transformation
doesn't change the domain. So the domain is
still from zero to infinity. Now the range
of our original y equals ln x was from negative
infinity to infinity. Shifting up by five
does affect the y values, and the range is
talking about the y values. But since the
original range was all real numbers, if you
add five to all set of all real numbers, you
still get the set of all real numbers. So
in this case, the range doesn't change either.
And finally, we already saw that the original
vertical asymptote of the y axis x equals
zero, when we shift that up by five units,
it's still the vertical line x equals zero.
In this next example, we're starting with
a log base 10 function. And since the plus
two is on the inside, that means we shift
that graph left by two. So I'll draw our basic
log function. Here's our basic log function.
So I'll think of that as y equals log of x
going through the point one, zero, here's
its vertical asymptote. Now I need to shift
everything left by two. So my vertical asymptote
shifts left, and now it's at the line x equals
negative two, instead of at x equals zero,
and my graph, let's see my point, one zero
gets shifted to, let's see negative one zero,
since I'm subtracting two from the axis, and
here's a rough sketch of the resulting graph.
Let's compare the features of the two graphs
drawn here. We're talking about domains, the
original kind of domain of from zero to infinity.
But now I've shifted that left. So I subtracted
two from all my exercises. And here's my new
domain, which I can also verify just by looking
at the picture. My range was originally from
negative infinity to infinity. Well, shifting
left only affects the x value, so it doesn't
even affect the range. So my range is still
negative infinity to infinity. My vertical
asymptote was originally at x equals zero.
And since I subtract two from all my x values,
that shifts that to x equals negative two.
In this last problem, I'm not going to worry
about drawing this graph. I'll just use algebra
to compute its domain. So let's think about
What's the issue, when you're taking the logs
of things? Well, you can't take the log of
a negative number or zero. So whatever is
inside the argument of the log function, whatever
is being fed into log had better be greater
than zero. So I'll write that down, we need
to minus 3x, to be greater than zero. Now
it's a matter of solving an inequality. Two
has got to be greater than 3x. So two thirds
is greater than x. In other words, x has to
be less than two thirds. So our domain is
all the x values from negative infinity to
two thirds, not including two thirds, it's
a good idea to memorize the basic shape of
the graph of a log function. It looks something
like this, go through the point one zero,
and has a vertical asymptote on the y axis.
Also, if you remember that you can't take
the log of a negative number, or zero, then
that helps you quickly compute domains for
log functions. Whatever's inside the log function,
you set that greater than zero, and solve.
This video is about combining logs and exponents.
Please pause the video and take a moment to
use your calculator to evaluate the following
four expressions.
Remember, that log base 10 on your calculator
is the log button. While log base e on your
calculator is the natural log button, you
should find that the log base 10 of 10 cubed
is three, the log base e of e to the 4.2 is
4.2 10 to the log base 10 of 1000 is 1000.
And eat the log base e of 9.6 is 9.6. In each
case, the log and the exponential function
with the same base undo each other, and we're
left with the exponent. In fact, it's true
that for any base a the log base a of a to
the x is equal to x. The same sort of cancellation
happens if we do the exponential function
in the log function with the same base in
the opposite order. For example, we take 10
to the power of log base 10 of 1000, the 10
to the power and the log base 10 undo each
other, and we're left with the 1000s. This
happens for any base a a to the log base a
of x is equal to x. We can describe this by
saying that an exponential function and a
log function with the same base undo each
other. If you're familiar with the language
of inverse functions, the exponential function
and log function are inverses. Let's see why
these roles hold for the first log role. log
base a of a dx is asking the question, What
power do we raise a two in order to get a
to the x? In other words, a to what power
is a to the x? Well, the answer is clearly
x. And that's why log base a of a to the x
equals x. For the second log rule, notice
that the log base a of x means the power we
raise a two to get x. But this expression
is saying that we're supposed to raise a to
that power. If we raise a to the power, we
need to raise a two to get x, then we'll certainly
get x. Now let's use these two roles. In some
examples. If we want to find three to the
log base three of 1.43 to the power and log
base three undo each other, so we're left
with 1.4.
Remember, that log base 10 on your calculator
is the log button. While log base e on your
calculator is the natural log button, you
should find that the log base 10 of 10 cubed
is three, the log base e of e to the 4.2 is
4.2 10 to the log base 10 of 1000 is 1000.
And eat the log base e of 9.6 is 9.6. In each
case, the log and the exponential function
with the same base undo each other, and we're
left with the exponent. In fact, it's true
that for any base a the log base a of a to
the x is equal to x. The same sort of cancellation
happens if we do the exponential function
in the log function with the same base in
the opposite order. For example, we take 10
to the power of log base 10 of 1000, the 10
to the power and the log base 10 undo each
other, and we're left with the 1000s. This
happens for any base a a to the log base a
of x is equal to x. We can describe this by
saying that an exponential function and a
log function with the same base undo each
other. If you're familiar with the language
of inverse functions, the exponential function
and log function are inverses. Let's see why
these roles hold for the first log role. log
base a of a dx is asking the question, What
power do we raise a two in order to get a
to the x? In other words, a to what power
is a to the x? Well, the answer is clearly
x. And that's why log base a of a to the x
equals x. For the second log rule, notice
that the log base a of x means the power we
raise a two to get x. But this expression
is saying that we're supposed to raise a to
that power. If we raise a to the power, we
need to raise a two to get x, then we'll certainly
get x. Now let's use these two roles. In some
examples. If we want to find three to the
log base three of 1.43 to the power and log
base three undo each other, so we're left
with 1.4.
If we want to find ln of e to the x, remember
that ln means log base e, so we're taking
log base e of e to the x.
If we want to find ln of e to the x, remember
that ln means log base e, so we're taking
log base e of e to the x.
Well, those functions undo each other and
we're left with x. If we want to take 10 to
the log of three z, remember that log without
a base written implies that the base is 10.
So really, we want to take 10 to the log base
10 of three z will tend to a power and log
base 10 undo each other. So we're left with
a three z. Finally, does this last statement
hold is ln of 10 to the x equal to x? Well,
ln means log base e. So we're taking log base
e of 10 to the x, notice that the base of
the log and the base of the exponential function
are not the same thing. So they don't undo
each other. And in fact, log base e of 10
to the x is not usually equal to x, we can
check with one example, say if x equals one,
then log base e of 10 to the one, that's log
base e of 10. And we can check on the calculator
that's equal to 2.3. In some more decimals,
which is not the same thing as one. So this
statement is false, it does not hold. We need
the basis to be the same for logs and exponent
to undo each other. In this video, we saw
that logs and exponents with the same base
undo each other. Specifically, log base a
of a to the x is equal to x and a to the log
base a of x is also equal to x
Well, those functions undo each other and
we're left with x. If we want to take 10 to
the log of three z, remember that log without
a base written implies that the base is 10.
So really, we want to take 10 to the log base
10 of three z will tend to a power and log
base 10 undo each other. So we're left with
a three z. Finally, does this last statement
hold is ln of 10 to the x equal to x? Well,
ln means log base e. So we're taking log base
e of 10 to the x, notice that the base of
the log and the base of the exponential function
are not the same thing. So they don't undo
each other. And in fact, log base e of 10
to the x is not usually equal to x, we can
check with one example, say if x equals one,
then log base e of 10 to the one, that's log
base e of 10. And we can check on the calculator
that's equal to 2.3. In some more decimals,
which is not the same thing as one. So this
statement is false, it does not hold. We need
the basis to be the same for logs and exponent
to undo each other. In this video, we saw
that logs and exponents with the same base
undo each other. Specifically, log base a
of a to the x is equal to x and a to the log
base a of x is also equal to x
for any values of x and any base a. This video
is about rules or properties of logs. The
log rules are closely related to the exponent
rules. So let's start by reviewing some of
the exponent rules.
for any values of x and any base a. This video
is about rules or properties of logs. The
log rules are closely related to the exponent
rules. So let's start by reviewing some of
the exponent rules.
To keep things simple, we'll write everything
down with a base of two. Even though the exponent
rules hold for any base, we know that if we
raise two to the zero power, we get one, we
have a product rule for exponents, which says
that two to the M times two to the n is equal
to two to the m plus n. In other words, if
we multiply two numbers, then we add the exponents.
We also have a quotient rule that says that
two to the M divided by n to the n is equal
to two to the m minus n. In words, that says
that if we divide two numbers, then we subtract
the exponents. Finally, we have a power rule
that says if we take a power to a power, then
we multiply the exponents. Each of these exponent
rules can be rewritten as a log rule. The
first rule, two to the zero equals one can
be rewritten in terms of logs as log base
two of one equals zero. That's because log
base two of one equals zero means two to the
zero equals one. The second rule, the product
rule, can be rewritten in terms of logs by
saying log of x times y equals log of x plus
log of y. I'll make these base two to agree
with my base that I'm using for my exponent
rules. In words, that says the log of the
product is the sum of the logs. Since logs
really represent exponents. This is saying
that when you multiply two numbers together,
you add their exponents, which is just what
we said for the exponent version. The quotient
rule for exponents can be rewritten in terms
of logs by saying the log of x divided by
y is equal to the log of x minus the log of
y. In words, we can say that the log of the
quotient is equal to the difference of the
logs. Since logs are really exponents, another
way of saying the same thing is that when
you divide two numbers, you subtract their
exponents. That's how we described the exponent
rule above. Finally, the power rule for exponents
can be rewritten in terms of logs by saying
the log of x to the n is equal to n times
log of x. Sometimes people describe this rule
by saying when you take the log of an expression
with an exponent, you can bring down the exponent
and multiply. If we think of x as being some
power of two, this is really saying when we
take a power to a power, we multiply their
exponents. That's exactly how we described
the power rule above. It doesn't really matter
if you multiply this exponent on the left
side, or on the right side, but it's more
traditional to multiply it on the left side.
I've given these rules with the base of two,
but they actually work for any base. To help
you remember them, please take a moment to
write out the log rules using a base of a
you should get the following chart. Let's
use the log rules to rewrite the following
expressions as a sum or difference of logs.
In the first expression, we have a log base
10 of a quotient. So we can rewrite the log
of the quotient
To keep things simple, we'll write everything
down with a base of two. Even though the exponent
rules hold for any base, we know that if we
raise two to the zero power, we get one, we
have a product rule for exponents, which says
that two to the M times two to the n is equal
to two to the m plus n. In other words, if
we multiply two numbers, then we add the exponents.
We also have a quotient rule that says that
two to the M divided by n to the n is equal
to two to the m minus n. In words, that says
that if we divide two numbers, then we subtract
the exponents. Finally, we have a power rule
that says if we take a power to a power, then
we multiply the exponents. Each of these exponent
rules can be rewritten as a log rule. The
first rule, two to the zero equals one can
be rewritten in terms of logs as log base
two of one equals zero. That's because log
base two of one equals zero means two to the
zero equals one. The second rule, the product
rule, can be rewritten in terms of logs by
saying log of x times y equals log of x plus
log of y. I'll make these base two to agree
with my base that I'm using for my exponent
rules. In words, that says the log of the
product is the sum of the logs. Since logs
really represent exponents. This is saying
that when you multiply two numbers together,
you add their exponents, which is just what
we said for the exponent version. The quotient
rule for exponents can be rewritten in terms
of logs by saying the log of x divided by
y is equal to the log of x minus the log of
y. In words, we can say that the log of the
quotient is equal to the difference of the
logs. Since logs are really exponents, another
way of saying the same thing is that when
you divide two numbers, you subtract their
exponents. That's how we described the exponent
rule above. Finally, the power rule for exponents
can be rewritten in terms of logs by saying
the log of x to the n is equal to n times
log of x. Sometimes people describe this rule
by saying when you take the log of an expression
with an exponent, you can bring down the exponent
and multiply. If we think of x as being some
power of two, this is really saying when we
take a power to a power, we multiply their
exponents. That's exactly how we described
the power rule above. It doesn't really matter
if you multiply this exponent on the left
side, or on the right side, but it's more
traditional to multiply it on the left side.
I've given these rules with the base of two,
but they actually work for any base. To help
you remember them, please take a moment to
write out the log rules using a base of a
you should get the following chart. Let's
use the log rules to rewrite the following
expressions as a sum or difference of logs.
In the first expression, we have a log base
10 of a quotient. So we can rewrite the log
of the quotient
as the difference of the logs. Now we still
have the log of a product, I can rewrite the
log of a product as the sum of the logs
as the difference of the logs. Now we still
have the log of a product, I can rewrite the
log of a product as the sum of the logs
So that is log of y plus log of z. When I
put things together, I have to be careful,
because here I'm subtracting the entire log
expression. So I need to subtract both terms
of this son.
So that is log of y plus log of z. When I
put things together, I have to be careful,
because here I'm subtracting the entire log
expression. So I need to subtract both terms
of this son.
I'll make sure I do that by putting them in
parentheses. Now I can simplify a little bit
by distributing the negative sign. And here's
my final answer. In my next expression, I
have the log of a product. So I can rewrite
that as the sum of two logs. I can also use
my power rule to bring down the exponent T,
and multiply it in the front. That gives me
the final expression log of five plus
I'll make sure I do that by putting them in
parentheses. Now I can simplify a little bit
by distributing the negative sign. And here's
my final answer. In my next expression, I
have the log of a product. So I can rewrite
that as the sum of two logs. I can also use
my power rule to bring down the exponent T,
and multiply it in the front. That gives me
the final expression log of five plus
t times log of two. One common mistake on
this problem is to rewrite this expression
as t times log of five times two. In fact,
those two expressions are not equal. Because
the T only applies to the two, not to the
whole five times two, we can't just bring
it down in front using the power rule. After
all, the power rule only applies to a single
expression raised to an exponent, and not
to a product like this. And these next examples,
we're going to go the other direction. Here,
we're given sums and differences of logs.
And we want to wrap them up into a single
log expression. By look at the first two pieces,
that's a difference of logs. So I know I can
rewrite it as the log of a quotient. Now I
have the sum of two logs. So I can rewrite
that as the log of a product. I'll clean that
up a little bit and rewrite it as log base
five of a times c over B. In my second example,
I can rewrite the sum of my logs as the log
of a product. Now, I would like to rewrite
this difference of logs as the log of a quotient,
but I can't do it yet, because of that factor
of two multiplied in front. But I can use
the power rule backwards to put that two back
up in the exponent. So I'll do that first.
So I will copy down the ln of x plus one times
x minus one, and rewrite this second term
as ln of x squared minus one squared. Now
I have a straightforward difference of two
logs, which I can rewrite as the log of a
quotient. I can actually simplify this some
more. Since x plus one times x minus one is
the same thing as x squared minus one. I can
cancel factors to get ln of one over x squared
minus one. In this video, we solve for rules
for logs that are related to exponent rules.
First, we saw that the log with any base of
one is equal to zero. Second, we saw the product
rule, the log of a product is equal to the
sum of the logs. We saw the quotient rule,
the log of a quotient is the difference of
the logs. And we saw the power rule. When
you take a log of an expression with an exponent
in it, you can bring down the exponent and
multiply it. It's worth noticing that there's
no log rule that helps you split up the log
of a song. In particular, the log of a psalm
is not equal to the sum of the logs. If you
think about logs and exponent rules going
together, this kind of makes sense, because
there's also no rule for rewriting the sum
of two exponential expressions. Log roles
will be super handy. As we start to solve
equations using locks. The chain rule is a
really useful method for finding the derivative
of the composition of two functions. Let's
start with a brief review of composition.
f composed with g means that we apply f to
the output of G as a diagram, this means we
start with x and apply g first.
t times log of two. One common mistake on
this problem is to rewrite this expression
as t times log of five times two. In fact,
those two expressions are not equal. Because
the T only applies to the two, not to the
whole five times two, we can't just bring
it down in front using the power rule. After
all, the power rule only applies to a single
expression raised to an exponent, and not
to a product like this. And these next examples,
we're going to go the other direction. Here,
we're given sums and differences of logs.
And we want to wrap them up into a single
log expression. By look at the first two pieces,
that's a difference of logs. So I know I can
rewrite it as the log of a quotient. Now I
have the sum of two logs. So I can rewrite
that as the log of a product. I'll clean that
up a little bit and rewrite it as log base
five of a times c over B. In my second example,
I can rewrite the sum of my logs as the log
of a product. Now, I would like to rewrite
this difference of logs as the log of a quotient,
but I can't do it yet, because of that factor
of two multiplied in front. But I can use
the power rule backwards to put that two back
up in the exponent. So I'll do that first.
So I will copy down the ln of x plus one times
x minus one, and rewrite this second term
as ln of x squared minus one squared. Now
I have a straightforward difference of two
logs, which I can rewrite as the log of a
quotient. I can actually simplify this some
more. Since x plus one times x minus one is
the same thing as x squared minus one. I can
cancel factors to get ln of one over x squared
minus one. In this video, we solve for rules
for logs that are related to exponent rules.
First, we saw that the log with any base of
one is equal to zero. Second, we saw the product
rule, the log of a product is equal to the
sum of the logs. We saw the quotient rule,
the log of a quotient is the difference of
the logs. And we saw the power rule. When
you take a log of an expression with an exponent
in it, you can bring down the exponent and
multiply it. It's worth noticing that there's
no log rule that helps you split up the log
of a song. In particular, the log of a psalm
is not equal to the sum of the logs. If you
think about logs and exponent rules going
together, this kind of makes sense, because
there's also no rule for rewriting the sum
of two exponential expressions. Log roles
will be super handy. As we start to solve
equations using locks. The chain rule is a
really useful method for finding the derivative
of the composition of two functions. Let's
start with a brief review of composition.
f composed with g means that we apply f to
the output of G as a diagram, this means we
start with x and apply g first.
Then we apply f to the output to get our final
results I'm going to call G, the inner function,
and F the outer function. Because g looks
like it's on the inside of f,
Then we apply f to the output to get our final
results I'm going to call G, the inner function,
and F the outer function. Because g looks
like it's on the inside of f,
in this standard notation, we can write h
of x, which is the square root of sine of
x as the composition of two functions, by
letting sine of x be the inner function, and
the square root function be the outer function,
which I write as f of u equals the square
root of u. I like to do this sort of dissection
of functions, by drawing a box around part
of the function, whatever is inside the box
becomes my inner function, whatever we do
to the box becomes our outer function, in
this case, taking the square root. This allows
us to write h of x as the composition, f of
g of x, where f and g are the outer and inner
functions defined here. Please take a moment
to write the next two functions as compositions
of functions, before you go on. A natural
way to write k of x as a composition is to
let our inner function be tan of x plus seacon
of x. The outer function describes what happens
to that box the inner function, it gets cubed
and multiplied by five. There's several ways
to write the next example as a composition
of functions. For example, we could take x
squared as our inner function, and then our
outer function takes a to the sign of that
inner function. Alternatively, we could take
the inner function to be sine of x squared.
And then the outer function
in this standard notation, we can write h
of x, which is the square root of sine of
x as the composition of two functions, by
letting sine of x be the inner function, and
the square root function be the outer function,
which I write as f of u equals the square
root of u. I like to do this sort of dissection
of functions, by drawing a box around part
of the function, whatever is inside the box
becomes my inner function, whatever we do
to the box becomes our outer function, in
this case, taking the square root. This allows
us to write h of x as the composition, f of
g of x, where f and g are the outer and inner
functions defined here. Please take a moment
to write the next two functions as compositions
of functions, before you go on. A natural
way to write k of x as a composition is to
let our inner function be tan of x plus seacon
of x. The outer function describes what happens
to that box the inner function, it gets cubed
and multiplied by five. There's several ways
to write the next example as a composition
of functions. For example, we could take x
squared as our inner function, and then our
outer function takes a to the sign of that
inner function. Alternatively, we could take
the inner function to be sine of x squared.
And then the outer function
has to be e to the power. It's also possible
to write our function r of x as a composition
of three functions. An inner function of x
squared, a middle function of sine and an
outermost function of e to the power, which
are right as h of V equals e to the V.
has to be e to the power. It's also possible
to write our function r of x as a composition
of three functions. An inner function of x
squared, a middle function of sine and an
outermost function of e to the power, which
are right as h of V equals e to the V.
When calculating the derivatives of complicated
functions, it's really important to recognize
them as compositions of simpler functions.
That way, we can build up the derivative in
terms of the simpler derivatives. And that's
the idea behind the chain rule. The chain
rule tells us if we have two differentiable
functions, then the derivative of the composition
f composed with g of x is equal to the derivative
of the outer function evaluated on the inner
function times the derivative of the inner
function. Sometimes the chain rule is written
instead, in lightness notation, that is the
dydx notation. To see how this works, let's
let u equal g of x. And let's let y equal
f of u. In other words, y is f of
When calculating the derivatives of complicated
functions, it's really important to recognize
them as compositions of simpler functions.
That way, we can build up the derivative in
terms of the simpler derivatives. And that's
the idea behind the chain rule. The chain
rule tells us if we have two differentiable
functions, then the derivative of the composition
f composed with g of x is equal to the derivative
of the outer function evaluated on the inner
function times the derivative of the inner
function. Sometimes the chain rule is written
instead, in lightness notation, that is the
dydx notation. To see how this works, let's
let u equal g of x. And let's let y equal
f of u. In other words, y is f of
g of x.
Now do u dx is just another way of writing
g prime of x, and d y d u is another way of
writing f prime of U. or in other words, f
prime of g of x. Finally, if we write D y
dX, that means we're taking the derivative
of f composed with g. So that's f composed
with g prime of x. Using this key, I can rewrite
the expression above as the y dx equals d
y d u
Now do u dx is just another way of writing
g prime of x, and d y d u is another way of
writing f prime of U. or in other words, f
prime of g of x. Finally, if we write D y
dX, that means we're taking the derivative
of f composed with g. So that's f composed
with g prime of x. Using this key, I can rewrite
the expression above as the y dx equals d
y d u
times d u dx. These are the two alternative
ways of writing the chain rule. Let's use
the chain rule to take the derivative of the
square root of sine x.
times d u dx. These are the two alternative
ways of writing the chain rule. Let's use
the chain rule to take the derivative of the
square root of sine x.
Actually, I'm going to rewrite this as h of
x equals sine x to the one half power to make
it easier to take derivatives. As a composition,
we're thinking of the inner function as sine
x and the outer function as the one half power.
So the chain rule tells us that to take h
prime
Actually, I'm going to rewrite this as h of
x equals sine x to the one half power to make
it easier to take derivatives. As a composition,
we're thinking of the inner function as sine
x and the outer function as the one half power.
So the chain rule tells us that to take h
prime
of x we need to take the derivative of the
outer function evaluated on the inner function
and then multiply that by the derivative of
the inner function, we know that the derivative
of the inner function, sine x is just cosine
x. And the derivative of the outer function
is one half times u to the negative one half.
So h prime of x is then one half times u to
the negative one half. But that's evaluated
on the inner function, sine of
of x we need to take the derivative of the
outer function evaluated on the inner function
and then multiply that by the derivative of
the inner function, we know that the derivative
of the inner function, sine x is just cosine
x. And the derivative of the outer function
is one half times u to the negative one half.
So h prime of x is then one half times u to
the negative one half. But that's evaluated
on the inner function, sine of
x.
And then we multiply that by cosine of x.
Again, that's the derivative of the outer
function evaluated on the inner function times
the derivative of the inner function. And
we found the derivative using the chain rule.
For the next example, our inner function was
tan x plus seacon X and our outer function,
f of u was five u cubed. So k prime of x is
15 times u squared. But that's the evaluated
on the inner function 10x plus seacon x, then
we still need to multiply that by the derivative
of the inner function 10x plus seacon x. So
we get the 15 tan x plus secant x squared
times the derivative of tan x, which is secant
squared x, plus the derivative of secant x,
which is secant x, tan x. And that's our chain
rule derivative. In this last example, we're
thinking of the outermost function as being
e to the power and its inner function is sine
of x squared. But sine of x squared itself
has an outer function of sine and an inner
function of x squared. So to find r prime
of x, we first have to take the derivative
of the outermost function, well, the derivative
of e to the power is just e to the power.
And then we multiply that by cosine of x.
Again, that's the derivative of the outer
function evaluated on the inner function times
the derivative of the inner function. And
we found the derivative using the chain rule.
For the next example, our inner function was
tan x plus seacon X and our outer function,
f of u was five u cubed. So k prime of x is
15 times u squared. But that's the evaluated
on the inner function 10x plus seacon x, then
we still need to multiply that by the derivative
of the inner function 10x plus seacon x. So
we get the 15 tan x plus secant x squared
times the derivative of tan x, which is secant
squared x, plus the derivative of secant x,
which is secant x, tan x. And that's our chain
rule derivative. In this last example, we're
thinking of the outermost function as being
e to the power and its inner function is sine
of x squared. But sine of x squared itself
has an outer function of sine and an inner
function of x squared. So to find r prime
of x, we first have to take the derivative
of the outermost function, well, the derivative
of e to the power is just e to the power.
And now we evaluate that on its inner function,
sine of x squared. But now by the chain rule,
we have to multiply that by the derivative
of the inner function, sine of x squared.
I'll copy down the E to the sine x squared.
And I'll use the chain rule a second time
to find the derivative of sine x squared.
Now the outer function is sine, and the derivative
of sine is cosine. I need to evaluate it on
its inner function of x squared, and then
multiply that by the derivative of the inner
function. After copying things down, I just
have to take the derivative of x squared,
which is 2x
And now we evaluate that on its inner function,
sine of x squared. But now by the chain rule,
we have to multiply that by the derivative
of the inner function, sine of x squared.
I'll copy down the E to the sine x squared.
And I'll use the chain rule a second time
to find the derivative of sine x squared.
Now the outer function is sine, and the derivative
of sine is cosine. I need to evaluate it on
its inner function of x squared, and then
multiply that by the derivative of the inner
function. After copying things down, I just
have to take the derivative of x squared,
which is 2x
by the power.
This video introduced the chain rule, which
says that the derivative of f composed with
g at x is equal to f prime at g of x times
g prime at x, or equivalently, d y dx is equal
to d y d u times d u dx. This video gives
some more examples and a justification of
the chain rule, and also includes a handy
formula for the derivative of a to the x with
respect to x, where A is any positive number.
In the next example, I want to show using
the chain rule that the derivative of five
to the x is equal to ln five times five to
the x. First, I want to rewrite five to the
x as easily ln five times x. And I can do
that because e to the ln five is equal to
five. So e to the ln five to the x power is
equal to five to the x. But e to the ln five
to the x power using exponent rules is just
e to the ln five times x. So if I want to
take the derivative of five to the x, after
rewriting it as e to the ln five times x,
let me think of the inner function as being
ln five times x. And I'm going to think of
the outer function as being E to that power.
That's what I wanted to Make the derivative
of. So by the chain rule, I can first take
the derivative of the outer function, derivative
of e to the power is just e to the power,
and I evaluate it at its inner function. But
then by the chain rule, I need to take the
derivative of the inner function, well, the
derivative of ln five times x is just the
constant coefficient ln five. And that's my
derivative. Now, I know that e to the ln five
times x is just five to the x. That's what
we talked about before. So my final answer
is five to the x times ln five, or I guess
I can rewrite that in the other order. That
is that there's nothing special about five
in this example, I could have done this same
process with any a base positive base a. So
I'm going to write that as a general principle
that the derivative of a to the x with respect
to x is equal to ln a times a to the x. This
is a fact worth memorizing. I'll use this
fact to compute the derivative of this complicated
expression, sine of 5x times the square root
of two to the cosine 5x plus one. To find
dydx, I'll first use the product rule, since
our expression is the product of two other
expressions. So D y dX is the first expression
times the derivative of the second expression,
which I'll go ahead and write using an exponent
instead of a square root sign, plus the derivative
of the first expression times the second expression.
Now I'll need to use the chain rule to evaluate
the derivative here. My outermost function
is the function that raises everything to
the one half power. So when I take the derivative,
I can use the power rule, bring down the one
half, right to the cosine 5x plus one to the
negative one half. But then by the chain rule,
I'm going to have to multiply by the derivative
of the inner function, which is to to the
cosine 5x plus one, I'll just carry along
the rest of my expression for now, what I
want to take the derivative of two to the
cosine 5x plus one, I'm going to have to use
the chain rule again, thinking of my outer
function as being two to the power plus one.
So let me copy things down on the next line.
Now taking the derivative, the derivative
of one is just zero, so I'm really just taking
the derivative of two to the cosine 5x. And
by my formula, this is going to be ln f two
times two
This video introduced the chain rule, which
says that the derivative of f composed with
g at x is equal to f prime at g of x times
g prime at x, or equivalently, d y dx is equal
to d y d u times d u dx. This video gives
some more examples and a justification of
the chain rule, and also includes a handy
formula for the derivative of a to the x with
respect to x, where A is any positive number.
In the next example, I want to show using
the chain rule that the derivative of five
to the x is equal to ln five times five to
the x. First, I want to rewrite five to the
x as easily ln five times x. And I can do
that because e to the ln five is equal to
five. So e to the ln five to the x power is
equal to five to the x. But e to the ln five
to the x power using exponent rules is just
e to the ln five times x. So if I want to
take the derivative of five to the x, after
rewriting it as e to the ln five times x,
let me think of the inner function as being
ln five times x. And I'm going to think of
the outer function as being E to that power.
That's what I wanted to Make the derivative
of. So by the chain rule, I can first take
the derivative of the outer function, derivative
of e to the power is just e to the power,
and I evaluate it at its inner function. But
then by the chain rule, I need to take the
derivative of the inner function, well, the
derivative of ln five times x is just the
constant coefficient ln five. And that's my
derivative. Now, I know that e to the ln five
times x is just five to the x. That's what
we talked about before. So my final answer
is five to the x times ln five, or I guess
I can rewrite that in the other order. That
is that there's nothing special about five
in this example, I could have done this same
process with any a base positive base a. So
I'm going to write that as a general principle
that the derivative of a to the x with respect
to x is equal to ln a times a to the x. This
is a fact worth memorizing. I'll use this
fact to compute the derivative of this complicated
expression, sine of 5x times the square root
of two to the cosine 5x plus one. To find
dydx, I'll first use the product rule, since
our expression is the product of two other
expressions. So D y dX is the first expression
times the derivative of the second expression,
which I'll go ahead and write using an exponent
instead of a square root sign, plus the derivative
of the first expression times the second expression.
Now I'll need to use the chain rule to evaluate
the derivative here. My outermost function
is the function that raises everything to
the one half power. So when I take the derivative,
I can use the power rule, bring down the one
half, right to the cosine 5x plus one to the
negative one half. But then by the chain rule,
I'm going to have to multiply by the derivative
of the inner function, which is to to the
cosine 5x plus one, I'll just carry along
the rest of my expression for now, what I
want to take the derivative of two to the
cosine 5x plus one, I'm going to have to use
the chain rule again, thinking of my outer
function as being two to the power plus one.
So let me copy things down on the next line.
Now taking the derivative, the derivative
of one is just zero, so I'm really just taking
the derivative of two to the cosine 5x. And
by my formula, this is going to be ln f two
times two
to the power of cosine 5x. But of course,
I have to use the chain rule
and multiply by that the derivative of the
inner function here, which is cosine 5x. Again,
I'm just going to carry the rest of the expression
along with me for the ride for now. Now we're
taking the derivative of cosine 5x, I think
of cosine as the outer function. And five
times x is the inner function. Similarly,
down here, sign is the outer function, and
5x is the inner function. So I can complete
my work by copying a lot of stuff down, and
now taking the derivative of cosine, which
is minus sine, evaluated at its inner function,
times the derivative of the inner function
5x, which is just five. And I'm going to add
to that the derivative of sine of 5x. Well,
the derivative of sine is cosine, evaluated
on its inner function times the derivative
of the inner function 5x, which is just five
times the rest of the stuff. I'll do a modest
amount of simplification, maybe bring the
constants out and combine any terms that I
can. And that's the end of that complicated
example. And the next example, we'll try to
find the derivative of a composition at the
value x equals one just based on a table of
values. So the chain rule says that the derivative
of f composed with g is just going to be f
prime evaluated g of x times g prime evaluated
x, but I want to do this whole process at
x equals one. So that's just going to be f
prime at g of one times g prime of one. Well,
g of one is two. So I really want f prime
at two, and f prime at two is 10. And g prime
at one is negative five. So my answer is negative
50. I'm not going to give a rigorous proof
of the chain rule. But I would like to give
a more informal explanation based on the limit
definition of derivative. So I'm going to
write the derivative of f composed with g
evaluated a point A, as the limit as x goes
to a of f composed with g of x minus f composed
with g of A divided by x minus a. I'll rewrite
this slightly. And now we're going to multiply
the top and the bottom by g of x minus g of
a, that doesn't change the value of expression,
provided that g of x minus g of A is not zero.
That's the detail on sweeping under the rug
here and why this is not a real proof, but
just a more informal explanation. Now if I
rearrange things, and rewrite the limit of
the product as the product of the limits,
my limit on the right here is just the derivative
of g. for the limit on the left, notice that
as x goes to a, g of x has to go to g of a,
since G is differentiable on there for continuous
function. So I can rewrite this and letting
say u be equal to g of x, I can rewrite this
as the limit as u goes to g of a of f of u
minus f of g of A over u minus g of a. Now
my expression on the left is just another
way of writing the derivative of f evaluated
at g of a. And I've arrived at the expression
for the chain rule. Let me just emphasize
again, this is just a pseudo proof, it's not
quite airtight, because g of x minus g of
a might be zero. In this video, we saw some
more examples of the chain rule justification
of it. And we saw that the derivative respect
to x
and multiply by that the derivative of the
inner function here, which is cosine 5x. Again,
I'm just going to carry the rest of the expression
along with me for the ride for now. Now we're
taking the derivative of cosine 5x, I think
of cosine as the outer function. And five
times x is the inner function. Similarly,
down here, sign is the outer function, and
5x is the inner function. So I can complete
my work by copying a lot of stuff down, and
now taking the derivative of cosine, which
is minus sine, evaluated at its inner function,
times the derivative of the inner function
5x, which is just five. And I'm going to add
to that the derivative of sine of 5x. Well,
the derivative of sine is cosine, evaluated
on its inner function times the derivative
of the inner function 5x, which is just five
times the rest of the stuff. I'll do a modest
amount of simplification, maybe bring the
constants out and combine any terms that I
can. And that's the end of that complicated
example. And the next example, we'll try to
find the derivative of a composition at the
value x equals one just based on a table of
values. So the chain rule says that the derivative
of f composed with g is just going to be f
prime evaluated g of x times g prime evaluated
x, but I want to do this whole process at
x equals one. So that's just going to be f
prime at g of one times g prime of one. Well,
g of one is two. So I really want f prime
at two, and f prime at two is 10. And g prime
at one is negative five. So my answer is negative
50. I'm not going to give a rigorous proof
of the chain rule. But I would like to give
a more informal explanation based on the limit
definition of derivative. So I'm going to
write the derivative of f composed with g
evaluated a point A, as the limit as x goes
to a of f composed with g of x minus f composed
with g of A divided by x minus a. I'll rewrite
this slightly. And now we're going to multiply
the top and the bottom by g of x minus g of
a, that doesn't change the value of expression,
provided that g of x minus g of A is not zero.
That's the detail on sweeping under the rug
here and why this is not a real proof, but
just a more informal explanation. Now if I
rearrange things, and rewrite the limit of
the product as the product of the limits,
my limit on the right here is just the derivative
of g. for the limit on the left, notice that
as x goes to a, g of x has to go to g of a,
since G is differentiable on there for continuous
function. So I can rewrite this and letting
say u be equal to g of x, I can rewrite this
as the limit as u goes to g of a of f of u
minus f of g of A over u minus g of a. Now
my expression on the left is just another
way of writing the derivative of f evaluated
at g of a. And I've arrived at the expression
for the chain rule. Let me just emphasize
again, this is just a pseudo proof, it's not
quite airtight, because g of x minus g of
a might be zero. In this video, we saw some
more examples of the chain rule justification
of it. And we saw that the derivative respect
to x
of A to the X is equal to ln of a times a
to the x. This video gives an explanation
for why the chain rule holds.
of A to the X is equal to ln of a times a
to the x. This video gives an explanation
for why the chain rule holds.
I'm not going to give a rigorous proof of
the chain rule. But I would like to give a
more informal explanation based on the limit
definition of derivative.
I'm not going to give a rigorous proof of
the chain rule. But I would like to give a
more informal explanation based on the limit
definition of derivative.
So I'm going to write the derivative of f
composed with g evaluated a point A, as the
limit as x goes to a of f composed with g
of x minus f composed with g of A divided
by x minus a. I'll rewrite this slightly.
And now we're going to multiply the top and
the bottom by g of x minus g of a, that doesn't
change the value of expression, provided that
g of x minus g of A is not zero. That's the
detail on sweeping under the rug here and
why this is not a real proof, but just a more
informal explanation. Now if I rearrange things,
and rewrite the limit of the product as the
product of the limits, my limit on the right
here is just the derivative of g. for the
limit on the left, notice that as x goes to
a, g of x has to go to G evey, since G is
differentiable on there for a continuous function,
so I can rewrite this and letting say u be
equal to g of x, I can rewrite this as the
limit as u goes to g of a of f of u minus
f of g of A
So I'm going to write the derivative of f
composed with g evaluated a point A, as the
limit as x goes to a of f composed with g
of x minus f composed with g of A divided
by x minus a. I'll rewrite this slightly.
And now we're going to multiply the top and
the bottom by g of x minus g of a, that doesn't
change the value of expression, provided that
g of x minus g of A is not zero. That's the
detail on sweeping under the rug here and
why this is not a real proof, but just a more
informal explanation. Now if I rearrange things,
and rewrite the limit of the product as the
product of the limits, my limit on the right
here is just the derivative of g. for the
limit on the left, notice that as x goes to
a, g of x has to go to G evey, since G is
differentiable on there for a continuous function,
so I can rewrite this and letting say u be
equal to g of x, I can rewrite this as the
limit as u goes to g of a of f of u minus
f of g of A
over
u minus g of a. Now my expression on the left
is just another way of writing the derivative
of f evaluated at G Ave. And I've arrived
at the expression for the chain rule. Let
me just emphasize again, this is just a pseudo
proof it's not quite airtight because g of
x minus g of a might be zero. That's all for
the justification of the chain rule. For a
complete proof. Please see the textbook implicit
differentiation is a technique for finding
the slopes of tangent lines for curves that
are defined indirectly, and sometimes aren't
even functions. So far, we've developed a
lot of techniques for finding derivatives
of functions defined explicitly, in terms
of the equation y equals something. In this
section, we'll consider curves that are defined
implicitly, in terms of any equation involving
x's and y's. So the points on this curve are
the values of x and y that satisfy this equation.
As you can see, when you have implicitly defined
curves, they are not necessarily functions.
And in fact, they can not only violate the
vertical line test, but they can cross themselves,
or be broken up into several pieces or look
like really cool pictures like this flower.
But small pieces of these curves do satisfy
the vertical line test for small pieces, y
is a function of x. And that allows us to
use our calculus techniques, especially the
chain rule, to compute derivatives for these
implicitly defined curves.
u minus g of a. Now my expression on the left
is just another way of writing the derivative
of f evaluated at G Ave. And I've arrived
at the expression for the chain rule. Let
me just emphasize again, this is just a pseudo
proof it's not quite airtight because g of
x minus g of a might be zero. That's all for
the justification of the chain rule. For a
complete proof. Please see the textbook implicit
differentiation is a technique for finding
the slopes of tangent lines for curves that
are defined indirectly, and sometimes aren't
even functions. So far, we've developed a
lot of techniques for finding derivatives
of functions defined explicitly, in terms
of the equation y equals something. In this
section, we'll consider curves that are defined
implicitly, in terms of any equation involving
x's and y's. So the points on this curve are
the values of x and y that satisfy this equation.
As you can see, when you have implicitly defined
curves, they are not necessarily functions.
And in fact, they can not only violate the
vertical line test, but they can cross themselves,
or be broken up into several pieces or look
like really cool pictures like this flower.
But small pieces of these curves do satisfy
the vertical line test for small pieces, y
is a function of x. And that allows us to
use our calculus techniques, especially the
chain rule, to compute derivatives for these
implicitly defined curves.
As usual, the derivative dy dx represents
the slope of a tangent line. For our first
example, let's find the equation of the tangent
line for the lips 9x squared plus four y squared
equals 25. drawn below at the point, one,
two. From the picture, it looks like the slope
of this tangent line should be about negative
one, but let's use calculus to find it exactly.
So there are at least two ways we could proceed.
First, we could solve for y, and then use
the same techniques that we've been using.
So if we solve for y, we get for y squared
equals 25 minus 9x squared. So y squared is
25 minus 9x squared over four, which means
that y is plus or minus the square root of
25 minus 9x squared over four, or in other
words, plus or minus the square root of 25
minus 9x squared over two, the plus answer
is giving us the top half of the ellipse.
And the minus answer is giving us this bottom.
Since the point one, two is on the top part
of the ellipse, let's focus on the positive
version. And let's take the derivative. But
first, let me rewrite one more time to put
it in a slightly easier form, instead of dividing
by two, I'm going to think of multiplying
by the constant one half. And instead of taking
the square root, I'm going to write that as
an exponent of one half here. So now if I
want to take the y dx, I can pull out the
constant of one half. And now I'll start using
the chain rule where my outer function
As usual, the derivative dy dx represents
the slope of a tangent line. For our first
example, let's find the equation of the tangent
line for the lips 9x squared plus four y squared
equals 25. drawn below at the point, one,
two. From the picture, it looks like the slope
of this tangent line should be about negative
one, but let's use calculus to find it exactly.
So there are at least two ways we could proceed.
First, we could solve for y, and then use
the same techniques that we've been using.
So if we solve for y, we get for y squared
equals 25 minus 9x squared. So y squared is
25 minus 9x squared over four, which means
that y is plus or minus the square root of
25 minus 9x squared over four, or in other
words, plus or minus the square root of 25
minus 9x squared over two, the plus answer
is giving us the top half of the ellipse.
And the minus answer is giving us this bottom.
Since the point one, two is on the top part
of the ellipse, let's focus on the positive
version. And let's take the derivative. But
first, let me rewrite one more time to put
it in a slightly easier form, instead of dividing
by two, I'm going to think of multiplying
by the constant one half. And instead of taking
the square root, I'm going to write that as
an exponent of one half here. So now if I
want to take the y dx, I can pull out the
constant of one half. And now I'll start using
the chain rule where my outer function
is
taking things to the one half power, and my
inner function is 25 minus 9x squared. So
I'll take the derivative of my outer function
by bringing the one half down, taking the
inner function to the negative one half. Now
I multiply by the derivative of the inner
function, which is negative 18x. If I simplify
a little bit, I get D y dX is negative 18x
over four times 25 minus 9x squared to the
one half power, or in other words, dy dx is
negative 9x over two times the square root
of 25 minus 9x squared. This formula only
holds for the top half of the ellipse for
the bottom half, we would need to use the
negative. Now I want to evaluate the derivative
at the point one, two, so I'm going to take
dydx. When x equals one, I get negative nine
over two times the square root of 25 minus
nine, which is negative nine eighths. Since
I've found the slope of the tangent line,
and I know that point one, two is a point
on the tangent line, I can now use the point
slope form to write down the equation of the
tangent line. simplified this becomes y equals
negative nine is x plus nine eights plus two,
or y equals negative nine, it's x plus 25.
It's now that we've solved the problem once
using a familiar method. Let's go back to
the beginning and solve it again using a new
method. method two is implicit differentiation.
The idea is that I'm going to take the derivative
with respect to x of both sides. If my equation
without having to solve for y, I can rewrite
the left side as nine times the derivative
of x squared plus four times the derivative
of y squared. And the right side, the derivative
of a constant is zero. Going back to the left
side, the derivative of x squared with respect
to x is 2x. Now for the derivative of y squared
with respect to x, I'm going to need to use
the chain rule, I'm going to think of taking
the squared power as my outside function,
I'm going to think of y itself as my inside
function, my inside function of x. Even though
my entire curve is not a function, for small
pieces of it, y is a function of x, so I can
get away with doing this, the derivative of
my outside function y squared is to y, and
the derivative of my inside function, y as
a function of x is just dydx. Now I can solve
for dy dx, which is going to tell me the slope
of my tangent line. And so I get negative
18x from here, divided by eight y from here,
which simplifies to negative nine fourths
times X over Y. Notice that the formula for
my derivative dydx has both x's and y's in
it. Of course, for this problem, if I wanted
to, I could solve for y in terms of x using
the original equation like I did in method
one, and plug that in for y and get an expression
entirely in terms of x, which should be the
same as the expression I got previously.
taking things to the one half power, and my
inner function is 25 minus 9x squared. So
I'll take the derivative of my outer function
by bringing the one half down, taking the
inner function to the negative one half. Now
I multiply by the derivative of the inner
function, which is negative 18x. If I simplify
a little bit, I get D y dX is negative 18x
over four times 25 minus 9x squared to the
one half power, or in other words, dy dx is
negative 9x over two times the square root
of 25 minus 9x squared. This formula only
holds for the top half of the ellipse for
the bottom half, we would need to use the
negative. Now I want to evaluate the derivative
at the point one, two, so I'm going to take
dydx. When x equals one, I get negative nine
over two times the square root of 25 minus
nine, which is negative nine eighths. Since
I've found the slope of the tangent line,
and I know that point one, two is a point
on the tangent line, I can now use the point
slope form to write down the equation of the
tangent line. simplified this becomes y equals
negative nine is x plus nine eights plus two,
or y equals negative nine, it's x plus 25.
It's now that we've solved the problem once
using a familiar method. Let's go back to
the beginning and solve it again using a new
method. method two is implicit differentiation.
The idea is that I'm going to take the derivative
with respect to x of both sides. If my equation
without having to solve for y, I can rewrite
the left side as nine times the derivative
of x squared plus four times the derivative
of y squared. And the right side, the derivative
of a constant is zero. Going back to the left
side, the derivative of x squared with respect
to x is 2x. Now for the derivative of y squared
with respect to x, I'm going to need to use
the chain rule, I'm going to think of taking
the squared power as my outside function,
I'm going to think of y itself as my inside
function, my inside function of x. Even though
my entire curve is not a function, for small
pieces of it, y is a function of x, so I can
get away with doing this, the derivative of
my outside function y squared is to y, and
the derivative of my inside function, y as
a function of x is just dydx. Now I can solve
for dy dx, which is going to tell me the slope
of my tangent line. And so I get negative
18x from here, divided by eight y from here,
which simplifies to negative nine fourths
times X over Y. Notice that the formula for
my derivative dydx has both x's and y's in
it. Of course, for this problem, if I wanted
to, I could solve for y in terms of x using
the original equation like I did in method
one, and plug that in for y and get an expression
entirely in terms of x, which should be the
same as the expression I got previously.
But I don't really
need to do that in order to solve this problem.
Instead, I can just plug in the x value of
one and the y value of two to get dy dx at
x equals one, equal to negative nine fourths,
times one half or negative nine, eight, which
we'll recognize as the same answer we got
before. So as before, we can compute the equation
for the tangent line. And we'll again get
y equals negative nine 8x plus 25, eights.
In this example, implicit differentiation
was a convenient way to find the derivative.
But it was possible to solve for y and use
standard methods instead. But in many examples,
like the next one, it's not possible to solve
for y directly. And so implicit differentiation
is the only way to go. implicit differentiation
is definitely the key to finding y prime for
this curve defined implicitly. So again, the
idea is to take the derivative of both sides
with respect to x, I can break this up into
pieces. And now use the product rule for the
first piece. So I get the first function x
cubed times the derivative of the second function
y squared, the derivative of y squared is
to y, d y dx, don't forget the dydx there,
because y is a function of x plus the derivative
of the first part 3x squared times the second
part
need to do that in order to solve this problem.
Instead, I can just plug in the x value of
one and the y value of two to get dy dx at
x equals one, equal to negative nine fourths,
times one half or negative nine, eight, which
we'll recognize as the same answer we got
before. So as before, we can compute the equation
for the tangent line. And we'll again get
y equals negative nine 8x plus 25, eights.
In this example, implicit differentiation
was a convenient way to find the derivative.
But it was possible to solve for y and use
standard methods instead. But in many examples,
like the next one, it's not possible to solve
for y directly. And so implicit differentiation
is the only way to go. implicit differentiation
is definitely the key to finding y prime for
this curve defined implicitly. So again, the
idea is to take the derivative of both sides
with respect to x, I can break this up into
pieces. And now use the product rule for the
first piece. So I get the first function x
cubed times the derivative of the second function
y squared, the derivative of y squared is
to y, d y dx, don't forget the dydx there,
because y is a function of x plus the derivative
of the first part 3x squared times the second
part
y squared.
Next, I need to take the derivative of sine
x, y on the do use the chain rule here. So
the derivative of the outside sine is cosine.
And now I need to take the derivative of the
inside x times y. And that's going to be a
product rule application. So x times D y dX,
plus the derivative of x, which is just one
times y. That all was just my left hand side.
But fortunately, my right hand side is easier.
The derivative of x cubed with respect to
x is 3x squared. And the derivative of y cubed
with respect to x is three y squared, dy dx.
Now I need to solve for the y dx. And since
it's scattered all over the place in three
different places, I'm first going to distribute
out to free it from these parentheses, and
then I'll try to move all the dydx is to the
left side. So distributing out I get, I get
this expression. And now moving alternatives
with dydx and add them to the left side and
all terms without dydx mm to the right side.
I'm going to get this expression here. Now
I'm going to factor out the dy dx. I'm just
using standard algebra techniques here. And
finally, I can just divide both sides by all
this mess, too. isolate the dydx. And I found
my derivative using implicit differentiation.
This video talked about using implicit differentiation
to find the slopes of tangent lines for curves
defined implicitly, the main two steps, were
first to take the derivative of both sides
with respect to x. And then to solve for dy
dx. This video is about finding the derivatives
of exponential functions, we've already seen
that the derivative of the exponential function,
e to the x is just itself, e to the x. But
what's the derivative of an exponential function
with a different base, like five to the x,
one way to find the derivative of an exponential
function like five to the X is to write five
as e to a power. So five, is the same thing
as e to the ln five, where ln is the natural
log or the log base. See, this makes sense
because ln five, which is the same thing as
log base e of five, means the power that we
raise E to to get five. So now if we take
e to the ln five, that means we raise e to
the power that we raise E to to get five?
Well, when you raise E to that power, you
get five. All right, if five is the same thing
as e to the ln five, then that means if we
take five to the x, that's the same thing
as e to the ln five raised to the x power
BI properties of exponents, when I take a
power to a power, I multiply the exponents.
so this can be written as e to the ln five
times x. Now I want to take the derivative
with respect to x of five to the x. So by
my rewriting trick, that's the same thing
as taking the derivative with respect to x
of e to the ln five times x. Now we know how
to calculate this using the chain rule, we
can think of e to the power as our outside
function, and ln five times x as our inside
function. So now by the chain rule, I take
the derivative of the outside function e to
the power, and that's just gives me e to the
power evaluated on the inside function. So
I stick ln five times x as my inside function,
and by the chain rule, I multiply that by
the derivative of the inside function, ln
five times x. Five is a constant. So let me
copy over first part, the derivative of a
constant times x is just the constant. Let
me rewrite this a little bit. So e to the
ln five times x is the same thing as e to
the ln five to the x power, just like before,
because the exponent rules say, when I take
a power to a power, I multiply the exponent,
and remember, is the LL five, it's just a
fancy way of writing five. So I've got five
to the x times ln five as the derivative with
respect to x of five to the x. The same argument
works not just for a base five exponential
function, but for any base exponential function.
So if I take the respect to x of A to the
X for any number A, I'm going to get
Next, I need to take the derivative of sine
x, y on the do use the chain rule here. So
the derivative of the outside sine is cosine.
And now I need to take the derivative of the
inside x times y. And that's going to be a
product rule application. So x times D y dX,
plus the derivative of x, which is just one
times y. That all was just my left hand side.
But fortunately, my right hand side is easier.
The derivative of x cubed with respect to
x is 3x squared. And the derivative of y cubed
with respect to x is three y squared, dy dx.
Now I need to solve for the y dx. And since
it's scattered all over the place in three
different places, I'm first going to distribute
out to free it from these parentheses, and
then I'll try to move all the dydx is to the
left side. So distributing out I get, I get
this expression. And now moving alternatives
with dydx and add them to the left side and
all terms without dydx mm to the right side.
I'm going to get this expression here. Now
I'm going to factor out the dy dx. I'm just
using standard algebra techniques here. And
finally, I can just divide both sides by all
this mess, too. isolate the dydx. And I found
my derivative using implicit differentiation.
This video talked about using implicit differentiation
to find the slopes of tangent lines for curves
defined implicitly, the main two steps, were
first to take the derivative of both sides
with respect to x. And then to solve for dy
dx. This video is about finding the derivatives
of exponential functions, we've already seen
that the derivative of the exponential function,
e to the x is just itself, e to the x. But
what's the derivative of an exponential function
with a different base, like five to the x,
one way to find the derivative of an exponential
function like five to the X is to write five
as e to a power. So five, is the same thing
as e to the ln five, where ln is the natural
log or the log base. See, this makes sense
because ln five, which is the same thing as
log base e of five, means the power that we
raise E to to get five. So now if we take
e to the ln five, that means we raise e to
the power that we raise E to to get five?
Well, when you raise E to that power, you
get five. All right, if five is the same thing
as e to the ln five, then that means if we
take five to the x, that's the same thing
as e to the ln five raised to the x power
BI properties of exponents, when I take a
power to a power, I multiply the exponents.
so this can be written as e to the ln five
times x. Now I want to take the derivative
with respect to x of five to the x. So by
my rewriting trick, that's the same thing
as taking the derivative with respect to x
of e to the ln five times x. Now we know how
to calculate this using the chain rule, we
can think of e to the power as our outside
function, and ln five times x as our inside
function. So now by the chain rule, I take
the derivative of the outside function e to
the power, and that's just gives me e to the
power evaluated on the inside function. So
I stick ln five times x as my inside function,
and by the chain rule, I multiply that by
the derivative of the inside function, ln
five times x. Five is a constant. So let me
copy over first part, the derivative of a
constant times x is just the constant. Let
me rewrite this a little bit. So e to the
ln five times x is the same thing as e to
the ln five to the x power, just like before,
because the exponent rules say, when I take
a power to a power, I multiply the exponent,
and remember, is the LL five, it's just a
fancy way of writing five. So I've got five
to the x times ln five as the derivative with
respect to x of five to the x. The same argument
works not just for a base five exponential
function, but for any base exponential function.
So if I take the respect to x of A to the
X for any number A, I'm going to get
a to the x times ln A. Now, you might be wondering,
what if I use the same roll on our old favorite
e to the x. So our base here is E. That means
I should get e to the x times ln e? Wait a
sec, ln E, that's log base e of E, that's
asking what power? Do I raise II today get
he? Well, the answer there is one. And so
the derivative respect to x of e to the x
by this new rule we have is e to the x, it
agrees with our old rule. I want to draw your
attention to the difference between two expressions.
And the first expression, dy dx of a to the
x, the variable that we're taking the derivative
with respect to is in the exponent. So for
this exponential function, or we use the derivative
rule that we just found, dy dx of a dx is
eight of the x times ln A. On the other hand,
if we take respect to x of x to the A, where
the variable x that we're taking the derivative
with respect to is in the base, then we don't
need this exponential rule. In fact, it doesn't
even apply, although we have here is the power
rule, right? dy dx of x cubed would be 3x
squared dy dx of x to the seventh would be
7x to the sixth and enjoy Add x of x to the
a is just a times x to the A minus one by
the power role. So it's important to pay attention
to where the variable is when you're taking
a derivative. In this video, we found that
the derivative with respect to x of five to
the x is given by ln five times five to the
x. And in general, the derivative of respect
to x of A to the X is going to be ln a times
a to the x. This gives us a general formula
for the derivative of exponential functions.
The main goal of this video is to figure out
the derivatives of logarithmic functions,
functions like y equals ln x, or y equals
log base A x for any positive base a, I want
to find the derivative of log base a of x.
In other words, I want to find the derivative
of y, where y is log base a of x. By the definition
of logarithms, log base a of x equals y means
that a to the Y power is equal to x. And that's
useful because now I can take the derivative
of both sides and use implicit differentiation.
Recall of the derivative of a to the power
is ln A times A to the power. But since why
we're thinking of as a function of x, I have
to multiply that by dou y dx by the chain
rule. The right hand side here is just one.
Solving for dydx, I get one over ln A times
A to the Y. But since age the y is equal to
x, I can rewrite that as the y dx equals one
over ln A times x. So the derivative of log
base a of x for any base a is one over ln
of A times x. And in particular, the derivative
of natural log of x is one over ln of E times
x. But since ln of E is just one, that saying
that the derivative of ln x is one over x,
this is a very handy fact. And this more general
derivative is also worth memorizing. While
we're talking about the derivative of the
natural log of x, let's look at the derivative
of the natural log of the absolute value of
x. The function y equals ln of absolute value
of x is of course closely related to the function
y equals ln of x, the difference being that
the domain for ln x is just x values greater
than zero, whereas the domain of ln of absolute
value of x is all X's not equal to zero. The
graphs are also related. When you look at
the graph of y equals ln absolute value of
x, it looks like you're seeing double since
the absolute value of x is equal to x, when
x is greater than or equal to zero and negative
x when x is less than zero, ln of the absolute
value of x is going to be equal to ln x when
x is greater than or equal to zero, and ln
of negative x when x is less than zero. If
I consider the derivative of ln of absolute
value of x, I can think of taking the derivative
of each piece separately. We just saw that
the derivative of ln x is one over x. So the
derivative of ln of minus x is going to be
one over minus x times the derivative of minus
x, which is minus one by the chain rule. Notice
that this second expression simplifies to
one over x. So the derivative of ln of absolute
value of x is equal to one over x, whether
x is positive or negative. This formula will
come in handy later when we start doing integrals.
In this video, we found that the derivative
of ln x is equal to one over x, kind of a
nice derivative. And more generally, the derivative
of log base a of x is one over ln A times
x. We've seen previously that the derivative
of x to a constant A is equal to a times x
to the A minus one. This is the power rule.
We've also seen that the derivative of a positive
number a raised to the x power is equal to
ln A times A to the X So we know how to take
the derivative when the variable x is in the
base, or when it's in the exponent. But what
if the variables in both the base and the
exponent, how do we take the derivative of
x to the x. To differentiate functions like
this, we'll need to use the technique of logarithmic
differentiation. To find the derivative of
x to the x, I'm going to set y equal to x
to the x. Now we want to find dy dx. Since
we don't know how to compute dydx directly,
so let's take the natural log of both sides.
taking the log is often a handy trick when
you have a variable in the exponent that you
don't know how to deal with, because the properties
of logs allow us to bring that exponent down
and multiply it. Now we have y implicitly
defined in terms of x, so let's use implicit
differentiation, we'll take the derivative
of both sides with respect to x. And now we
should have no trouble taking the derivatives
because we've gotten rid of the awkward exponential
expression. So the derivative on the left
of ln y is one over y times dy dx. And the
derivative on the right using the product
rule is x times one over x plus one times
ln x.
a to the x times ln A. Now, you might be wondering,
what if I use the same roll on our old favorite
e to the x. So our base here is E. That means
I should get e to the x times ln e? Wait a
sec, ln E, that's log base e of E, that's
asking what power? Do I raise II today get
he? Well, the answer there is one. And so
the derivative respect to x of e to the x
by this new rule we have is e to the x, it
agrees with our old rule. I want to draw your
attention to the difference between two expressions.
And the first expression, dy dx of a to the
x, the variable that we're taking the derivative
with respect to is in the exponent. So for
this exponential function, or we use the derivative
rule that we just found, dy dx of a dx is
eight of the x times ln A. On the other hand,
if we take respect to x of x to the A, where
the variable x that we're taking the derivative
with respect to is in the base, then we don't
need this exponential rule. In fact, it doesn't
even apply, although we have here is the power
rule, right? dy dx of x cubed would be 3x
squared dy dx of x to the seventh would be
7x to the sixth and enjoy Add x of x to the
a is just a times x to the A minus one by
the power role. So it's important to pay attention
to where the variable is when you're taking
a derivative. In this video, we found that
the derivative with respect to x of five to
the x is given by ln five times five to the
x. And in general, the derivative of respect
to x of A to the X is going to be ln a times
a to the x. This gives us a general formula
for the derivative of exponential functions.
The main goal of this video is to figure out
the derivatives of logarithmic functions,
functions like y equals ln x, or y equals
log base A x for any positive base a, I want
to find the derivative of log base a of x.
In other words, I want to find the derivative
of y, where y is log base a of x. By the definition
of logarithms, log base a of x equals y means
that a to the Y power is equal to x. And that's
useful because now I can take the derivative
of both sides and use implicit differentiation.
Recall of the derivative of a to the power
is ln A times A to the power. But since why
we're thinking of as a function of x, I have
to multiply that by dou y dx by the chain
rule. The right hand side here is just one.
Solving for dydx, I get one over ln A times
A to the Y. But since age the y is equal to
x, I can rewrite that as the y dx equals one
over ln A times x. So the derivative of log
base a of x for any base a is one over ln
of A times x. And in particular, the derivative
of natural log of x is one over ln of E times
x. But since ln of E is just one, that saying
that the derivative of ln x is one over x,
this is a very handy fact. And this more general
derivative is also worth memorizing. While
we're talking about the derivative of the
natural log of x, let's look at the derivative
of the natural log of the absolute value of
x. The function y equals ln of absolute value
of x is of course closely related to the function
y equals ln of x, the difference being that
the domain for ln x is just x values greater
than zero, whereas the domain of ln of absolute
value of x is all X's not equal to zero. The
graphs are also related. When you look at
the graph of y equals ln absolute value of
x, it looks like you're seeing double since
the absolute value of x is equal to x, when
x is greater than or equal to zero and negative
x when x is less than zero, ln of the absolute
value of x is going to be equal to ln x when
x is greater than or equal to zero, and ln
of negative x when x is less than zero. If
I consider the derivative of ln of absolute
value of x, I can think of taking the derivative
of each piece separately. We just saw that
the derivative of ln x is one over x. So the
derivative of ln of minus x is going to be
one over minus x times the derivative of minus
x, which is minus one by the chain rule. Notice
that this second expression simplifies to
one over x. So the derivative of ln of absolute
value of x is equal to one over x, whether
x is positive or negative. This formula will
come in handy later when we start doing integrals.
In this video, we found that the derivative
of ln x is equal to one over x, kind of a
nice derivative. And more generally, the derivative
of log base a of x is one over ln A times
x. We've seen previously that the derivative
of x to a constant A is equal to a times x
to the A minus one. This is the power rule.
We've also seen that the derivative of a positive
number a raised to the x power is equal to
ln A times A to the X So we know how to take
the derivative when the variable x is in the
base, or when it's in the exponent. But what
if the variables in both the base and the
exponent, how do we take the derivative of
x to the x. To differentiate functions like
this, we'll need to use the technique of logarithmic
differentiation. To find the derivative of
x to the x, I'm going to set y equal to x
to the x. Now we want to find dy dx. Since
we don't know how to compute dydx directly,
so let's take the natural log of both sides.
taking the log is often a handy trick when
you have a variable in the exponent that you
don't know how to deal with, because the properties
of logs allow us to bring that exponent down
and multiply it. Now we have y implicitly
defined in terms of x, so let's use implicit
differentiation, we'll take the derivative
of both sides with respect to x. And now we
should have no trouble taking the derivatives
because we've gotten rid of the awkward exponential
expression. So the derivative on the left
of ln y is one over y times dy dx. And the
derivative on the right using the product
rule is x times one over x plus one times
ln x.
This simplifies to one over y d y dx equals
one plus ln x. So D y dX is going to equal
y times one plus ln x. and replacing y with
x to the x, I have dy dx is x to the x times
one plus ln x. This technique of taking the
log of both sides differentiating and solving
for dydx is known as logarithmic differentiation.
And it's enormously useful whenever you have
variables in both the base and the exponent.
Here's another example where our variable
is in both the base and the exponent. So as
before, I'm going to set y equal to the expression
that I want to differentiate and compute dydx.
First, I'll take the log of both sides. Use
my log rules to bring my exponent down and
multiply it and take the derivative of both
sides with respect to x. On the left, I get
one over y d y dx. And on the right, I get
one of our x times the derivative of ln tangent
x, which is one over tangent x times the derivative
of tangent x, or secant squared x, continuing
with the product rule, and didn't take the
derivative of one of our x, that's going to
be the derivative of x to the minus one, which
is minus one times x to the minus
This simplifies to one over y d y dx equals
one plus ln x. So D y dX is going to equal
y times one plus ln x. and replacing y with
x to the x, I have dy dx is x to the x times
one plus ln x. This technique of taking the
log of both sides differentiating and solving
for dydx is known as logarithmic differentiation.
And it's enormously useful whenever you have
variables in both the base and the exponent.
Here's another example where our variable
is in both the base and the exponent. So as
before, I'm going to set y equal to the expression
that I want to differentiate and compute dydx.
First, I'll take the log of both sides. Use
my log rules to bring my exponent down and
multiply it and take the derivative of both
sides with respect to x. On the left, I get
one over y d y dx. And on the right, I get
one of our x times the derivative of ln tangent
x, which is one over tangent x times the derivative
of tangent x, or secant squared x, continuing
with the product rule, and didn't take the
derivative of one of our x, that's going to
be the derivative of x to the minus one, which
is minus one times x to the minus
two
times ln tangent of x. Simplifying the right
hand side, I get one over x times one over
sine x over cosine x times one over cosine
squared x minus ln 10x over x squared. rewriting,
I can flip and multiply to get one over x
times cosine x over sine x times one over
cosine squared x minus the second term, canceling
one copy of cosine and rewriting in terms
of cosecant and secant, I get this expression,
I still have to solve for dy dx.
times ln tangent of x. Simplifying the right
hand side, I get one over x times one over
sine x over cosine x times one over cosine
squared x minus ln 10x over x squared. rewriting,
I can flip and multiply to get one over x
times cosine x over sine x times one over
cosine squared x minus the second term, canceling
one copy of cosine and rewriting in terms
of cosecant and secant, I get this expression,
I still have to solve for dy dx.
So multiplying both sides by y, I get the
following. And since y was equal to 10x to
the one over x, I can rewrite everything in
terms of x. The technique of logarithmic differentiation
is most useful when taking the derivative
of an expression that has a variable in both
the base and the exponent, like in this example,
but sometimes it's also handy just as a way
to take the derivative of a complicated product
and quotient like in this example. Now, we
could take the derivative here just by using
the quotient rule on the product rule, but
it's a little easier to take the log of both
sides. And the reason is that when we take
the log of a product, we get a sum and the
log of a quotient is a difference and sums
and quotients are a lot easier to deal with.
So in this example, the log of y is equal
to ln of x plus ln of cosine of x minus ln
of x squared plus x to the fifth power, I
can even bring that fifth power down, because
that's another one of my log roles. Now, it's
much more straightforward to take the log
of both sides. On the left, I have one over
y dydx, as usual, and on the right, the derivative
of ln x is one over x, the derivative of ln
cosine x is one over cosine of x times negative
sine of x. And the derivative of ln x squared
plus x is one over x squared plus x times
2x plus one. I'll solve for dydx and get y
times one over x minus sine x over cosine
x, that's the same as tangent x minus five
times 2x plus one over x squared plus x. Now
I can just rewrite y in terms of x and I'll
be done. Again, I didn't have to use logarithmic
differentiation. To find this derivative,
I could have just used the product rule in
the quotient rule, but logarithmic differentiation
made it computationally much easier. In this
video, we learned how to take the derivative
of expressions that have a variable both in
the base and in the exponent. And the idea
was first to set y equal to the expression
we want to derive. Next, to take the natural
log of both sides. Next, to derive both sides.
And finally, to solve for dy dx. This process
is called logarithmic differentiation. The
inverse of a function undoes what the function
does, so the inverse of tying your shoes would
be to untie them. And the inverse of the function
that adds two to a number would be the function
that subtracts two from a number. This video
introduces inverses and their properties.
Suppose f of x is the function defined by
this chart. In other words, f of two is three,
f of three is five, f of four is six, and
f of five is one, the inverse function for
F written f superscript. Negative 1x undoes
what f does. Since f takes two to three, F
inverse takes three back to two. So we write
this f superscript, negative one of three
is two. Similarly, since f takes three to
five, F inverse takes five to three. And since
f takes four to six, f inverse of six is four.
And since f takes five to one, f inverse of
one is five. I'll use these numbers to fill
in the chart. Notice that the chart of values
when y equals f of x and the chart of values
when y equals f inverse of x are closely related.
They share the same numbers, but the x values
for f of x correspond to the y values for
f inverse of x, and the y values for f of
x correspond to the x values for f inverse
of x. That leads us to the first key fact
inverse functions reverse the roles of y and
x. I'm going to plot the points for y equals
f of x in blue.
So multiplying both sides by y, I get the
following. And since y was equal to 10x to
the one over x, I can rewrite everything in
terms of x. The technique of logarithmic differentiation
is most useful when taking the derivative
of an expression that has a variable in both
the base and the exponent, like in this example,
but sometimes it's also handy just as a way
to take the derivative of a complicated product
and quotient like in this example. Now, we
could take the derivative here just by using
the quotient rule on the product rule, but
it's a little easier to take the log of both
sides. And the reason is that when we take
the log of a product, we get a sum and the
log of a quotient is a difference and sums
and quotients are a lot easier to deal with.
So in this example, the log of y is equal
to ln of x plus ln of cosine of x minus ln
of x squared plus x to the fifth power, I
can even bring that fifth power down, because
that's another one of my log roles. Now, it's
much more straightforward to take the log
of both sides. On the left, I have one over
y dydx, as usual, and on the right, the derivative
of ln x is one over x, the derivative of ln
cosine x is one over cosine of x times negative
sine of x. And the derivative of ln x squared
plus x is one over x squared plus x times
2x plus one. I'll solve for dydx and get y
times one over x minus sine x over cosine
x, that's the same as tangent x minus five
times 2x plus one over x squared plus x. Now
I can just rewrite y in terms of x and I'll
be done. Again, I didn't have to use logarithmic
differentiation. To find this derivative,
I could have just used the product rule in
the quotient rule, but logarithmic differentiation
made it computationally much easier. In this
video, we learned how to take the derivative
of expressions that have a variable both in
the base and in the exponent. And the idea
was first to set y equal to the expression
we want to derive. Next, to take the natural
log of both sides. Next, to derive both sides.
And finally, to solve for dy dx. This process
is called logarithmic differentiation. The
inverse of a function undoes what the function
does, so the inverse of tying your shoes would
be to untie them. And the inverse of the function
that adds two to a number would be the function
that subtracts two from a number. This video
introduces inverses and their properties.
Suppose f of x is the function defined by
this chart. In other words, f of two is three,
f of three is five, f of four is six, and
f of five is one, the inverse function for
F written f superscript. Negative 1x undoes
what f does. Since f takes two to three, F
inverse takes three back to two. So we write
this f superscript, negative one of three
is two. Similarly, since f takes three to
five, F inverse takes five to three. And since
f takes four to six, f inverse of six is four.
And since f takes five to one, f inverse of
one is five. I'll use these numbers to fill
in the chart. Notice that the chart of values
when y equals f of x and the chart of values
when y equals f inverse of x are closely related.
They share the same numbers, but the x values
for f of x correspond to the y values for
f inverse of x, and the y values for f of
x correspond to the x values for f inverse
of x. That leads us to the first key fact
inverse functions reverse the roles of y and
x. I'm going to plot the points for y equals
f of x in blue.
Next, I'll plot the points for y equals f
inverse of x in red. Pause the video for a
moment and see what kind of symmetry you observe
in this graph. How are the blue points related
to the red points, you might have noticed
that the blue points and the red points are
mirror images over the mirror line, y equals
x. So our second key fact is that the graph
of y equals f inverse of x can be obtained
from the graph of y equals f of x by reflecting
over the line y equals x. This makes sense,
because inverses, reverse the roles of y and
x. In the same example, let's compute f inverse
of f of two. This open circle means composition.
In other words, we're computing f inverse
of f of two. We compute this from the inside
out. So that's f inverse of three. Since F
of two is three, and f inverse of three, we
see is two. Similarly, we can compute f of
f inverse of three. And that means we take
f of f inverse of three. Since f inverse of
three is two, that's the same thing as computing
F of two, which is three. Please pause the
video for a moment and compute these other
compositions. You should have found that in
every case, if you take f inverse of f of
a number, you get back to the very same number
you started with. And similarly, if you take
f of f inverse of any number, you get back
to the same number you started with. So in
general, f inverse of f of x is equal to x,
and f of f inverse of x is also equal to x.
This is the mathematical way of saying that
F and envir f inverse undo each other. Let's
look at a different example. Suppose that
f of x is x cubed. Pause the video for a moment
and guess what the inverse of f should be?
Remember, F inverse undoes the work that F
does. You might have guessed that f inverse
of x is going to be the cube root function.
And we can check that this is true by looking
at f of f inverse of x, that's F of the cube
root of function, which means the cube root
function cubed, which gets us back to x. Similarly,
if we compute f inverse of f of x, that's
the cube root of x cubed. And we get back
to excellence again. So the cube root function
really is the inverse of the cubing function.
When we compose the two functions, we get
back to the number that we started with. It'd
be nice to have a more systematic way of finding
inverses of functions besides guessing and
checking. One method uses the fact that inverses,
reverse the roles of y and x. So if we want
to find the inverse of the function, f of
x equals five minus x over 3x, we can write
it as y equals five minus x over 3x. Reverse
the roles of y and x to get x equals five
minus y over three y, and then solve for y.
To solve for y, let's multiply both sides
by three y. Bring all terms with wisened to
the left side, and alternans without y's and
then to the right side, factor out the y and
divide to isolate y. This gives us f inverse
of x as five over 3x plus one. Notice that
our original function f and our inverse function,
f inverse are both rational functions, but
they're not the reciprocals of each other.
And then General, f inverse of x is not usually
equal to one over f of x. This can be confusing,
because when we write two to the minus one,
that does mean one of our two, but f to the
minus one of x means the inverse function
and not the reciprocal. It's natural to ask
if all functions have inverse functions, that
is for any function you might encounter. Is
there always a function that it is its inverse?
Next, I'll plot the points for y equals f
inverse of x in red. Pause the video for a
moment and see what kind of symmetry you observe
in this graph. How are the blue points related
to the red points, you might have noticed
that the blue points and the red points are
mirror images over the mirror line, y equals
x. So our second key fact is that the graph
of y equals f inverse of x can be obtained
from the graph of y equals f of x by reflecting
over the line y equals x. This makes sense,
because inverses, reverse the roles of y and
x. In the same example, let's compute f inverse
of f of two. This open circle means composition.
In other words, we're computing f inverse
of f of two. We compute this from the inside
out. So that's f inverse of three. Since F
of two is three, and f inverse of three, we
see is two. Similarly, we can compute f of
f inverse of three. And that means we take
f of f inverse of three. Since f inverse of
three is two, that's the same thing as computing
F of two, which is three. Please pause the
video for a moment and compute these other
compositions. You should have found that in
every case, if you take f inverse of f of
a number, you get back to the very same number
you started with. And similarly, if you take
f of f inverse of any number, you get back
to the same number you started with. So in
general, f inverse of f of x is equal to x,
and f of f inverse of x is also equal to x.
This is the mathematical way of saying that
F and envir f inverse undo each other. Let's
look at a different example. Suppose that
f of x is x cubed. Pause the video for a moment
and guess what the inverse of f should be?
Remember, F inverse undoes the work that F
does. You might have guessed that f inverse
of x is going to be the cube root function.
And we can check that this is true by looking
at f of f inverse of x, that's F of the cube
root of function, which means the cube root
function cubed, which gets us back to x. Similarly,
if we compute f inverse of f of x, that's
the cube root of x cubed. And we get back
to excellence again. So the cube root function
really is the inverse of the cubing function.
When we compose the two functions, we get
back to the number that we started with. It'd
be nice to have a more systematic way of finding
inverses of functions besides guessing and
checking. One method uses the fact that inverses,
reverse the roles of y and x. So if we want
to find the inverse of the function, f of
x equals five minus x over 3x, we can write
it as y equals five minus x over 3x. Reverse
the roles of y and x to get x equals five
minus y over three y, and then solve for y.
To solve for y, let's multiply both sides
by three y. Bring all terms with wisened to
the left side, and alternans without y's and
then to the right side, factor out the y and
divide to isolate y. This gives us f inverse
of x as five over 3x plus one. Notice that
our original function f and our inverse function,
f inverse are both rational functions, but
they're not the reciprocals of each other.
And then General, f inverse of x is not usually
equal to one over f of x. This can be confusing,
because when we write two to the minus one,
that does mean one of our two, but f to the
minus one of x means the inverse function
and not the reciprocal. It's natural to ask
if all functions have inverse functions, that
is for any function you might encounter. Is
there always a function that it is its inverse?
In fact, the answer is no. See, if you can
come up with an example of a function that
does not have an inverse function. The word
function here is key. Remember that a function
is a relationship between x values and y values,
such that for each x value in the domain,
there's only one corresponding y value. One
example of a function that does not have an
inverse function is the function f of x equals
x squared. To see that, the inverse of this
function is not a function. Note that for
the x squared function, the number two and
the number negative two, both go to number
four. So if I had an inverse, he would have
to send four to both two and negative two.
The inverse would not be a function, it might
be easier to understand the problem, when
you look at a graph of y equals x squared.
Recall that inverse functions reverse the
roles of y and x and flip the graph over the
line y equals x. But when I flipped the green
graph over the line y equals x, I get this
red graph. This red graph is not the graph
of a function, because it violates the vertical
line test. The reason that violates the vertical
line test is because the original green function
violates the horizontal line test, and has
2x values with the same y value. In general,
a function f has an inverse function if and
only if the graph of f satisfies the horizontal
line test, ie every horizontal line intersects
the graph. In most one point, pause the video
for a moment and see which of these four graphs
satisfy the horizontal line test. In other
words, which of the four corresponding functions
would have an inverse function, you may have
found that graphs A and B, violate the horizontal
line test. So their functions would not have
inverse functions. But graph C and D satisfy
the horizontal line test. So these graphs
represent functions that do have inverses.
functions that satisfy the horizontal line
test are sometimes called One to One functions.
Equivalent way of function is one to one,
if for any two different x values, x one and
x two, the y value is f of x one and f of
x two are different numbers. Sometimes, as
I said, f is one to one, if, whenever f of
x one is equal to f of x two, then x one has
to equal x two. As our last example, let's
try to find P inverse of x, where p of x is
the square root of x minus two drawn here.
If we graph P inverse on the same axis as
p of x, we get the following graph, simply
by flipping over the line y equals x. If we
try to solve the problem, algebraically, we
can write y equal to a squared of x minus
two, reverse the roles of y and x and solve
for y by squaring both sides and adding two.
Now if we were to graph y equals x squared
plus two, that would look like a parabola,
it would look like the red graph was already
drawn together with another arm on the left
side. But we know that our actual inverse
function consists only of this right arm,
we can specify this algebraically by making
the restriction that x has to be bigger than
or equal to zero. This corresponds to the
fact that on the original graph, for the square
root of x, y was only greater than or equal
to zero. Looking more closely at the domain
and range of P and P inverse, we know that
the domain of P is all values of x such that
x minus two is greater than or equal to zero.
Since we can't take the square root of a negative
number. This corresponds to x values being
greater than or equal to two, or an interval
notation, the interval from two to infinity.
The range of P, we can see from the graph
is our y value is greater than or equal to
zero, or the interval from zero to infinity.
In fact, the answer is no. See, if you can
come up with an example of a function that
does not have an inverse function. The word
function here is key. Remember that a function
is a relationship between x values and y values,
such that for each x value in the domain,
there's only one corresponding y value. One
example of a function that does not have an
inverse function is the function f of x equals
x squared. To see that, the inverse of this
function is not a function. Note that for
the x squared function, the number two and
the number negative two, both go to number
four. So if I had an inverse, he would have
to send four to both two and negative two.
The inverse would not be a function, it might
be easier to understand the problem, when
you look at a graph of y equals x squared.
Recall that inverse functions reverse the
roles of y and x and flip the graph over the
line y equals x. But when I flipped the green
graph over the line y equals x, I get this
red graph. This red graph is not the graph
of a function, because it violates the vertical
line test. The reason that violates the vertical
line test is because the original green function
violates the horizontal line test, and has
2x values with the same y value. In general,
a function f has an inverse function if and
only if the graph of f satisfies the horizontal
line test, ie every horizontal line intersects
the graph. In most one point, pause the video
for a moment and see which of these four graphs
satisfy the horizontal line test. In other
words, which of the four corresponding functions
would have an inverse function, you may have
found that graphs A and B, violate the horizontal
line test. So their functions would not have
inverse functions. But graph C and D satisfy
the horizontal line test. So these graphs
represent functions that do have inverses.
functions that satisfy the horizontal line
test are sometimes called One to One functions.
Equivalent way of function is one to one,
if for any two different x values, x one and
x two, the y value is f of x one and f of
x two are different numbers. Sometimes, as
I said, f is one to one, if, whenever f of
x one is equal to f of x two, then x one has
to equal x two. As our last example, let's
try to find P inverse of x, where p of x is
the square root of x minus two drawn here.
If we graph P inverse on the same axis as
p of x, we get the following graph, simply
by flipping over the line y equals x. If we
try to solve the problem, algebraically, we
can write y equal to a squared of x minus
two, reverse the roles of y and x and solve
for y by squaring both sides and adding two.
Now if we were to graph y equals x squared
plus two, that would look like a parabola,
it would look like the red graph was already
drawn together with another arm on the left
side. But we know that our actual inverse
function consists only of this right arm,
we can specify this algebraically by making
the restriction that x has to be bigger than
or equal to zero. This corresponds to the
fact that on the original graph, for the square
root of x, y was only greater than or equal
to zero. Looking more closely at the domain
and range of P and P inverse, we know that
the domain of P is all values of x such that
x minus two is greater than or equal to zero.
Since we can't take the square root of a negative
number. This corresponds to x values being
greater than or equal to two, or an interval
notation, the interval from two to infinity.
The range of P, we can see from the graph
is our y value is greater than or equal to
zero, or the interval from zero to infinity.
Similarly, based on the graph, we see the
domain of P inverse is x values greater than
or equal to zero, the interval from zero to
infinity. And the range of P inverse is Y
values greater than or equal to two, or the
interval from two to infinity. If you look
closely at these domains and ranges, you'll
notice that the domain of P corresponds exactly
to the range of P inverse, and the range of
P corresponds to the domain of P inverse.
This makes sense because inverse functions
reverse the roles of y and x. The domain of
f inverse of x is the x values for F inverse,
which corresponds to the y values or the range
of F. The range of f inverse is the y values
for F inverse, which correspond to the x values
or the domain of f. In this video, we discussed
Similarly, based on the graph, we see the
domain of P inverse is x values greater than
or equal to zero, the interval from zero to
infinity. And the range of P inverse is Y
values greater than or equal to two, or the
interval from two to infinity. If you look
closely at these domains and ranges, you'll
notice that the domain of P corresponds exactly
to the range of P inverse, and the range of
P corresponds to the domain of P inverse.
This makes sense because inverse functions
reverse the roles of y and x. The domain of
f inverse of x is the x values for F inverse,
which corresponds to the y values or the range
of F. The range of f inverse is the y values
for F inverse, which correspond to the x values
or the domain of f. In this video, we discussed
five key properties of inverse functions.
inverse functions reverse the roles of y and
x. The graph of y equals f inverse of x is
the graph of y equals f of x reflected over
the line y equals x. When we compose F with
F inverse, we get the identity function y
equals x. And similarly, when we compose f
inverse with F, that brings x to x. In other
words, F and F inverse undo each other. The
function f of x has an inverse function if
and only if the graph of y equals f of x satisfies
the horizontal line test. And finally, the
domain of f is the range of f inverse. And
the range of f is the domain of f inverse.
These properties of inverse functions will
be important when we study exponential functions
and their inverses logarithmic functions.
This video defines the standard inverse trig
functions, sine inverse cosine inverse and
tan inverse. In this crazy looking graph,
please focus first on the thin black line.
This is a graph of y equals sine x. The graph
of the inverse of a function can be found
by flipping the graph of the original function
over the line y equals x. I've drawn the flipped
graph with this blue dotted line. But you'll
notice that the blue dotted line is not the
graph of a function, because it violates the
vertical line test. So in order to get a function,
that's the inverse of y equals sine x, we
need to restrict the domain of sine of x,
we'll restrict it to this piece that's drawn
with a thick black line. If I invert that
piece, by flipping it over the line y equals
x, I get the piece drawn with a red dotted
line here. And that piece does satisfy the
vertical line test. So it is in fact a function.
of the regular sine x has domain from negative
infinity to infinity, or restricted sine x
has domain from negative pi over two to pi
over two. It's it's range is still from negative
one to one, just like the regular sine x.
Because I've taken the biggest possible piece
of the graph whose flipped version is still
a function. The inverse sine function is often
written as arc sine of x. And since inverting
a function reverses the roles of y at x, it
reverses the domain and the range. So arc
sine of x, the inverse function has domain
from negative one to one, and range from negative
pi over two to pi over two, which seems plausible
from the graph. Now an inverse function undoes
the work of a function. So if the function
sine takes angle theta, two numbers, x, then
the inverse sine, or arc sine takes numbers
x, two angles theta. For example, since sine
of pi over two is one, arc sine of one is
pi over two. And in general, the output of
arc sine of x is the angle between negative
pi over two and pi over two whose side is
x. y is equal to arc sine x means that x is
equal to sine of y. But since there are many
angles, y who sine is x, right, they all differ
by multiples of two pi. We specify also, that
y is between negative pi over two and pi over
two. That was the whole point of doing this
domain restriction in order to get a well
defined inverse value. There's an alternate
notation for inverse sine. Sometimes it's
written as sine to the negative one of x.
But this notation can be confusing, so be
careful. In particular, sine to the negative
one of x does not equal one over sine of x.
One over sine of x the reciprocal function
is another word for cosecant The backs, but
sign to the negative one of x is another word
for arc sine of x, the inverse sine function,
which is not the same thing as the reciprocal
function. Let's go through the same process
to build an inverse cosine function, we start
with a graph of cosine of x, we flip it over
the line y equals x to get the blue dotted
line. But the blue dotted line is not a function.
So we go back and restrict the domain for
our original cosine of x to just be between
zero and pi. The resulting red graph now satisfies
the vertical line test. So it's a proper inverse
function. Our restricted cosine has domain
from zero to pi, and range from negative one
to one. And so our inverse function, arc cosine
has domain from negative one to one, and range
from zero to pi. Since cosine takes us from
angles to numbers, arc cosine takes us from
numbers back to angles. For example, cosine
of pi over four is the square root of two
over two. So arc cosine of the square root
of two over two is equal to pi over four.
arc cosine of x is the angle between zero
and pi, whose cosine is x. In other words,
y equals r cosine of x means that x is equal
to cosine of y, and y is between zero and
pi. Since otherwise, there'd be lots of possible
answers for an angle y whose cosine is x.
The alternative notation for arc cosine is
cosine inverse. And again, we have to be careful.
cosine to the negative 1x is not the same
thing as one over cosine of x. one over cosine
of x is also called secant of x. cosine to
the negative 1x means arc cosine, the inverse
function, and these two things are not the
same. Finally, let's look take a look at inverse
tangent function. Here's a graph of tangent
and black, these vertical lines aren't really
part of the function, they're just vertical
asymptotes. So in order to get actual function,
when we flip over the line y equals x, we
take just one piece of the tangent function.
Here we've taken the piece marked in black,
we flip that over the line y equals x, we
get this piece in red, which is actually a
function because it satisfies the vertical
line test. Now, you might ask, would it be
possible to pick a different piece of the
tangent function to invert? And the answer
is yes, we could do that. And on another planet,
maybe mathematicians do that. But on our planet,
we use the convention that we pick this piece
of tangent to invert, which is kind of a convenient
choice since it's centered here around the
origin. In the previous two examples, our
choice of restricted domain for sine and for
cosine was also a convention that led to a
conveniently defined inverse function. In
any case, based on our choice, our restricted
tan function has domain from negative pi over
two to pi over two. We don't include the endpoints
in that interval, because our restricted tan
function has vertical asymptotes, that negative
pi over two pi over two, so it's not defined
there. The range of our restricted tan function
is from negative infinity to infinity. Therefore,
arc tan of X has domain from negative infinity
to infinity and range from negative pi over
two to pi over two. Once again, tangent is
taking us from angles to numbers. So arc tan
is taking us from numbers to angles. For example,
tangent of pi over four is one, and therefore,
arc tan of one is pi over four. So arc tan
of x means the angle between negative pi over
two and pi over two whose tangent is x.
y is equal to arc tan x means that x is equal
to tangent of y and the Why is between negative
pi over two and pi over two. The inverse tan
function can also be written as 10 to the
minus one of x. And once again, tan inverse
of x means the inverse trig function, arc
tan of x. And it's not equal to one over tan
of x, which is called cotangent of x. And
that's all for this video on the three basic
inverse trig functions. sine inverse x, also
known as arc sine of x, cosine inverse x,
also known as arc cosine x, and tan inverse
x, also known as arc tan x. In this video,
we'll use implicit differentiation to find
the derivatives of the inverse trig functions.
First, the inverse sine function. Recall that
y equals sine inverse of x means that y is
the angle in radians whose sine is x. In other
words, we can write x equals sine of y as
an almost equivalent statements, I say almost
equivalent, because there are lots of different
y's whose side is x, lots of different angles
can have the same resulting side. And for
the inverse sine function, we specify that
that angle y has to be between pi over two
and negative pi over two, that's just the
convention. Be careful not to mistake sine
inverse of x, which is an inverse function,
and one over sine x, which is a reciprocal
function. These are not the same thing. This
negative one does not mean reciprocal here,
it means inverse function. There is another
notation for inverse sine, which is arc sine.
So arc sine of x is the same thing as sine
inverse of x, we want to find the derivative
of sine inverse of x, in other words, the
derivative of y with respect to x, where y
is sine inverse of x, I'm going to rewrite
this equation here as x equals sine y, and
then use implicit differentiation. So taking
the derivative of both sides with respect
to x, I have derivative of x is equal to the
derivative of sine y. In other words, one
is equal to cosine of y times dy dx. Solving
for dydx, I have that dydx is one over cosine
of y. Now I found the derivative, but it's
not in a super useful form, because there's
still a Y and expression, I'd rather have
it all in terms of x. Well, I could rewrite
this as dy dx is one over cosine of sine inverse
of x, since after all, y is equal to sine
inverse of x, but that's still not a super
useful form, because it's difficult to evaluate
this. So instead of doing this, I'm going
to look at a right triangle. I want to label
my triangle with y and x. Since y is my angle,
I'll put it here. And since sine of y is x,
and sine is opposite over hypotenuse, I can
label my opposite side with x and my hypothesis
with one. From this, I can figure out the
length of my remaining side, it's going to
have to be the square root of one minus x
squared by the Pythagorean Theorem. Now I
can compute cosine of y just from the triangle.
Cosine of y is adjacent overhype hotness,
so that's the square root of one minus x squared
over one, or just the square root of one minus
x squared. I've been implicitly assuming that
y is a positive angle between zero and pi
over two when I've been drawing this triangle,
but you can check that the same formula also
works. If y is a negative angle, think of
it going down here on the unit circle instead
of up here.
So now that I have a formula for cosine y
in terms of x, I can go back to my derivative
and substitute and I get dy dx is one over
the square root of one minus x squared. In
other words, I found a formula for With the
derivative of inverse sine of x, we can carry
out a similar process to find the derivative
of inverse cosine y equals cosine inverse
x means that x is equal to cosine of y. And
by convention, y lies between zero and pi.
To find the derivative of arc cosine of x,
arc cosine is just an alternative notation
for cosine inverse, I can write y equals arc
cosine of x, and equivalently x equals the
cosine of y. And then I want to find dydx.
Using implicit differentiation, please pause
the video and try it for yourself before going
on. So starting with the equation x equals
cosine y, we're going to take the derivative
of both sides with respect to x. The derivative
of x is one, and the derivative of cosine
y is negative sine y, dy dx. So d y dx is
equal to negative one over sine y. As before,
I can draw and label a right triangle, the
angle is y. And now I know that x is cosine
of y. So I'm going to put x on the adjacent
side and one on my partner's leaving the square
root of one minus x squared on the opposite
side, which means that sine of y, which is
opposite overhype hotness, is equal to the
square root of one minus x squared. And so
dy dx is going to be negative one over the
square root of one minus x squared. And I
have my formula for the derivative of arc
cosine of x. inverse tangent can be handled
very similarly. And again, you may want to
try it for yourself before watching the video.
Y equals inverse tangent of x means that x
is tangent of y. And the convention is that
y is supposed to lie between negative pi over
two and pi over two. Proceeding as before,
we write y equals our tan of x and x equals
tan of y, take the derivative of both sides.
So we get one equals secant squared of y d
y dx. Solving for dydx we have one over seacon
square root of y. And using our right triangle
as before, we can label the angle of as y.
Since I know that tangent y is x, and tangent
is opposite over adjacent, I'm going to label
the opposite side x and the adjacent side
one, which gives us a hypothesis of the square
root of one plus x squared. Now we know that
secant of y is one over cosine of y. So that's
going to be hi partners over adjacent. So
that's the square root of one plus x squared
over one. And so secant squared of y is just
the square of this, which is one plus x squared.
Now I can substitute into my formula for dy
dx, and I get dy dx is one over one plus x
squared, which gives me a nice formula for
the derivative of inverse tangent. The other
inverse trig functions cotesia inverse, seacon
inverse and cosequin inverse, have derivatives
that can be computed. Similarly, the following
table summarizes these results. In some books,
you may see absolute value signs around the
X for the formulas for inverse secant and
inverse cosecant. Of course, when x is positive,
this makes no difference. And when x is negative,
this discrepancy comes from differences in
the convention for the range of y for these
inverse trig functions seeking inverse and
cosecant numbers.
Notice that the derivatives of the inverse
trig functions that start with CO, all have
negative signs in front of them and are the
negatives of the corresponding inverse trig
functions without the CO that makes it easier
to remember them. You should memorize these
formulas. Let's do one example using the formulas
that we just found. Let's compute The derivative
of tan inverse of A plus x over a minus x,
we'll want to use the formula for the derivative
of tan inverse x. Now, to compute dydx, for
our function, we can use the chain rule, the
outside function is tan inverse, whose derivative
is one over one plus the inside function squared,
we'll need to multiply that by the derivative
of the inside function. I'll just copy over
the first part and take the derivative of
a plus x over a minus x using the quotient
rule. So I put the denominator on the bottom
and square it. And then I take low times d,
hi, the derivative of a plus x with respect
to x is just one minus high D low, the derivative
of a minus x with respect to x is negative
one. I'll simplify my numerator, a minus x,
the negative one and the negative sign here
cancel, so I get plus a plus x. On the denominator,
I have one plus a plus x squared over a minus
x squared, multiplied by a minus x squared.
canceling in the numerator, I get to a and
distributing and the denominator I get a minus
x squared plus a plus x squared. If I expand
out the denominator, the same simplifies to
two a over two A squared plus 2x squared,
or just a over a squared plus x squared, which
is a pretty nice derivative. So now you know
the derivatives of the inverse trig functions.
And you also know how to find them using implicit
differentiation, if you ever forget them.
When two or more quantities are related by
an equation, then their rates of change over
time are also related. That's the idea behind
related rates. And this video gives an example
of related rates involving distances. A tornado
is 20 miles west of us, heading due east towards
Phillips Hall at a rate of 40 miles per hour.
you hop on your bike and ride due south at
a speed of 12 miles per hour. How fast is
the distance between you and the tornado changing
after 15 minutes. In a related rates problem,
it's always a good idea to draw a picture
first, that can help you uncover the geometry
of the problem and see how quantities are
related. In this problem, we have a right
triangle. Because the tornadoes traveling
due east and the bicycles traveling due south
at right angles. Let's assign variables to
the quantities of interest. I'll call the
distance between the tornado and Phillips
Hall a. Although it starts at 20 miles, it
varies with time, and therefore it's a good
idea to assign it a letter a variable. I'll
use B to refer to the distance between Philips
Hall and the bicycle, a quantity that also
varies with time. And I'll let c stand for
the distance between the tornado and the bicycle.
The problem asks us to find how fast this
distance is changing. In other words, DC dt.
The next step is to write down equations that
relate the quantities of interest. In this
problem, we know by the Pythagorean Theorem,
that a squared plus b squared equals c squared.
We're interested in how fast the distance
between you and the tornado is changing. That's
a rate of change. And the rate at which the
bicycle is traveling and the tornado is moving.
These are also rates of change. In order to
work these rates of change into the problem,
I'm going to take the derivative of both sides
of this equation with respect to time. That's
the third step. So I'm going to take DDT of
a squared plus b squared. And that's equal
to DDT of C squared. Notice that I'm thinking
of a B and C as functions of T here, since
they vary over time, on the left side, I get
to a times dA DT using the chain rule,
plus two B DB dt. And on the right side, I
get to see DC dt. Now I can use the information
given to me in the problem to plug in numbers
and solve for the quantity of interest DC
DT since the tornado was moving at a rate
of 40 miles per hour The distance between
the tornado and Philip's Hall is decreasing
at 40 miles per hour. In other words, da dt
is negative 40. That negative sign is important
here, and comes from the fact that the distance
is decreasing. Since the bicycle is moving
at 12 miles per hour, the distance between
Philips Hall and the bicycle is increasing
at a rate of 12 miles per hour. So DBT is
positive 12. The quantity is a, b and c are
constantly changing. But at the time of interest,
t equals 15 minutes or in hours, 0.25 hours,
we can figure out what a B and C are. The
tornado is starts 20 miles away, but it's
moving at a rate of 40 miles per hour. So
after a quarter of an hour, it's gone 10 miles,
that means after a quarter of an hour, it's
only 10 miles away. And so at the time of
point two, five hours, a equals 10. The bike
is moving at 12 miles per hour. So after a
quarter of a mile, it's gone three miles.
And so at this time, b equals three. Now using
the same equation we started with, we can
plug in a and b and solve for C, we know that
c squared is going to be 10 squared plus three
squared. So C is going to be the square root
of 109. Plugging in the numbers into this
equation, we get two times 10 times negative
40 plus two times three times 12 equals two
times the square root of 109 times DC dt.
So DC dt is going to be negative 800 plus
72 over two times a squared of 109, which
is approximately negative 35. In other words,
the distance between the tornado and us is
decreasing at 35 miles per hour, the tornado
is gaining on us quickly.
These same steps will get you through a variety
of related rates problems. A couple of cautionary
notes. Don't plug in numbers to send. Any
quantities that vary with time should be written
as variables, so you can properly take the
derivative with respect to time. In addition,
be careful to use negative numbers for negative
rates of change. That is, for quantities that
are decreasing, we wouldn't have gotten the
right answer if we hadn't have used a negative
40 for the rate of change of the distance
here. In this video, we solved the related
rates problem, and found that riding a bicycle
may not be the best way to escape a tornado.
In this classic related rates problem, water's
flowing into a cone shaped tank, and we have
to figure out how fast the water is rising.
Water flows into a tank at a rate of three
cubic meters per minute, the tank is shaped
like a cone with a height of four meters,
and a radius of five meters at the top, we're
supposed to find the rate at which the water
level is rising in the tank. When the water
height is two meters. we've drawn our picture.
Now let's label some quantities of interest.
It's fine to use numbers for the quantities
that stay fixed throughout the problem. Like
the dimensions of the tank. For any quantities
that are varying with time, I need to use
letters variables to represent those quantities.
So the height of the water is varying throughout
the problem. I'll call that H. And it might
be handy to also talk about the radius of
the part of the cone that's filled with water.
I'll call that our ultimately I want to find
the rate at which the water level is rising.
So that's DHD T. Next, I want to write down
equations that relate the quantities of interest.
From geometry, I know that the volume of a
cone is 1/3 times the area of the base times
the height. So the volume of water in the
cone is going to be 1/3 times pi r squared
times h since h is the height of the piece
of the code that contains water. And pi r
squared is the area of that circular base
for that piece of account. I'm calling it
the base even though it's at the top. There's
one more equation that's going to be handy
here that comes from similar triangles. From
similar triangles, we know the ratio of sides
for the little triangle here is the same as
the ratio of sides for the big triangle. In
other words, we know that our over h is going
to be equal to five over four. I can use this
relationship to eliminate one of the variables
in this equation. Let's think for a minute
which one we want to eliminate. Since we're
ultimately interested in finding DHD T, we
need to keep the variable h in here. But since
we don't have any information about how are
you changing, it's a good idea to get rid
of the R. So let's solve for r here. And we
get r equals five fourths times h, and plug
that back into our volume equation. So we
get v equals 1/3 pi times five fourths h squared
times h. Or in other words, V equals 25/48
pi h cubed. Now we're gonna derive both sides
of the equation with respect to time t, to
get rates of change into the problem. Remember
that we're thinking of the volume of water
and the height of water as functions of time
t, we get dv dt equals 2548. It's pi times
three h squared DHD t. Now let's plug in numbers
and solve for the quantity of interest DHD
T. From our problem, we know that water's
flowing into the tank at a rate of three cubic
meters per minute. So dv dt is three, we're
asked to find the rate at which the water
level is rising when the water height is two
meters. So that's when h is two. Plugging
in those values and solving for a DHD T, we
get d h dt is equal to three divided by 2540.
It's pi times three times two squared, which
is 12 over 25 pi meters per second, are about
point one five meters per second.
This video solve the related rates problem
involving volume, and use the trick of finding
similar triangles to eliminate one variable.
In this video, we'll do a related rates problem
involving rotation and angles. a lighthouse
that's half a mile west of shore, has a rotating
light that makes two revolutions per minute
in the counterclockwise direction, the shore
runs north south, and there's a cave directly
east of the lighthouse. How fast is the beam
of light moving along the shore at a point
one mile north of the cave. we've drawn a
picture. Now let's label it with variables
for all the quantities that are changing with
time, the distance between the lighthouse
and the cave that's fixed. So we don't have
to put a variable for that. But the distance
between the cave and the point on the shore
where the light is hitting, that's varying.
So I'll call that say x. Since we want to
know how fast the beam of light is moving,
we're going to want to know how that distance
x is changing. In other words, we want to
calculate dx dt, when x is one. The high partners
of this right triangle made by the beam of
light is also changing with time as as the
angle here between the beam of light and the
East West line, I'll call that angle theta.
And the angle up here, I suppose is also changing
and call that fee. This angle is the right
angle between the East West line and the north
south line. So that doesn't change, it's always
90 degrees. Next, we want to write down equations
to relate the quantities of interest. Whenever
I see a right triangle in a problem, I'm tempted
to write down the Pythagorean theorem, which
in this case would say one half squared plus
x squared equals h squared. But in this particular
problem, it doesn't look like that's going
to help us much because of a tiger in theory
and would relate x and h. But we don't have
any information about how H is changing. The
only rate of change information given to us
is this two revolutions per minute. Two revolutions
per minute is indirectly telling us how this
angle theta is changing. Because if the light
beam is making two revolutions per minute,
then since they're two pi radians in a revolution,
that amounts to a change of four pi radians
per minute for the angle theta. Therefore
I'd really like to write down the equation
that has to do with theta and x. And from
trig, I know that tangent of theta is opposite
over adjacent. So I can write down tangent
theta equals x divided by one half. Or in
other words, tangent theta is 2x. This is
the equation that I need that relates x and
theta. Now I'm going to derive both sides
with respect to time t. And I get second squared
theta, d theta dt equals two times dx dt.
Next, I can plug in numbers and solve for
my quantity of interest, which is dx dt when
x equals one. We already figured out from
the two revolutions per minute, that d theta
dt is four pi. Now secant theta is one over
cosine theta. And since cosine theta is adjacent
ever had partners, it's reciprocal is high
partners over adjacent. So in our picture,
that gives us h over one half. Well, when
x equals one, H, is going to be the square
root of one squared plus a half squared by
the Pythagorean Theorem. And we'll divide
that by one half. And simplifying, we get
the square root of five fourths divided by
one half, which ends up as the square root
of five. So let's plug these values into our
equation involving derivatives. And we get
the square root of five squared per second
squared times four pi, four d theta dt
equals two times dx dt. Solving for dx dt,
we get dx dt is five times four pi divided
by two, or 10 pi. So what are the units here
on dx dt, since our distance has been in miles,
and our time is in minutes, this is 10 pi
miles per minute. If I want to convert this
to more standard units of miles per hour,
I can just multiply my 10 pi miles per minute
by 60 minutes per hour to get 600 pi miles
per hour. That works out to about 1885 miles
per hour, which is pretty darn fast. In this
related rates problem, we related rotations
per minute, to a change in angle per minute.
And we use the trig equation to relate angle
and side length. solving a right triangle
means finding the length of all the sides
and the measures of the angles given partial
information. In this example, we're given
the length of one side and the measure of
one angle, plus we know the measure of this
right angle is 90 degrees, we need to find
the measure of the third angle labeled capital
A, and the length of the two sides labeled
lowercase b and lowercase C. To find the measure
of angle A, let's use the fact that the measures
of the three angles of a triangle add up to
180 degrees. So that means that 49 degrees
plus 90 degrees plus a is equal to 180 degrees.
So A is equal to 180 degrees minus 90 degrees
minus 49 degrees, which works out to 41 degrees.
To find the length of the side D we have a
couple of possible options. We could use the
fact that tan of 49 degrees, which is opposite
over adjacent is B over 23. So b is 23 times
tan 49 degrees, which works out to 26.46 units.
Alternatively, we could use the fact that
tan of 41 degrees is 23 over b since now if
we're looking at the angle here 23 is our
opposite and B is an adjacent That's a little
bit harder to solve algebraically. But we
can write B tan 41 degrees equals 23, which
means that B is 23 divided by tan 41 degrees.
With a calculator that works out again to
26.46. The reason we want to use 10 in this
problem and not say sine or cosine is because
10 of say 49 degrees relates, and the unknown
side that we're looking for be to the side
that we know the measure of, if we had use
sine instead, would be saying that sine of
49 is B over C, and we'd have two unknowns,
which would make it difficult to solve. Next,
to find the side length C, we can have a few
options, we could use a trig function again,
for example, we could use the cosine of 49
degrees, that's adjacent over hypotenuse,
which is 23 oversee. Solving for C, we get
that C is 23 over cosine 49, which works out
to 35.06 units. Another option would be to
use the Pythagorean Theorem to find C. Since
we know 23 squared plus b squared equals c
squared. In other words, that's 23 squared
plus 26.46 squared equals c squared, which
means that C is the square root of that song,
which works out again, to 35.06. To review,
the ideas we used were, the sum of the angles
is equal to 180 degrees. We used facts like
tangent of an angle being opposite over adjacent
and similar facts about sine and cosine. And
we use the Pythagorean Theorem. This allowed
us to find all the angles and side lengths
of the triangle, knowing just the side length
of one side and the angle of one of the non
right angles to begin with. In this next example,
we don't know any of the angles except for
the right angle, but we know to have the side
lengths.
To find the unknown angle theta, we can use
the fact that cosine theta is adjacent overhype
hotness, so that's 10 over 15. Cosine is a
good trig function to use here, because this
equation relates our unknown angle to our
two known sides. So we just have one unknown
in our equation to solve for. To solve for
theta, we just take the cosine inverse of
10/15, which is 0.8411 radians, or 48.19 degrees.
To find the measure of angle fee, we could
use the fact that sine of fee is 10 over 15
and take sine inverse of 10/15. But probably
a little easier, let's just use the fact that
these three angles do 180 degrees. That tells
us that fee plus 90 plus 48.19 is equal to
180. Which means that fee is 41.81. Finally,
we can find x either using a trig function,
or by using the Pythagorean Theorem. To find
it using a trig function, we could write down
something like tan of 48.19 degrees is x over
10. To find that using the Tyrion theorem,
we'd write down 10 squared plus x squared
equals 15 squared. I'll use a Pythagorean
theorem and find the x by doing the square
root of 15 squared minus 10 squared. That
gives me an answer of 11.18. Notice that we
use many of the same ideas as in the previous
problem. For example, the fact that the sum
of the angles is 180. The Pythagorean theorem
and the trig functions like tan, sine and
cosine, we also use the inverse trig functions
to get from an equation like this one to the
angle. This video showed how it's possible
to find the length of all the sides of a right
triangle, and the measures of all the angles
given partial information. For example, the
measure of one angle and one side or from
two sides. This video gives some definitions
and facts related to maximum and minimum values.
functions. function f of x has an absolute
maximum at the x value of C. If f of c is
greater than or equal to f of x for all x
in the domain of f. The point with x&y coordinates
of C FRC is called an absolute maximum point.
And the y value f of c is called the absolute
maximum value. Now, if I draw a graph of f,
the y value f of c is the highest value that
that function ever achieves. And an absolute
maximum point is just a point where it achieves
that maximum value. Now, it's possible for
a function to have more than one absolute
maximum point, if there happens to be a tie
for the highest value. But a function has
at most one absolute maximum value. A function
f of x has an absolute minimum that x equals
C, if f of c is less than or equal to f of
x, for all x in the domain of f. In this case,
the point c f of c is called an absolute minimum
point. And the y value f of c is called the
absolute minimum value. In the graph of f
of x, f of c is now the lowest point that
the function achieves anywhere on its domain,
and C SOC, are the coordinates of a point
where the function achieves that minimum value.
For example, this function has an absolute
minimum value of about negative eight has
an absolute minimum point with coordinates
three, negative eight. If this function stops
here, and just has a domain from zero to four,
then the function has an absolute maximum
value of 10 at the absolute maximum point
with coordinates for 10. If however, the function
keeps going in this direction, it will not
have an absolute maximum value at all. absolute
maximum and minimum values can also be called
global maximum and minimum values.
In addition to absolute maximum mins, we can
talk about local maximums. So a function f
of x has a local maximum at x equals C. If
f of c is greater than or equal to f of x,
for all x, near C. By near C, we mean there's
some open interval around C for which this
was true. For our graph of f, we have a local
maximum right here. Even though it's not the
highest point anywhere around since there's
a higher point up here, this is the highest
point in an open interval around see the point
C FFC is called a local maximum point. And
the y value f FC is called a local maximum
value. Similarly, a function f of x has a
local minimum at x equals C, if f of c is
less than or equal to f of x for all x, near
C. And the point c f of c is called a local
minimum point. And the y value f of c is called
a local minimum value. A function might have
many local minimum values. In this example,
assuming that the domain is zero to four,
we have a local minimum point right here.
Because it's the lowest point anywhere nearby.
It also happens to be an absolute minimum
point. Now turning our attention to local
maximums, we have a local maximum point right
here with coordinates about one two. Since
f of one is as high or higher than f of x
for any x value in an open interval around
one. In this example, the absolute maximum
point of 410 does not count as a local maximum
point. Simply because we can't take an open
interval on both sides of for the function
doesn't exist on the right side. And so for
that sort of technical reason, we end up with
an absolute maximum point That's not a local
maximum point here. local maximum and minimum
values can also be called relative maximum
and minimum values. Please take a look at
this graph and pause the video for a moment
to mark all local maximum minimum points,
as well as all global, that is absolute maximum
points. See if you can find the absolute maximum
value and the absolute minimum value for the
function. I'm going to mark the local maximum
points in green, and the absolute maximum
points in red. The function definitely has
a local men
here. Since this is the lowest point anywhere
nearby and then open interval, and there's
a local max point here. There's also a local
min point here, where the function also hits
a low point and open interval. But that local
man is also an absolute man. So I'll mark
it half green and half red. There's also a
local min point here at the point three, two,
since this point is the as low or lower than
any point in an open interval. And the function
is defined in an open interval around three,
even though it's discontinuous there. In fact,
this point is tied for local minimum, with
all the points on this interval here, between
two and three, there are as low or lower than
all points in an open interval around them.
The point 04 doesn't count as a local max,
because the function is not defined on the
other side of zero. So there's no open interval
to to consider. This point is also not an
absolute maximum because the function gets
higher over here. In fact, as long as this
trend continues, the function f of x has no
absolute maximum value at all, because its
values just keep getting higher and higher
as x goes off to infinity. There's one more
point that I want to consider. And that's
this point here, at three, three and a half.
Well, it's tempting to say that f has a local
maximum here, it looks like it's the highest
point in the ground. But in fact, there is
no point here at three 3.5. Right, the functions
value at three is actually down here, too.
So there's no point here to be a local maximum
point. And if you start looking at points
really close to that point, those aren't local
maximums either, because you can always find
a point just a little bit higher as you get
closer and closer, but don't quite reach this
missing point of three 3.5. So we have all
the absolute and local maximum points marked.
And now to find the absolute maximum value.
Well, we just said that there is none. But
the absolute minimum value is the y value
of this absolute minimum point here. So I'd
say that's about 0.5. Here I've drawn the
graph of a function. What do you notice about
the derivative of this function at its local
maximum and minimum points, please pause the
video and think about it. Well, the local
maximum minimum points are here, here and
here. And at two of those points, the derivative
f prime of c equals zero. And that the third
point, f prime of c does not exist, because
the function has a corner. A number c is called
a critical number for a function f if f prime
of c does not exist, or f prime of c exists
and equals zero. So in other words, all of
these local maximum minimum points for this
example, they're all critical points. And
this is true in general, if f has a local
max or min at C, then C must be a critical
number for F. We also say that the point c
f of c is a critical point for F. It's important
not to read too much into this statement.
The statement says that if f has a local max
or man at C then C must be a critical number.
But the converse doesn't hold. In other words,
if c is a critical number, then f may or may
not have a local max or men at sea. One example
to keep in mind is the function f of x equals
x cubed at a value of C of zero. Since f prime
of x is 3x squared, we have that f prime of
zero equals zero. So zero is a critical number.
But notice that F does not have a local maximum
man at x equals zero.
In this video, we defined absolute and local,
maximum and minimums. We also defined critical
numbers, which are numbers c, where f prime
of c equals zero, or f prime of c does not
exist. We noted that if f has a local max
or min at C, then C is a critical number.
But not necessarily advice. In this video,
we'll see how the first derivative and the
second derivative can help us find local maximums
and local minimums for a function. Recall
that f of x has a local maximum at x equals
C. If f of c is greater than or equal to f
of x, for all x, in an open interval around
C, F of X has a local minimum at x equals
C. If f of c is less than or equal to f of
x, for all x, in an open interval around C.
In this example, the function f has a local
maximum at x equals six at x equals 11. And
a local minimum at x equals about 10. We've
seen before that if f has a local max or local
min at x equals C, then f prime of c is equal
to zero or it does not exist. Number C at
which f prime of c is zero or does not exist,
are called critical numbers. But you have
to be careful, because it is possible for
F to have a critical number at C. That is
a place where if privacy is equal to zero,
or does not exist, but not have a local max,
or min at x equals C. In fact, this happens
in the graph above, at x equals two, since
f prime of two is zero, but there's no local
max or min there. Please pause the video for
a moment and try to figure out what's different
about the derivative of f in the vicinity
of x equals two, where there's no local max
or min, and in the vicinity of x equals 610
and 11 where there are local maxes and mins.
Near the critical point at x equals two, the
derivative is positive on the left and positive
again on the right. But near the local maximums,
the derivative is positive on the left and
negative on the right. And near the local
minimum, the derivative is negative on the
left and positive on the right. These observations
help motivate the first derivative test for
finding local maximums and minimums. The first
derivative test says that if f is a continuous
function near x equals C, and if c is a critical
number, then we can decide if f has a local
maximum or minimum at x equals c by looking
at the first derivative near x equals C. More
specifically, if we know that f prime of x
is positive for x less than c, and negative
for x greater than c, then our function looks
something like this. Or maybe like this, your
x equals C, and so we have a local max at
x equals C. If on the other hand, f prime
of x is negative for x less than c, and positive
for x greater than c, then our function looks
something like this. Or maybe like this, your
x equals C and so we have local men at x equals
see. If our first derivative is positive on
both sides of C or negative on both sides
of C, then we do not have a look All extreme
point at all at x equals C. Instead, our graph
might look something like this, or maybe like
this. The first derivative test is great,
because it lets us locate local extreme points
just by looking at the first derivative. The
second derivative test gives us an alternative
for finding local maximum points by using
the second derivative. Specifically, the second
derivative test tells us that if f is continuous
near x equals C, then if f prime of c is equal
to zero, and f double prime of c is greater
than zero,
then f has a local min at x equals C. If on
the other hand, f prime of c equals zero,
and f double prime of c is less than zero,
then f has a local max at x equals C. Note
that if f double prime of c is equal to zero,
or does not exist, then the second derivative
test is inconclusive. We might have a local
max or a local man at x equals C, or we might
not. So we'd have to use a different method
like the first derivative test to find out.
In this video, we introduced the first derivative
test and the second derivative test, which
allow us to determine if a function has a
local minimum or a local maximum at a certain
value of x. In this video, I'll work through
two examples of finding extreme values, that
is, maximum values and minimum values of functions.
In the first example, we're asked to find
the absolute maximum and minimum values for
this rational function g of x on the interval
from zero to four, these maximum and minimum
values could occur at critical numbers in
the interior of the interval, or they could
occur at the endpoints of the interval. So
we'll need to check the critical numbers,
and check the endpoints and compare our values.
To find the critical numbers, those are the
numbers where g prime of x is equal to zero
or does not exist. So let's take the derivative
g prime of x using the quotient rule. So we
get x squared plus x plus two squared on the
denominator, and then we have low times d
high, the derivative of the numerator is one
minus high times the derivative of the denominator,
that's 2x plus one. Before we figure out where
that zero or doesn't exist, let's simplify
it a little bit. So we can multiply out the
numerator. I'll distribute the negative sign.
And I'll add together like terms in the numerator,
I'm just leaving the denominator alone on
all these steps. So our simplified numerator
is going to be minus x squared plus 2x plus
three. Now that I've simplified the derivative,
I can figure out where it's equal to zero
and where it doesn't exist. Let me clear a
little space. Now the only way that g prime
of x could not exist, is if the denominator
is zero. But on our interval, where x is between
zero and 4x squared plus x plus two is always
greater than or equal to two. So the denominator
is never zero on this interval. In fact, it
turns out that x squared plus x plus two is
never zero, even if we look outside this interval.
And you can check that if you want to use
the quadratic formula. But in any case, we
don't have to worry about the places where
g prime of x does not exist. So we only have
to worry where g prime of x is equal to zero.
To find where g prime of x is equal to zero,
we just have to check where the numerator
is equal to zero. So I'll set negative x squared
plus 2x plus three equal to zero and multiply
both sides there by negative one and a factor
I get that x equals three or x equals minus
one. So these are my critical numbers. But
notice that one of these critical numbers
negative one doesn't even lie within my interval,
so I don't have to worry about it. All I have
to worry about is x equals 3x equals three
is one place where my function g could have
an absolute maximum or minimum. So let's figure
out G's value there by plugging in three for
x that evaluates to to 14th, or one set So
we've checked the critical numbers. Now let's
go ahead and check the endpoints. Those are
the point the x values of zero, and four,
since our interval is from zero to four. Plugging
in, we get that g of zero is negative one
half, and g of four is 320 seconds. I sometimes
like to make a table of all these candidate
values.
The candidate x values are 03, and four and
the corresponding g of x values we found were
negative a half 1/7, and 320 seconds. Now
to find the absolute maximum and minimum values,
all I have to do is figure out which one of
these y values is the biggest and which is
the smallest. Well, clearly negative one half
is a smallest, so that's the absolute minimum
value. And we just need to compare 1/7 and
320 seconds to see which is bigger. Now, 1/7
is the same as 320 firsts, which is going
to be bigger than 320 seconds. So one half
1/7 is our absolute max value. We can confirm
this by looking at a graph of our function
g. Remember, we're just interested in the
interval from zero to four. So we're just
interested in this section of the graph. And
it does look like the minimum value is here
at when x equals zero minimum value of negative
one half like we found, and the maximum value.
Well, I'm not sure exactly where it is from
this graph, but it does look like it's somewhere
around three. And that is a value of something
around 1/7. So the graph does confirm what
we found as a more precise answer using calculus.
For the next example, let's find the absolute
extreme values for the function f of x, which
is the absolute value of x minus x squared,
on the interval from negative two to two.
As before, we can find absolute extreme values
by checking first the critical numbers, and
then also the endpoints of the interval negative
two and two. To find the critical numbers,
we need to take the derivative of our function.
But because our function involves the absolute
value, it's a little tricky to take the derivative.
Instead, let's first rewrite f using piecewise
notation. Recall that, if we're looking at
the absolute value of x, when x is bigger
than or equal to zero, absolute value of x
is just x. So f of x will be x minus x squared.
On the other hand, when x is less than zero,
the absolute value of x is negative x. So
f of x will be negative x minus x squared.
Now to take the derivative, we can take the
derivative of each piece. So when x is bigger
than zero, I don't want to take the derivative
when x equals zero, because there might be
funny things happening, you know, a cost per
corner, so I'm just gonna worry about when
x is bigger than zero, and when x is less
than zero, for now, when x is bigger than
zero, I can just use the power rule I get
one minus 2x is the derivative when x is less
than zero, I get negative one minus 2x. And
now to find where I have critical numbers,
I need to find where f prime of x is equal
to zero, or f prime of x does not exist. Well,
f prime of x equals zero, where one minus
2x equals zero for x bigger than zero. And
where one, negative one minus 2x is equal
to zero for x less than zero. So that corresponds
to x equal one half for x bigger than zero,
and x equals negative one half for x less
than zero. So those are my first two critical
numbers. And that is they do lie within my
interval that I'm interested in. But I also
have to worry about where f prime of x does
not exist. And the candidate x value for that
is where x equals 01 way to convince ourselves
the derivative does not exist when x equals
zero is to look at the fact that the derivative
is very close to one for x values, very close
to zero from the right side and very close
to negative one for x values from the left
side. So the graph of the function is going
to have to be sloping down with a slope near
negative one for x less than zero and up with
a slope near one for x greater than zero,
and so it'll end up having a cost per corner
there.
Also notice that even if I weren't 100% sure
that the derivative didn't exist at x equals
zero, it's not going to hurt to consider this
x equals zero as a possible additional candidate
for the absolute max or min value. So I've
got my three critical numbers, and my end
points are just going to be x equals negative
two and x equals two. So let me make a chart
of values my x values to consider are negative
two, negative one half 01, half and positive
two, and my corresponding f of x values are
going to be, let's say absolute value of negative
two minus negative two squared works out to
two minus four, which is negative two, I plug
in negative one half, I get one half minus
1/4, which is 1/4. plug in zero, I get zero.
and plugging in one half, I get 1/4. And plugging
in two, I get negative two again. So now my
biggest value is going to be 1/4. So that's
my absolute max value, and my smallest value
is going to be negative two. So that's my
absolute min value, I can confirm what I found
looking at the graph. So here I've graphed
my function, y equals absolute value of x
minus x squared on the interval from negative
two to two. And I can see indeed, that my
absolute min is going to be a value of negative
two, it occurs at two absolute minimum points,
and my absolute maximum is going to be a value
of about 1/4. And that occurs at two absolute
maximum points. And that concludes this video
on finding extreme values. the mean value
theorem relates the average rate of change
of a function on an interval to its instantaneous
rate of change, or derivative. Let's assume
that f is a function defined on a closed interval
a, b, and maybe defined in some other places
to let's assume that f is continuous on the
whole closed interval. And that is differentiable
on the interior of the interval, then the
mean value theorem says that there must be
some number c in the interval a, b, such that
the average rate of change of f on a B is
equal to the derivative of f at C. In symbols,
we can write the average rate of change as
f of b minus F of A over B minus A. And that
has to equal f prime at C for some number
C. On the graph, the average rate of change
of f is the slope of the secant line. And
so the mean value theorem says that there's
some number c, somewhere in between a and
b, so that the slope of the secant line is
exactly the same as the slope of the tangent
line at that x value of C. The number c is
not necessarily unique. So I encourage you
to pause the video and see if you can draw
a graph of a function where there's more than
one c value that works. So you might have
drawn something maybe like this. Now, if we
draw our secant line, there's two values of
c, where the slope of the tangent line is
equal to the slope of the secant line. In
this example, we're asked to verify the mean
value theorem for a particular function on
a particular interval. Verify means that we
need to check the hypotheses of the theorem
hold. And also the the conclusion holds. The
hypotheses are that f is continuous on the
closed interval, one three, and that is differentiable
on that interior of that interval. Both of
these facts are true, because f is a polynomial.
Now we need to verify that the conclusion
of the mean value theorem holds. In other
words, we need to find a number c in the interval
one, three, such that the derivative of f
at C is equal to the average rate of change
of f on the interval from one to three.
Now f prime of x is 6x squared minus eight.
So f prime at any number c is just six c squared
minus eight. We can also compute f of three
just by plugging in and get 31 and f of one
is negative five. Plugging in these values
into our equation, we get that six c squared
minus eight has to equal 31 minus negative
five over To, in other words, six c squared
minus eight had better equal 18, which means
that six c squared needs to equal 24. So C
squared has to equal four, which means that
C has to equal plus or minus two. Since negative
two is not in the interval from one to three,
we're left with a c value of positive two.
So C equals two is the number we're looking
for. And at C equals to f prime is equal to
18, which is the average rate of change of
f on the interval. we've verified the mean
value theorem. In this example, we're told
that f of one is seven, and that the derivative
of f is bounded between negative three and
negative two. On the interval one six, we're
asked to find the biggest and smallest values
that f of six could possibly be. Well, the
mean value theorem gives us one way of relating
the derivative of the function to its values
on the endpoints of the interval. More specifically,
the mean value theorem tells us that the average
rate of change F of six minus f of one over
six minus one is equal to the derivative f
prime of c, for some C, in the interval, one,
six. Since the derivative is bounded between
negative three and negative two, we know that
the average rate of change is bounded between
negative three and negative two. We know that
f of one is seven. And now we can solve this
inequality for f of six. Multiply the inequality
by five and add seven. And now we can see
that negative eight is the smallest possible
value for F six and negative three is the
largest possible roles, there is an important
special case of the mean value theorem. If
f is a function defined on the closed interval
a b, and f of x is continuous on that whole
closed interval, differentiable on the interior
of the interval. And if f of a is equal to
f
of b,
then there's a number c in the interval a,
b, such that f prime of c is zero. If we look
at a graph of such a function that has equal
values at a, and at B, we can see where its
derivative has to be zero at a maximum, or
a minimum in between A and B. To see why the
rolls there is a special case of the mean
value theorem. Think about what the mean value
theorem would say about this function, it
would say there is a C, such that f prime
of c is equal to the average rate of change
of the function. But since f of b and F of
A are the same, by our assumption, this average
rate of change is just zero. And so the mean
value theorem, its conclusion is that there's
a C, such that f prime of c equals zero, which
is exactly the conclusion of rules theorem.
In this video, we saw that for a function
that's continuous on a closed interval, and
differentiable on the interior of that interval,
the average rate of change of the function
is equal to the instantaneous rate of change
of the function, f prime of c for some C in
the interval. This video gives two proofs
of the mean value theorem for integrals. the
mean value theorem for integrals says that
for continuous function f of x, defined on
interval from a to b, there's some number
c between A and B, such that f of c is equal
to the average value of f. The first proof
that I'm going to give uses the intermediate
value theorem. Recall that the intermediate
value theorem says that if we have a continuous
function f defined on an interval, which I'll
call x 1x, two, if we have some number l in
between, f of x one and f of x two, then f
has to achieve the value l somewhere between
x one and x two. Keeping in mind the intermediate
value theorem, let's turn our attention back
to the mean value theorem for integrals. Now,
it's possible that our function f of x might
be constant on the interval from a to b. But
if that's true, then our mean value theorem
for integrals holds easily, because f AV is
just equal to that constant, which is equal
to f of c for any c between A and B. So let's
assume that f is not constant, will it continue
continuous function on a closed interval has
to have a minimum value and a maximum value,
which I'll call little m, and big M. Now,
we know that F's average value on the interval
has to be between its maximum value and its
minimum value. If you don't believe this,
consider the fact that all of F's values on
the interval have to lie between big M and
little m. And if we integrate this inequality,
we get little m times b minus a is less than
or equal to the integral of f is less than
or equal to big M times b minus a. Notice
that the first and the last integrals, were
just integrating a constant. Now if I divide
all three sides by b minus a, I can see that
little m is less than or equal to the average
value of f is less than or equal to big M
as I wanted. Now, I just need to apply the
intermediate value theorem with F's average
as my number L and little m and big M as my
values of f of x one and f of x two. The intermediate
value theorem says that F average is achieved
by f of c for some C in between my x one and
x two. And therefore, for some C in my interval
a b. And that proves the mean value theorem
for integrals. Now I'm going to give a second
proof for the mean value theorem for integrals.
And this time, it's going to be as a corollary
to the regular mean value theorem for functions.
Recall that the mean value theorem for functions,
says that if g of x is continuous on a closed
interval,
and differentiable on the interior of that
interval, then there's some number c in the
interval, such that the derivative of g at
C is equal to the average rate of change of
G, across the whole interval from a to b.
Let's keep the mean value theorem for functions
in mind, and turn our attention back to the
mean value theorem for integrals. I'm going
to define a function g of x to be the integral
from a to x of f of t dt, where F is the function
given to us in the statement of the mean value
theorem for integrals. Notice that g of A
is just the integral from a to a, which is
zero, while g of B is the integral from a
to b of our function. Now, by the fundamental
theorem of calculus, our function g of x is
continuous and differentiable on the interval
a, b, and g prime of x is equal to f of x.
And by the mean value theorem for functions,
we know that g prime of c has to equal g of
b minus g of a over b minus a, for some numbers,
C and the interval a b, if we substitute in
the three facts above, into our equation below,
we get f of c is equal to the integral from
a to b of f of t dt minus zero over b minus
a, which is exactly the conclusion that we
wanted to reach. This shows that the mean
value theorem for integrals really is the
mean value theorem for functions where our
function is an integral. And this completes
the second proof of the main value theorem
for integrals. So now I've proved the mean
value theorem for integrals in two different
ways. And I've used a lot of the great theorems
of calculus along the way in this video, We'll
solve inequalities involving polynomials like
this one, and inequalities involving rational
expressions like this one. Let's start with
a simple example, maybe a deceptively simple
example, if you see the inequality, x squared
is less than four, you might be very tempted
to take the square root of both sides and
get something like x is less than two as your
answer. But in fact, that doesn't work. To
see why it's not correct, consider the x value
of negative 10. Negative 10 satisfies the
inequality, x is less than two, since negative
10 is less than two. But it doesn't satisfy
the inequality x squared is less than four,
since negative 10 squared is 100, which is
not less than four. So these two inequalities
are not the same. And it doesn't work to solve
a quadratic inequality just to take the square
root of both sides, you might be thinking
part of why this reasoning is wrong, as we've
ignored the negative two option, right? If
we had the equation, x squared equals four,
then x equals two would just be one option,
x equals negative two would be another solution.
So somehow, our solution to this inequality
should take this into account. In fact, a
good way to solve an inequality involving
x squares or higher power terms, is to solve
the associated equation first. But before
we even do that, I like to pull everything
over to one side, so that my inequality has
zero on the other side. So for our equation,
I'll subtract four from both sides to get
x squared minus four is less than zero. Now,
I'm going to actually solve the associated
equation, x squared minus four is equal to
zero, I can do this by factoring 2x minus
two times x plus two is equal to zero. And
I'll set my factors equal to zero, and I get
x equals two and x equals minus two. Now,
I'm going to plot the solutions to my equation
on the number line. So I write down negative
two and two, those are the places where my
expression x squared minus four is equal to
zero.
Since I want to find where x squared minus
four is less than zero, I want to know whether
this expression x squared minus four is positive
or negative, a good way to find that out is
to plug in test values. So first, I plug in
a test value in this area, the number line,
something less than negative two, say x equals
negative three. If I plug in negative three
into x squared minus four, I get negative
three squared minus four, which is nine minus
four, which is five, that's a positive number.
So at negative three, the expression, x squared
minus four is positive. And in fact, everywhere
on this region of the number line, my expression
is going to be positive, because it can jump
from positive to negative, without going through
a place where it's zero, I can figure out
whether x squared minus four is positive or
negative on this region, and on this region
of the number line by plugging in test value
similar way, evaluate the plug in between
negative two and two, a nice value is x equals
00 squared minus four, that's negative four
and negative number. So I know that my expression
x squared minus four is negative on this whole
interval. Finally, I can plug in something
like x equals 10, something bigger than two,
and I get 10 squared minus four. Without even
computing that I can tell that that's going
to be a positive number. And that's all that's
important. Again, since I want x squared minus
four to be less than zero, I'm looking for
the places on this number line where I'm getting
negatives. So I will share that in on my number
line. It's in here, not including the endpoints,
because the endpoints are where my expression
x squared minus four is equal to zero and
I want it strictly less than zero, I can write
my answer. As an inequality, negative two
is less than x is less than two, or an interval
notation as soft bracket negative two, two
soft bracket. Our next example, we can solve
similarly, first, we'll move everything to
one side so that our inequality is x cubed
minus 5x squared minus 6x is greater than
or equal to zero. Next, we'll solve the associated
equation by factoring. So first, I'll write
down the equation. Now I'll factor out an
x. And now I'll factor the quadratic. So the
solutions to my equation are x equals 0x equals
six and x e equals negative one, I'll write
the solutions to the equation on the number
line. So that's negative one, zero, and six.
That's where my expression x times x minus
six times x plus one is equal to zero. But
I want to find where it's greater than or
equal to zero. So again, I can use test values,
I can plug in, for example, x equals negative
two, either to this version of expression,
or to this factored version. Since I only
care whether my answer is positive or negative,
it's sometimes easier to use the factored
version. For example, when x is negative two,
this factor is negative. But this factor,
x minus six is also negative when I plug in
negative two for x. Finally, x plus one, when
I plug in negative two for x, that's negative
one, that's also negative. And a negative
times a negative times a negative gives me
a negative number. If I plug in something
between negative one and zero, say x equals
negative one half, then I'm going to get a
negative for this factor, a negative for this
factor, but a positive for this third factor.
Negative times negative times positive gives
me a positive for a test value between zero
and six, let's try x equals one. Now I'll
get a positive for this factor a negative
for this factor, and a positive for this factor.
positive times a negative times a positive
gives me a negative. Finally, for a test value
bigger than six, we could use a x equals 100,
that's going to give me positive positive
positive. So my product will be positive.
Since I want values where my expression is
greater than or equal to zero, I want the
places where n equals zero. And the places
where it's positive. So my final answer will
be close bracket negative one to zero, close
bracket union, close bracket six to infinity.
As our final example, let's consider the rational
inequality, x squared plus 6x plus nine divided
by x minus one is less than or equal to zero.
Although it might be tempting to clear the
denominator and multiply both sides by x minus
one, it's dangerous to do that, because x
minus one could be a positive number. But
it could also be a negative number. And when
you multiply both sides by a negative number,
you have to reverse the inequality. Although
it's possible to solve the inequality this
way, by thinking of cases where x minus one
is less than zero or bigger than zero, I think
it's much easier just to solve the same way
as we did before. So we'll start by rewriting
so that we move all terms to the left and
have zero on the right, well, that's already
true. So the next step would be to solve the
associated equation. That is x squared plus
6x plus nine over x minus one is equal to
zero. That would be where the numerators 0x
squared plus 6x plus nine is equal to zero,
so we're x plus three squared is zero, or
x equals negative three, there's one extra
step we have to do for rational expressions.
And that's we need to find where the expression
does not exist. That is, let's find where
the denominator is zero. And that said, x
equals one. I'll put all those numbers on
the number line, the places where my rational
expression is equal to zero, and the place
where my rational expression doesn't exist,
then I can start in with test values. For
example, x equals minus four, zero and two
work. If I plug those values into this expression
here, I get a negative answer, a negative
answer and a positive answer. The reason I
need to conclude the values on my number line
where my denominator is zero is because I
can my expression can switch from negative
to positive by passing through a place where
my rational expression doesn't exist, as well
as passing by passing flew to a place where
my rational expression is equal to zero. Now
I'm looking for where my original expression
was less than or equal to zero. So that means
I want the places on the number line where
my expression is equal to zero, and also the
places where it's negative. So My final answer
is x is less than one, or an interval notation,
negative infinity to one. In this video, we
solved polynomial and rational inequalities
by making a number line. And using test values
to make a sign chart. The first and second
derivative of a function can tell us a lot
about the shape of the graph of the function.
In this video, we'll see what f prime and
f double prime can tell us about where the
function is increasing and decreasing, is
concave up and concave down and has inflection
points. We say that a function is increasing.
If f of x one is less than f of x two, whenever
x one is less than x two. In other words,
the graph of the function goes up. As x increases
from left to right, we say the function f
is decreasing. If f of x one is greater than
f of f two, whenever x one is less than x
two. In other words, the height of the function
goes down as we move from left to right. In
this graph, it's a little hard to say what's
happening when x is near two, is it completely
horizontal, or is the graph slightly increasing?
If we assume it's slightly increasing, then,
in this example, f of x is increasing as x
ranges from zero to six, and again as x ranges
from 10 to 11. The graph is decreasing for
x values between six and 10. And for x values
between 11 and 12, the first derivative of
f can tell us where the function is increasing
and decreasing. In particular, if f prime
of x is greater than zero for all x on an
interval, then f is increasing on this interval.
This makes sense, because f prime being greater
than zero means the tangent line has positive
slope. Similarly, if f prime of x is less
than zero for all excellent interval, then
f is decreasing on this interval. That's because
a negative derivative means the tangent line
has a negative slope.
A precise proof of these facts can be found
in the textbook, or in another video, we say
that a function is concave up on an interval
from a to b. If informally, it looks like
a bowl that could hold water on that interval.
More formally, the function is concave up
on that interval. If all the tangent lines
for the function on that interval, lie below
the graph of the function. The function is
concave down on the interval from a to b.
If informally, it looks like an upside down
ball that would spill water on that interval.
Or more formally, the function is concave
down. If all the tangent lines lie above the
graph of the function on an interval. In this
example, f is concave up around here. And
again around here. On the left piece, it looks
like part of a ball that could hold water.
So we can say that f is concave up on the
intervals from two to four, and the interval
from eight to 11. f is concave down on this
piece, and this piece and this piece, so we
can say that f is concave down on the interval
from zero to two, from four to eight, and
from 11 to 12. The concavity of a function
is related to its second derivative. Here,
where the function is concave up, its derivative
is going from essentially zero to larger positive
values. So the first road was increasing,
which means the second derivative is positive.
On this section of the graph, which is also
concave up, the driven is going from negative
values to zero. That's an increase in the
first derivative. So that means the second
derivative here must be positive. And in this
piece, where the first term is going from
zero to positive values, the first derivative
is also increasing, so the second derivative
is also positive. On the parts of the function
that are concave down, we can see that in
this example, the second derivative is negative.
Here, the first derivative is going from positive
towards zero, that's a decrease in the first
derivative or a negative second derivative.
Here the first derivative is going from positive
to zero to negative, that's also a decreasing
first derivative or a negative second derivative.
And the same thing happens on this section
here. In general, we can use the second derivative
to predict the concavity of a function. The
concavity test says that if the second derivative
is positive for all x on an interval, then
the function f is concave up on that interval.
Similarly, if the second derivative is negative
for all x on the interval, then the function
f is concave down on that interval. One way
to remember the concavity test is that a positive
second derivative gives us a happy face. So
the smile is supposed to be a concave up function.
And a negative second derivative gives us
a sad face where the smile or the frown, I
guess, is a concave down function. Next, let's
talk about inflection points. A function has
an inflection point at x equals C, if it's
continuous at C, and it changes concavity
at C. In other words, f has an inflection
point at x equals C. If f changes from concave
up to concave down at x equals C, or it changes
from concave down to concave up. In this graph,
if we draw the concavity regions again, we
see that F has an inflection point at x equals
two, where the function changes from concave
down to concave up at x equals four, where
the function changes from concave up to concave
down at x equals eight, and again, at x equals
11. Since concavity, has to do with the second
derivative being positive or negative, inflection
points happen where the second derivative
changes sign from positive to negative, or
from negative to positive. And that's exactly
what the inflection point test says. If f
double prime of x changes sign
at x equals C, then f has an inflection point
at x equals C. Now in order to change from
positive to negative or negative positive,
f double prime has to go through zero, or
go through a point where it doesn't exist.
But you have to be careful, just because f
double prime is zero, it doesn't exist, does
not guarantee that you necessarily have an
inflection point, because it could be zero
and still be positive on both sides or negative
on both sides. For example, if f of x is x
to the fourth, then f prime of x is for x
cubed, and f double prime of x is 12x squared.
So f double prime at zero is certainly zero.
But there is no inflection point at x equals
zero. In fact, the graph of f of x equals
x to the fourth looks kinda like a flattened
quadratic, and so there's no change in calm
cavity, f is concave up on both sides of x
equals zero. In this video, without the first
derivative can tell us where the function
is increasing and decreasing, while the second
is concave up and concave down. And the second
derivative, changing sign from positive to
negative or negative or positive can tell
us where we have inflection points. Since
lines are much easier to work with, and more
complicated functions, it can be extremely
useful to approximate a function near a particular
value with its tangent line. That's the central
idea of this video. Let's start with an example.
Suppose that F of T is the temperature in
degrees Fahrenheit at time t measured in hours,
where t equals zero represents midnight. Suppose
that f of six is 60 degrees, and the derivative
f prime of six is three degrees per hour.
What's your best estimate for the temperature
at 7am and at 8am? Please pause the video
for a moment to make your estimate. The temperature
at 6am is 60 degrees. So the temperature at
7am, which we're calling F of seven is approximately
60 degrees. But we can do better than this.
At 6am, the temperature is rising, in fact,
it's rising at a rate of three degrees per
hour. If this rate of change continues, then
by 7am, the temperature will have risen three
degrees and reached 63 degrees. And by 8am,
the temperature will have had two hours to
rise from 60 degrees by a rate at a rate of
three degrees per hour. So f of eight should
be about 60 degrees plus the three degrees
per hour times two hours or 66 degrees. These
estimates use all the information, we're given
both the value of the temperature at six,
and its rate of change. Let's see what these
estimates mean graphically, in terms of the
tangent line. I'll draw a rough graph of temperature
over time. And I'll also draw in the tangent
line at time six. At time six, the height
of the function and the tangent line is equal
to 60 degrees. The tangent line has slope
three degrees per hour. So that's a rise of
a run of three, which means that seven o'clock,
which is one hour, after six o'clock, the
tangent line has risen by three degrees. And
at eight o'clock, the tangent line has risen
by another three degrees. So at seven o'clock,
our tangent line has had 63 degrees, and at
eight o'clock, our tangent line has height
66 degrees. When making these estimates, here,
we were actually using the tangent line to
approximate our function. Our actual temperature
function may be rising more steeply than the
tangent line, or it possibly could be rising
less steeply, like in this picture. But either
way, the tangent line is a good approximation
for our function. When time is near six o'clock.
The idea of approximating a function with
its tangent line is a very important idea
that works for any differentiable function.
Let f of x be any differentiable function
and let A be an arbitrary x value. Let's suppose
we know the value of f at a, we'll call it
F of A. And let's say we want to find the
value of f, add an x value near a, let's call
it a plus delta x where delta x means a small
number. If we can't compute f of a plus delta
x directly, we can try to approximate it using
the tangent line.
We know that the tangent line has a slope
given by f prime of a. And so when we go over
by a run of delta x, the tangent line goes
up by a rise of f prime of A times delta x.
So the height of the tangent line is going
to be f of a plus f prime of A times delta
x. The linear approximation principle says
that we can approximate our function with
our tangent line. In other words, f of a plus
delta x is approximately equal to f of a plus
f prime of a delta x. Remember that delta
x is supposed to be a small number, because
if you get too far away from a, your tangent
lines no longer going to be a good approximation
of your function. But how small is small enough
is sort of a judgment call. Sometimes the
approximation principle is written with different
symbols, if we let x equal a plus delta x,
so x is a number close to a, then delta x
is x minus a. And we can rewrite the approximation
principle, as f of x is approximately f of
a plus f prime of A times x minus a. The quantity
on the right side here is sometimes referred
to as l of x, and called the linearization
of f at A. That is the linearization of f
of a is l of x, which is equal to f of a plus
f prime of A times x minus a. So the approximation
principle can also be written as f of x is
approximately equal to l of x. Let's look
a little more closely at this linearization
equation and what it has to do with the tangent
line. Suppose we were going to try to write
down the equation of the tangent line at x
equals a, well, the equation for any line
can be given in point slope form as y minus
y naught equals the slope times x minus x
naught. Since we're looking for the tangent
line that goes through the point A f of a,
we can set x naught equal to a and y naught
equal to f of a. Also, the slope of the tangent
line is just f prime of a. So we can rewrite
this as y minus F of A equals f prime of A
times x minus a solving for y, we get y equals
f of a plus f prime of A times x minus a.
So this equation for the tangent line is really
just the equation that we have for the linearization.
But linearization is really just a fancy word
for the tangent line. There's a lot of notation
and definitions on this page. But there's
only one important principle that you need
to remember. And that's the idea that you
can approximate a function with its tangent
line. If you can keep that idea and this picture
in mind, then it's easy to come up with this
approximation principle. And its alternative
forms. Let's use the approximation principle
in an example, the approximation principle
tells us that f of a plus delta x is approximately
equal to f of a plus f prime of A times delta
x, we need to figure out what f should be
what a should be, and what delta x should
be. Since we're trying to figure out the square
root of 59, it makes sense to make our function
the square root function. For a, we'd like
to pick something that is easy to compute
f of a, well, what's the number close to 59,
that is easy to compute the square root of
64 springs to mind. So let's set a equal to
64. Since we're trying to compute the square
root of 59, we want a plus delta x to be 59.
In other words, 64 plus delta x is 59. And
so delta x should be negative five, it's fine
to have a negative number for delta x. Now
plugging into our approximation formula, we
have f of 59 is approximately equal to f of
64, plus f prime of 64 times negative five.
Since f of x is the square root of x, or in
other words, x to the one half power, f prime
of x is going to be one half x to the minus
one half power, or one over two times the
square root of x. So f prime of 64 is one
over two times the square root of 64, which
is 1/16. I can rewrite my red equation to
say the square root of 59 is approximately
the square root of 64 plus 1/16 times negative
five, which is eight minus five sixteenths,
or 7.6875. using a calculator, I can get a
more exact value of the square to 59. my calculator
says 7.68114575, up to eight decimal places.
Let me draw the picture that goes along with
this approximation. We have the square root
function, and at x equals 64, we're looking
at the tangent line. Our delta x here is a
negative five, and gets us down to 59. So
we're using the value of our tangent line
right here to approximate our actual square
root function right here. As you can see from
the picture, it looks like the tangent line
value should be slightly bigger than the actual
value. And in fact, that's what we get. Then
next example is very similar. We call it the
linearization of a function is just the equation
for its tangent line. Namely, the linearization
at a is f of a plus f prime of A times x minus
a. And the approximation principle says that
f of x, the function is approximately equal
to its linearization. Its tangent line, at
least when x is near a. This is basically
the same formula that we use in the last problem,
we're just calling our value x this time instead
of a plus delta x. Since we're trying to estimate
sine of A value, it makes sense to let our
function be sine of x. For a, we want to pick
a number that's close to 33 degrees, for which
it's easy to calculate sine of that number.
Well, sine of 30 degrees is easy to calculate.
So let's make a equal to 30 degrees, but let's
put it in radians and call it pi over six.
in calculus, we pretty much always want to
use radians for sine and cosine especially
when taking derivatives. Since the derivative
formula, D sine x dx equals cosine of x only
works when x is in radians, our x needs to
be 33 degrees, since that's the value, we
want to estimate the sine of, we need to multiply
by pi over 180 degrees to convert it to radians.
So that becomes 11 pi over 60 radians. Let's
plug in for F and a first to get the linearization.
And then we'll plug in for x next. So the
linearization of our function is going to
be sine of pi over six, plus the derivative
of sine at pi over six times x minus pi over
six. That is l of x is one half, since sine
of pi over six is one half, plus cosine of
pi over six times x minus pi over six, cosine
of pi over six is the square root of three
over two. So this is our equation for the
tangent line, or the linearization of sine
of x at pi over six. Now we know that sine
of x is approximately equal to as linearisation,
as long as x is near pi over six. So in particular,
sine of our 33 degrees in radians, which is
11 pi over 60 is approximately equal to one
half plus a square root of three over two
times 11 pi over 60 minus pi over six.
That simplifies to one half plus the square
root of three over two times pi over 60. And
now I'm going to cheat a little bit and use
my calculator to get a decimal value for this
of about 0.5453. Now if I use my calculator
to find sine of 11 pi over 60, directly, remember,
that's the same thing as sine of 33 degrees.
my calculator tells me it is 0.5446, approximately.
So you can see our approximation using the
linearization is very close to the calculators,
more accurate value. Notice that in this example,
the approximate value based on the linearization
is slightly higher than the actual value.
And you can see why from a graph of sine.
The tangent line at pi over six lies slightly
above the graph of sine x. Therefore, the
approximate value based on the linearization
will be slightly bigger than the actual value
of sine of 33 degrees. In this video, we use
several formulas to express one key idea.
The main formulas were the approximation principle,
the linear approximation, and the linearization.
The key idea is that a differentiable function
can be approximated near a value x equals
A by the tangent line at x equals a. The differential
is a new vocabulary word wrapped around the
familiar concept of approximating a function
with its tangent line. This figure should
look familiar from the previous video on linear
approximation is the same picture. Suppose
we have a differentiable function, f of x,
and we know the value of f at some x value
a. That is, we know the value of f evey, but
we don't know the value of f at some nearby
x value a plus delta x. That is we don't know
f of a plus delta x. So we draw the tangent
line to f of x at x equals a. And we use the
tangent line at a plus delta x as an approximation
for the function at a plus delta x. Since
the tangent line has slope of f prime of a,
the rise of a run is f prime of a. So if this
run here is delta x, this rise has to be f
prime of A times delta x. So the height of
the tangent line here at a plus delta x is
going to be f of a plus f prime of A times
delta x. That's just the height here plus
the extra height here. And since we're using
that height to approximate In our function,
we say that f of a plus delta x is approximately
equal to f of a plus f prime of A times delta
x equivalently. If I subtract F of A from
both sides, I get f of a plus delta x minus
f of a is approximately equal to f prime of
A times delta x. This equation is just the
approximation principle that we've seen before.
And this is a very slight alteration of it.
So there's nothing new yet. But now I'm going
to wrap some new notation around this familiar
concept. The differential dx is another way
of writing delta x, you can think of it as
a small change in the value of x. The differential
df is defined as f prime of x dx, or equivalently
f prime of x delta x. Sometimes this is written
as d y instead, but d y just means the same
thing here as df. Sometimes it's handy to
specify the differential add a particular
value of x, like a value of x equals a, and
this is written df equals f prime of a dx,
or f prime of a delta x. Notice that the value
of a is not apparent when you just write down
d f, or d y.
Finally, the change in f, which is written
delta f, is defined as f of x plus delta x
minus f of x for some value of x, for example,
f of a plus delta x minus f of a, this can
also be written as the change in y. Using
these new definitions, we can now rewrite
our approximation principle to say, delta
f is approximately equal to d f, the change
in the function is approximately equal to
the differential course this could also be
written as the change in Y is approximately
equal to d y. In the picture, we can now write
d x for the run, and D, F, for the rise of
the tangent line. Pause the video and take
a moment to find delta f in this picture,
though delta f is f of a plus delta x minus
f of a, so that's this height here. I'll write
that as delta f, or delta y. So the approximation
principle, written in differential notation,
is just saying that the rise of the function,
delta f is approximated by the rise in the
tangent line df. Let's use the differential
and an example. For the function f of x equal
to x times ln x. Let's first find the differential
df. We know that df is equal to f prime of
x dx. And f prime of x by the product rule
is equal to x times the derivative of ln x,
which is one over x plus the derivative of
x, which is one times ln x. So in other words,
one plus ln x. Therefore, df is equal to one
plus ln x times dx. When x equals two, and
delta x equals negative point three, well
delta x is the same thing as dx, we can just
plug in those values and get df is one plus
ln of two times negative 0.3. as a decimal,
that's approximately negative 0.5079. Now
delta f is defined as f of x plus delta x
minus f of x. So for our function, that's
x plus delta x times ln of x plus delta x
minus x ln x. Plugging in the given values
for x and delta x, we get delta f is two minus
0.3 times ln of two minus 0.3 minus two ln
two, which according to my calculator is negative
zero. Point 4842. And we see that the change
in the function between two and two minus
point three is closely approximated by the
change in the tangent line. As expected. The
differential is often used to estimate error,
as in this example, suppose that the radius
of a sphere is measured as eight centimeters
with a possible error of point five centimeters.
So the sphere that we measure looks something
like this, but the actual sphere might be
slightly bigger, or slightly smaller, we want
to use the differential to estimate the resulting
error in computing the volume of the sphere.
Well, the volume of a sphere is given by four
thirds pi r cubed, where r is the radius.
If our radius changes by point five centimeters,
our volume will change by substantially more.
And that change in volume is the error the
resulting error in measuring volume. But instead
of computing delta V directly, we're asked
to approximate it using the differential.
So we're going to use the fact that delta
V is approximately equal to dv, which is easier
to compute.
By definition, dv is equal to the derivative
of our function, I'll just call that v prime
as a function of r times Dr. Now, v prime
of r is equal to four pi r squared, just by
taking the derivative. And here, we're interested
in an R value of eight, and a value of Dr.
Same as delta r of 0.5 centimeters. So dv
is going to be four pi r squared Dr. And when
I plug in R and D R, I get four pi times eight
squared times 0.5, which is 128 pi, or as
a decimal 402.1 centimeters. That's our error
estimate, which seems quite a bit bigger than
our original error of point five in measuring
the radius. Now, the relative error of a function
is its error over the original value of the
function. So in our case, it's the change
in volume over the actual volume. Since we're
using the differential instead, we'll compute
the relative error as dv over V. Now, the
volume when r is eight centimeters, is four
thirds times pi times eight cubed. And dv,
we already saw was four pi times eight squared
times 0.5. So dv divided by V is given by
this ratio, which simplifies to 0.1875. So
an 18.75% relative there. To me, the relative
error gives a better sense for the error than
the absolute error estimate above. This video
introduced the idea of the differential, we
said that we could think of dx as just being
another way of writing delta x, but df represents
the rise in the tangent line, and is equal
to f prime of x times dx. Whereas delta f
is the rise in the actual function F. And
that's f of x plus delta x minus f of x. On
the picture, dx is the run, df is the rise
in the tangent line. And delta f is the rise
in the actual function. In the language of
differentials, we can restate the approximation
principle to say that the change in f can
be approximated by the differential. In the
past, we've encountered limits, like the limit
as x goes to two of x minus two over x squared
minus four. We can't evaluate this limit just
by plugging in two for x, because x minus
two goes to zero, and x squared minus four
goes to zero as x goes to two. This is known
as a zero over zero indeterminate form. It's
called indeterminate because we can't tell
what the limit is going to be just by the
fact that the numerator goes to zero and the
denominator goes to zero. It depends on how
fast the numerator and the denominator are
going to zero compared to each other. And
the final limit of the quotient could be any
number at all, or it could be infinity or
it could not even exist. In the past, we've
been able to evaluate some limits in zero
over zero indeterminate form by using algebraic
tricks to rewrite the quotients. In this video,
we'll introduce lopi talls rule, which is
a very powerful technique for evaluating limits
and indeterminate forms. A limited of the
form the limit as x goes to a of f of x over
g of x is called a zero over zero indeterminate
form, if the limit as x goes to a of f of
x is equal to zero, and the limit as x goes
to a of g of x is equal to zero. A limit and
this form is called an infinity over infinity
and determinant form. If the limit as x goes
to a of f of x is equal to infinity or minus
infinity. And the limit as x goes to a of
g of x is equal to infinity or minus infinity.
We saw an example of a zero over zero indeterminate
form in the introductory slide.
One example of a infinity over infinity and
determinant form is the limit as x goes to
infinity of 3x squared minus 2x plus seven
divided by negative 2x squared plus 16. Notice
that as x goes to infinity, the numerator
goes to infinity while the denominator goes
to negative infinity. In these definitions
of indeterminate form, it's possible for a
to be negative infinity or infinity, like
it is in this example, but it doesn't have
to be loopy. talls rule can be applied when
f and g are differentiable functions. And
the derivative of g is nonzero in some open
interval around a except possibly in a under
these conditions, if the limit as x goes to
a of f of x over g of x is zero over zero
or infinity over infinity indeterminant form
than the limit as x goes to a of f of x over
g of x is the same thing as the limit as x
goes to a of f prime of x over g prime of
x, provided that the second limit exists,
or as plus or minus infinity. Let's look at
loopy tiles rule in action. In this example,
as x goes to infinity, the numerator x goes
to infinity and the denominator three to the
x also goes to infinity. So we have an infinity
over infinity indeterminate form. So let's
try applying lopi tiles rule, our original
limit should equal the limit as x goes to
infinity of the derivative of the numerator,
which is one divided by the derivative of
the denominator, which is ln of three times
three to the x, provided that the second limit
exists or as infinity or negative infinity.
In the second limit, the numerators just fixed
at one. And the nominator goes to infinity
as x goes to infinity. Therefore, the second
limit is just zero. And so the original limit
evaluates to zero as well. In this example,
we have a zero over zero indeterminate form,
because as x goes to zero, sine of x and x,
both go to zero in the numerator, and sine
of x cubed goes to zero in the denominator.
So using low Patel's rule, I'll try to evaluate
instead, the limit I get by taking the derivative
of the numerator and the derivative of the
denominator, the derivative of sine x minus
x is cosine of x minus one, and the derivative
of sine x cubed is three times sine x squared
times cosine x using the chain rule. Now let
me try to evaluate the limit again, as x goes
to zero, cosine of x goes to one. So the numerator
here goes to zero. As x goes to zero, sine
of x goes to zero and cosine of x goes to
one, so the denominator also goes to zero.
So I still have a zero over zero indeterminate
form. And I might as well try applying loopy
toss rule again. But before I do, I want to
point out that cosine of x is going to one.
So the cosine of x here really isn't affecting
my limit. And in fact, I could rewrite my
limit of a product as a product of limits
where the second limit is just one and can
be ignored from here on out. Now apply lopatok
rule on this first limit, which is a little
bit easier to take the derivatives and so
the derivative of the top is minus sine x.
And the derivative of the bottom is six times
sine x times cosine x. Now let's try to evaluate
again, as x goes to zero, our numerator is
going to zero, and our denominator is also
going to zero. But hang on, we don't have
to apply lobby towels rule again, because
we can actually just simplify our expression,
the sine x on the top cancels with the sine
x on the bottom. And we can just rewrite our
limit as the limit of negative one over six
cosine of x, which evaluates easily to negative
one, six.
In this example, I want to emphasize that
it's a good idea to simplify after each application
of lopi talls rule. If you don't simplify,
like we did here, then you might be tempted
to apply loopy towels rule and additional
time when you don't need to, which might make
the problem more complicated. Instead of simpler
to solve this video, we were able to evaluate
zero over zero and infinity over infinity
indeterminate forms by replacing the limit
of f of x over g of x with the limit of f
prime of x over g prime of x, provided that
second limit exists. This trick is known as
lopi tels rule. We've seen that lopatok rule
can be used to evaluate limits of the form
zero over zero, or infinity over infinity.
In this video, we'll continue to use lopi
towels rule to evaluate additional indeterminate
forms, like zero times infinity, infinity
to the 00 to the zero, and one to the infinity.
In this example, we want to evaluate the limit
of a product. Notice that as x goes to zero
from the positive side, sine x goes to zero,
and ln x goes to negative infinity. Remember
the graph of y equals ln x. So this is actually
a zero times infinity indeterminate form.
Even though the second factor is going to
negative infinity, we still call it a zero
times infinity and indeterminate form, you
can think of the Infinity here as standing
for either positive or negative infinity.
It it's indeterminant. Because as x goes to
zero, the sine x factor is pulling the product
towards zero, while the ln x factor is pulling
the product towards large negative numbers.
And it's hard to predict what the limit of
the product will actually be. But the great
thing is, I can actually rewrite this product
to look like an infinity over infinity and
determinant form, or a zero over zero and
determinant form. Instead of sine x times
ln x, I can rewrite the limit as ln x divided
by one over sine x. Now as x goes to zero,
my numerator is going to negative infinity.
And since sine x is going to zero through
positive numbers, my denominator one over
sine x is going to positive infinity. So I
have an infinity over infinity indeterminate
form. Now, I could instead choose to leave
the sine x in the numerator, and instead,
put a one over ln x in the denominator. If
I do this, then as x goes to zero through
positive numbers, sine x goes to zero. And
since ln x goes to negative infinity, one
over ln x goes to zero. And so I have a zero
over zero indeterminate form. Sometimes it
can be difficult to decide which of these
two ways to rewrite a product as a quotient.
One rule of thumb is to take the version that
makes it easier to take the derivative of
the numerator and denominator. Another trick
is just to try one of the ways and if you
get stuck, go back and try the other. I'm
going to use the first method of rewriting
it because I recognize that one over sine
x can be written as cosecant of x. And I know
how to take the derivative of cosecant x.
Using low Beatles rule on this infinity over
infinity and determinant form, I can rewrite
my limit as the limit of what I get when I
take the derivative of the numerator, that's
whenever x divided by the derivative of the
denominator, that's negative cosecant x cotangent
x. As always, I want to simplify my expression
before going any further. I can rewrite my
trig functions in the denominator in terms
of sine and cosine. cosecant x is one over
sine x cotangent x is cosine of x over sine
of x. Now flipping and multiplying, I get
the limit as x goes to zero plus of one over
x times sine squared of x over negative cosine
of x. In other words, the limit of negative
sine squared x over x cosine x,
we know that cosine of x goes to one as x
goes to zero. So I can rewrite this as the
limit of negative sine squared x over x times
the limit of something that goes to one. So
I once again have a zero over zero indeterminate
form. And I can apply lopatok rule yet again,
taking the derivative of the top, I get negative
two, sine x, cosine of x. And the job of the
bottom is just one. Now I'm in a good position
just to evaluate the limit by plugging in
zero for x in the numerator, I get negative
two times zero times one, the denominator
is just one, so my final limit is zero. In
this limit, we have a battle of forces. As
x is going to infinity, one over x is going
to zero. So one plus one over x is going to
one, but the exponent x is going to infinity,
it's hard to tell what's going to happen here.
If we had one, to any finite number, that
would be one. But anything slightly bigger
than one, as we raise it to a bigger and bigger
powers, we would expect to get infinity. So
our limit has an independent permanent form,
it's hard to tell whether the answer is going
to be one infinity, or maybe something in
between. Whenever I see an expression with
a variable in the base, and a variable in
the exponent, I'm tempted to use logarithms.
If we set y equal to one plus one over x to
the x, then if I take the natural log of both
sides, I can use my log roles to rewrite that
by multiplying by x in the front. Now, if
I wanted to take the limit as x goes to infinity
of ln y, that would be the limit of this product,
x times ln one plus one over x. As x goes
to infinity, the first factor x goes to infinity.
One plus one over x goes to just one and ln
one is going to zero. So we have a infinity
times zero indeterminate form, which we can
try to rewrite as an infinity over infinity,
or a zero over zero indeterminate form. Let's
rewrite this as the limit of ln one plus one
over x divided by one over x. This is indeed
a zero over zero in determinant form. So we
can use lobi tiles rule and take the derivative
of the top and the bottom, the derivative
of the top is one over one plus one over x
times the derivative of the inside, which
would be negative one over x squared. And
the derivative on the bottom, the derivative
of one over x is negative one over x squared,
we can actually cancel out these two factors,
and rewrite our limit as the limit as x goes
to infinity of one over one plus one over
x, which is just equal to one, since one over
x is going to zero. So we found that the limit
of ln y is equal to one, but we're really
interested in finding the limit of y, which
we can think of as e to the ln y. Since ln
y is going to one, e to the ln y must be going
to e to the one. In other words, E. So we
found that our original limit is equal to
E. And in fact, you may recognize that this
limit is one of the ways of defining IE.
In the previous example, we had a one to the
internet Today in determinant form, and we
took logs and use log roles to write that
as an infinity times zero and determinant
form. Well, the same thing can be done if
we have an infinity to the zero indeterminate
form,
or
a zero to the zero indeterminate form. So
one to the infinity, infinity to the zero,
and zero to the zero, are all indeterminate
forms that can be handled using lobi toss
rule. In this video, we saw that a zero times
infinity indeterminate form could be converted
to a zero over zero, or infinity over infinity
indeterminate form by rewriting f of x times
g of x as f of x divided by one over g of
x, or as g of x divided by one over f of x.
We also saw how to use lopi talls rule on
these three sorts of indeterminate forms by
taking the ln of y, where y is our f of x
to the g of x that we want to take the limit
of. This video is about Newton's method for
finding the zeros of a function, f of x. In
other words, the values of x that make f of
x equal to zero. The zeros of a function can
also be thought of as the x intercepts of
its graph. Suppose we want to find a solution
to the equation either the x equals 4x. This
equation cannot be solved using standard algebraic
methods. For example, taking the ln of both
sides doesn't really help because we still
get x equals ln of 4x, which is just as hard
to solve. Instead, we can look for approximate
solutions. Looking at the graph of y equals
e to the x and y equals 4x, we see there should
be two solutions, one at approximately x equals
little more than two and the other around
x equals maybe point three or point four.
Newton's method will allow us to make much
more accurate approximations to the solution
of this equation, then we can do by just glancing
at the graph. To use Newton's method, instead
of looking at the equation, e to the x equals
4x. We'll look at the equation E to the X
minus 4x equals zero. And in fact, we'll define
the function f of x to be e to the x minus
4x. And look for zeros of that function. After
all, finding a zero of this function is the
same as finding a solution to our original
equation. So now we're trying to solve the
equivalent problem of finding the zero of
the function f of x equals e to the x minus
4x. That's the function that's drawn below.
I'm going to focus on this zero, the one near
to, and I'm just going to make an initial
guess anything reasonably close to the actual
zero should do. So I'll just put an initial
guess right here, and I'll call it x one.
Now x one is not actually zero of my function,
and I'll write the point on the graph above
it as x one, f of x one. To get a better estimate
for the zero of my function, I'm going to
make use of the tangent line to my function
that goes through this point. So the second
step will be to find this tangent line. Since
the tangent line is a reasonably good approximation
to the function, the point where the tangent
line crosses the x axis should be closer to
the point where the function itself crosses
the x axis, which is the point I'm looking
for. So the third step will be to find the
x intercept for the tangent line. I'll call
this x intercept, x two. Now I'm just going
to repeat this process. I'll use x two as
my next guess. I'll follow it up to the function
where I have the point x to f of x two, and
then I'll draw a new tangent line and get
a new intercept. I can repeat this process
as often as I need to, to get a sufficiently
accurate approximation to my actual zero of
my function. Now that I've described the process
graphically, let's find some equations that
go along with this picture. If I start with
the initial guess, of x one, then the tangent
line through x one, f of x one is given by
the x Bayesian y equals f of x one plus f
prime of x one times x minus x one.
You might remember this equation from a section
on linearization. And it's really just comes
from the formula y minus y one equals m x
minus x one that holds for any line, where
m here is the derivative at x one, and y one
is f of x one. plugging into that equation,
we have y minus f of x one equals f prime
of x one times x minus x one, which simplifies
to y equals f of x one plus f prime of x one
times x minus x one. So that's where this
linearization equation comes from. It's just
the equation of the tangent line. Now, if
we want to find the x intercept of the tangent
line,
we just said
the tangent line equation equal to zeros,
we have zero equals f of x one plus f prime
of x one times x minus x one, and we solve
for x. so this can subtract f of x one from
each side, divided by f prime of x one and
solve for x. We're calling this new x intercept
x two. So x two is x one minus f of x one
over f prime of x one. Now we have our second
guess, x two, and we can again find the tangent
line through x two, f of x two, that tangent
line will be given by the same sort of equation.
And if we then find the x intercept, the same
algebraic steps, get us to the analogous equation
x three equals x two minus f of x two over
f prime of x two. And more generally, as we
repeat this process over and over again, our
n plus one guess is going to be given by x
n plus one equals x n minus f of x n over
f prime of x n. That's the J equation at the
core of Newton's method. Now that we've got
the theory down, let's grind through the problem
at hand with some numbers. Our function has
the equation f of x equals e to the x minus
4x. So f prime of x is e to the x minus four.
So from Newton's methods equation, we have
in general, X sub n plus one is X sub n minus
e to the x sub n minus four times X sub n
over e to the x sub n minus four. Let's start
with for example, x sub one equals three,
then x sub two is going to be three minus
e cubed minus four times three over e cubed
minus four. plugging this into a calculator,
I get x sub two equals 2.4973, and so on.
Now to cube compute x sub three, I have to
take this whole number and plug that in to
my formula. I've written it out as just 2.49.
But for accuracy, when I actually computed
my calculator, I'll use the entire number.
my calculator gives me this answer for x of
three and continue in this process, I can
get x of 4x 5x sub six. If I compute one more,
x of seven, I noticed that I have no change
to my value in the number of digits that the
calculator spits out. So at this point, my
Newton's methods iterations have converged.
And I have an answer that's accurate to about
eight decimal places. I found one zero for
my function. And if I wanted to find the second
zero, the one over here, I would just need
to start with an initial value that's close
to this x coordinate, perhaps an initial value
of zero might be good. In this video, we developed
an algorithm for getting increasingly accurate
approximations to the zero of a function.
The central equation that we used was this
one which tells us how to get from one approximation,
X sub n to the next 1x sub n plus one. When
we go from a function, say 3x plus sine x
to its derivative, in this case, three plus
cosine x, that's called differentiating, or
finding a derivative. Anti differentiating,
or finding an antiderivative, takes us the
other direction, from a derivative to a function
that has that as its derivative.
For example, if g prime of x is 3x squared,
that's the derivative. What could g of x the
original function be? Well, g of x could be
x cubed, since the derivative of x cubed is
3x squared. Or it could also be g of x equals
x cubed plus seven, for example, or g of x
equals x cubed plus any constant, where I
write a general constant with a capital C.
That's because the derivative of a constant
zero, so the derivative of x cubed plus a
constant is just going to be 3x squared, no
matter what the constant is. A function capital
F of X is called an antiderivative of lowercase
F of X on an interval a, b, if the derivative,
capital F prime of X is equal to lowercase
F of X on that interval a b. In other words,
we can think of little f as being the derivative
of the function capital F. In the above example,
x cubed is an antiderivative of 3x squared.
And in fact, x cubed plus C for any constant
C is also an antiderivative of 3x squared.
When we add on a general constancy, that's
sometimes referred to as a general antiderivative,
we found a general family of anti derivatives
for the function 3x squared. But could there
be other anti derivatives, other functions
whose derivative is 3x squared. In fact, there
are no others. And one way to think about
this intuitively, is if you have two functions
with the same derivative, it's like having
two runners in a race that always speed up
and slow down at exactly the same times. If
one of those runners starts ahead of the other,
then the distance between them will always
stay exactly the same. That's the vertical
distance drawn here on the graph. And that's
the constant C, that separates one antiderivative
y equals x cubed from another y equals x cubed
plus C. And in general, if capital F of X
is an antiderivative for a little f of x,
then all other anti derivatives can be written
in the form capital F of x plus C for some
constancy. A more rigorous justification of
this fact, can be proved using the mean value
theorem, as I'll do in a separate video. If
you know the derivatives for some standard
functions, then it's pretty easy to get some
anti derivatives. For example, the antiderivative
of one is x. Since the derivative of x is
one, if we want to make that a general antiderivative,
we can add a constant C, the antiderivative
of x is x squared over two because when I
take the derivative of x squared over two,
the two that I pulled down and multiply cancels
with the two in the denominator, leaving me
x. Again, I can make this a more general antiderivative
by adding a constant C. More generally, the
antiderivative of x to the n for any and that's
not equal to negative one is given by x to
the n plus one divided by n plus one plus
a constant C. I can check this by taking the
derivative of x to the n plus one over n plus
one. The n here is just a constant. So using
the power rule, I get n plus one times x to
the n divided by n plus one that yields x
to the n, which is what I want it. We can
think of this rule as the power rule for anti
differentiating since it's closely related
to the power rule for differentiating. Now,
this rule doesn't apply when n equals negative
one. Notice that we'd be dividing by zero
if n were negative one but we can handle the
case when n equals negative one separately,
since x to the negative one is one of our
x, we recognize that the antiderivative of
one of our x is just ln of the absolute value
of x plus C. Since the derivative of ln of
the absolute value of x is one over x, please
pause the video and see how many more anti
derivatives you can fill in in this table.
You should get all of these formulas based
on the analogous formulas for differentiating,
notice that the antiderivative of sine x is
negative cosine x not cosine x, because the
derivative of cosine x is negative sine x.
If I have a constant times x to the n, I'm
going to call the constant a instead of C,
since I've already got some C's floating around.
If I want the antiderivative of A times x
to the n, that's just going to be a times
the antiderivative of x to the n, which is
x to the n plus one over n plus one plus a
constant say that's because when I take the
derivative of a constant times a function,
I can just pull the constant out. More generally,
the antiderivative of a constant A times any
function, little f of x is just going to equal
A times the antiderivative of little f of
x, which I'll denote with capital F of X,
plus a constant C. The antiderivative of f
of x plus g of x is capital F of X, plus capital
G of x plus c, where capital F and capital
G are the antiderivative of lowercase F and
lowercase J. This is because the derivative
of a sum is equal to the sum of the derivatives.
Let's use this information to compute the
antiderivative for f of x equals five over
one plus x squared minus one over two times
the square root of x. First, I'm going to
rewrite f of x as five times one over one
plus x squared minus one half times x to the
minus one half. I know that the antiderivative
of one over one plus x squared is arctangent
of x. And by the power rule for anti differentiating
the antiderivative of x to the minus one half,
I get by raising the exponent by one, negative
one half plus one is positive one half, and
then dividing by the new exponent by my constant
multiplication rules, I can just multiply
by my constants. And that's my antiderivative
capital F of X, I've have to remember the
plus C for the general antiderivative, I can
simplify a little bit by canceling these one
halves. And I get a final answer of five times
arc tan of x minus a squared of x plus C.
In this video, we introduced anti derivatives
and build a table of anti derivatives based
on our knowledge of derivatives. In this video,
we'll solve problems where we're given an
equation for the derivative of the function.
And we're given an initial condition, something
like f of one equals seven. And we have to
find the function f of x. In this first example,
suppose g prime of x is e to the x minus three
times sine x. and g of two pi is five, we
need to find g of x. Well, g of x is an antiderivative
of e to the x minus three sine x. So g of
x is of the form e to the x plus three cosine
of x plus a constant C. That's because the
derivative of e to the x is e to the x, the
derivative of cosine x is minus sine x, and
the derivative of a constant is just zero.
Now I need to find the value of the constant
C that makes this initial condition come true.
If I plug in two pi for x, I get e to the
two pi plus three times cosine of two pi plus
C, and that needs to equal five. Since cosine
of two pi is one, I have that e to the two
pi plus three plus c equals five. And so C
is equal to two minus e to the two pi. So
my function g of x is equal to either the
x plus three cosine x Plus two minus e to
the two pi. In this example, we're given the
second derivative of f. And we're given two
initial conditions, f of one is zero, and
f of zero is two.
To start, I'm going to rewrite f double prime
of x in a more manageable form. by distributing,
I get the square root of x times x minus the
square root of x over x. and rewriting with
exponents, we get x to the three halves minus
x to the minus one half. Next, I'm going to
find f prime of x, which is the antiderivative
of f double prime of x. So f prime of x, using
the power rule for anti derivatives, I raised
the exponent of three halves by one to get
five halves, and then divide by the new exponent
five halves. Similarly, I raised negative
one half by one to get one half and divide
by the new exponent one half. And I'll add
on a constant see, let me simplify a little
here, instead of dividing by five halves,
multiply by two fifths, and instead of dividing
by one half, multiply by two. Now I've got
an expression for f prime of x, but I need
an expression for f of x, which is the antiderivative
of f prime, and so all anti differentiate
again. So now I have two fifths times x to
the seven halves over seven halves minus two
times x to the three halves over three halves,
the antiderivative of a constant C is C times
x, and then I'll add on a new constant D.
After simplifying a bit, I'm ready to use
my initial conditions, in order to solve for
my constant C and D. When I plug in zero for
x, all my x terms vanish, I'm just left with
D, so d has to equal two. So I can rewrite
my function, setting D equal to two. And now
my second condition says that f of one equals
zero. So plugging in one for x, I get 430
fifths minus four thirds plus c plus two,
and that has to equal zero, which means that
c is negative two, minus 430 fifths, plus
four thirds, which simplifies to minus 80
to 100, and fifths. If we plug that in for
C, we get a final answer for f of x. And that
finishes the problem. In this final example,
we're not given any equations, so we have
to make them up ourself, we're told that we're
standing at the edge of a cliff, at height
30 meters, with throw a tomato up in the air
at an initial velocity of 20 meters per second.
The tomato then falls down to the ground due
to gravity. And we want to find how long that
takes and what its velocity is at impact.
We know that the acceleration due to gravity
is negative 9.8 meters per second squared.
If we're working in metric units. The similar
figure if we're working in units of feet,
is negative 32 feet per second squared. The
negative sign is because gravity is pulling
objects down towards the ground in the negative
direction. We're also given the initial condition,
that velocity at time zero is 20 meters per
second. That's a positive velocity because
we're throwing the tomato up. And we're told
that the initial position s of zero is 30
meters. So let's start with the equation that
acceleration is negative 9.8. In other words,
S double prime of t is negative 9.8. Therefore,
S prime of t is negative 9.8 t plus a constant
c one. And from my initial condition about
velocity, I know that s prime of zero is 20.
So in other words, S prime of zero is negative
9.8 times zero plus c one that has to equal
20. Which means that c one is equal to 20.
Substituting in 20 for C one, I can rewrite
s prime of t Now I can find f of t, the antiderivative
of S prime. And that's going to be negative
9.8 times t squared over two plus 20 t plus
a second constant C two.
Using my second initial condition, f of zero
equals 30. I can plug in zero for t, and get
an expression that equals 30. Since all the
terms drop out, besides the C two, that tells
me that C two is 30. And so I can find my
equation position by substituting 34 c two.
Now I want to find out how long it takes the
tomato to hit the ground. So that's going
to be the time when s of t equals zero. Setting
zero equal to my expression for S of t, I
can use the quadratic formula to solve for
t, and I get t equals approximately negative
1.17, or 5.25. The negative time doesn't make
sense for the problem. So I'm left with a
time of impact of 5.25 seconds. Now to find
the velocity of the impact, I need to plug
that time into my velocity equation. In other
words, my equation for S prime. So s prime
of 5.25, is 9.8 times 5.25, plus 20, which
simplifies to negative 31.45 meters per second,
probably enough to squash the tomato. And
that's all for this video on finding anti
derivatives using initial conditions. In this
video, I'll use the mean value theorem to
show that the antiderivative zero has to be
a constant. And then any two anti derivatives
of the same function have to differ by a constant.
In a previous video, I stated the fact that
if f of x is one antiderivative of a function,
little f of x, than any other antiderivative
of that same function can be written in the
form capital F of x plus C for some constant
C. In other words, any two antiderivative
of the same function have to differ by a constant.
To prove this fact, let's first note that
if the derivative of a function, g prime of
x is equal to zero on an interval than the
original function, g of x must equal C for
some constant C. This statement follows from
the mean value theorem, because the mean value
theorem tells us that for any x one and x
two in our interval, the average rate of change
between x one and x two is equal to the derivative
at some number x three in between x one and
x two. But by assumption, g prime is zero
everywhere on the interval, so g prime of
x three must be equal to zero. This means
that our numerator, g of x want to minus g
of x one has to equal zero. In other words,
g of x two is equal to g of x one, but that's
true for any x one and x two. So all the values
of G are equal, and G must be a constant.
The second observation that I want to make
is that if G one and G two are two functions,
which have the same derivative, then g one
of x must equal g two of x plus C for some
constant C. This statement follows from the
previous statement, because if G one prime
of x is equal to g two prime of x, then g
one prime of x minus g two prime of x must
equal zero. But that means if I look at the
function g one of x minus g two of x, and
take its derivative, that has to equal zero,
since the derivative The difference is the
difference of the derivatives. Now our previous
statement tells us that if the derivative
of a function is zero, the function must be
a constant, and therefore, g one of x minus
g two of x equals C for some constant C, which
means that g one of x is equal to g two of
x plus C, which is what we wanted to prove.
So we've proved that any two functions with
the same derivative have to differ by a constant
or in other words, If capital F of X is one
antiderivative of a function than any other
antiderivative must be of the form capital
F of x plus C. This concludes the proof that
any two anti derivatives of a particular function
must differ by a constant. This video will
review summation notation, that is, the sigma
notation used to write a song.
In this expression, using the greek capital
letter sigma, the letter I is called the index.
The number one is called the lower limit of
summation, or the starting index. And the
number five is called the upper limit of summation,
or the ending index, we evaluate this expression
by summing up to the I, for all values of
i starting from one and ending at five and
stepping through the integers. In other words,
we start with i equals one and take two to
the one. And then we add to it two to the
two, two to the Three, two to the four, and
two to the five. If we do the arithmetic,
this comes out to 62. In the second expression,
our index is J, and we start with J equals
three and go up to J equals seven, once again,
stepping through integer values. So we have
to add up 1/3 plus 1/4, plus 1/5, plus one,
six, and then our last term is one seven.
This sum is equal to 153, over 140. When we're
given a psalm like this one, it can be handy
to write it in sigma notation, because it's
more compact. But to do so, we have to look
for the pattern between the terms. In this
case, the terms all differ by three. So I
can think of nine as being six plus three,
and 12, as being six plus twice, three, and
15 as being six plus three times three, and
so on. In fact, we can even think of six itself
as being six plus zero times three to fit
this pattern. Now we can write the sum as
sigma of six plus i times three, where I ranges
from zero to four. Here, we're thinking of
six plus three as six plus one times three.
Now, there are other ways to write this sum
and sigma notation. For example, we could
notice that each of the terms is a multiple
of three. And in fact, six is three times
two, nine is three times three, and so on.
And so we could write our sum as sigma of
three times n, where n ranges from two to
six. The choice of the letter we use for the
index doesn't matter at all. For example,
we could also write this as sigma from K equals
two to six of three times k. Here, k and n
play the same role. Please pause the video
for a moment and try to write this next example
in sigma notation. Since the denominators
are powers of two, we could write the denominators
as two to the i, where i ranges from two to
five. The numerators are one less than the
denominators, so we can write the numerators
as two to the i minus one was we're adding
these terms up, we write sigma, and we I go
from two to five. In this video, we reviewed
summation notation, or sigma notation for
writing sums. In this video, we'll approximate
the area under a curve using tall skinny rectangles,
this will introduce the idea of an integral.
Let's start by approximating the area under
this curve y equals x squared in between x
equals zero, and x equals three by approximating
it with six rectangles.
There's several ways to do this. For example,
I could draw rectangles for the right side
of each rectangle is as tall as the curve.
We'll call this using write endpoints. Alternatively,
we could line up our rectangles, so the left
side of each rectangle is as high as the curve.
We'll call this use Left endpoints. Notice
that the leftmost rectangle in this picture
is degenerate and has height zero. If we're
using the picture with the right endpoints,
then the base of each rectangle has size one
half. And the height of each rectangle is
given by the value of our function, y equals
x squared on the right side of the rectangle.
So for example, the area of the first rectangle
is its base times its height, which is point
five times 0.5 squared. The 0.5 squared comes
from me evaluating the function at this point
0.5 to get the height. Similarly, the area
of the second rectangle is going to be also
base times height basis, still point five,
and now the height is going to be one squared,
or one. If we continue like this, and add
up all our areas, we get the area of all six
rectangles is given by this expression. Notice
that there are six terms here, one for each
rectangle, each rectangle has base of point
five, and has height given by the right endpoint,
we can write this in sigma notation as the
sum of 0.5 times 0.5 times i squared, where
I ranges from one to six. This works because
the numbers in parentheses here are all multiples
of point five. The first one is point five
times one, and the last one, three is point
five times six. Now if we compute the sum,
we get 91 eighths, which is 11.375. Notice
from the picture, that the sum of areas of
rectangles is an over estimate for the area
under the curve, we can do the same sort of
computation for this green picture using left
endpoints, and we'll get an under estimate
for the area under the curve, I invite you
to try it for yourself before going on with
the video. For the green rectangles, the first
rectangle has area zero, the second rectangle
has area given by its base of 0.5 times its
height of 0.5 squared. And if we compute all
six areas and add them up, we get a similar
expression to the previous one, only this
time, we end with a 2.5 squared, which is
the height of our last rectangle. One way
to write this in sigma notation, is still
starting with i equals one for the first rectangle
to six for the last one, we use the base.
And then for the height, we use 0.5 times
I minus one,
squared.
This works because when I is one, i minus
one is zero, so we start with a height of
zero like we should. And when I is six, we
get point five times six minus one, which
is point five times five, or 2.5, just like
we want it to be, if we add up the sum, we
get an answer of 55 eighths, which is equal
to 6.875, which is an underestimate for the
true area under the curve. Now there's a big
gap between 6.875 and 11.375. So it'd be nice
to get tighter bounds on the area. One way
to do this is by using more rectangles, for
example, 12 rectangles instead of six. Again,
we could choose to use right endpoints, which
gives us an over estimate of area in this
case, or we could use left endpoints, which
gives us an under estimate. The area of the
eyes rectangle is given by the base times
the height, and the base is going to be in
this case 0.25. While the height is given
by the functions value on the right endpoint,
the right endpoint of the eyes rectangle is
going to be 0.25 times I and the function
is the squaring function. So that height will
be given by point two, five i squared. The
area of all the rectangles can then be given
by the sum from i equals one to 12 for the
12 rectangles of 0.25 times 0.25 i
squared.
If we work out that sum, it comes to 10.156.
Again, we can do the same thing with left
endpoints. Now the area of the eye, the rectangle,
is given by base times height, which is point
two, five. And now the height is given by
the value of the function on the left endpoint.
So that's going to be 0.25 times I minus one.
And we need to square that, since our function
y equals x squared is giving the height of
my rectangles. So the area of all the rectangles
together is going to be the sum from the first
rectangle to the 12th rectangle of 0.25 times
0.25, times I minus one
squared.
That works out to 7.906. So we're honing in
on the actual area under the curve. Now it's
somewhere between about eight and about 10,
we can keep getting better and better estimates
of area by using more and more rectangles.
For example, if we want to use 100 rectangles,
then our area of all rectangles using right
endpoints is going to be given by the sum
from i equals one to 100 of the basis times
the heights. Now the base of each rectangle
will be 100 of the length here from zero to
three. In other words, the base will be three
over 100. The eyes right endpoint, which I'll
call X sub i, is going to be just three over
100 times I, since you get to the right eye
threat endpoint by taking I copies of a rectangle
of width three one hundredths. Therefore,
the eyes height is going to be given by this
is right endpoint squared, or three one hundredths
times i squared. So we can write our sum of
areas as sigma from i equals one to 100 of
three one hundredths times three one hundredths
times i squared. The formula using left endpoints
is similar. The if left endpoint is going
to be three one hundredths, times I minus
one, since if we're using left endpoints,
we only have to travel through i minus one
rectangles to get to the left endpoint of
the rectangle. So our area for the left endpoints
becomes the sum from i equals one to 100 of
three over 100 times three over 100 times
I minus one squared. These two psalms work
out to be 9.1435 and 8.8654. At this point,
you might be willing to wager a guess that
our exact area under the curve is probably
going to be nine. But to determine the exact
area for sure, let's do this process of dividing
into rectangles one more time. And this time,
we'll just use an rectangles where n is some
big number. Since we're dividing an interval
of length three into n little pieces, the
width of each sub interval, in other words,
the base of each rectangle, we'll be given
by three over n. I'll call this delta x as
a little tiny bit of x. Now the right endpoint,
x by is given by three over n times i. Since
we have to travel through I rectangles, each
of width three over n on order to get to that
right endpoint. So our height, H sub i is
given by the functions value on that right
endpoint. We can work out similar expressions
for the picture using left endpoints here.
Our estimate of area using right endpoints
is then the sum from i equals one to n of
three over n times three I over n squared.
And our estimate using left endpoints is a
sum from i equals one to n of three over n
times three, i minus one over n squared, the
more rectangles we use, in other words, the
bigger the value of n, the closer our estimated
area will be to our exact area under the curve.
And therefore, the exact area is given by
the limit the limit as n goes to infinity
of this song, which is known as a Riemann
sum,
there are really two possible limits, we could
use right endpoints or left endpoints. But
as the picture suggests, these two limits
should turn out to be the same thing. In fact,
there are other options between sides using
right endpoints and left endpoints, we could,
for example, use the midpoints of our intervals
to compute our areas of rectangles. And that
limit should also end up as the same thing.
So we have an expression for the area under
the curve y equals x squared
between the
values of x equals one and x equals three.
And that's given by the limit of this psalm
called a Riemann sum. I'll stick with the
right endpoint version for now, to compute
the exact area, we have to evaluate this limit,
which is tricky. I'm going to start by rewriting.
Since three and n don't involve the index
I, I can pull them outside of this summation
sign. I'll clean this up a little bit. Now
will you need to use the fact that the sum
of the first n squares of the integers is
equal to n times n plus one times two n plus
one
over six,
we can check that formula for a few values
of n. For example, if n equals two, we're
summing out one squared plus two squared,
which is five. And we're plugging in two times
two plus one times four plus one over six
from the formula, which also equals five.
If we use this formula, in our limit calculation,
we get this expression, which simplifies to
nine halves, by dividing 27 by six, we can
cancel a copy of n and get n plus one times
two n plus one over n squared. I'm going to
pull out the nine halves. And now I observe
I have the limit of a rational expression,
where the highest power term on the numerator
is going to be two n squared, the highest
power and there's nominators just the n squared,
so that's going to be a limit of two, multiply
that by by nine halves, and I get a limit
of nine, just like I expected from the previous
work. So that was a big production. But we
did successfully find the area under the curve,
and it was nine. In this video, we approximated
the area under a curve by taking the limit
as the number of rectangles goes to infinity
of the area of the rectangles, which is given
by a psalm called a Riemann sum of the basis
times the heights of the rectangles. The basis
are often written as delta x, and the heights
are given by the function value on the left
endpoint, or the right endpoint, or some other
point in the interval. For our purposes, f
was always x squared. But this sort of expression,
called a Riemann sum, can be used more generally,
to evaluate the area under any continuous
function. In previous sections, we thought
of the definite integral as representing area,
and we've computed it as a number. In this
section, we'll think of the integral itself
as a function of the bounds of integration.
And we'll describe the first part of the fundamental
theorem relating the derivative and the integral.
Suppose f of x has the graph shown here, and
let g of x be the integral from one to x of
f of t dt. I'm using t as my variable inside
my integrand Here, just to distinguish it
from the variable x that I'm using in my bounds
of integration, this expression just means
the net area between one and some value x
on the x axis. I'll call geovax, the accumulated
area function, because as x increases, g of
x, measures how much net area has accumulated.
Let's calculate and plot some values of g
of x. g of one is the integral from one to
one of f of t, dt, that's just zero. Since
the bounds of integration here the same, g
of two is the integral from one to two of
f of t, dt. That's the net area from one to
two, which is to square units. g of three
is the integral from one to three. Now, we've
added on an additional two units here, and
an additional one unit up here from this triangle,
for a total of five, g of four is g of three
with some additional area tacked on the additional
area measures three units. So g of four is
eight. Please pause the video and fill in
the next few values of J.
When we go from g of four to g of five, we
add on an extra unit of area. So g of five
is nine. As we go from g of five to g of six,
we start accumulating negative area, because
f is now below the x axis. So here I've accumulated
one unit of negative area, which means that
g of six is one less than g of five. In other
words, gf six is eight, g of seven is five.
Since we accumulate three more units of negative
area, to find g of zero, the integral from
one to zero of f of t dt, I'm going to rewrite
this integral as negative the integral from
zero to one of f of t dt. Since there are
two units of area between zero and one, g
of zero is negative to apply all these values
of G on these coordinate axes, and connect
the dots to get an idea of what g of x looks
like. Now let's think about the derivative
g prime of x. We know that g prime of x is
positive, where g of x is increasing, but
g of x is increasing, wherever we're adding
on positive area, that is when f of x is positive.
So we have that g prime of x is positive,
where f is x is positive.
Also,
g prime of x is negative, where g of x is
decreasing. That happens when we're adding
on negative area because f of x is negative.
So we can see that g prime of x is negative,
where f of x is negative. Also, g prime is
zero at this local maximum, where f is zero.
At that instant, we're not adding on any positive
or negative
area.
If we look a little closer, we can see the
rate at which g of x is increasing depends
on the height of f of x. When f of x is tall,
or high, we're adding on area very quickly.
While when f of x is low or small, we're adding
on area more slowly. So the rate of change
of G. In other words, g prime of x is behaving
very much like the function f of x itself.
And in fact, it turns out that g prime of
x is equal to f of x. This is the first part
of the fundamental theorem of calculus.
The Fundamental Theorem of Calculus Part One
says that of f of x is a continuous function
on the closed interval from a to b, then for
any x in this interval, the function g of
x, the integral from a to x of f of t dt is
continuous on the interval a b and differentiable
on the inside of this interval, and for Furthermore,
g prime of x is equal to f of x, as we saw
in the previous example. The proof of this
fact relies on a limit definition of derivative,
and can be found in a later video. For now,
let's do some examples based on this fact.
First, let's find the derivative with respect
to x of the integral from five to x of the
square root of t squared plus three dt. The
Fundamental Theorem of Calculus tells us that
this expression here thought of as a function
of x is differentiable, and its derivative
is just the integrand function evaluated on
x. This is great, we don't have to do any
work here at all. To evaluate the derivative,
we just plug in x, where we see the T here,
the derivative and the second expression is
also the square root of x squared plus three,
it might seem odd that these two expressions
have the same derivative. But remember, in
both cases, we're taking the derivative of
the accumulated area function. And the rate
at which area accumulates doesn't depend on
the lower bound of the integral. That is,
it doesn't depend on where we start counting,
it just depends on the height of the function
at x.
For this third example, remember that the
integral from x to four is the same thing
as the negative of the integral from four
to x. So we get the negative of the derivative
from four to x. and applying the fundamental
theorem of calculus, this lesson is negative
the square root of x squared plus three, it
makes sense that we should get a negative
answer for this example. When we're integrating
from X to four, then as x increases, our area
actually decreases. So our accumulated area
function should have a negative derivative.
This last example is more complicated, because
instead of just having x as our upper bound,
we have a function of x sine of x, we can
think of sine of x as being the inside function,
and the accumulated area function as being
an outside function and apply the chain rule.
In general, the chain rule says that we have
the derivative with respect to x of a function
of u of x, then that's the same thing as the
derivative with respect to u of that function
at U times the derivative of the inside function
u of x with respect to x, applying the chain
rule to our accumulated area function, where
you have x is sine x, we have that the derivative
respect to x of the integral from four to
sine x of the integral of t squared plus three
DT can be written as the derivative by two
you, I've accumulated area function from four
to you have the integrand times the derivative
with respect to x of our u of x, which is
just sine x, we can apply the fundamental
theorem of calculus to calculate the first
derivative. By just plugging in you for T,
we get you squared plus three. And then the
derivative of sine x, of course, is just cosine
of x. Since we want our final answer to be
entirely in terms of x, we're going to rewrite
this as the square root of sine x squared
plus three times cosine x, or just the square
root of sine squared x plus three times cosine
of x. We could have gotten this answer more
quickly by just plugging in this entire expression
sine of x in where we saw the T here in the
integrand, and then multiplying the answer
by the derivative of sine x due to the chain
rule.
This video introduced the fundamental theorem
of calculus part one that says that the derivative
of the integral of a function is just the
original function in some sense, taking the
derivative and does the process of taking
the integral. derivatives and integrals are
closely related. inverse operations. This
video introduces the second part of the fundamental
theorem of calculus. Another way of relating
derivatives and integrals. Part Two of the
fundamental theorem of calculus says that
if f is a continuous function on the closed
interval a b, then the integral from a to
b of f of x dx is equal to capital F of b
minus capital F of A, where capital F is any
antiderivative for lowercase F. That is, capital
F is a function whose derivative is lowercase
F. The proof of part two of the fundamental
theorem of calculus follows directly from
part one. And I'll give that proof in another
video. But here, I just want to make a few
comments about what this theorem means. If
we think of f of x as the derivative of capital
F of x, then this is saying that the integral
of the derivative is equal to the original
function evaluated on the endpoints. I also
want to comment on the phrasing any antiderivative.
Suppose capital G of X is a different antiderivative
for lowercase F. We know that any two anti
derivatives differ by a constant. So we know
that g of x has to equal capital F of X plus
some constant. So if we take g of b minus
g of a, that's going to be the same thing
as f of b plus c minus f of a plus C. And
since this constant sees subtract out to cancel
here, this is just f of b minus f of a. So
this difference is the same value, no matter
which antiderivative of lowercase f we use.
And that's why we can say that capital F can
be any antiderivative. Part Two of the fundamental
theorem of calculus is super useful, because
it allows us to compute integrals simply by
finding anti derivatives and evaluating them.
Finding anti derivatives tends to be really
easy. Computing integrals, using the Riemann
sum definition is really hard. And so because
of the fundamental theorem of calculus, we
don't have to go through all those lengthy
and tedious computations, we've involving
limits of areas of rectangles, all we have
to do to evaluate an integral is find an antiderivative,
and evaluate it. Let's see how this works
in some examples. In this first example, the
antiderivative of 3x squared is x cubed. And
the antiderivative of negative four over x
is minus four times ln absolute value of x.
We could add a plus C to make it a general
antiderivative, but we don't really need it.
The fundamental theorem says that we can use
any antiderivative, so we might as well use
the simplest one, where c equals zero. Now
we need to evaluate this antiderivative on
the endpoints of negative one and negative
five. And we usually write this as a vertical
line with a negative one at the bottom and
a negative five at the top to mean evaluation.
In other words, the notation capital F
of X
between A and B means capital F of b minus
capital F of A, which is what we need to compute
for our antiderivative here. So now we just
plug in negative five for x, and then we subtract
what we get when we plug in negative one for
x. In this example, you can see why it's important
to write the antiderivative of one over x
as ln absolute value of x not just ln of x,
because ln of the absolute value of five,
which is ln a five actually has an answer,
whereas ln of negative five would not exist.
I can simplify this expression a little bit,
I get negative 125 minus four ln five minus
negative one, plus four ln of one. Since ln
of one is zero, this becomes negative 124
minus four ln five. That's about negative
130 point 438. In this next example, we need
to find the antiderivative for this expression
y squared minus y plus one over the square
root Why. Now we can't take the antiderivative
separately of the numerator and the denominator,
because that's just not how the quotient rule
works for differentiation. So it doesn't work
that way for anti differentiation either.
Instead, let's try to simplify this expression
to make it look more like something we can
take the antiderivative of. So I'm going to
rewrite the denominator as y to the one half
power. And dividing by y to the one half is
the same thing as multiplying by y to the
negative one half distributed, distributing
and adding exponents, I get y to the three
halves minus y to the one half plus y to the
negative one half. Now that's something I
can take the antiderivative of just using
the power rule and reverse y to the three
halves, becomes y to the five halves by adding
one to the exponent, I divide by the new exponent.
Now here, I get y to the three halves divided
by three halves, and here are negative one
half plus one is positive one half, I need
to evaluate this between four and one. let
me simplify a little bit. And now I'll substitute
in values. Now four to the five halves is
the same thing as four to the one half raised
to the fifth power. So that's two to the fifth
power, or 32. Similarly, for the three halves
is four to the one half cubed, so that's two
cubed, or eight, and four to the one half
is just two. And one to any power is just
one. And after some arithmetic, I get an answer
of 146 15th.
The Fundamental Theorem of Calculus, part
two can be stated this way, for a function
capital F with continuous derivative, the
integral of the derivative is equal to the
original function evaluated on the bounds
of integration. In this video, I'll prove
both parts of the fundamental theorem of calculus.
The first part of the fundamental theorem
of calculus says that if f of x is a continuous
function, then the function g of x defined
as the integral from a constant A to the variable
x of f of t dt is differentiable, and has
derivative equal to the original function,
f of x.
To prove this theorem, let's start with the
limit definition of derivative. The derivative,
g prime of x, by definition, is the limit
as h goes to zero of g of x plus h minus g
of x over h. Now g of x is defined as an integral
from a to x. So g of x plus h is going to
be the integral from a to x plus h, just plugging
in x plus h for x of f of t dt. g of x is
the integral from a to x
of f of t dt.
By properties of integrals. The integral from
a to x plus h minus the integral from a to
x is just the integral from x to x plus h.
Now informally, the integral from x to x plus
h can be closely approximated by a skinny
rectangle with height, f of x and width, H.
And so this limit is approximately the limit
as h goes to zero of f of x times h over h,
which is just f of x. But let's make this
argument a little more precise. Let's let
capital M be the maximum value that f of x
achieves on this little sub interval, and
lowercase m be the minimum value achieved.
In this picture, they occur on the endpoints
of the interval from x to x plus h, but they
could also occur somewhere in the interior.
But we know that f of x does have to have
a minimum value and a maximum value, since
it's a continuous function by assumption on
a closed interval. Now we know that the integral
of f of t dt from x to x plus h has to be
less than or equal to capital M times h and
bigger than a to lowercase m times h. This
is one of the properties of integrals, and
can be verified visually by comparing this
shaded red area to the small blue rectangle,
which has area lowercase m times h, and comparing
it to the area of the big rectangle, which
has area capital M times h equivalently, the
integral from x to x plus H of F of t dt divided
by h has to be less than or equal to capital
M and greater than or equal to little m. But
the intermediate value theorem, which holds
for all continuous functions, says that this
intermediate value that lies between the minimum
and maximum value of f has to be achieved
as f of c for some C in the interval. Therefore,
I cannot replace this integral in the limit
expression above by just simply the value
f of c for some c between x and x plus h.
The value of C here depends on x and h. But
as h goes to zero, C has to get closer and
closer to x. And since f is continuous, this
means that this limit is equal to
f of x.
We've now proved the first part of the fundamental
theorem of calculus, that the derivative of
g exists and equals f of x. The second part
of the fundamental theorem of calculus says
that if f is continuous, then the integral
from a to b of f of x dx is equal to the antiderivative
of lowercase F, which I'll denote by capital
F, evaluated at B minus that antiderivative
evaluated today. Part Two of the fundamental
theorem follows directly from part one. Let's
let g of x be defined as the integral from
a to x of f of t dt. Then part one of the
fundamental theorem of calculus tells us that
g prime of x exists and equals lowercase f
of x. In other words, capital G is an antiderivative
for a lowercase F. Now g of the minus g of
A is by definition, the integral from a to
b of f of t dt minus the integral of a from
a to a of f of t dt. The second integral is
zero, since the bounds of integration are
identical. So part two of the fundamental
theorem of calculus is true if I use the antiderivative
capital
G.
But the theorem is supposed to be true for
any antiderivative. So let's let capital F
be any antiderivative of lowercase F, we know
that capital F of x has to equal capital G
of X plus some constant since any two antiderivative
for the same function differ by a constant,
and therefore, capital F of b minus capital
F of A is going to equal capital G of B plus
C minus capital G of A plus C. The constant
C cancels out, and we just get capital G of
b minus capital G of A, which we already saw
was equal to the integral from a to b of lowercase
f of t dt. So the left side of this equation
is equal to the right side. And the fundamental
theorem of calculus Part two is proved for
any antiderivative. This completes the proof
of the fundamental theorem of calculus. This
video is about the substitution method for
evaluating integrals, also known as u substitution.
As the first example, let's try to integrate
to x sine of x squared dx. Now sine of x squared
is the composition of the function sine and
the function x squared. And notice that the
function x squared has derivative to x, which
is sitting right here and the integrand. I'm
going to make the substitution u equals x
squared, and then I'll write d u is equal
to 2x dx. That's differential notation. To
find d u, I take the derivative have X squared
and then multiply by the differential dx,
I can then rewrite the integrand as sine of
u. And the 2x. dx becomes do after making
this substitution, I can integrate, because
the antiderivative of sine of u is negative
cosine of u. And I'll add on the constant
of integration. I'm not finished yet, my original
problem was in terms of x, and now I've got
a function in terms of u. So let's substitute
back in since u is equal to x squared, I can
replace that, and I have my final answer.
To verify that this final answer is correct,
that it really is the antiderivative of what
we started with, let's take the derivative
of our answer and make sure we get back the
function to x sine of x
squared.
If we take the derivative of negative cosine
of x squared plus C, then we get the derivative
of a constant is zero, so we have the derivative
of negative cosine, that's equal to sine of
the inside function x squared times the derivative
of the inside function using the chain rule.
And we do in fact, get back to the integrand
that we started with. Notice that we use the
chain rule when taking the derivative to check
our answer. Let's try some more examples of
use substitution. When looking for what to
substitute as you, it's good to look for a
chunk that's in the integrand, whose derivative
is also in the integrand. It's also good enough
to just have a constant multiple of the derivative
in the integrand. So in the first example,
we might use the chunk one plus 3x squared,
as are you. The derivative of that expression
is six times x. And even though six times
x isn't completely in the integrand, we do
have a factor of x in the numerator, that's
just a constant multiple away from the derivative
of 6x. So let's write out d u, that's going
to be 6x dx. And I'm going to go ahead and
rewrite this as x dx is equal to one six d
U. writing it this way, it makes it easy to
substitute one six d u for x dx. And then
in my denominator, my one plus 3x squared
becomes u. I can rewrite this as one six times
the integral of one over u d u you and I recognize
that the antiderivative of one over u is ln
absolute value of u. Substituting back in
for you, I get a final answer of one six ln
absolute value of one plus 3x squared, plus
say, the absolute value signs are not really
necessary in this example, since one plus
3x squared is always positive. As our next
example, let's look at the integral of e to
the 7x dx. one chunk with us here is u equals
7x. If we do that, then d u is just seven
dx.
And so we have dx is equal to 1/7 do substituting
in we have the integral of e to the u times
1/7 d u, I can pull the 1/7 out and integrate
e to the u to the app, just either the U and
substituting in for back for 7x, I get e to
the 7x plus C. I encourage you to pause the
video to check that these two answers are
correct. By taking derivatives. You'll notice
that you use the chain rule each time. Next,
let's do an example with a definite integral,
the integral from E to E squared of ln x over
x dx. If we set u equal to ln x, then d u
is the derivative of ln x, that's one of our
x times dx. This is a much better choice of
you than say setting u equal to x from the
denominator, because then d u would just be
dx. And when we did the substitution, nothing
would really change. For definite integrals,
we need to deal with the bounds of integration
here e and d squared. We really have two options,
worry about them now or worry about them later.
I'll show you the worry about them. Now method
first. Our bounds of integration E and E squared
are values of Bax as we convert everything
in our integral from x to you, we need to
convert the bounds of integration from values
of x to values of u also. Now, when x is equal
to e, u is equal to ln IV, which is one, just
using this equation. Similarly, when x is
equal to E squared, u is equal to ln t squared,
which is two. So as I rewrite my integral,
I'm going to replace the bounds with one and
two. And now my ln x becomes my u and my dx
divided by x becomes my do, they're going
to grow of UD u is equal to use squared over
two, and I evaluate this between the bounds
of u equals two and u equals one to get two
squared over two minus one squared over two,
which is one half. Notice that when we did
the problem this way, we never actually had
to get back to our variable x, we stayed in
the variable u and evaluated. The second way
of dealing with the bounds of integration
is to worry about them later. Let's go back
to the beginning of the problem. We're just
about to substitute u equals ln x and d u
equals one over x dx. Instead of substituting
in for the bounds of integration, I'm going
to temporarily ignore them and just evaluate
the indefinite integral ln x over x dx, which
I can substitute in as you times do, we can
evaluate that to get you squared over two.
Normally we'd have a plus c constant. But
since we're ultimately going to be doing a
definite integral, we don't really need the
constant here. Now, just like when we're doing
indefinite integrals, I'm going to get back
to the variable x by substituting back in
for you U is ln of x. So I square that and
divided by two, and then I can go back to
my original bounds of integration, those bounds
are the x values of E squared, and E. Plugging
in those bounds, I get ln of E squared quantity
squared over two minus ln of E squared over
two, which evaluates to two squared over two
minus one over two, which is again, one half.
This video gave some examples of use substitution
to evaluate integrals. This method works great
in examples like this one, where there's a
chunk that you can call you whose derivative
or at least a constant multiple of its derivative
is also in the integrand.
You've already seen how u substitution works
in practice. In this video, I'll try to explain
why it works. u substitution is based on the
chain rule. Recall the chain rule says if
we take the derivative of a function, capital
F of lowercase g of x with respect to x, we
get the derivative of capital F evaluated
on the inside function g of x times the derivative
of g of x.
If we just write that equation in the opposite
order, we have that an expression of the form
f prime of g of x times g prime of x can all
be wrapped up as the derivative of a composite
function, f of g of x. Now if I take the integral
of both sides of this equation with respect
to x, on the right side, I'm taking the integral
of a derivative.
Well, the integral or antiderivative of a
derivative is just the original function,
capital f of g of x plus C. Now when we do
use substitution, we're really just writing
this equation down. We are seeing an expression
of the form f prime of g of x times g prime
of x dx, we're recognizing you as g of x and
d u as g prime of x dx. So we're rewriting
this expression as the integral of capital
F prime of u d u do and that integrates to
just capital F of u plus C. And then we're
substituting back in for you To get capital
f of g of x plus C, the beginning and end
of this process are exactly the same as the
left side and right side of our chain rule
expression above. So when you're doing u substitution
to integrate, you can thank this chain rule
that's behind it all. This video introduces
the idea of an average value of a function.
To take the average of a finite list of numbers,
we just add the numbers up and divide by n,
the number of numbers. In summation notation,
we write the sum from i equals one to n of
Q i all divided by n. But defining the average
value of a continuous function is a little
different. Because a function can take on
infinitely many values on an interval from
a to b, we could estimate the average value
of the function by sampling it at a finite
Li many evenly spaced x values. I'll call
them x one through x n. And let's assume that
they're spaced a distance of delta x apart,
then the average value of f at these sample
points is just the sum of the values of f
divided by n, the number of values are in
summation notation, the sum from i equals
one to n of f of x i all divided by n. This
is an approximate average value of f, since
we're just using n sample points. But the
approximation gets better as the number of
sample points n gets bigger and bigger. So
we could define the average as the limit as
n goes to infinity of the sample average.
I'd like to make this look more like a Riemann
sum. So I need to get delta x in there. So
I'm just going to multiply the top and the
bottom by delta x. And notice that n times
delta x is just the length of the interval
b minus a. Now as the number of sample points
goes to infinity, delta x, the distance between
them goes to zero. So I can rewrite my limit
as the limit as delta x goes to zero, of the
sum of FX II times delta x divided by b minus
a. Now the limit of this Riemann sum in the
numerator is just the integral from a to b
of f of x dx. And so the average value of
the function is given by the integral on the
interval from a to b divided by the length
of the interval. Notice the similarity between
the formula for the average value of a function
and the formula for the average value of a
list of numbers, the integral for the function
corresponds to the summation sign for the
list of numbers. And the length of the interval
B minus A for the function corresponds to
n, the number of numbers in the list of numbers.
Now let's work an example. For the function
g of x equals one over one minus 5x. On the
interval from two to five, we know that the
average value of G is given by the integral
from two to five of one over one minus 5x
dx divided by the length of that interval,
I'm going to use use of the tuition to integrate,
so I'm going to set u equal to one minus 5x.
So d u is negative five dx. In other words,
dx is negative 1/5 times do. Looking at my
bounds of integration, when x is equal to
two, u is equal to
one minus five times two, which is negative
nine. And when x is equal to five, u is equal
to negative 24. substituting into my integral,
I get the integral from negative nine to negative
24 of one over u times negative 1/5. Do and
that's divided by three. Now dividing by three
is same as multiplying by 1/3. And as I integrate,
I'm going to pull the negative 1/5 out and
then take the integral of one over u, that's
ln of the absolute value of u evaluated in
between negative 24 and negative nine. The
absolute value signs are important here because
they prevent me from trying to take the natural
log of negative numbers to evaluate
get negative 1/15 times ln of 24 minus ln
of nine, I can use my log rolls to simplify
and get negative 1/15 ln of 24 over nine,
that's negative 1/15 ln of eight thirds, and
as a decimal, that's approximately negative
0.0654. So I found the average value of G.
Now my next question is, does g ever achieve
that average value, in other words, is there
a number c in the interval from two to five
for which GFC equals its average value? Well,
one way to find out is just to set GFC equal
to G's average value. In other words, set
one over one minus five c equal to negative
1/15 ln of eight thirds, and try to solve
for C. There are lots of ways to solve this
equation. But I'm going to take the reciprocal
of both sides, subtract one from both sides
and divide by negative five. This simplifies
to three over ln of eight thirds, plus 1/5,
which is approximately 3.25. And that x value
does lie inside the interval from two to five.
So we've demonstrated that g does achieve
its average value over the interval. But in
fact, we could have predicted this to be true.
Gs average value has to lie somewhere between
GS minimum value and maximum value on this
interval. And since G is continuous on the
interval from two to five, it has to achieve
every value that lies in between as minimum
and maximum, including its average value.
The same argument shows that for any continuous
function, the function must achieve its average
value on an interval. And this is known as
the mean value theorem for integrals. Namely,
for any continuous function f of x on an interval
from a to b, there has to be at least one
number c, between A and B, such that f of
c equals its average value, or, in symbols,
f of c equals the integral from A b of f of
x dx divided by b minus a. This video gave
the definition of an average value of a function,
and stated the mean value theorem for integrals.
If we rewrite the formula for average value
a little, then we can see a geometric interpretation
for average value, the area of the box with
height the average value is the same as the
area under the curve. This video gives two
proofs of the mean value theorem for integrals.
the mean value theorem for integrals says
the for continuous function f of x, defined
on an interval from a to b, there's some number
c between A and B, such that f of c is equal
to the average value of f. The first proof
that I'm going to give us is the intermediate
value theorem. Recall that the intermediate
value theorem says that if we have a continuous
function f, defined on an interval, which
I'll call x 1x, two, if we have some number
l in between f of x one and f of x two, then
f has to achieve the value out somewhere between
x one and x two. Keeping in mind the intermediate
value theorem, let's turn our attention back
to the mean value theorem for integrals. Now
it's possible that our function f of x might
be constant on the interval from a to b. But
if that's true, then our mean value theorem
for integrals holds easily, because f AV is
just equal to that constant, which is equal
to f OC for any c between A and B. So let's
assume that f is not constant. Well, like
continuous function on a closed interval has
to have a minimum value and a maximum value,
which I'll call little m, and big M. Now we
know that F's average value on the interval
has to be between its maximum value and its
minimum value. If you don't believe this,
consider the fact that all of us values on
the interval have to lie between big M and
little m. And if we integrate this inequality
We get little m times b minus a is less than
or equal to the integral of f is less than
or equal to big M times b minus a. Notice
that the first and the last integrals, we're
just integrating a constant. Now if I divide
all three sides by b minus a, I can see that
little m is less than or equal to the average
value of f is less than or equal to big M
as I wanted. Now, I just need to apply the
intermediate value theorem, with F average
as my number L and little m and big M as my
values of f of x one and f of x two. The intermediate
value theorem says that F average is achieved
by f of c for some C in between my x one and
x two. And therefore, for some C in my interval
a b. And that proves the mean value theorem
for integrals. Now I'm going to give a second
proof for the mean value theorem for integrals.
And this time, it's going to be as a corollary
to the regular mean value theorem for
functions. Recall that the mean value theorem
for functions, says that if g of x is continuous
on a closed interval,
and differentiable on the interior of that
interval, then there's some number c in the
interval, such that the derivative of g at
C is equal to the average rate of change of
G, across the whole interval from a to b.
Let's keep the mean value theorem for functions
in mind, and turn our attention back to the
mean value theorem for integrals. I'm going
to define a function g of x to be the integral
from a to x of f of t dt, where F is the function
given to us in the statement of the mean value
theorem for integrals. Notice that g of A
is just the integral from a to a, which is
zero, while g of B is the integral from a
to b of our function. Now, by the fundamental
theorem of calculus, our function g of x is
continuous and differentiable on the interval
a, b, and g prime of x is equal to f of x.
And by the mean value theorem for functions,
we know that g prime of c has to equal g of
b minus g of a over b minus a, for some numbers,
C and the interval a b, if we substitute in
the three facts above, into our equation below,
we get f of c is equal to the integral from
a to b of f of t dt minus zero over b minus
a, which is exactly the conclusion that we
wanted to reach. This shows that the mean
value theorem for integrals really is the
mean value theorem for functions where our
function is an integral. And this completes
the second proof of the main value theorem
for integrals. So now I've proved the mean
value theorem for integrals in two different
ways. And I've used a lot of the great theorems
of calculus along the way.